John similga is back with this massive
react 18 course John is one of the most
viewed instructors on our Channel this
course is perfect for people brand new
to react and for people who want to
learn about the latest version of react
for their front-end web development
projects hey what's up I'm John from
recording addict then I'm super excited
to present the react 18 and Redux
toolkit tutorial video
recently react released its latest
version react 18 and I believe it's the
perfect time to explore all of the
exciting new features such as suspense
API
extra libraries such as Redux toolkit
and build tools such as wheat
in addition we'll be discussing the
latest and most useful vs code
extensions and configurations so long
story short in this video we're going to
learn react from the very scratch using
its latest and greatest features as well
as tooling I really don't want to bore
you with the long list of things we're
going to cover in this video so if
you're looking for something specific or
simply just need some persuasion please
reference the timestamps available in
the description
since it's not my first rodeo
effectively I believe it's already a
third time I'm recording a react
tutorial video I added a bunch of useful
stuff
for example a readme file with all of
the notes bunch of challenges to
immediately test our knowledge and of
course tons of useful resources where
you can find more info on some specific
topic
as a quick sign note this content is
part of my rear course and since quite
often I get this question
what's the difference between the video
and the course
let me just answer it here
first course contains way more content
at the moment it's somewhere around 60
hours specifically it contains more
tutorials for advanced libraries and
more complex custom projects
second
if there are any changes let's say react
War one of the libraries comes out with
an update I'm able to update the course
content which unfortunately is
impossible to do with the YouTube video
and third I provide assistance
so if you get stuck on some specific
topic or project during the course I'll
help you to troubleshoot the issue
lastly if you enjoy the content and want
to enroll in my react or any of my other
web dev courses just navigate to
johnsburg.com again the URL is www
johnsmilk.com sign up for my newsletter
and get any of my courses for just ten
dollars
simply choose the course you want to
attend and I'll provide a discount code
for you to use at the checkout alright
and welcome to the course and we're
going to kick things off
by quickly covering what in the world is
react and there's no better place to
start
than official Docs which by the way are
located at this URL
react.js.org again the URL is www
.react.js.org and once we navigate there
we're greeted by this one profound
sentence react is a JavaScript library
for building user interfaces
that's it my friends not a 10-page essay
just a short concise one sentence
explanation
and while I'm a big fan
of such straight to the point answers
let me elaborate a bit on that so react
was developed by Facebook
um it's still maintained by Facebook but
as you know now the company name is meta
its initial release was all the way back
in 2013.
and currently it is by far the most
popular JavaScript library to build user
interfaces
as a side note some of react competitors
are angular View and swelt now if
there's one thing I want you to take
away from this video
it's this one when it comes to react
it's all about components
and you can think of components as
independent chunks of user interfaces
components can be as small as one HTML
element let's say a button or a heading
2.
or you can be a rebel and jam your
entire Facebook clone in one component
at the end of the day a lot of it
depends on your preference and approach
in reality though you'll probably avoid
the one component route
since such approach somewhat defeats the
entire purpose of using react in the
first place
you see the benefit of component is that
you can build bunch of
independent isolated and most
importantly reusable user interfaces but
you can then piece it together just like
the Lego blocks and as a result build
even super big and complex apps without
going insane
well your app can have as many
components as you like it will always
have at least one
called a root component we already
glossed over it a bit but just to
reiterate
the major benefits of using components
and essentially react to develop your
next app are following you can build
independent pieces of user interfaces
meaning changing logic or layout in one
component will not break your whole app
and once the component is ready to go
you can reuse it all throughout your app
but the component code is still stored
in one place so if you ever need to make
some changes you don't have to run
around like a headless chicken
simply locate the component apply the
changes and all of the instances will be
automatically updated and of course
let's not forget about the speed you see
behind the scenes react is using
something called a virtual Dom where
only the component that needs to be
updated is affected and what's really
cool it's done without re-rendering the
whole app which in turn of course
increases the speed of your final
product and as a result the user
experience as well before I let you go I
also want to show you great example of
react components in action and I'm going
to use our beloved Twitter
if we take a look at the sidebar we can
see list of links
and you'll notice this repeating pattern
where each link
as the icon as well as the text
so with the react what we can do we can
set up a component that is going to
accept
those two things the icon
and a text
and essentially once we have the
structure in place every time
we want to use that link We simply need
to provide the data show the icon
and the text and what's really cool
if we want to change something about the
structure we only need to do that in one
place and then all of the instances
where we use the link are going to be
automatically updated
and if we keep looking
in reality
there's tons of repeating patterns not
just in Twitter but pretty much in any
app or site that you see for example
this feed notice again we have the photo
we have the name of the person who's
posting We have the Twitter handle and I
can go on and on and on so notice with
every post only the values are changing
so it's the same deal
we set up a structure and then we just
pass in the data and if you're looking
at it you're like well okay what's the
big deal well try doing that with HTML
and CSS
you see with just HTML we don't have any
kind of templating correct
so effectively we'll have to hard code
all of this
but that's not the case with react and
if you're still not convinced hopefully
by the time I show you the first
component you'll see why react is so
popular when it comes to building user
interfaces when it comes to course
requirements my expectation is that
you're familiar with fundamentals of
HTML CSS and most importantly JavaScript
I can honestly say
that the more JavaScript you know
especially es6
the easier is going to be pick up react
since at the end of the day
react is just JavaScript
so if you're familiar with basic tags
the general concept
behind CSS selectors
array methods and for example a spread
operator
you'll be in good shape
now it's not the end of the world if
you're still getting comfortable with
JavaScript
just keep in mind that once in a while
you'll have to do some extra studying
yes of course
I'll try to cover
even the straight up vanilla.js features
in as much detail as I possibly can
but at the end of the day it's a area
course so if you still need more info
please be prepared to utilize external
resources
and one such resource is my YouTube
channel coding addict
more specifically JavaScript nuggets
playlist
so before each video
where we will utilize some vanilla.js
feature
I'll share a link to a corresponding
video
where I cover that feature in vanilla.js
environment and hopefully that way you
can simply watch the video get up to
speed with what the specific feature is
doing
and continue with the course videos all
right and up next let's work on our Dev
environment
is it when it comes to react it requires
more tooling then straight up vanilla
jazz
where we only need text error and a
browser
now not to worry
the setup is still extremely
straightforward
and you'll only need to do it once
meaning
once the setup is in place you will be
able to start your react project
in a lightning speed
okay and let's start with the browser
yes
since we'll be developing Web projects
we do need a browser
I personally use Chrome
but technically it's optional
you'll be able to follow along with a
different browser as well
just keep in mind that here and there
your results might slightly differ
now let me be very clear I'm not saying
that your entire project won't work on a
different browser
keep in mind that each browser has some
default presets and therefore the same
element for example input in different
browsers can look slightly different
if you also want to download the Chrome
go to your favorite search engine which
in my case is Google Chrome type install
Google Chrome click on a link and follow
the instructions all right and up next
we've got text editor
I'm going to use Visual Studio code
pretty much a standard these days
but just like the browser you can follow
along with a different text editor the
only downside here and there I will show
some Nifty ways to speed up our
development
and you'll have to search for
alternative
available in your text editor
as far as my configuration I keep it as
close to default as possible
simply because I'm recording content as
far as my extensions I'm not going to
cover them in this video since in my
opinion a more solid approach is to
Showcase what the extension is doing
with the actual example
so once we reach a point where one of
the extensions becomes useful I'll stop
and explain in detail and don't worry
you won't need all of these extensions
to follow along
and the same goes for settings Json
I will showcase the code once we
actually need to work in the file
now just in case you are like super
eager to see my config right away
just navigate to my GitHub profile
and look for this repo vs code setup
2022.
again the repo is vs code setup 2022.
lastly if you want to install Visual
Studio code just navigate to this URL
and follow the instructions
not bad not bad and before we install
node.js let's quickly talk about this
scary thing the terminal or if you use
Windows the command prompt and first
let's just establish that terminal is
simply an alternative way to communicate
with our computer
so instead of graphical interface we
just type commands also don't worry we
won't run any dangerous commands in this
course like wiping out the entire file
system or anything like that for the
most part we'll run some basic commands
like CD which stands for changing
directory as well as commands provided
by create react app a tool which we will
install in few videos
lastly throughout the course I'll also
utilize the integrated terminal and
visual studio code
please keep in mind that we can use them
interchangeably essentially you'll get
the same results
and the only reason why I prefer
integrated terminal and visual studio
code is simply because it right away
points to the existing project
effectively it requires less work and up
next let's install node.js on our
machine now if you're not familiar with
node.js it's a cross platform JavaScript
runtime environment which allows us to
build fast and scalable Network
applications
if you want to check whether the node is
already present on your machine just
navigate back to the terminal and type
node
hyphen hyphen version or dash dash
version again the command is node hyphen
hyphen version press return and if it
returns some numbers you're good to go
however if it returns something along
the lines of command not found please
continue with the video
now in order to install a brand new node
instance we need to navigate to this URL
nodejs.org or you can simply go to your
search engine type install node and
most likely this is going to be the
first link but again the URL is
nodejs.org it will right away detect
which operating system you're using
and in my case that is mac and I highly
highly highly highly highly recommend
installing the LTS version instead of
the current one again
I recommend installing the LTS version
since that way there's a smaller chance
you'll have to chase some weird bugs
you see we will use some external
libraries and it takes some time for
those libraries to catch up with the
node versions as well
so if you go with LTS which is a stable
version there's a higher chance library
or a package will work without any
issues which can't be said about the
current version
the time of this recording
the latest LTS version is 1812 but of
course
since you're watching this in the future
your number most likely will be
different it will be higher with that
said let me emphasize something just
because you're using different node
version
most likely a newer node version does
not mean does not mean that the course
content is old or invalid
effectively we only use node to run our
react app basically we'll use node to
create a new react app instance
so newer or older node version does not
affect our code again let me be very
clear and the reason why I'm being so
annoying because I get these questions
and Q a so I just want to address them
here and if by any chance a newer node
version will introduce some breaking
changes to our entire setup rest assured
I will update the course content so
again download the LTS version follow
the instructions and once the install is
complete type again
in a terminal node
dash dash version again the command is
node bash Dash and version and if
everything is correct you'll see the
node version
however if you get the error please
utilize your search engine and
troubleshoot the issue since you won't
be able to follow along with the
upcoming videos and once we have
successfully installed node
now let's finally spin up our first
react application
like I mentioned before unlike vanilla
Jazz react does require more tooling but
luckily for us we won't have to do it
manually
for the longest time the most popular
option for scaffolding react apps from
scratch was packaged by the name of
create react app
but as everything in web dev things are
changing and they're changing fast and
as I'm recording the third iteration of
the react tutorial
actually there's a better and more
popular option called Veet and yes it is
pronounced Veet not white now since you
will encounter create react app code
examples in bunch of videos and blog
posts during the first part of react
tutorial so during the fundamentals part
we are going to use create react app and
once we get to Advanced react Concepts
then we're going to switch to beat and
of course I'll discuss why at this time
beat is a better option once we get
there
don't worry both of them have similar
setups so it's going to be a very easy
transition I promise you so as I was
saying during the first part of react
tutorial we are going to utilize package
called create react app and you can
easily find it by just typing create
react app in your search engine
it was created and it's being supported
by the Facebook team which means that we
can always be sure
that it uses all the latest and more
importantly
correct setup
and if you go through docs you'll see
that the main goal of this package
is to
speed up our development basically with
the help of this package we can right
away start building our awesome react
applications instead of tinkering
and getting frustrated with complex
config setups and effectively
in order to get started we want to open
up our terminal navigate to our working
directory in my case that is going to be
desktop and run of this command npx
create react app and the name of your
application so in their example it's my
app
now before we do that let me explain the
npm part
you see when we install node
we also install npm or node package
manager
which allows us to quickly install
external packages
and normally the command is going to be
npm install or npmi for short and then
the package name and don't worry if this
sounds iffy it will make all the sense
in the world once we install our first
package and yes we'll do that throughout
the course now why this command starts
with npx instead of npm simply because
instead of installing the create react
app package on our machine which by the
way used to be their old approach
so we needed to install that globally
and then we were able to create that new
react application instance
now we want to execute this package
in order to create that new react app
instance so instead of installing create
react app on our machine we will just
execute it and as a result we get a
brand new react application on our
machine and yes basically every time
we want to start working on new react
app we'll have to repeat the same steps
so let's try it out I mean you can type
it manually you can copy it's really up
to you in my case I think I'm just going
to copy I'm going to navigate back and
first
let's just
get on the same page
so as I'm looking at my thermal I can
see that I'm sitting in the root and I
can definitely
check that by just typing LS which
effectively is just going to give me all
the directories that I have and notice
here I have desktop so in my case since
I want to set this project
in desktop
I'm going to use CD which is change
directory and then navigate to the
desktop now do you have to
work on a desktop no of course not
for example you can set it up in your
documents this part is really up to you
so I'm going to go with CD then
stop so now I can clearly see that
instead of root I'm located in a desktop
again pretty much
the same idea as with graphical
interface the difference is that now of
course we're just typing the command and
then I'm going to copy and paste this
command now let me right away show you a
possible error that you might get and
therefore I'll just keep this my app and
I'll change that in a second so let's
say if you run this command
and it spins back the following error a
fix that works for me is to add at
latest at the end of create react app
now if the install
is successful then of course you don't
need to do anything but if you run into
the same error just go with NPH then
create react app then add add latest and
then come up with a name so in my case
I'm going to call this tutorial like so
again
I'm located in the desktop we run npx
because we want to execute this package
and in order to avoid this bug we just
go with ADD latest and then whatever is
the name of our project and in my case
that is tutorial press enter
and the
package is going to start setting up the
application now it takes a little bit of
time
so I'll stop the video and I'll resume
it once the install is complete okay it
looks like the install is complete and
like I mentioned before essentially we
have two places where we can run more
commands
we can do that in the terminal or we can
do that in the integrated terminal so
notice here we have this npm start run
build test as well as the eject and I'll
talk about these commands a little bit
later first I just want to spin up the
application and in order to do that we
need to run npm start and notice over
here pretty much says what the command
is doing it starts up the development
server on our machine now
like I just said we have two places
where we can run that we can use the
terminal but
make sure that you navigate to this
actual project because at the moment I'm
located in the desktop
so the fastest one is basically to drag
and drop this one and once I press enter
notice now I'm located in tutorial
so now I can run this npm start and
essentially it's going to spin up the
dev server however I prefer the
integrated terminal that is in the
visual studio code and how we can run
that well we first need to open up our
text error when we need to open up this
project in our text error which again
I can simply drag and drop and once
we're done with that we want to open up
the integrated terminal and in my case
the shorthand for that is control and
tilde and tilde key is located just to
the left of the one key so press this
one and notice you'll have the terminal
and again what's really cool about this
integrated terminal
that we're right away located in this
particular project so I don't have to
worry whether I'm in a desktop or I'm in
some other folder I know for sure that
integrated terminal
always point back to my project
and let's spin up that application so
I'm going to go over here with npm and
start
and effectively this is going to spin up
our
react application
and we'll have our application on
localhost 3000 and this is how our
initial application is going to look
like
as a side note I prefer setting up vs
code and browser side by side since that
way I don't have to switch screens
if I want to showcase something in the
browser
but it's totally optional you're not
required to do that also it's a Mac
thing
so effectively it has nothing to do with
react
so here's what I want to do I want to
move this one down
then I'll make it bigger smaller again
now it's going to be on my desktop
essentially I'll grab the code
and then set it side by side
I'll spend the next video
going over the files and folders that we
can find in our new instance
in this video I'll simply showcase
that every time we make some changes in
our code
the dev server will right away update
the browser as well
now you don't have to code along again
we haven't covered what is the source
folder and all that but in my case I'm
going to go to Source folder then app.js
and instead of this paragraph I'm just
going to say I don't know maybe heading
1 so I'll just change from the paragraph
to a heading 1 and then I'll say react
tutorial once you save check it out
right away we see the latest version in
the browser which is really really
awesome
it definitely speeds up our development
and like I said in the following video
I'll go over the files and folders that
we can find in our new react app
instance okay and once we're done with
the install now let's cover react
fundamentals
as a side note if you ever want to
reference
the complete source code just navigate
to my GitHub profile and look for this
repo
more specifically search for
fundamentals directory
also in there you'll find a readme file
with all of the topics we're going to
cover in the fundamentals section and
yes I will reference this file quite a
bit in the upcoming videos as far as the
readme I tried such approach in my meron
course and since students seem to really
like it I decided to implement it in my
other courses as well basically the goal
of the readme file is to save your time
on note-taking and to allow you to
complete tasks independently if that's
your preferred way of learning content
all right and once we have created our
first react app now let's quickly
discuss files and folders provided by
create react app
and first up we've got node modules and
effectively in there you'll find all of
our dependencies
essentially the dependencies our project
is using and if you're iffy on the whole
dependencies concept just wait a little
bit in few minutes we'll cover
package.json and once we do that it's
going to be easier to see the big
picture after that we've got public
folder which contains static assets
including index.html
which basically is the thing that is
served to the browser
in other words index HTML is responsible
for whatever you see in the browser and
if you decide to inspect index HTML file
you'll see that it's pretty typical HTML
file
so if you crack it open you'll see that
it has
typical tags it has the head
element it also has the body one and in
the head element
we can change the title get the fonts
CSS maybe even a favicon and just to
show you
that I'm not making this up I'm gonna
navigate there I'll search for title
tags and let's right here react tutorial
or whatever
value you want to provide and check it
out the moment I change it
I also can see that in the browser now
one thing that is very very important
is this div with ID of root
believe it or not our entire application
effectively lives over here and I know
it sounds somewhat unbelievable but
effectively our workflow is going to be
following
we'll set up whatever logic
we want or need in The Source One In The
Source folder
and then it's going to get injected in
this route and essentially as a result
we'll render our application in the
browser and don't worry I will come back
to this concept quite a few times
because
I fully understand that the first time
you see that you're like whoa that's
some really impressive stuff yep I agree
after that we've got Source folder which
basically is the brain of our app
and therefore in there we'll do all of
our work now I'm not going to cover any
of the files
in Source folder for now since create
react app creates bunch of boilerplate
and actually I prefer
especially
while we're covering fundamentals
setting everything up together from the
scratch but in short in the source we
will set up all our components Pages
utils functions assets CSS and whatever
else we need for our project
as we continue with the course you'll
see that there are really no
restrictions on the folder structure
inside source so the way you manage your
code really comes down to your
preference as long as there's index.js
which is going to be our JavaScript
entry point so remember the ID root in
the index.html once we're done adding
our functionality like I said it's going
to get injected in there and as a result
we will render our application in the
browser after Source we've got dot git
ignore which specifies which files will
be ignored by The Source control
effectively get
so if you navigate there you'll see a
list of files and folders that are going
to be ignored once we push our project
up to GitHub for example after that we
got package log but let's just skip it
for now and first let's discuss package
Json
and effectively
package Json contains useful info about
our project now we will mostly be
interested in two things in script as
well as the dependencies
now package.json is not specific to
react apps pretty much every node
project has one so let's take a peek
essentially like I said useful info
about our project and you'll also most
likely hear this term manifest file so
in here we can see the name you can see
the version and like I said
we are mostly interested in two things
independencies our project is using so
these are the main dependencies as well
as the script so these are the commands
we can run
in our project
that's why when we run npm start
essentially it sets up our application
and yes we'll discuss the other commands
a little bit later for now we're
literally interested in this one the npm
start now when it comes to commands
normally you go with npm run and then
the command but with start we can simply
go with npm and then start
now if you
picked up the node modules you probably
noticed that it's huge
it's literally massive but in the
package.json we actually have way less
dependencies so what's up with that
or you see so these are the main
dependencies our project is using but we
need to keep in mind that every time we
get the dependency so some kind of
Library some other devs were kind enough
to set up and essentially we're just
utilizing the code in that Library
well those libraries can have
dependencies on their own
which is the case over here
so every time we'll install dependency
which of course it will do during the
course there's going to be more
dependencies because the dependency has
its own dependencies hopefully I'm
making myself clear so again these are
the main dependencies and then
since they have dependencies on their
own the node modules is quite big and
that's actually one of the reasons why
you will always see it in git ignore I
mean in most cases so when we're pushing
this up to a GitHub
normally known modules are not included
because they're huge and there's also no
need if you have package Json the moment
you will run npm install
essentially you'll right away install
all dependencies so not just the main
libraries but also the dependencies that
they are using and that's why we also
need a package lock
because essentially it's a snapshot of
our
entire dependency tree now I can tell
you right away that you really are not
going to do any work in the package lock
or node modules so
this is just the general info and pretty
much you can forget about them all of
our work is going to happen in the
source and then yes once in a while
we'll navigate to a package Json we'll
discuss some package and yes we'll add
few commands of our own but that's later
in the course and lastly we have a
readme file which essentially is a
markdown file where you can share more
info about the project for example build
instructions and summary and while we're
still on the topic of readme I just want
to showcase how you can quickly get the
readme that I provided now again you
don't have to do it
it's totally up to you but just in case
you're interested navigate to that repo
look for fundamentals then click on
readme then you want to go with raw
essentially select everything
go back now of course I already have
these values here select everything
that's currently in a readme copy and
paste and you are good to go now one
last thing that I quickly want to
mention here and there your results
might differ a little bit as far as the
browser just because
I'm using zoom level
so at the moment I have 175 that's
pretty typical for me but here and there
you might see me going more or less
since that way I can showcase some stuff
better again not a big deal it doesn't
mean that the code is different I'm just
saying that visually here and there our
results might differ just because I use
specific zoom level that's about it and
up next we're going to remove some
boilerplate code well create react app
is super useful tool unfortunately it
adds quite a bit of boilerplate code and
especially while we're covering react
fundamentals I prefer setting up
everything from scratch
since that way we can build everything
together
and in the process discuss the main
purpose of some specific file or code
snippet so that said our first task is
going to be somewhat straightforward
remove most of the boilerplate and we're
going to do that in the following way
navigate to your sidebar remove the
entire Source folder event create one
from the scratch yes I know
this might sound redundant but this is
what we're gonna do and then inside of
it we want to create index.js I can tell
you right away that your application is
going to break don't worry we'll fix it
in the next video so let's navigate over
here
notice the source folder I want to
remove it
yep the entire folder it goes to trash
then we want to create a new folder
let's call it source and inside of the
source let's create that file
our JavaScript entry point so the
index.js and once we do that like I said
our application is going to look
different don't worry we'll fix it in
the next video and also in this video I
want to mention that throughout the
course I'll toggle the sidebar just so I
have more real estate and in my case the
shortcut is command B now if you're
using different operating system there's
a great possibility that your shortcuts
are different and in order to get the
shortcuts for your Visual Studio code
just navigate to this Cog and then look
for keyboard shortcuts so for example if
I mention toggle sidebar
you can go here and then type toggle and
then sidebar and somewhere
in there you'll find your shortcut and
the reason why I prefer using such
shortcuts is because they save a bunch
of time and in the long run massively
speed up the development all right and
now let's finally set up our first
component and in order to create
a component in react
effectively this is what we'll need to
do
and as you're looking at it your first
thought probably is wait a minute
guy with a weird accent that looks a lot
like a JavaScript function
and guess what
you're absolutely positively 100 correct
yes in order to create a component in
react essentially we need to create a
function yes of course there are
differences
essentially that's the whole point of
the section
is to show you
what differences are there between the
good old vanilla.js function
and the components that we'll be
creating react but always always always
when you think of component think of
function every time we want to create a
component think I need to create a
function NES it can be
function with good old function keyword
or you can create the arrow function
that part doesn't really matter like I
said
a lot depends on your preference now we
will cover more rules later
for now I just want you to be aware that
we want to start our components with
capital letter
that's very important yes we're creating
a function but we want to start with a
capital letter
and we must must must must must return
some kind of HTML from this function
now technically this HTML is called js6
but
you'll see in a bunch of blog posts and
you'll hear me throughout this course as
well
effectively to use them interchangeably
yes what we're doing from the function
we are returning HDML
essentially this is going to be the tag
that is displayed on screen and
technically you can return empty one
you're just not going to see any content
on the screen so once we know this info
let's just go to index.js and let's
create that function again the actual
syntax is really up to you in my case I
think I'm gonna go with good old
function keyword just because I feel
like good old function today then let's
type return and whatever we want to
display on our screen so I'm not going
to be very original and I'm just going
to say my
first
component so we're done
but once we save nothing happens
and you're like wait a minute you just
said that we're going to create the
function and we're going to be good to
go so normally every time we'll create a
component we'll need to do these two
things we'll need to create a function
AKA component and we'll need to export
it now if you're not familiar with es6
modules don't worry about it we'll spend
quite a few videos on it and essentially
what we're doing here is we're just
exporting this particular component and
then we can use it anywhere in our
application again we'll focus on that
a little bit later I really want to I
kind of hone in on the react stuff first
again if you're not familiar don't worry
we'll cover it if you are familiar you
know that essentially we're exporting as
default so we can just grab it anywhere
in our application and we can render it
essentially on the screen now this is
different though in the index.js that's
where we're setting up our root
component remember I said that we can
have as many components as we want I
mean you can have thousands and
thousands thousands of components but
you'll always have at least one
so that's the root component that's the
sucker that we will inject into that
idea route remember we talked about it
uh when we discuss the folder structure
I said that there's a public one there's
index HTML and then there is this famous
ID root so now what we want to do
we want to inject this greeting sucker
into that ID route and then since this
is
our JavaScript entry point we do need to
add a little bit more code now please
keep in mind just like this code it's
not specific to react this is es6
modules so in here we export stuff away
from the file and in here we import and
we're actually importing from the
libraries basically from our
dependencies again if you are even less
a little bit later
I'll cover
everything in detail okay don't worry
about it for now just worry about the
component
and the function you need to create
that's it and essentially as far as this
entry point
we want to grab react and react Dom and
notice this one is coming from react
package and this one is coming from
react Dom forward slash client
and then restore our function that
doesn't change and then we want to go to
react Dom create a root
so there's a special method that creates
the root and it's looking for one thing
it's looking for that ID now how we can
select ID in vanilla address we go
document get element by ID root and then
eventually we go with a root dot render
again if you're looking in this code and
you're like whoa this got really
confusing really fast this is going to
be your typical setup and I'll show you
the extension that actually sets up all
the code for you this is only for our
root
component for our JavaScript entry point
and I can tell you right away that once
we set it up
we'll pretty much forget about all this
code that's why again I know I've said
this already ten thousand times
Focus please on this one rest of the
stuff we'll figure out as we continue
with the section so first let's grab
those two Imports we're looking for
react so let me type over here if you
want of course you can copy and paste
from the readme so let's go here with
the react and as I said I'll most likely
vs code is going to give you the order
import if it doesn't then again just
look for react then we want to go with
import react
and then Dom and then this is coming
from react Dom Library forward slash
and client and as I say note
they change the syntax in react 18.
so prior to that there was react Dom
render now they create that route first
so right after the greeting we want to
go with const
and we'll create a root so react Dom and
now we're looking for that create root
and now let's select
the ID
with the value of root so this is where
we go back to vanilla JavaScript and we
go with get element by ID
and yes we're looking for the ID of root
and once we have all of this in place we
want to go with a root and then render
and here we want to pass our component
now when we create a component we create
a function correct we create a
JavaScript function now when we want to
render it the syntax is following we go
here with the angle bracket so then the
name of the component and then one thing
we need to know about react that we
always always need to self-close it
so this is again one of the rules that
we'll discuss a little bit later just
remember that when you pass in the
component you have two options you can
pass it like so with the opening one
and the closing one even though there's
nothing in between
yes that's the case or you can self
close it but you always always
have to do that you cannot just leave it
like this notice it right away
shows this red squiggly align and that
means that there is error in our
application and once we save it we
should see my first component in the
browser now if you don't just go back
here and refresh since we're messing
with the source folder and all that
maybe create react app just needs a
little nudge
now if for some weird reason you're
still stuck on this error don't panic
since we tinkered with index.js we just
need to give create react app A little
nudge basically we need to restart the
server so navigate to your integrated
terminal press Ctrl C which is going to
stop the server and then restart the
server with npm start again navigate to
the terminal
press Ctrl C which is going to stop the
server and then just restart the server
with npm
start and at the very end of the video I
just want to showcase the casing so if I
go here and if I let's say go with
greeting and then greeting over here
again the same deal we'll have an error
notice I have nothing on the screen and
if I open developer tools and warning
with that greeting blah blah blah blah
blah so again we don't want to do that
we always want to start with capital
letter and once I fix the casing of
course everything works as expected
we're done setting up our first
component if there's one thing I want
you to take away from this video
every time you think of component think
of function
that's it if you do that you'll be solid
and once we're done with our first
component I think this is an excellent
time for me to show you
the extensions I use as well as my
settings Json setup and first let's
start with two easy ones so the ones
that don't require much explanation and
that is auto rename tag and highlight
matching tag so if you want to take a
look at those extensions so that's how
the auto or name tag looks like and then
the Highlight one looks like this
essentially you just go search for
extensions
you install it in some cases you might
need to restart the text error and after
that you're pretty much good to go as
far as the auto rename tag if I go here
and let's say select a setting two
notice right away I'm changing the
values in the opening one as well as the
closing one so if I go here with heading
3 and save yep I'll have the heading
three now in the browser now when it
comes to the matching tags this is
technically optional you don't have to
do it but I just prefer when I select
the element I can right away see both of
these tags and again the extension is
this one now once you install
probably your results are going to be
tiny bit different just because I
customized the way it looks so let me go
here to the settings Json and showcase
that
and again
remember repo I shared that's where you
can get the code so let's keep on
scrolling and notice over here I have
this
highlight matching tag Styles and then I
added these values and essentially if
you want to know your options just
navigate to the docs of the extension
essentially in there they provide all of
the details
so those are the easy ones now let's
actually start working with some heavy
lifters
first one is prettier which is really
awesome because it formats the code
so if I go back to index.js and if I do
something silly like this again there's
technically nothing wrong with my code
but imagine
if all my files look like this
I mean you would have to agree that it's
somewhat annoying so once I save check
it out
everything is back
to tip top shape why well because I use
this extension by the name of prettier
once you install this extension you'll
also need to add some modifications to
the settings Json so let me showcase
that as far as the settings we have two
options so essentially we have this the
GUI
this is where we can basically see and
then we have settings Json where
essentially we add rules
to the Json file
now as far as the settings the ones that
I prefer are format
and then I have format on paste and
format on Save and also very very
important otherwise it's not going to
work you wanna
set up your default formatter as a
pre-year so let me go back over here
and then we want to go with default
format yep over here notice I selected
prayer so this is what you need to do
most likely you'll have this none and if
that's the case it's not going to work
even after you install it and then once
you select this once you go with
prettier in settings Json
essentially you will have no that's for
the Emma that's not what I want to do
with my showcase 3M is probably going to
be easier you'll see editor for my own
paste format on Save yada yada then we
have this one the default formatter and
then these are just the rules that I
applied again you can search for them
here in the GUI or you can add them
directly here in settings Json so as you
can see my preference is the single
quote and I don't use the semicolons so
if I change that around of course
allow the double quotes and I'll have
the semicolons
this is totally
again up to you you don't have to use
the same settings
then we've got Emmett so throughout the
course you'll see me
essentially do something like this where
I go with heading 2 and let's say if I
want to go with an ID I go with the
hashtag and I'm going to call this I
don't know something something over here
and then if let's say I want to add a
class I'm going to go with DOT so this
adds a class and again this is going to
be some value
and check it out I right away have this
option where I simply need to press
return or the Tab Key at least that's my
setup
in some cases students have said that
they only can use tab in some cases they
say that they can only use return again
that's something that you need to check
in my case I can use either of them and
notice the moment I press the enter or
tab I right away have this value now
we'll discuss why this is a class name
not a simple class a little bit later
don't focus on that one but I'm simply
trying to say is that
in order to speed up development
effectively I'm not going to type the
opening tag and the closing tag
essentially I'm just going to type what
element I want to add and then e-file
use some classes I'm just going to go
Dot and then the class name the class
name or the ID now these are not going
to be that often but classes for sure
will do this way so we go with heading 2
and now let me again type my first and
then component
and essentially this is done by Emmett
and Emmett comes by default
in vs code so it's right away available
however
if we want Emma to work
in react we need to add this code
to our Json
now you can also search for it in the
GUI but to tell honestly I find this
approach
more straightforward or basically you go
with press code and once you add it
you're going to be good to go if you
want you can copy it from my readme or
you can just pause the video and type it
that's really up to you just make sure
that you have this code there's the
Showcase that I'm not making this up
I'll try to find it yep it's over here
so I'm at include languages and we want
to add JavaScript and then JavaScript
react and once you do that Emmett is
going to work in react effectively
in our component and I guess the last
thing I want to cover in this video is
the awesome snippet extension and this
is super super super
helpful extension uh you're looking for
this one now I'm too lazy to say the
whole name just look for es7 and then
somewhere there you'll see Snippets and
essentially this
allows us
to set up our components really fast so
remember I said this is going to be our
typical component
we don't have to type it ourselves and
we haven't covered
the exports and imports and all that but
I'll showcase the typical setup so let's
navigate to the source and we want to
create a new file so every time we'll
need a new component
we'll create a new file because
components sometimes can be really big
again this is really up to you if you
want to jam all your components in one
file who am I to judge you so let's go
here with new file and we can go with
uppercase or we can go with lowercase
just remember that the extension
essentially
is going to
set up the component
based on file name so I'm in a testing I
have installed this extension so
everything's in play I don't need to
add anything
to the settings Json pretty much once
your install you're good to go and then
you'll see in the dark that they have
tons and tons and tons and tons of
Snippets that they provide and
essentially you just want to click on
Snippets
and then be prepared to spend the rest
of the day going through those Snippets
so I'm not going to cover all of them of
course you can
spend some time in the darks what we're
gonna use pretty much all throughout the
course
r a f c e which is a arrow function
right away with export and then
rfce which is a regular function with
the export so if we go to the testing
once we have installed the extension
notice I have essentially right away
these Snippets so this is going to
create a component as a arrow function
and notice how the names match
and if I go with the other one
if I go here with the r
f
c e this is going to create a regular
function now don't let this fool you
notice over here how we're using the
lowercase
it's only going to work because we will
import it and we'll set it up with the
uppercase
and therefore for the most part you'll
see me essentially setting up files with
the uppercase right away so that way I
know that there are going to be no issue
now one last thing that I want to
mention about this particular extension
is that once you initially install it
most likely you'll see this import for
react on top of the file and I think
probably is going to be faster if I just
showcase the settings one so
let's navigate to the settings we're
looking for react Snippets and we have
this import react so let me navigate
there so settings here
then we want to go with react Snippets
and notice over here how my one is
unchecked
most likely once you install it it's
going to be checked
so in here notice it says that we need
to restart vs code and all that
and effectively what's going to happen
pretty much every time you run the
snippet again doesn't really matter
which one you'll get this import react
from react now that used to be
the older syntax so prior to react
version 17
we had to also right away import react
we don't have to do that anymore now if
you have the import
there's nothing wrong with that
so
the code is not going to be wrong just
because you have the import
but since technically we don't need to
import essentially we can set up our
Snippets extension to avoid importing
react for pretty much every component
and again
if you navigate to settings GUI look for
react Snippets and then you just need to
uncheck it yep again we'll have to
restart the vs code and just to Showcase
that I'm not making this up I'm going to
remove the testing one
let me create a new file I'll say test
over here
JS and now let me run the snippet I
actually prefer
the arrow function syntax so most likely
throughout the course
that's the syntax that I'm going to use
and now check it out I don't have any
import for react again there's nothing
wrong if you do but I just showcased how
we can remove that and also my component
name matches exactly to my file name so
those are my extensions as well as
settings Json setup in the long run it
will greatly speed up your workflow
and now we're ready to dive back into
the awesome world of react all right and
up next let's see how I react
create jsx under the hood
and first let me just reiterate the main
rules that we want to start with capital
letter
as far as our component and we must
return something now it looks like in
the latest version
if we don't return anything it doesn't
throw an error
but it used to do that in the previous
versions however if you're not returning
anything from component it kind of
defeats the entire purpose for the
component and as far as the jsx if you
find the whole syntax super weird let me
just reiterate that
the whole idea is to make our lives
easier
technically if we want to we can call
create element which essentially
is what the react is doing under the
hood but I'm pretty sure that by the end
of this video
you'll probably agree with me that using
jsx is a little bit easier so let's
navigate to index.js and this video
might be a little bit annoying because
I'll comment this one out the first one
since I don't wanna
essentially create two separate
components and then change the values
here as well so let me showcase how we
can create a component by calling react
dot create element because remember
react is a JavaScript library so
essentially under the hood we are using
JavaScript we are calling this method
but in order to make our lives easier we
can actually type here jsx
so first let me just
copy this comment this one out and let
me showcase that I can go here with
return
and I can type react Dot and then create
element and then here we need to provide
three things
what element we want to create
perhaps which we haven't covered so for
now we'll just pass in empty object and
then what value is going to be inside of
that element so let's try this one out
I'm going to go with heading 2. or pass
in the empty props empty object and I'll
say the typical hello world let me save
it and everything works
okay well that's awesome
but keep in mind that
our components are not going to be as
straightforward as this one what if
let's say I want a div and then inside
of the div I'm gonna have the heading 2.
like I said this video
is going to be a little bit more
annoying than the usual ones because
I'll toggle them back and forth
so if I want to do that I can simply go
here with a div
so so let me type the div tag and then
I'll place that heading 2 inside of it
so let me take this one out
set it up and of course technically
since it's a div we don't see that but I
can guarantee you
that the element exists
so if we take a look at the root notice
so I do have the div and then I have the
heading to
so the next question is well how we can
set this one up with create element
well
check it out
we need to go to react create element
then since the parent now is div that's
what we're creating again same deal with
the props don't worry about them just
empty object
and then since the heading 2 is sitting
inside of it again we type react dot
create element and then we pass
the data and hopefully you see where I'm
going with this
I mean you can have maybe 20 50 or
whatever elements in here in this one
component
and what do you think is going to be
easier
typing the HTML AKA jsx
or during these acrobatics now I'm not
going to set up the code if you want you
can copy and paste and you'll see that
yes it still works but you'd have to
agree with me as weird as it looks the
first time you see this kind of approach
in the long run
it's going to be easier
and more straightforward than calling
bunch of react dot create elements
all right and up next let's talk about
the jsx rules
so before we discussed the rules for the
components and again I'll repeat capital
letter and we need to return something
now let's talk about djsx rules so
essentially the stuff that we are
returning let's start with this one we
always always always always always need
to return a single element basically one
parent element so if we take a look at
our return
we can go here as wild and crazy as we
want so let's imagine that I want to go
here with div inside of the div I decide
that there's going to be a heading 3 and
in there I'll say hello people after
that we want to go with another list
in there there's going to be a list item
inside of the list item I'm gonna go
with that href for now I'm just gonna
add the
over here don't worry there's probably
going to be a warning in the console we
don't really care about it and let's say
over here
hello world
let's save it and as you can see
everything works there are no issues and
as I say not I don't want this one over
here however problems are going to start
if for some reason I understand that you
know what right next to this div I need
to have a heading too so not inside of
the div but right next to it
check it out right away I have this red
squiggly line pretty much running all
throughout my code why because we cannot
we cannot return in jsx
adjacent elements so we always always
need to return a one parent element so
what's the solution
first let me type some kind of code
I'm gonna go with hello world and
effectively what we want to do is to
wrap both of them
so for now I'm just gonna go with div
and I'll talk about why maybe it's not
the best way but let me grab the opening
and closing tag and check it out the
moment we save everything works again so
I know I already said this
a thousand times we need to return one
parent element so once we refactor we
are good to go now this is not a rule
but keep in mind that
whatever elements we set up they
actually live in the browser
so we are actually returning them it's
not like we're just making them up in a
code notice I have div div and then
heading two so again this is not a rule
if you're
favorite element is div you can
definitely do show who am I to judge but
I do suggest
sticking with HTML semantics where we
can use the section element we can use
the article and of course whatever
element you want to create so for nav we
can use nav footer header and hopefully
you see where I'm going with this again
it's not a rule if you want to add I
don't know 100 divs in your component
absolutely
react is not going to complain about it
however
as far as maintaining the code it might
be an issue down the road again just a
suggestion and also another approach we
can take if let's say you don't want to
add any semantic elements and you're
also maybe not in a fan club of div you
can add fragment
so fragment allows us to group elements
without adding those extra nodes and
essentially we have two ways that we can
use that we can go with react Dot and
then fragment so notice the syntax it's
kind of like a component opening and
closing one or there is a shorthand so
in here we can go with angle brackets
and we just need to make sure that we
close it so let's try it out I'm going
to go back to index.js let's say that I
don't want to go with Section which is
also an option of course so once I save
here notice now the section is returned
not a div
but if let's say I'm not a fan of that
type of approach I can just remove the
code and I can go to react Dot and then
fragment so we're importing react that's
something you'll need to do then if
that's the case and we go with react dot
fragment and once we save notice
that essentially
there's not that extra div so we have ID
root
but we don't have that div
type of syntax we only have this one div
that we have over here and like I said
the shorthand is following just remove
the stuff and everything is going to
work
after that let's talk about the camel
case property naming convention
if you're familiar when it comes to
attributes in the index.html
you write them in a following way for
example tab index on click
for read-only when it comes to jsx
don't be surprised if you see the camel
case property naming convention please
don't worry about this code effectively
what it's doing the values and all that
just focus on naming here so instead of
tab index we're going to type tab index
as a camel case if we want to use 4 for
the label in the jsx we'll use html4
again those are just the rules and of
course as we're progressing on the
course every time
we'll add that chemical case property
I'll tell you hey this is the rule that
we need to use and this is just
something that you need to remember
again please don't focus on this code
I'm not going to type it we're going to
cover all of this in great detail
essentially while we have those funny
curly brackets and all that for now just
don't be surprised if you see this type
of naming convention
also speaking of naming conventions we
don't have class something that I
already showed you when we work with
Emmett so if I go back and to this
device I want to add some kind of class
it's not going to be class so you can
type here like this but it's not going
to work we need to go with class name
again just the rule that we need to
remember that's it we need to go with
last name and then we provide some kind
of value over here some class name and
then if we take a look
somewhere there yep notice
eventually in the browser
it's set up as a class but in our code
it's going to be a class name and up
next let's discuss how we need to handle
elements that don't have the closing tag
so as you know in HTML we have some
elements that do have closing tags and
some that don't for example image or
input and HTML5 has somewhat spoiled as
well
if we want we can now omit the
self-closing and everything is going to
be rendered just fine however we cannot
do that in react all the elements that
don't have the closing tag we need to
self-close them so essentially you need
to add this forward slash
otherwise you'll get an error so if I
navigate over here and let's say I'm
gonna go with input now say text if I
remove the forward slash I'll right away
get the narrow
so make sure if you use the element that
doesn't have the closing tag
to self close it and lastly let's talk
about the formatting as you've probably
noticed
when it comes to return sometimes
we have these parentheses
and sometimes there are no parentheses
so what's up with that
well you see parentheses are here to
help us
technically you don't need to use them
so now let me go back to the heading 2.
and let's say hello world I save and
everything works however if
by mistake
I move this to the next line You'll see
that it right away gets grayed out
and essentially we'll have no content in
the browser so if you're not using
parentheses you need to make sure
that your opening tag is in the same
line as return so set it up here
and I removed one character and then we
can do whatever we want so again we save
it and then of course previous format
for us if you have parentheses you don't
need to worry about it and a friendly
suggestion keep in mind that we are
using prettier so a lot of times per
year we'll add them or we'll remove them
so
I wouldn't suggest stressing about it
just something to keep in mind so notice
over here if I have those parentheses it
doesn't really matter where the opening
tag is I save it and prettier removes it
for me anyway just keep in mind the
general concept if you want to add them
add them if not make sure that the
opening tag is in the same line as the
return okay and up next let's discuss
whether we can Nest components and the
short answer
is yes and let's also see how we can do
that
so if I go back to my index.js
um let's say I decide that my component
is going to be more complex I'll add a
div
I'll say inside of the dev heading 2 and
I'll call this John Doe and then right
below it we're gonna go with paragraph
This is my message
and then down Route I decide that you
know what
these pieces are reusable
or I just want to simplify this file I
don't want to have the setting to and
paragraph
how I can set this value in a different
component and then render that component
well when you start by creating a
component and I'll purposely set up
two Arrow functions one is going to be
implicit return
so basically without the curlies and the
other one is going to be with the curly
braces just to Showcase that yes of
course it is possible so let's start
here with const so that's my first
component person and this is where I'll
set up that implicit return I'll say
Arrow function and essentially what I
want to return is this
I'm gonna go with my adding two
then let's copy and paste and now let's
set up that message in this case though
we will go
without curly so now we do need to
provide explicitly that return otherwise
it's not going to work basically we're
not going to be adding anything here so
let me move this sucker up let me say
return and now of course I want to
change this I'm going to grab
and I want to copy and paste so I have
three components now I have the greeting
I have the person as well as the message
so how we can nest
components well we simply need to
reference the name
and again same rules apply that's where
we go here with this Capital case and
also remember we cannot just place them
side by side
so we will have to set up some kind of
parent now in my case that's div
remember
you can go with some other
element as far as HTML semantics or you
can go with react fragments so for me
I'm just going to keep the div basically
we just want to reference we want to go
here with person
and then we also want to display the
message NES before you ask
we can Nest another
50 000 components inside of these ones
so imagine
you go here you'll create more
components you'll Nest them here and
then all of them are going to be
displayed eventually in the greeting and
effectively this is how our applications
are going to look like
so have that root one
so single root component the convention
is to name it app but you don't have to
and inside of it we Nest rest of our
components
so all the components we need for our
app
for example inside of the app we missed
a page component which contains more
components navbar sidebar and a header
now
those components might or might not have
their own nested components and
hopefully you see where I'm going with
this
we inject our root component in a div
with an ID of root in the index.html
which is located in the public folder
and as a result our app is nicely
displayed in a browser regardless
regardless whether it has 5 or 300
components okay and up next let me
showcase a awesome extension for the
browser which effectively will allow us
to see our component structure so for
that I'm actually going to open up a new
browser
tab just so you can see it on full
screen then we want to look for these
three dots
more tools and then extensions now in my
case of course
the extensions are you present but since
I wanna
showcase how we can get one I'll remove
it
then we go over here
Chrome web store
and let's search for react
developer and then tools
get it over here
yep we want to add it ADD extension
and once everything is in place now
let's navigate to a local host 3000 and
once we do that we can close this tab
then inspect
and you'll see this components tab
once you install the extension you'll
have this one and now check it out now
it does complain about the strict mode
so you'll see this warning over here
don't worry about it everything works
fine and we'll discuss the strict mode a
little bit later so check it out this is
our root component the greeting again we
haven't discussed the props and all that
and functionality don't worry about it
for now just focus on this
so we can clearly see our component
structure and this is super useful
once your apps become big and complex
since it's much easier to troubleshoot
you can literally pinpoint the component
and then see what is happening inside
again the extension is react developer
tools and if you haven't installed it
already just go to Chrome web store and
set it up on your browser all right and
I think at this point we have acquired
enough knowledge to start working on our
first project the Amazon best sellers
effectively a list of best selling books
and of course in the process we'll cover
more interesting react topics for
example how to add CSS how to handle
images
what are the props just to name a few
and our goal is to implement some of the
features
from this Amazon page now of course
We're Not Gonna recreate the whole page
but the main features will try to
recreate using react
and we're going to start actually with
the structure
so in the index.js I want you to create
a book component where technically you
can call it whatever you want and then
in there
let's just set up three components now I
can tell you right away that later we
will refactor
to one component it's only one book
component we're starting this way just
because I want to emphasize one more
time
the way you set up the application is
really up to you there is no rule that
says
you have to do one way or the other way
if you want to create component for
every single element
you can definitely do so if you want to
jam your entire application in one
component that's also an option
so a lot of times it really comes down
to a preference so first
we'll create three components notice
effectively we're just returning some
elements here
and then eventually we will refactor it
so I have the book component and there I
have few more components and then I have
book list component
which we actually
render
so this is the one that we pass into a
so let's set up this one and then we'll
get the values from the Amazon so first
let me navigate to the index one so at
the moment I have this greeting and all
that
I won't need this I'm going to go with
const and let's start over here with
book and list so that's my component
essentially it's going to be a section
so let's set up a return over here
and for now it's going to be an empty
section so there's not going to be
anything in there then let's remove
these two and now let's set up that
component so const book that's the
component as far as return we're gonna
go here with an article so we're setting
up the article for the book and then
inside of the book component will render
three more components and also in a
process I want to showcase that yes
essentially we can Nest as many levels
deep as we want so notice in here we
have book list then book is going to be
rendered inside of it and then inside of
the book we'll have three more
components and let's start I guess over
here with an image so I'm gonna go here
and since we don't have the values yet
I'm going to provide the heading 2 but
eventually of course it's going to be a
proper image element so let me change
this and I'm going to go with heading 2.
and we'll just say image Place holder
now I'm purposely showing multiple ways
how we can set up D components so notice
this is going to be implicit return
but we can also set up the explicit one
so first let me change around and say
that
second one is going to be title and here
we're looking
forward heading two so that doesn't
change we only want to change the
content and I'm just gonna write here
title and then last one is going to be
the author author and in order to make
it more interesting let me just cut it
out let me set up the curlies and let's
go to the return
as you can see
the result is exactly the same
we'll have some elements rendered on the
screen
it really comes down to our preference
so it's not going to be a image
placeholder we'll type over here
author let's save it and we want to move
up now we want to render all three
components so let's start with the image
then we want to go with our I believe
what title
over here and then last one is going to
be the author and then in the book list
let's move up
and let's say that we want to render a
book
for now let's just render one book
component and then we'll worry about the
rest of them so let's save and in here I
still have the greeting so I want to
change that one around let's go with
book list once we save check it out so
this is the result
essentially I have these three elements
rendered on the screen and we can
definitely see that if we go to elements
and notice here this is the root like I
said this is going to be our entry point
and then I have the section and in there
I have the article and before we even
get the values let me showcase something
really cool so in react if I just copy
and paste basically if I set up more
instances of this book component notice
now of course they're right away
rendered on screen and what's even more
cool
if let's say I decide that you know what
it's not going to be a book title
what if I want to go with title
of the book
you can save it and check it out all the
component instances right away have that
value again really really cool that we
don't need to run around
and change those values manually
effectively we just change it in one
place and we're good to go so we're done
with the structure
now let's go back to read me and see
what we need to do
so essentially you have a few options
you can go to your search engine and
type Amazon best-selling books or you
can follow this link now of course if by
the time you're watching this the link
doesn't work I mean the
companies change their resources quite
often so if you navigate to this link
and it doesn't exist then of course
you'll have to search for it the reason
why I'm providing the link
is simply because
that way you can work with the same
exact list since Amazon has
quite a lot of those lists out there now
you'll still be able to follow along
don't worry about it I'm just saying
just in case you want to work with the
same exact list I'm providing a link and
before we continue let me make something
extremely extremely clear
you won't have to buy anything there
again you won't have to buy anything
from Amazon and second this is not some
kind of lame attempt to trick you into
using an affiliate link
this is not an affiliate link it's
literally just the URL to the list that
I'm using I want to make this extremely
clear
and essentially we're just using it
because I don't want to come up with
these values I want to provide the real
values so once I'm done with this boring
round now let me navigate
to my list and again you can actually
copy and paste here or you can click
command and then
follow the link just remember that if
you have the same setup it's going to
open over here so of course that's why
I'll grab this one
navigate copy and paste and unless by
the time you're watching the video
Amazon has already removed the page this
is what you should see obviously your
values might be different but the idea
is going to be exactly the same
and effectively this is where we want to
grab those values I want to start with
image then I want to get the
title and after that I want to get the
author now I'm going to open them
because it's going to be easier to copy
and paste the values and let's start
with an image so essentially here's what
we want to do we're going to go to copy
image address and once it's saved in the
clipboard let's navigate back to
index.js and where we have the
placeholder now let's go with that image
tag and then let's provide those values
so in here we want to go with the source
and source is going to be equal to
whatever URL
we have in a clipboard and then as far
as the alternative well I'm going to
provide the title for that
so in order to get the title I already
opened a book in a new tab so let me
navigate here now I'm not going to grab
the whole thing
it's kind of a Overkill let me just copy
and paste here the title
and the same here with the heading too
and lastly we want to get the author
which I believe the fastest way is just
a copy like this
so let me provide here where I have the
heading for let's save it and yes it's
gigantic and all that don't worry we'll
add a little bit of CSS later and
essentially we'll fix the issue again
the cool thing is that
since we set up multiple book instances
you're gonna right away see that they're
rendered on the screen and whatever
changes will make in the individual
components will right away
be displayed on the screen now we don't
need that many book instances so you
know what for now why don't we just
leave four simply because we'll be
setting up a grid layout pretty soon so
if you have the same result
we're good to go and in the next video
we'll take a look how we can add CSS to
our react project beautiful at this
point we know how we can render HTML
but what about CSS
because as you can see I mean it's cute
to have this kind of list but
you probably agree with me that it does
require some CSS and essentially it's
not as difficult as one might think
effectively we just need to create a CSS
file now as always name is really up to
you
but I'm gonna go with index CSS since my
JavaScript file is index.js we want to
set up the Styles and lastly we want to
import that in our index.js file now I
can tell you right away that
for bigger projects
most likely you'll have a folder with
CSS files
which again
is totally
okay
you can definitely do so you'll just
have to change the path if you want to
set up the entire folder with bunch of
CSS files you can definitely do so
they don't have to be separate files in
the source
and as far as the logic I just wanna
create a reset
and then add to a body
from family background and a color then
we'll import and then we'll worry about
the classes
so let's start over here so I'm going to
navigate to Source again if you want you
can create a folder just your path is
going to change I really want to
emphasize that
because I keep getting questions about
it so I want to answer them here so
let's start here with index CSS as
always if you want to call this banana
CSS
it's also a cool option let's go here
with that reset
so margin margin zero
batting zero
and box sizing equal to a border box
border box okay beautiful and then let's
select the body now of course as you're
looking at the browser you won't see any
changes
in order for those changes to take place
we do need to import so first let's just
set up those Styles we're gonna go here
with font family and I'm going to set it
equal to a system font slightly that is
actually
my preference then let's go with
background and we're gonna go with
hashtag F1 F5
and f8 okay so that's the gray one and
then as far as the color I'm gonna go
with hashtag 222
let's save it like I said the browser
still displays the same list and now
let's navigate to index.js and we want
to import that index CSS
now later when we import JavaScript
files you'll see that we don't need to
add extension
and for the most part we'll say what we
want to import whether that is some kind
of array or whether that is the
component when it comes to CSS we want
to grab the entire file and we must must
must must provide the file extension so
since I have index CSS in the index.js I
want to go with import and then like I
said we need to go with the path so
this is our own asset
these are assets that are coming from
the libraries so when it comes to
libraries we don't need to provide a
path libraries are installed so we just
need to provide the library name now
when it comes to our own assets we need
to provide a path to that asset and it's
always going to start with DOT now there
might be two dots if we have to go one
level up but one that means that we're
in the same folder
so in the same folder we go with Dot and
then forward slash and notice it right
away offers me the test now I don't want
to test instead what I want is index and
then Dot and like I said the entire
file name including the extension with
the JavaScript files you won't have to
do that and the moment we save we should
see some changes and check it out it
looks like
some changes were applied now it's kind
of hard to see so let me navigate to the
big screen so notice this is our Giant
image and then we have some text then
this is the background now if you want
to take a look as always
just go to developer tools and you'll
notice that we have some Styles already
okay awesome so now let's keep working
I want to style the book list and I also
want to style the book
my single component
and essentially we just want to add the
class
now of course you can style in the index
CSS like you normally would let's say if
you want to select the section but in
most cases you would use some kind of
class and we just need to remember that
in react there is no class so I'm gonna
go here with some value and if I'll save
if we navigate to the browser
in the console we should see invalid
down property Clash did you mean class
name
so yes when it comes to react if we want
to add a class in the jsx we need to go
with class name not just class and once
we do that
it's exactly the same as we normally
would in
HTML basically we add the class and
we're good to go we have the Styles and
we don't need to worry about anything
else just the name is a little bit
different and in here I'm going to go
with book list
so book list and then the same I'll
apply to the book
so let me copy and paste I want to go to
the article
and then instead of book list it's going
to be a book
and basically I want to set up some kind
of grid layout once we get to 768
um as far as the book well I just want
to add some background make sure that
the image sits nicely in the card as
well as add some styles to you a heading
2. so let's navigate back to index CSS
first let's just grab the book list I'm
going to set up the width to be 90 of
the screen width then Max width is going
to be 1170.
so it's always going to be at least 90
percent of the screen width but it's
never going to be bigger than 1170. I
want to add some margin top bottom five
Rems I want to place it in the center so
I'm going to go with Auto and then I'll
right away display grid
and as far as the gap for the rows and
the columns it's going to be two Rems
again
the problem right now is the image
since the size is quite big that's why
we have this look so you know what I'm
actually going to skip a little bit and
I'm just going to say book so now I'm
selecting the article that has the class
and you know what I'll right away add
this IMG so I'll select the image and
I'm just going to say that width should
always be 100 so now it will nicely fit
in our card and object fit is going to
be equal to a cover we save it and
notice now of course
our project looks more presentable now
back to the book list once we get to 768
I want to set up that three column
layout so in here let's go with media
media okay screen and we're going to add
a Min width
so let's go here with and and min
width and that is going to be equal to
seven
68 pixels so once we get to that screen
size
we'll have that three column layout so
book list here and then inside of it
let's go with grid template columns
that's the property repeat and three and
one fraction let's save it as you can
see on a small screen
there's no difference but once we get to
the big screen we have nice three column
layout and now let me just continue with
the book
first I want to add some background and
I'm gonna go with the white one so
hashtag FFF then we want to go with
border radius and that is going to be
equal to 1 Rems then we'll add a little
bit of padding
in my case I'm gonna go with two Rems
and then text align Center so Place
everything in the center
we already have the image one so so we
really need to focus on heading two
that's it so book heading two
and then margin top one REM and as far
as the font size I think I'm gonna go
with one Rems and now what I can do is
set up the zoom again to 175 since
everything is nicely displayed in the
browser and again if we take a look at
the
bigger browser window we can also see a
nice list so that's how we can add
the most basic CSS to our react project
we create a CSS file again I'm going to
repeat yes
can be index it can be shaken back CSS
whatever if you want to set up the
folder the only difference is when you
import then of course you need to start
with DOT since it's going to be in the
same folder then forward slash the
folder name and then the file
effectively we want to import everything
so later with JavaScript you'll see how
we're importing something specific from
the file whether that is component
whether that is a data but with CSS we
grab everything and we need to provide
always always a extension as well which
is not something we're gonna have to do
with the JavaScript files
with this in place now let's talk about
the images in react okay and once we
know how we can apply
CSS to our react project now let's talk
about images and I can tell you right
away that
it's an optional video technically if
you don't want to follow along you don't
have to but again it's the case where
I'm getting questions about it in the
course q a so I just thought that it's
very useful if I showcase everything
step by step
and essentially when it comes to images
we have three options
we have external images that are hosted
on a different server please keep
something in mind
this image
is hosted
on a different server
so
Amazon
essentially
is providing this asset so we're not
doing anything we just take this URL
and we provide it for our image tag and
you can definitely take this URL and
you'll see that this is the image
so hopefully that is clear that's our
first option so let's say when we'll be
serving our data from our own database
or getting some external API
if there's going to be an asset for
example image asset then there's always
going to be a URL that points back to
some kind of external server so that's
our first option
pretty straightforward correct just
provide the URL and we're good to go
and after that we have two options for
local images one in the public folder
which we're going to cover in this video
but since it's less performant
it's not something we're going to
implement in our projects
and then we have local images in the
source folder which is a better solution
for assets since under the hood they get
optimized so throughout the course we'll
stick with the source folder if we have
local images but since we haven't
covered the imports and exports and all
that and since we'll have to utilize the
S6 modules for that for now
we'll just put it on hold
but since I want you to be aware of this
option of public folder even though it's
not something we're going to implement
since it's less performant in this video
I'll show you how we can set it up again
I'm getting questions in course q a
so
I might as well cover everything step by
step and essentially the steps are
following we want to save the image it
can be any image but of course I'll use
same image
we want to create a images folder in
public now technically you don't have to
again create the folder but since in
most cases you'll have multiple assets
for your project it kind of makes sense
to set up the folder structure as long
as that image is in a public it's going
to be available so keep in mind
technically you don't have to have the
images folder and then we want to copy
and paste the image we downloaded
we want to rename it now that's totally
optional but in my case I'll do that and
then in a source where we have the image
stack we want to replace the URL
so instead of the external one we'll use
the internal one and in the process
you'll see that pretty much any asset we
add to the public is right away publicly
available hopefully that makes sense so
in my case I know that I'm going to call
this book one and in the source notice
I'm going to go forward slash images
because it's in the folder if it
wouldn't be in folder then of course I
would just go with DOT forward slash and
then the file name and then book and the
full extension so let's try this one out
I'm going to navigate here I believe I
can actually
get it from the source as well but just
to Showcase that of course
we can get it from the entire list let's
navigate here notice the save image as
option and I'm gonna go right away over
here and I'm gonna say book and one
let's save the file now it's on a
desktop I want to navigate
to my desktop I'm going to open up my
project
okay then very important we want to
place this in the public so not in a
source The Source option will cover
later we want to go with images
then we want to drag and drop this
sucker here and then this one over here
and once it's available you'll actually
notice
if you take the URL now
again in my case the name is following
but if you use a different name then of
course you need to use that one if you
take here this forward slash and added
to your localhost 3000 you'll see that
right away it's available so I have this
localhost 3000 so that's the server
that I'm working with notice if we copy
and paste
the full path so images and then book
and whatever extension if I press here
notice this is going to be my image so
whatever we place in the public right
away is publicly available and what that
means is that we can also use it in our
code
so now we just want to navigate back to
index.js
and instead of this external URL
we want to go dot forward slash
then images and then book one on the
extension so essentially whatever we
place over there
is immediately available in our code
as well as in the browser
again the reason why this is not a
popular option is because
these assets
don't get optimized so later when we'll
place our Assets in the source folder
under the hood they get optimized
and therefore
the end result is better our application
is faster
but yes
you also have an option to
put your assets in the public and then
access them in a code or provide them in
the browser and lastly I just want to
showcase that if you go back to your
project and again inspect the elements
you'll see now that the path
URL path actually goes back to our own
server and notice again this is going to
be the full path localhost so that's our
server then images and then book one
so since the image the asset is on the
same
server we don't need to go with the full
URL essentially we just need to set up a
path that is relative
to our public folder hopefully it's
clear and up next let's talk about CSS
in jsx all right and once we're familiar
how we can add
styles using external style sheet now
let's take a look how we can add CSS
in our jsx and effectively we just need
to pick the element
we want to apply our styles to and then
we need to go with style attribute and
we need to set it equal to the curly
braces
and essentially these curly braces just
mean that we're going back to the
JavaScript plan and we'll discuss them
in more detail in one of the following
videos when we cover the rules of jsx
basically when we cover how we can add
JavaScript to jsx for now just focus
that you need to provide the curly
brushes and then inside of it we need to
provide a JavaScript object so please
don't think that it's some kind of
special
react syntax where you need to go with
these double curlies no
effectively since we need to provide the
object here that's why I have this
result we always start with one curly
braces and then at the end of the video
I'll show you how we essentially can
just pass the reference to the object
now when God's about the object is that
it's a JavaScript object what that means
is that if you have a CSS property
that has The Hyphen you'll have to
capitalize and as far as the values
they'll have to be here as string so
let's try it out here I'm going to save
let's navigate to
index.js and let's look for a heading
four so like I said we go here with
style notice automatically it's set up
with the curly braces and here we
provide that JavaScript object
so let's start here with color and as
far as the value again key value Pairs
and then the values are as strings so
hashtag 617
and we want to go d98 then we want to go
with font size so let's add a comma not
a semicolon and go with font size and
that is equal to again
quotation marks
0.75
Rems by the way it looks like in the
readme I'm missing the RM part
so of course in your case that's not
going to be the case anymore so let me
save here and then
we're looking for a third one and that
is going to be margin and again we are
not going with margin hyphen top we go
here with margin top and we want to set
it equal to 0.5
Rems let's save it
as you can see the styles were applied
but one gotcha we need to be aware of I
guess one more gotcha we need to be
aware of
at the end of the day these are inline
styles
so what that means General CSS rules
apply
so what am I talking about well if let's
say
you'll try to select the same heading 4
in CSS and try to change the properties
that we already set up over here with
the inline one it's not going to work so
letter spacing yeah it's going to work
since we don't have it over here
but as far as the color if I try to go
with red it's not going to work and in
order to speed this up I'm just going to
copy
so we're going to go here copy and paste
the notice yeah the letter spacing
change but not the color now why am I
telling you that is because later
as you're progressing with react you'll
most likely start working with external
libraries
I don't know maybe a slider library or a
model Library whatever
and one thing to be aware of
those libraries do use inline Styles
here and there
some quite often some less so keep in
mind if you'll want to change some
styles that the library provides
sometimes it's not going to be enough to
just go to the CSS and change it
if the library is using inline Styles
you'll have to figure out how you can
modify those inline Styles and only then
you will be successful so don't get
frustrated if you install the library
and you try to
add your own Styles but it's not working
always always
first check the elements and if you see
the inline Styles you know that you'll
have to do more work and lastly I just
want to mention that yes there is an
alternative
remember
we're providing here a object now we're
writing JavaScript correct
so what we can do
well we can create one
and we can create the object here we can
create it outside of the component that
doesn't really matter and we can just
provide the reference notice how the
values don't change
values exactly are the same
the only difference is that now instead
of passing that object directly
we just set up the reference so let's
try it out I'm going to go to index.js
and this is the case where if you have
of course the implicit return you will
have to refactor to explicit since I'm
going to be setting up this object over
here so you won't be able to do that
with a title
but since the author is right away
set up as a explicit I'm good to go so
let me go here and set up that long name
so const and then inline heading
Styles and that is equal to my object
and effectively I'll just cut it out
here
I'll cut it out here copy and paste and
then we go with inline heading Styles
now the reason why I'm showing you that
is because again
if you'll work with someone else's code
you might see either of these Solutions
you might see the object passed in
directly or you might see them
separately and basically
this is the point that I want to make in
this video for the most part
there are multiple approaches available
so there is no right or wrong
if your preference is to set up the
objects and pass them in this way
go ahead and do that if not if you want
to pass them directly in the code that's
also an option as long as the result is
the same it really comes down to your
preference
now why we won't use the inline Styles
in this course because if you ever work
with inline Styles you know that they're
somewhat of a pain so yes it's a good
solution here and there but in general
you'll want to stick with external style
sheet maybe some CSS libraries and all
that because adding styles of course one
by one to each element is somewhat
painful but please be aware of this
option because you might see that in
someone else's code all right and up
next let's see how we can use JavaScript
in jsx so in the previous video we
covered CSS now let's talk about
JavaScript and before we continue I want
to refactor this to a single book
component and I'm not going to give you
the entire speech one more time
essentially my preference is to set up a
component with all of these elements so
this is exactly what I'm going to do but
yes
you can always split it up into more
components so I want to navigate back
and essentially where I have the book
I'll remove all of them and basically I
just want to grab the elements one by
one of course I'll remove the other ones
so let me take this one out
so this is going to be right after image
and I'm also not going to use this
inline setup essentially I'm going to
add that code in CSS
so let me take the heading 4.
I'll place right after heading 2. I'll
move the style
and effectively I just want to copy
these Styles and set it up in the index
CSS and in order to speed this up I'm
going to grab this code as you can see
pretty much the same properties and
values I just don't want to spend time
on typing them so let me navigate back
I'll move this one and copy and paste
and as far as the index.js well I want
to remove all of this so now I have book
list
with four book components and then I
have a book component
now the only thing is that I need to
remove this semicolon now let's talk
about jsx
and like we already discussed in the
previous video
if we add these curlies in jsx that
means we're going back to the JavaScript
land so essentially we can use our
vanilla.js logic inside of the curlers
now one big gotcha is that the value
must be an expression so essentially it
needs to return a value and of course
I'll show you the example and I'll also
show you what happens if we provide a
statement so there's a difference
expression returns a value statement
does not and let's just start by setting
up the variable somewhere here
and
I'm going to name this title and
effectively where we have the heading 2
with the title let's pass it in so
notice in here we go back
to the JavaScript so we set up the
curlies and since we have the variable
we can directly access it and you'll see
what are the benefits back in the index
.js
let's go over here and let's grab this
value
for the title so let's cut it out and
I'll set it up over here I'll say const
title and again you can set it up inside
of the component or you can set it up
outside of the component in the file or
you can set it up in a different file
and then import it we just haven't
covered the es6 modules yet so let's set
it equal to a string so that doesn't
change and now instead of
card coding here in the heading two
we're gonna go here with title and
effectively whatever changes we apply
right away will be displayed in the
browser so it's already somewhat Dynamic
now of course we're not getting the data
from somewhere else from the external
API for example and all that stuff but
we're already moving in the right
direction
so when you think of dynamic think of
less hard coding
so that's the first then let's take a
look how we can set up the author as
well
so now let me take this value and just
to Showcase that it's still going to
work
I'm gonna go here and let's come up with
a value author copy and paste and same
deal we go back
huge JavaScript land and we simply
provide the variable in this case
then let me show you some instances
where this is going to fail where
basically if we'll set up a statement
it's not going to work so first let me
go right after the heading four and
we're gonna go with paragraph So if
we'll write a statement and if we'll say
let X is let's say equal to 6. pretty
much right away you'll get an error and
you'll get these quickly lines again we
can only pass here an expression
and essentially the expression returns a
value now this is a side note but if we
want to comment something out in jsx we
need to go with this syntax and of
course there is a shortcut for that so
in my case that is command and forward
slash but if you want to see in your
operating system go to edit and notice
it's going to be toggle line comment so
that's how we can comment out and of
course once I do
notice I don't get the error and let me
showcase one more time with the new
expression so let's say if I have 6 plus
6 this is going to work because again
this returns some kind of value
hopefully that is clear so every time we
want to go back to a JavaScript
we just set up the curlies and we can
start applying our logic and lastly let
me just showcase that we can do more
than just accessing the variables of
course when it comes to Strings we have
a cool method by the name of two
uppercase so we can simply provide that
we can invoke it and as you can see we
don't get the narrow the author is now
in uppercase now I'm going to clean up
basically I'll just leave these
variables over here
and remove these ones just keep in mind
that if you ever need a reference you do
have a readme so let me remove this also
this one as well I also want to clean up
this gibberish
and up next let's talk about props in
react all right and up next let's talk
about props and why they're so useful
and also so powerful
first let's start by doing a little bit
of spring cleanup or essentially I just
want to set up three variables with all
of the values so for author title and
image and where I have the book
component I want to access them so
pretty much the same thing again we're
just not
hard coding anymore and yes I'll place
it above the book list and you'll see in
a few videos why so let me move the
sticker up first then I want to do the
same thing with the author and now let's
set up that image one so const
const time G is equal to
um let's just grab this string now copy
and paste and now where I have the
source what do we do we set up the
curlies so now we're back in JavaScript
plan and we provide the variable name
awesome then the same we're gonna do
with alternative
so let's just provide here title and
before we go any further let's discuss
parameters and arguments and as a note
you can actually take this code
set it up anywhere in the index.js
and
effectively is going to run so if I go
and inspect the console I should see job
and developer so in vanilla Jazz for
every function we can provide parameters
when we're setting up the function and
then when we invoke the function we
provide the arguments and then of course
whatever logic we have in this case is
just a log
gets executed okay hopefully we're clear
on that and now let me remove this code
so what does it have to do with react
well
but it also has to be some kind of way
how we can pass the data down to our
component because at the moment yes it's
nice yes we're using the variables and
all that but ideally of course you would
want different
books rendered in the browser correct so
at the moment we're pretty much
rendering the same but we need to come
up with a way how we can pass data
different data
to individual components so we have the
same structure but the data is going to
be different and the way we do that is
by using of the props object so every
component we create gets automatically
there's props object which essentially
is the parameter now we can call this a
shake and bake it's an awesome choice
but a common convention is calling this
props
so again it's provided right away by
default so we don't need to do anything
so instead of creating a component and
then saying yeah there's going to be a
param it's right away provided
so react effectively injects that
so if I type here props I know that this
props will automatically be passed down
to me and now let's go with log and we
have a few places where we can log that
we can log it here in the function body
again above the return if you place
anything after returns not going to run
or we can do that directly here in the
jsx so we can go with console and log
now I'll actually remove this one right
away
but I just want to showcase and you know
there's going to be too many console
logs so I'll go back to two books for
now
and then eventually we'll add more so if
you take a look at the console you'll
see four objects again the reason why we
have four because we have two console
logs and we have two components so if we
do two times two yes we have four and
check it out now for now it's an empty
object but that's already a good start
that means that we'll be able to access
something now we have not provided that
something
so we have an empty object but it is a
awesome start and the way we provide
those values is here
so again
props here when we set up the component
but then when we render the component
that's where we provide eprops and again
we'll start with the manual way where I
can go here with job and then equals and
then if it's string then we need to use
the quotation mark if it's a number or
variable whatever then we need to
provide the curlish so
in here I can go job developer
and as far as the second book why don't
we change things around I'm going to say
here random
title and then the second one will be
number like I said
when it comes to numbers we need to use
the curlies
if we have a string then we just use
quotation marks and if let's say we want
to provide here the variable same deal
curlies and then we can access it for
now let's just use the number I'm going
to say 22. and the moment I say like I
said I will remove this log there's no
need to over complicate things
now what I see in the console job
developer so this is an object
that's the props object
and then for the second one I have title
and number okay so this is clear now how
we can access those values
well
just like any regular object it's an
object these are the properties and
these are the values what do we normally
do in JavaScript we go with object dot
property correct same deal over here
now since these are extra props
basically since we're just testing I'm
going to add more paragraphs and I'll
copy and paste essentially the most
basic way we go here with the curlies so
we go back to the JavaScript plan and we
go with props job
then we want to set up props again we're
referencing the same object go title and
then we go with props and a number let's
save it and don't care about the console
right now but you'll notice that
basically
our components now have some extra
values
now one important thing if you don't
provide the prop
even though in your structure you're
accessing it
you have nothing there so notice how the
first component has the job prop with
this value I don't see it anywhere in my
second component why well because it's
not over here it's not present in the
second component so that's very
important
to remember
the prop will be only displayed if it's
actually provided
so the first one doesn't get the title
or number notice nothing is rendered in
the browser why well because we don't
provide them
so again
you'll have the structure
you'll provide the props and then you'll
be able to display them if the prop is
not provided
either you're not going to display
anything or you'll get an error let's
say if you're trying to access some kind
of value that doesn't exist please keep
that in mind
so that should do it for
the generic setup again
we provide here the prop name then we
provide the value now let's use the
author title and image
so instead of the testing ones now let's
actually provide those values so I'm
going to remove all these paragraphs
let's save and then one by one let's
provide them
so what is the first value author now as
far as the prop name does it have to
match here no
you can write banana but when you're
accessing that's when you have to go
with props.banana
so this is the name this is the value
and yes
a common of course convention is to use
the same one but it's not always
possible so we just go with author
author curlies we go back to JavaScript
and then we provide the variable and the
same thing over here title is equal to
battle and then lastly what do we have
we have the image same deal we provide
all of them and in order to speed this
up I'll grab this and I'll copy and
paste and once we have successfully set
up all the props now of course instead
of accessing these variables directly we
need to go with props dot image props
dot title and yes of course in the
following videos we'll take a look how
we can shorten this up
but for now object property object
property and effectively it matches
whatever we're passing here
so we want to go here with props dot
title and then we want to go with props
dot author once we save if everything is
correct we'll have the same list
but the difference right now of course
that we are providing these values
dynamically which is really cool but we
also need to keep in mind that if we
don't provide some specific prop well
we're not going to render anything on
the screen check it out since the second
book component doesn't get the image we
just see the alternative hopefully that
is clear and in the next video we'll
take a look how we can
make our setup more Dynamic all right
and once we're clear on the most
straightforward setup
now let's make things more interesting
and create two of those objects yes
we won't have totally Dynamic setup yet
that is still coming where basically
we'll just iterate over the list grab
the values and render everything on the
screen but at least we'll be moving in
the right direction so here's what I
want you to do first create a object
with
the same three variables we already used
in the previous one so author title and
image now create a object in my case I'm
going to call this first book and set
them up as properties
then
create a second object and essentially
just go to Amazon and get those values
and don't worry about the local image
just use the external one it's going to
be faster unless you really want to just
keep in mind eventually we'll still
switch back to a local
image option using source so it doesn't
really matter and then we'll see how we
can provide unique values
paste on our data so let's start working
on that where first in the index.js I
want to create two
objects I'm going to go here with const
and then first book that's the object
and then we want to grab all of those
values I'm not sure whether I'm going to
be able to just copy and paste so I'm
gonna do it this way so author then we
want to grab your title
that is equal to this one
and then lastly I have IMG
and that is equal
to list string value we can remove the
properties
and let's just add for sure that image
hopefully it's clear
uh we need to provide all of the props
okay that's good as you can see we get
an error since there are no properties
anymore don't worry we'll fix that in a
second
so now we want to copy and paste and
let's come up with a different name of
course we can have two variables with
the same name
then let's navigate
to our list
and I'm just going to look for some
other random book and as I said this one
actually is a very good book again this
is not
some kind of Amazon promotion I'm just
saying it is a good book so let me grab
the title I guess first
then we want to grab the
author by the way
collect something
we want to take the title here
provide so that's the author and then
lastly we want to get that image so I'm
gonna go with copy image address and we
just want to provide it here so copy and
paste and now instead of accessing the
variables we're gonna go with first book
or the second book so either of these
objects and we can probably put already
two and two together we'll use basically
one object
per component and essentially we just
want to access
those properties so instead of author
I'm going to go here with the first book
and in order to speed this up I'll just
set up multiple cursors in my case that
is with option and the mouse click and
I'll just say first
book Dot and then whatever property and
essentially we want to repeat
for a second component as well so again
same deal
we use multiple cursors
second book and then dot once we save
check it out now we have already a
dynamic list
again it's not totally Dynamic but we're
moving in the right direction and if you
take a look at our console log you'll
see the values that we're getting
so these are already different values
the structure is the same but since
we're providing different values to our
props the result that we see on the
screen is also different
structure is the same the result is
different since the values the data that
we're providing is different right and
up next let's take a breather and let's
discuss multiple approaches how we can
access props in the component and before
we continue
let me just make something extremely
clear there is no right or wrong
again I know you're probably sick of me
saying this but it really comes down to
your preference the reason why I'm
showing multiple approaches because I
want you to be aware
just in case you see that in someone
else's code
also in this video we will highly highly
highly lean on the the structuring
concept in vanilla Jazz and if you're
not familiar with the concept or if you
see
a feature during the video that maybe is
new to you I suggest watching this video
the JS nuggets playlist on my YouTube
channel and the link is over here and in
there we cover everything in vanilla.js
setup and in more detail and ensure the
structuring in vanilla.js just allows us
to pull out the properties
so we don't need to reference the object
anymore and in the long run it just
saves us time as far as the example
again if you want to copy and paste you
can definitely do so you can set it up
in the index.js but I'm just gonna
show you here in the readme that if we
have an object with some kind of
properties instead of doing this so the
object name and then the property we can
just pull them out so that's the the
structuring we need to reference of
course the main object and here we go
with whatever properties we want to pull
out and then in rest of the code
we just need to reference these two so
we don't have to go anymore with some
object and then dot name and in our case
it just allows us to do this
where we have the perhaps object and
instead of going props.props dot props
dot we can simply go with props pull out
the properties that we know exist over
there again
let me repeat one more time you cannot
magically access the prop if it's not
there so if you don't provide when you
set up the component
it's not going to be there
hopefully that is clear and essentially
then we can just go with the property
name so let's try it out let me navigate
here
I know that I'll access over there
three
props
so object with three properties image
title and author
and that is equal to a propped object so
what do we need to do well now we just
need to remove
all the prop instances that's it let's
save and if everything is correct the
result is going to be exactly the same
the difference well we need to type less
we just reference these properties once
and we're good to go now alternatively
and this is something that I do discuss
in the video so again if this is new to
you I strongly suggest referencing that
video we can also destructure
in function parameters so in our case
that's the props object now keep in mind
though once we do that if you'll try to
cancel log props it's not going to be
defined so what am I talking about well
this is a function
right
and at the moment we have props
parameter now since it's an object we
destructured inside of the function body
instead I'm going to say all right I
know that the object is going to be
there and I right away want to pull
these properties out
Again Properties need to match exactly
and everything
but essentially we don't need to add
this line of code we can do directly
here in the function parameters let's
remove this
save and check it out again everything
still works and like I mentioned
in the beginning of the video it really
comes down to your preference you'll see
some people who use this type of setup
and you'll see some that implement this
one and it really comes down to
what is your preference
which code makes the most sense to you
at the end of the day they deliver the
exact same result instead of using
props.props.props Dot we just grab the
prop
and set it up in our jsx okay and up
next let's discuss special prop in react
called children
which provides access to everything we
render
between component tags as I say note the
goal of this video is just to showcase
the general concept of children prop
since honestly at least during the
course we'll only use it when we need to
set up context API
so if by the end of the video you're
still iffy on some stuff or just don't
see bunch of use cases for children prop
it's totally okay
we'll return to this concept
when we cover context API
and essentially let's imagine this
scenario what if for some reason
I want to render paragraph and a button
in one of the components it doesn't
really matter which one just one of them
well you can say we can go to a book
component let's add some dummy text
and let's also add a button
and let's just say click me let's save
and everything is awesome but of course
since we're adding it
to the component all the instances get
the paragraph as well as the button
so what's the solution well we could
render it
in between the tags we just need to pick
the component so in my case I'm gonna go
with the second one or I'm sorry I'm
working with the first one I'm telling
you the second one so I want to do that
with the first one but again it doesn't
really matter which one we just want to
create a opening and closing tag
then and as I know this is the incorrect
syntax we want to do it this way and
then place the paragraph and the button
in between those Stacks so let's get it
out here
and let's set it up and the moment I
save I actually don't see them in any of
the components so what's up with that
well you see
if we want to render something that is
between the component tags we need to
use a special prop
and the name is children
now before we access the children let me
just make something really clear
since we're already destructuring in the
component since we're accessing the
object we'll need to provide the prop
over here
now if you still have this setup where
you have props you can log it and you'll
see the children and that's why I will
switch to this one to the second
approach just so you can see that one
component
has the props and the other one doesn't
again you can use either of these
approaches just remember that children
is going to be over here
if you're destructuring right away in
the parameters so let me just showcase
that so we go here with children prop
and the name must be exact so don't type
here children like this don't say
children's or whatever no it has to be
children's so this is an extremely
important point it's a special prop
provided by react so we cannot use
whatever name we like we have to use
children and if we want to render the
children we simply go with curlies and
then
access the prop let's save it and now
you'll notice that the first one has the
paragraph as well as the button
now we can move this up and down as we
like so let's say if I want to place it
on top just render Children First
again there's really no rule for it
really depends on your setup and now let
me refactor it just so we can see
basically a props and that way I can
showcase the children so let me cut this
one out I'll say Here Comes copy and
paste let's set it equal to props
props over here and let's log it
so let's go over here with log and let's
say props
and once I open up the developer tools
and console notice over here
so I have two objects but the first one
actually has this children
so notice special prop and essentially
we just need to set it up in our jsx now
the second one doesn't have that
children prop
so as a result it doesn't render
anything
wait let me just showcase how it's going
to look like on a big screen so
basically we have these two cards and
optionally
if you want to
set up your cards in a way that they're
not stretching we just need to add a
little bit of CSS logic so
let's navigate to index CSS
we have book
heading four again I'm not going to keep
that paragraph and a button but just in
case
you want to keep it for your reference
we can add here margin
1 RM 0 and 0.5
so that's for the paragraph and then
if you want all your cards to
basically start at one point and just
end where the content ends you can go
here with align items and start and
essentially or at least it should work
not the line itself sorry align
and items and then start and once you
say notice so essentially your cards are
just going to be spanning as much as the
content instead of stretching so by
default
when it comes to CSS grid it stretches
all the items so if this one has a bunch
of content then this one will also
stretch like I said in my case I'm not
going to keep it if you ever need a
reference you can always find it in the
readme so I'll leave I guess the props
in such a way but I'll remove the
children
I'll move children over here I'll keep
the log because
pretty often we use it and now let me
remove the paragraph as well as the
button so that's the general concept
behind children which again essentially
allows us to access everything we are
rendering between the component tags
okay and now let's finally set up a
proper list and iterate over it which
will be our actual setup in all the
course projects
and most likely in all your other
projects as well so yes finally we have
arrived at the list which is going to be
our typical approach as they said now
during this video we'll utilize the rain
method called map and if you're not
familiar with it please reference this
JavaScript nuggets video where I cover
it in great detail
and essentially we'll start with
refactoring
first
I want to create an array in my case I'm
going to call it books and then let's
remove everything from the book list
and after that I'll show you an error
that we're gonna get if we try to render
objects so let's get cracking I'm going
to navigate back
I have two objects now I want to place
them in the array
so I'm going to say const and books so
that's my array and now let's Place both
of these objects in there so we don't
need the names anymore basically we can
just remove this
and this we can add right away comma
and we can remove this part as well as
the semicolon so now I have my structure
effectively I have an array
of items and each item is that object
now also we right away want to remove
everything that we have in the book list
otherwise of course we're going to get
the error and now let me showcase what
happens if we try to render objects in
react so if I go with the correlation so
I'm going back to JavaScript and I'm
going to say box so I want to access the
books variable
and then if we take a look at the
console we'll see these giant error
messages and essentially here's the deal
in react we cannot render
object directly in the jsx and I'm
purposely showing you this error because
throughout your react Journey
when you work with data here and there
you might see this error so the first
thing you want to do is double check the
data that you're rendering
if you see objects are not valid as
react child blah blah blah blah that
means
you need to double check your data
essentially somewhere in your data you
have an object and we cannot directly
display it in jsx now what's the
solution well eventually we'll use map
method we'll iterate over pull out the
properties
and one by one basically pass them to a
book component but before we do that
let me just show you step by step how we
can work with arrays in react so first
let me just remove this error again for
time being we won't see anything on
screen
and let's just create a basic array
let's say const names noun is equal to I
don't know John Peter and Susan why not
I'm not being particularly original but
hey it's Thursday and I think that
regular names are good enough if you
want to go on shake and bake Bobby Lee
of course you can do that and if I'm
gonna go back to my book list and if I'm
gonna change and I'll say names once I
save I can see that everything is nicely
displayed on the screen
so we can definitely render array
but most likely you will agree with me
that
it would be nicer if we could wrap these
values in some kind of HTML because
essentially at the moment I just have
here this string so again yes I'm going
to go back to the root I'll take a look
at the book list and notice effectively
I just have these string values
so how we can wrap this in some kind of
element
so instead of displaying these strings
essentially we'll display elements well
this is where the map method is going to
come into play
so let me show you first in the readme
basically react method creates a new
array from calling a function for every
array element so
I have names array I can use the map
method and I'm going to call a callback
function for every item in the array and
this is going to return a new array
and eventually
we'll wrap
our items
the moment these strings
in the heading one so let's try this one
out back in the index.js I'm going to go
here with const and then new
names then let's set it equal to names
map so again this returns a new array we
pass in the Callback function and
essentially the first parameter
references the item so if the item is
going to be an object it will reference
the object if the item is string
it's going to reference that string and
hopefully we are on the same page and
since it's a parameter we can name it
whatever we want in my case I'm going to
call this name and yes this is the case
where you can call this a vegetable as
long as you reference it correctly
you'll be good to go before we do
anything let's just see what are those
values so console log what do you know I
have John Peter and Susan so those are
the string values
and what's really cool that we can
effectively just set up a return
and we want to return a HTML element
wrapping that specific
string of course with objects it's going
to be a little bit different but for now
we simply want to go here with return
and then whatever element you want in my
case I'm going to go with heading one
and now I want to access it so now I
want to say you know what grab me this
name parameter and before we render
anything let me just showcase what is
the value for new names let's save it
and in the console you'll see a new
array which is of course awesome and
then check it out
now I have those react elements
so essentially instead of doing this
manually
we iterate over the list
we wrap it in some kind of element and
we're good to go and as a result
basically we can just replace names with
new names
save it and what do you know now I
actually have three heading ones with
these values and as you can see this
right away
opens up a lot of doors
because this truly is a dynamic setup I
have some kind of data which is a list
and I can iterate over that list
and return
whatever HTML structure I want to see on
a screen now don't worry about this key
prop
erly we'll fix this warning in few
videos also I want to mention that since
we have this option to go back
to JavaScript land essentially you can
also take this code and right away write
it over here remember we are looking for
expression so we want to get some kind
of value back and essentially with map
this is what we're getting so if you
don't like setting up the new variable
and then accessing it you can do this
directly so essentially we're still
doing the same thing the difference
right now is that we're writing
everything here inside of the component
again two flavors there's no right or
wrong
you can use either of these options the
result is going to be exactly the same
again we iterate over the list and we
just wrap the elements
in some kind of HTML structure
and once we are familiar with the basic
setup up next we'll take a look how we
can do the same thing with our books
array okay and up next let's set up a
proper list and essentially what I mean
by that is
iterating over the bookstore and then
for every item eventually we'll return a
component
so let's start by just navigating back
to index.js
and we want to remove everything that
has to do with names
of course you can keep it for your
reference just keep in mind that it's
already available in readme so it
doesn't really matter so again let me go
back to empty book list and like I
mentioned in the previous video if you
want to set up a new variable and then
render it in the book list
totally
okay option in my case I'm going to do
it right away in the book list
effectively I'll iterate over and return
that new array so we want to start here
with box then map and again we're
passing the Callback function so yes
you'll see the syntax over and over and
over and over again and the honestly
fetching data
and rendering it on a screen
is going to be your bread and butter
when it comes to react applications it's
hard for me to imagine a project where
you won't be doing at least one of them
so
yes this is the syntax you'll see over
and over and over again and don't worry
the more times you'll write this
the more familiar you'll be with the
entire setup so again we have this
callback function here and we just need
to decide what we want to return because
remember when it comes to functions by
default they return
undefined all right so yes explicitly we
need to set up a return and for now
let's just go here return and then div
and just so you can see that pretty much
everything works even if we don't access
values from the array let me just go
here with heading one we're heading two
whatever doesn't really matter and let's
just say item here
and you'll notice that actually
everything works
so I have those items on the screen why
well because I have an array with two
items we are iterating over here and
then for every item this is what we
return so technically we don't need to
even access it now it kind of makes
sense right
since we're iterating over the list we
want to access those values but
technically we don't have to and now
let's grab here this book
so this is what I'm going through
do with my parameter I'm going to name
this a book just please keep in mind we
cannot pass it directly so if I go here
with book and I'll do the same thing
I'll say book I'll get the same error
again object are not valid as a react
child so what do we need to do well
we need to pull out the properties
so we can either destructure them
or we can simply go to book that title
and the reason why I logged it because I
want you to see that we're iterating
over and pretty much we're getting
each object so yes if you have 200 of
them
you'll have 200 logs you'll access 200
items and now effectively we simply
wanna
like I said access the property now
eventually of course I will structure it
and all that for now I just want to
showcase that if I go here with title
I'll have title in my heading twos if
I'll go with author I'll get an author
now for the image of course it's going
to make sense if I
set it up
in different element but hopefully you
see where I'm going with this what's
next well even though we can nicely
return HTML elements directly in our
callback function
let's also remember that we still have
this book component
so why don't we put two and two together
so we have a book component that already
has the HTML
and it's simply looking for these three
things
image title and author
so if we go back
to our callback function
and if we return book and pass in the
values it should work
correct so let's try it out I'm going to
go back to my return I'm going to write
here book so I'm rendering now the book
component
and for now let's just pass them one by
one
in the following videos I'll show you
how we can pass the entire object as
well as how we can spread out the
properties which is my favorite way of
passing in the props but for now let's
just go one by one and let's say over
here book and then remember all these
properties are over here so above the
return we want to go with const then set
it equal to a book so essentially we are
destructuring something that we covered
already before and we want to go with
image then title and author and yes I
know that those properties are in there
so as far as the return since I know
that I need to pass them as props what
do we need to do we just go here image
is equal to image
title is equal to title and hopefully
you see where I'm going with this
one by one essentially I just passed
them in and as a result you'll see this
cool setup where again we have structure
in one place
we have a structure for the book
component
and essentially
we just iterate over
some data some list
we pull out the properties out of the
object
and then for every item we return this
component
and essentially we get this awesome
setup
where now all our logic is here
in order to render stuff on a screen we
simply need to iterate over and for
every item we just need to return the
component
all right next let's get rid of that key
prop warning in the console and
basically every time
you'll render a list of items in react
react wants to keep track of those items
so we need to provide a unique value and
set it equal to a key prop
and typically it's going to be an ID and
since we're creating this list ourselves
essentially we'll go back and just add
these two properties keep in mind that
the property name doesn't have to be ID
just these values need to be unique so
if you call this vegan food truck it's
totally okay as long as you provide
unique values and they don't have to be
numbers
essentially you can turn this into a
string of one and string of two and
hopefully you see where I'm going this
and lastly normally
will be fetching data from some kind of
external resource anyway so
those values again most likely IDs will
be right away provided
and I'll talk about the indexes
at the end of the video and why we
should
avoid that so first let's just go back
to index.js and we want to add those
unique values again not going to be
particularly original I'm just going to
go with id1 and id2 and yes if you have
10 of them then
basically manual you add this one id1
and id2 in my case
then we want to navigate and we want to
set this key prop on the main return
so it's not going to work if we go here
and set it equal to key and then the
Eddy
because this is the element that I'm
returning when I'm iterating over the
list
keep that in mind and
the reason why I'm saying that because I
get these questions in course q and I
where in some project it's confusing
where we should set the key so always
always always
look for the place where you're
iterating over
the data and then you want to set on the
item that you're returning basically if
there's going to be this type of setup
so let me go back here and show that ID
if you have this type of setup then add
it on a div not on a heading 2.
hopefully that is clear so let's go back
over here now we know that in the book
we actually have Daddy correct so we
pull it out and then just like they
suggest in console we just go with key
and set it equal to an ID and what do
you know the moment I save it everything
is fine
now
as you're looking at someone else's code
you'll see this approach as well
essentially this just saves a little bit
of time where
in the map the second parameter is the
index
so
you know that in JavaScript
arrays are zero index based the first
item is going to have the value of zero
then one and if you have 100 items that
means that you'll have those values from
0 to 99 and technically you can get away
with passing this index into a key yes
you'll see this type of approach in
general I don't advise doing that even
though you can get away with it
because it only works for the list that
you know will never change so basically
if we'll have some kind of option to
remove items from the list then this is
not going to work effectively there's a
high chance you'll get some bugs down
the road
now if you know 100 that the list is not
going to change yes you can cheat a
little bit but in general I don't advise
using such an approach so that's how we
can set up the key prop we just need to
set it equal to some kind of
unique value
that is in our data okay and before we
discuss events in react
let's take a look at two options how we
can pass the entire object as props
so effectively if we take a look at the
index.js Everything Is Awesome
but what if I don't know we have 20
items in this particular object
we can see that I think we're doing
double the work
I pull out all the items over here
and then I need to repeat the same steps
or if you go with props.name same deal
in the component
so is there any way how we can
simplify our life
here when we're iterating over the list
and essentially we have two options
we can pass the entire object as a prop
or we can use the spread operator which
essentially is the method that I prefer
the most
but let's start by passing the entire
object so inside of the map method
instead of pulling them out one by one
here's alternative I can simply go to my
book component and I can say book prop
so I need to come up with a name and
I'll name this exactly the same as my
parameter and I'll set it equal to my
book object
however once we save
we'll see nothing on screen why well
because remember
now props
is an object but inside of it I have
another object I have a book object
so in order to pull these properties out
I have two options I can go here with
props DOT book or another one if you're
destructuring right away in the function
parameter this is the syntax
again if you're not familiar with it
please watch the the structuring video
that I shared previously in the readme
so essentially I know that there is a
object and I just pull these properties
out that's the syntax again those are
our two options
either we just go with props Dot and
then whatever is the object
or we can restructure it right here in
the function parameters again
essentially it just saves us here on
getting these properties now we'll still
need to get an ID
so this is the case where you can either
pull it out or you can just say book and
then whatever is that property
and then of course in that case you can
just remove all of them this is totally
up to you
and the method that I prefer the most is
actually a little bit different
where we can use the spread operator and
again if you're not familiar with the
spread operator I will give you the
general overview but if you want to find
out more info just please follow this
link where I cover everything in great
detail and essentially the spread
operator so these three dots allow us to
copy
from the arrays or from the object so if
you have friends and then if you want to
create a new array you go here with data
dot friends and then let's say you want
to add a friend and if you log you'll
see that effectively you have two
arrange and again this is copying so
this is not going to be passed as a
reference and the same goes for the
object if you have some object and then
if you want to create a new one you go
with dot dot and you copy the properties
from some object and then let's say you
add another property and if you log
you'll see that essentially you have a
new object with all of these properties
now in react here's what we can do if I
have
a object
and if I want to pass all of those
properties
as props one by one I simply set up the
curlies here and I go with dot dot dot
and then that object
and once you log you'll see that all of
them are effectively passed down as
props so let's try this out and let me
know right away tell you that it's
not going to access anything from the
book so this line is going to
effectively fail
so let's go back to the book list and
instead of setting this up as book
equals the book
simply want to go with curlies
we want to go dot dot and when we want
to pass in the object again this line is
going to fail right now because we are
trying to access properties that don't
exist there is no book anymore
so now we need to go back and let's just
log and check it out so now one by one
we pass those properties down including
the ID of course now we don't use it in
a book
but it's not a big deal
so again
this is totally up to you
if you want to pass the entire object
down as props you can definitely do so
just come up with the property or you
can spread out all the values the end
result is going to be exactly the same
and it really comes down to your
preference
if you prefer the first wave
use that one if you prefer the second
one the spread operator
then of course go with that one now
since
I prefer the second option
that's why in the course you'll most
likely see me doing this
the spread operator approach rendering a
list with the help of components is
awesome
but of course it would be nicer if the
user could interact with our application
otherwise our app is somewhat boring so
long story short
our app needs to respond to events
for example when the user clicks the
button submits the form and rest of the
good stuff
so up next let's talk about how we can
handle events in react
now let me right away bring the cold
bucket of water and just say that all
our examples will focus on logging stuff
yes that's going to be the case simply
because we have not covered what is
State and react and what hook we use to
control the state
and therefore we really can't change
what we currently see on a screen don't
worry
all of that is coming up now let's just
focus on the main points
and essentially
if you're a little bit familiar with
vanilla.js you know that
effectively the setup is following
we have some kind of button form input
whatever then we select that element and
we can add event listener and I guess
the most common or basic or however you
want to say it is the click event
so we have the event we pass the name
and then we have the Callback function
in the Callback function we can access
the event object which
contains bunch of cool stuff for example
the element we're selecting
what value is inside of it and of course
bunch of other things and also we can do
something when that event takes place
and when it comes to react essentially
the setup is extremely similar
we have an element and of course in our
case that element is located in the jsx
in the component we have an event
and remember when we talked about Lee
kamokesh this is the time when we will
write on click instead of click
like we have been doing in vanilla.js
and then the Callback function
basically
a functionality we want to invoke
when that
event fires now if you want to see all
of the available
events in react you can follow this link
so let me copy this one just to Showcase
but I strongly suggest not memorizing
all of them because list is quite long
and essentially if you'll ever need to
use a specific event you can always go
there and get the exact syntax
the idea for all of them is the same
again
element event and a function and notice
over here how basically we're passing in
the reference so we go back to a
JavaScript land we set up the curlies
and same how we reference the variable
now we're referencing the function and
like I mentioned before
in all our examples we'll invoke alert
or log just because we haven't covered
how we can control what we can see on a
screen all of that is coming up
and I can also say that during the
course
mostly we'll use these three so on click
which responds to click events on submit
which fires off when the user submits
the form and on change which fires off
when the user is providing value in the
input again I strongly strongly
so just not memorizing all of them over
here
I mean in my opinion it's a waste of
your time if you'll ever have some kind
of specific use case
and come back over here you can get the
exact name for that event and you're
good to go because again the idea for
all of them is going to be exactly the
same
and once we have covered the journal
setup now let's create event examples
component which I'm going to render
above
the books one
and the reason why I'm doing that is
because eventually we'll just have the
books so this one will stay for your
reference
and of course since you have the readme
I'll be able to remove the event
examples so in the event examples
we want to set up a section form
with heading 2.
so some kind of title I guess input
and we want to go with a button with the
on click now let's not worry about these
functions for now as well as the name of
the event over here let's just set up
the basic return
so essentially let's just worry about
the jsx we're returning so let me
navigate to index.js and I think I'm
going to do right after the book list
because like I just said I am going to
eventually remove it anyway so why not
I'm gonna go with const and then let's
name this event
examples so that is going to be my
component
inside of it for now let's just go to
return
just so we can see that everything has
been set up correctly
so let's go with heading one and then
I'll say events let's save that and then
we want to go back to the book list
and effectively you want to do that
before the books so this is really up to
you if you want to set it up here in the
bottom
that's also an option but in my case I'm
going to go above and I'm just going to
access the event examples now if you
want to place them side by side in the
book list then of course just remember
that we need to use that react fragment
or div or whatever because there has to
be one element that we're returning and
also keep in mind that I'm placing this
in a section because there is already
some CSS so if you won't place it inside
of the section then effectively it's
just going to be hanging out here on the
left top corner so let me save it I have
your events so I'm good to go and as a
quick sign up this is usually what I do
I mean I'm not returning and hitting one
each and every time but I always like to
set up my component so I know that
definitely it's being rendered on a
screen there's no point to set up the
entire logic and then start chasing some
weird bugs
if let's say the initial setup was wrong
so in order to
avoid chasing my own tail I usually
start by rendering something on screen
and then once I can clearly see that I
mean the component setup is correct then
we can move on and start adding the
logic over here hopefully this wasn't
too long of the explanation and now
let's just set up that return
where basically we want to go
with another section
then inside of the section let's right
away go with form now we don't need the
action here
usually if you go damage right away it
gives you an action just as a side note
as far as the heading tools say typical
form
and then we want to go with inputs for
now it's going to be a text input but I
just want to add a little bit of
inline styles so let's go with style
it's an object and then let's say margin
one Rems usually we won't do that we
won't add the inline Styles but this is
the case where I thought
it's a great example of using such
approach and then let's also go with
name and we'll set up the example just
because I want to showcase something in
the following videos
and as far as the value I'm going to go
with examples so we know that in HTML we
can add name attributes
to the inputs and in the following
videos I'll show you how we can access
them in react and then right outside of
the form let's set up that button
as far as the value I'm just going to go
to click me
so we have our setup
and now let's just reiterate when I
covered I guess five minutes ago
where basically we have these events
so if we want to respond to user typing
something in the input the event name is
on change this is the case where we kind
of just simply come up with our own
names yes they need to match exactly
and if we want to respond to click
events we simply go here with on click
and then we need to pass in the
reference so we need to set up those
functions again they can be inside of
the component they can be outside of the
component they can be coming from
another file that part is irrelevant we
just need to pass those functions as a
reference and then every time that event
is going to fire
guess what react is going to execute the
functionality we have inside of the
reference function
I'm not going to be particularly
original I'm just going to say handle
form input handle button click yes in
react World this is somewhat typical
essentially to start the name with
handle but again it's not a rule so
let's go back to index.js let's go above
the return and let's come up with those
two functions now of course we can
pass them interchangeably
as long as you have the reference
function
you can pass the same one in the input
as well as the button click but
most likely you'll have some specific
Logic for the input or for the button
click so let's go here with handle form
sorry at four but form input for now
we're gonna go with pretty basic Arrow
function and we'll simply go log and
we'll say handle form input then we'll
copy and paste and we'll just change
some stuff around so it's not going to
be handle form input
we'll say handle button click and
instead of log why don't we go with
alert
let's save that and then like I said the
event
to handle
form inputs is on change
we go to any input in our case this one
the text one and we go with on change
so every time user is going to type
something in the input the event will
fire
and yes this functionality
will be executed so we go here with
handle form input so we pass the
reference and we want to do same thing
here with the button in this case though
the event name is on click
what do we do we pass here the reference
handle button and click I just make sure
that the name is exact and let me open
up the dev tool since there's going to
be some console logs as I said you know
it I think I can remove this sucker for
now the props one
if only to use it later of course I will
uncomment it so let's try that out with
a button check it out the moment I press
F handle form input then of course it's
because I didn't change the name my
apologies
so in here we want to go with handle and
then button click
of course you can leave the same one but
just so you can see that I'm not messing
with you I'm going to go click the
correct one
and of course we want to press OK OK
and then let's click one more time
handle button click awesome
so we can see that this functionality
works and the same is going to be with
our input so I'm going to go here and
start typing
notice in the console I have these logs
which means that again we're responding
to the events
and as a result of course our
application is more Dynamic and again
you'll need three things you'll need an
element you'll need an event
and you can always find all of the
events
in react docs and lastly you need a
reference to a function or a callback
function that you're going to invoke
once the event takes place or fires off
remember in the last video when we
discussed the events in vanilla address
we covered that
when we pass the Callback function we
have access to an event object
and in that object we can
find bunch of useful info and guess what
we can do the same thing in react
so every
callback function so every function that
we're referencing
is going to have
access to that event and since it's a
parameter of course we can give it
whatever name we want so you can go with
e which is pretty popular you can go
with event and always bananas is also an
option
and let's just log it in the input so we
can see
what values we're getting back and then
we'll talk about the form submissions so
as far as the annual form input I'm
going to go here and
we'll do few logs in this video so let's
start with an event and check it out and
here we'll find bunch of useful info now
the ones that we'll use the most are
event.target.name so Target effectively
is going to point back to an element in
our case since we're logging it in the
input yes it's pointing back to an input
and then remember in the previous video
we set up name is equal to an example
and if we want to access that name we go
to
event.target.name and if you want to get
the value we go with event.target.value
and essentially this is going to allow
us
to collect
the data from the input and again we're
not going to cover the entire example
because we haven't covered the state yet
but just to Showcase that it's actually
a case let me go here with log and then
event.target essentially is going to be
our input and then let's copy and paste
and if you want of course you can write
some additional text over here
just so you can see which one is which
but in my case I'm going to go the first
one name and then the second one value
and again it's going to log once we
provide some value in input and notice
so the first one is my element the
second one is the value that we provide
for the name so of course if I'll change
this around and if I'll say
product and if I'm going to go back to
an input any file type some kind of
letter now of course
in the console I'll see the product
and the third one is the actual value
in the input and last one is the
original
log that we set up in the previous video
so these two will use quite often
throughout the course and also we'll use
prevent default which is very useful
when we have it formed
so if we want to respond to form
submissions we just need to set up an
event so we're going to go here with on
submit and let's
create that function as well so let me
copy and paste and I'm going to rename
it to handle form submission
hopefully I'm spelling this correctly
and for now let's just log something at
least try to actually will fail
that's the whole purpose why we covered
the event object so let's go with form
sub method and then let's pass in the
handle
form submission
and once I save I mean it doesn't really
matter whether we type something in the
input or no if we'll press enter
essentially your turn we should see
something in the browser but we don't
so we can clearly see that something
happened notice over here we have this
product but we didn't see anything in
the browser and the reason for that is
because the default behavior of the
forms is to collect those values
and essentially
send it to
some URL now in this case we don't want
to do that we want to handle the forms
ourselves
and that's why we want to access the
event again
same as with handle form input we have
right away access to it and in there
there is a function called
event Dot and then prevent
default so this is also something that
we use quite often and effectively this
just means that we will handle those
form submissions ourselves and as you
can see now we can clearly see this log
in the console
so each and every
reference function is going to have
access to event in there we can find
bunch of useful things but mostly will
work with Target target.name
target.value as well as event prevent
default now if for some weird reason you
still don't see the log once you submit
the form don't panic and just try this
Mouse click on the input and then press
enter or return on the keyboard
basically we want to set focus on the
input
and don't worry in the following videos
we will add a button to submit the form
which actually is going to be our setup
for the rest of the course and in that
case we won't have to do all of these
acrobatics and before we continue let's
just take a small break and let's
discuss something that
pops up quite often in the course q a
and that essentially is how we can
handle form submissions in HTML again
please keep in mind that at the end of
the day we're still writing HTML we're
still writing CSS and yes JavaScript and
essentially we have two options
if we set up
a button with type submit
in the form
we can also utilize that button
but keep in mind that the value has to
be submit
so if it's just going to be a button
then it's not going to work so let me
just showcase what I'm talking about I'm
going to go back to index.js
and essentially where I have the form
first let me move this sucker up over
here let me add type and then equals to
A Button
and then let's copy and paste and we're
not going to have any on clicks over
here
and instead of type button we're gonna
go here with
submit and then instead of Click me just
so we can see which one is a which we're
going to go with submit and I'll move it
up
so let's save I have this submit one
and you know what
just so it's not all over the place I'll
add a div and just wrap the button the
second one the quick one and check it
out now of course we can click and
notice we nicely submitted the form
why well because we have on submit on
the form
and we have the Callback function and of
course we prevent the default and you
already know rest of the stuff
now if I'll click this one
I'll have the alert
so if we have just type button it's not
going to submit the form then please
keep in mind this is straight up HTML
setup
that's effectively how it works
now if you do want to set up an event
over here on this button let's say you
just don't like this unsubmit here in
the form you can definitely do so
and the logic is going to work exactly
the same but
the event you want to set up over here
is on click so here's what I'm talking
about
if for some reason you don't like this
setup you can remove
but in here you're not going to write on
submit
so you're not going to go here on submit
and then
let's say pass in the value let me try
that one notice over here up in paste
okay good
notice right so it's not going to work
you're going to get an error
in order to properly submit this form
we'll have to go here with on click
because it's a button
so you need to provide here on click and
then again both of them work so we can
submit the form with enter if I just go
to an input and press return key or if I
click the button and again both of them
are in your readme so you can clearly
see if you want to use the button code
on click if you're using the form just
make sure this one is type submit
because type button
it's not going to work hopefully that is
clear and now we can move on to the next
topic and while we're still on the event
topic let me throw you a mind grenade
remember I believe two videos ago when
we discussed the basic setup
in vanilla address
we use this example
now what is happening over here
I have here Anonymous callback function
right
now of course you can set up here the
variable set it equal to a function or
you can pass here directly
Arrow function which by default is
anonymous
the main point is that we can directly
pass in Anonymous function
so
do you think we can do that you know
react and of course the answer is yes
so you'll also see
this alternative approach
where instead of setting up those
functions here or in the file or in a
separate file
we pass the anonymous function directly
so in my case of course I'm passing here
the arrow function now please keep in
mind we're not invoking it over here
we just pass
the function so of course this logic is
going to run when well when we click on
a button in this case so let's try it
out I'm going to navigate back of course
I keep repeating this but I just want to
make it clear all of this code is
available and read me for your reference
so I'll simply do this I'll remove and I
don't think I'm gonna worry about the on
submit
so let me remove it keep in mind that
yes essentially it works the same way
but instead of using reference
I'm going to go with my arrow function
and then whatever logic we want to do
in our case what do we want to do we
simply want to log yes for now we'll
just be a little bit conservative so
let's go here with console log and then
say click me and of course we'll have an
error because we don't have here the
reference so let's do the same thing and
I guess one of the major gotchas here is
that we still have access to this event
object
so that doesn't change if I want to go
log
and inside of it I want to go with
event.target.value I'll still access
whatever is in the input and yes it's
still going to fire every time the user
types something in input again those
things don't change but you'll see this
shorter syntax
is there a rule no
if you want to use this one use this one
if you want to set up the reference use
that one mostly it depends on how much
logic you have if let's say you have
this input
and you're just accessing the value
quite often you'll see this approach if
you have some kind of button click and
then there's 20 lines of code
theoretically you can set it up over
here just keep in mind that you'll have
to set up the curlies and all that but I
mean most realistically then you'll set
up a reference function and now check it
out
both of them work exactly the same
but effectively we just have less lines
of code and since I'm enjoying mind
grenades so much I'm effectively
throwing them at you
let me throw another one
and that is the simple fact that
components are independent by default
and if this at the moment sounds like
okay well what's the big deal let me
show you an example
um after that I'll probably spend five
minutes just raving about it and let's
start I guess by removing the events
again we cover the basics we'll return
to events many times throughout the
course it's one of the main features to
any application if it's Dynamic so
there's no need to keep that component
here it's always available in readme and
therefore I'm going to go to index and
first I'll remove
the reference
and then I'll actually remove the
component
and now let's try to set up an event in
the book component and it's going to be
somewhat straightforward where I want to
set up a function I'll call this display
title if you want to practice
on setting up Anonymous callback
functions you can definitely do so in my
case I'll have a reference and I simply
want to log the title that's it
not much and of course we do need to set
up the event we need to reference the
function
and
it kind of makes sense to have some kind
of value in there as far as the value
inside of the button so let's start here
doesn't really matter where you place it
I think I'm gonna do it in between just
because I have some margins
so let's go here with on click for now
we don't have the function
so let me first just type display
title and then above it let's go with
that function const
display title and
let's go here and log that
so I already have the log so just so I
can speed this up or copy and paste oh
uncommon this one and we're gonna go
with title so what am I logging here
a title prop correct
so let's go here let's say display title
let's save it let's find the button
somewhere here
and check it out right away in the
console I see the same exact title that
is displayed in component
and guess what
if I click
the same button in the second component
it does the same only this time
it references the title that is
associated with the second component
and if you have done
pretty much any work in vanilla.js
you know that you need to do quite a bit
of acrobatics to get to that point
to essentially have some functionality
directly point to that one specific item
and just to give you an example let me
show you one of the JavaScript projects
that we're working on my course
I think it was this one either the
questions or the tabs I think it was
tabs
no sorry what was the questions my bad
my bad I'm gonna go back we're going for
questions and notice I mean it's not
earth shattering functionality basically
we're just displaying some kind of
content once we click on a tab but trust
me
in order to get to that point
where each of these buttons only
reference the specific item it's not as
easy as just setting up here to function
and the button so if you open up the
developer tools the sources tab
and more specifically MJS
you'll see that we're selecting all of
the questions we iterate over the
questions as we're iterating we're
selecting
the button and then essentially we
toggle the text inside of the function
now again there's multiple ways how you
can set up the logic
we also cover the alternative
that's not the point
the point is that in vanilla.js it
doesn't come by default
you cannot just right away go to a
specific element and say that
the functionality is going to apply only
to that element
you need to do more work and that is not
the case in react
so this is
an extremely powerful concept where
essentially whatever functionality will
have inside of the component
it's narrowed down to that component
where in vanilla.js in order to
have this type of functionality you need
to jump through the Hoops you need to do
some acrobatics
in react
it comes by default we don't need to do
anything okay and up next let's talk
about react data flow and in the process
I will cover what is prop Drilling and
the first thing we need to keep in mind
that in react
we can only pass the data down
so in our case we can only pass data
from book list to a book component
not other way around and yes if you have
a component
nested inside of the book component
and if you want to pass something from
the book list all the way down to that
component you'll have to go through the
book component of course there are
alternatives so later on
will cover context API we'll talk about
Redux and
of course you can use other state
libraries for that as well but by
default
we can only pass the props down
and essentially in a process we're doing
something called prop drilling so let's
just take a look at the example and
you'll see what I'm talking about first
let's navigate to index.js
I don't need the title
but I will keep the button because we'll
implement it in this example as well
it's not going to be display title we'll
just say click me doesn't really matter
what you write over there and then as
far as the book list let me come up with
first variable so const some value and
I'll go with Shake
and bake and up next let's set up a
function
so hopefully it's clear that when it
comes to this type of variable
effectively
we would just set up
the prop correct now in this case of
course we're iterating over the list and
we're passing into a book but let's say
if I have I don't know some component
over here so some component in order to
pass it down what would I do well I will
just pass it here as a prop right so I
would say some value is equal to some
value name is as always up to you but I
mean
in my case I'm just going to go with the
same name so some value equals the sum
value hopefully that is clear
but what about if we have a function so
let's say what if I have a function that
has a name of display value and in here
I'm accessing that variable in the
component
so I'm accessing the variable that is in
the book list component again we're just
going to be logging
we don't know how to control the state
yet so how do we pass this function down
well effectively it's the same thing we
need to come up with a prop name and we
need to pass it as a value
same deal we're iterating over the book
and we have actually this book component
so I'll pass it here just keep in mind
the same works with any component that
you have
in the jsx so let me remove this one
because otherwise I'll get an error of
course there is no sum component and let
me just go here with display value
equals
to display value
and how do we access it and as I say not
the first I'll have the error over here
because there's nothing in the on click
so for now
let's just deal with display value
and in order to access it
it's in the props again if you want you
can log it
sure
in my case I already know that it's
there so I'm gonna go display value so
we grab the function and again we just
pass it as a reference that's it that's
all we have to do and now if we open up
the devtools
we'll nicely see
that we log shake and bake and it's
going to work the same in all of the
components and again the main points are
we can only pass props down
so from the parent to the child
and effectively it means that if you
have really nested structure
you'll have to go through all of those
components which of course
can get annoying
and that's what prop drilling stands for
the annoying part of passing perhaps
literally down I don't know 10
components or five components or
whatever now at least in my opinion
passing the props
from parent to child is not a prop
drilling again that comes down to
preference but in my opinion that's
totally okay if you have a parent and
you pass it down to a child however
if there is a grandchild basically if
there is a child component inside of the
book and then you have to do the same
thing essentially you don't use it in
the book component but you pass it down
to whatever component in jsx yes in that
case at least in my opinion it becomes
prop Drilling and we'll come back to
this topic
a little bit later when we discuss the
Alternatives when we discuss context API
Redux and all that stuff again this is
just to give you a general infill
and one last time let me just repeat
that in react
as far as data flow we can only pass
props down from the parent to the child
okay and before we discuss es6 modules
in react applications let's also cover
more complex example when
we have a function in a component and we
need to invoke it in the child and as I
said this is something that keeps
tripping people up later in the course
so please pay a close attention
and in here we'll start with a little
challenge where essentially in the book
list component I want you to create a
get book function
now that get book function
accept ID as an argument
and it finds a book
I can give you a hint I'm gonna use the
find method and if you're not familiar
with that you can reference this video
in JavaScript nuggets
and we're not going to do anything
basically we want to grab the books all
right we're going to find the book that
matches the ID that we're passing in and
we just want to log it we want to log
our result again we don't know how to
control the state yet
so don't worry about that part just set
up the function log the book
that matches the ID that you passed in
and then pass that function down to a
book component and try to invoke it on a
button click
so essentially just like in the last
video
pass the function down come up with
whatever prop to structure it grab the
ID and try to invoke it
and
most likely you'll hit a bug and that
essentially is the entire reason for
this video so first try to set it up
yourself
and the next video I'll show you my
solution for the get book function and
also two possible solutions for the bug
that you might encounter okay so let's
get cracking I'm going to navigate back
for now I have this display value I
still know that I'm going to use the
button so I'll just
remove the reference as well as display
value
the prop is also not going to be here
I don't need these values and let's
first come up with the function so const
get book
then it's going to be looking for the ID
and
as far as the logic I want to find a
book so I'm going to go with constant
book is equal to books dot find
so I'll use the find method and in here
we pass in the Callback function and
we need to come up with the parameter in
my case I'm going to go with bulk and I
wanna search in the array for the book
whose ID matches this one how can we do
that well we can go with book.id is
equal to the ID that we're passing in
and then like I said we're not going to
be controlling anything what we can see
on the screen but we do want to log the
book
again I'm going to get this error and
you know what it's probably annoying to
some people so I'll just remove it and
I'll set it up from the scratch so let's
save it yep everything works all that is
nice now we need to pass it down okay
same deal just go get book is equal to
our function get book awesome then this
time let's log it just so we can
definitely see that it's there so both
of them get this function get book all
right awesome so let's grab it get book
it's coming this one out for now we
already have the button so we simply
want to go on click
and here comes the gotcha
so how are we going to invoke it
I mean
you can try to do this way
so get book here as a reference click me
undefined
why it's undefined well because it's
looking for ID
right
okay let's pass in the array
let's go here with get book Let's invoke
it and let's pass it in
so technically what's missing here is
the ID
all right so I know it's there I know
it's in the props object so let me just
grab it
but now I have a different issue so I
have the logs
all this is nice
but it's not happening on a button click
essentially it happens when the
application loads why
because we have parentheses here
and in JavaScript
essentially if we have a logic like this
where we have a function and then we
invoke it
what happens well we run the logic right
so it's the same thing if I would go
over here and if I would say I don't
know two for example right so in here
I'll pass in some kind of ID I will get
that book
so this is correct but we need to keep
in mind that this runs instantly and the
same thing happens over here
we're not running this when we invoke
this is not a reference anymore and the
reason why I'm being so annoying and I
keep repeating this because again later
in the course as our applications get
more complex this seems to be tripping a
lot of people up
yes in JavaScript once we set up the
function if we don't have it as a
reference if we have parentheses
we'll invoke it right away
and that's not what we want to do in
this case in this case we don't want to
do that so in the following video I'll
show you two possible solutions okay so
we have tiny bug in the code and the
first option is to set up wrapper inside
of the child component
so again our main issue is that we are
invoking this
where we have the on click
so in that case it runs instantly what's
the solution well in the child we can
come up with
a different function in my case I'm
going to call this get single book
and
will invoke the get book inside of the
function
so now we can pass the get single book
and we're good to go you'll see that
everything is actually correct so let me
just I guess comment this one out
just in case you ever need it for your
reference so get book get book all that
is good but instead of invoking it we're
gonna go with const get single book
again
if you want to name this get my
groceries that's also going to work
the main point is that we want to invoke
get book and grab the ID again this will
get us the ID
that belongs to that component as we're
iterating over list again in the second
component it's not going to get the ID
from the first one that's the beauty of
react and instead of going with get book
we're gonna go with get single book and
what do you know now of course
everything is going to work so I'll
save and once I click check it out this
actually gets me the book with an idea
of one
and it references
the book that is inside of the component
which is just awesome and of course I
can keep clicking and I'm going to be
getting this book so let me I guess
clean out the console and if I'll click
on a second one hopefully you see where
I'm going with this and yes
eventually this is how we're going to
remove items from the list now the logic
is going to be a little bit different
but the idea is going to be the same
again
the main thing that I'm trying to
Showcase over here is that
we need to pass a reference we cannot
invoke the function right away and as
far as the second option
it's a little bit more challenging I
guess as far as the concept where
I can pass the anonymous function
so think of it this way the general idea
doesn't change I still pass the
reference I'm just not naming it here
I pass in the anatoms function and then
I invoke it so let's go back to index
and
instead of get single book which is a
valid approach again this really comes
down to your preference the reason why
I'm showing you both of them because
again
as you're going to be looking at someone
else's project
you most likely see
one of those approaches so I just want
you to be aware of them where you can go
to get book and then pass the ID same
deal here is a reference and inside of
the function that's when we invoke the
book and check it out once I click again
I get the correct value in the console
all right and up next let's talk about
es6 modules
or a way for us to split up our
application into multiple files and of
course folders
and have the ability to Import and
Export the code
which essentially
helps us to organize our application
because if we take a look at the
index.js I mean everything is awesome
we have the list we iterate over we have
the book component and all of that is
great but you can probably imagine that
as our application grows this is not
sustainable I mean we need to have some
kind of way where we can split up the
code correct where we have separate
functionalities
in different places and then if we need
that if we need the component or data or
whatever
we just access it and the way we do that
is by using es6 modules which again are
not unique to react react just uses them
and if you have ever used node before in
the previous versions of node they used
to use only common JS now they also use
es6 modules and again it's the same
principle just the syntax is a little
bit different and you'll see it's
extremely straightforward so first I
just want to remove all the get book
logic as always
it's available in the readme if you ever
need a reference
so I don't need to get book and I'm
pretty sure I'm not gonna need the ID my
apologies if I will and if I'll have to
rewrite
hopefully you can forgive me and I don't
need the button okay good let's remove
that
and now
essentially I want to come up with a
file name we have two flavors when it
comes to imports and exports we have a
named one and we have a default one
as always you can use whichever you
prefer in most cases what you'll see if
you have let's say a one component in
the file you'll do that as a default one
and if you have multiples they will be
named now is it the only way how you can
do that no but if I'll show you pretty
much
every flavor of Import and Export this
video is going to be two hours long so
we'll focus on two main ones name the
export and default export and the only
thing we need to understand
is that when we import with the named
one we need to use the same name so name
must must must must must must be the
same and with the default one we can
come up with whatever value we want
literally that's the main difference
so first let's go to source and let's
create box.js and book JS so this is
going to be for our component and this
is going to be for our data and then I
want to remove books array from index.js
and I want to add it to books j s
so let's try this one out new file I'm
going to go with books JS that's where
I'll have my data and yes of course I
can name this data as well if I want and
I'm going to go with book JS let's start
with the books array
so let's get the data away from the
index so let's clean up this file so I
want to cut it out and I want to place
it in the box of course the moment I
save I'll have big fat error why
because books is not defined
of course I'm accessing it over here but
there is no books anymore
so in here we have this array and like I
said we have two flavors and essentially
with books I'll show you both and then
with the book one we'll just use the
default one so in here I can go with
export notice I simply want to go with
export and then whatever
variable I'm exporting or function or
hopefully you see where I'm going with
this now again there are a few different
flavors to this but we'll just stick
with the most common ones so we'll save
over here and then back in the index we
need to repeat these steps however this
is our own file so this is where that
path comes into play when we go to
import and this is extremely extremely
important we need to go with curlish
which means that
we'll be getting a specific item meaning
the item you're exporting is exported as
named export so this needs to match
exactly what I have in the file learn
from and what do you know I'm looking
for the books and remember I told you
when we covered CSS JavaScript files we
don't need to do that and the moment we
save check it out everything works now
if I'm gonna go here with carrot banana
or whatever Bob it's not going to work
so this is exported as books so anywhere
anywhere in your application you need to
access books that's a must you cannot
just willingly come up with a different
name so that's the first option we have
let me go here with books and like I
said I'll show you right away both of
them but we'll stick with the named one
now alternatively here's what we can do
I can remove this export for now
and I could say export default
and then of course I need to reference
the books
one thing we need to keep in mind that
we can only have one default export per
file
so you cannot have like 10 default
exports that's the whole point that you
have one default export and the biggest
difference is that in the index.js we
don't have any more this syntax we
simply need to go with import and pretty
much we're saying we're importing
anything and this could be banana
and I just need to change it here of
course right so I need to go here with
banana and of course everything works so
hopefully this gives you a good idea
again
named and default and the biggest
difference is that with default you
actually can
name it however we want in the index.js
this is something that we talked about
it before where you can technically set
up a component with lowercase and Export
it but when you import you will still
have to use the application so first let
me just go back to the name one
export we use like I said the default
one
in the book component
let's remove this and then in the
index.js that's when we want to go back
to the books
little detour
my apologies and now let's go with the
component the reason why I showed you
both I don't want you to think that you
can only do default with a component
you can do with any data so up next
let's take this sucker out let's remove
and
I have book JS copy and paste and
remember the extension that I used
before
so
the Snippets one
check it out I can of course create the
component this way as well and notice
how I right away have that export
default book so now you know what that
line of code is doing so let me copy and
paste again and we're going to go with
export
export default
and we're looking for the book component
then we're going to navigate back
and we want to go with import
and book from the book
also I want to right away mention that
technically vs code tries to provide the
Auto Import and when I say technically
because I mean unfortunately sometimes
it doesn't work but don't be surprised
if for example you see me or some other
instructor doing something like this
where I can go with book and then notice
out right away sets up that component
now of course I'm not passing anything
in here and it's looking for those props
and all that but hopefully you see that
yes I can type the component and visual
studio code is going to try to help me
and the reason why I say tries to help
you because here and there it just fails
so let me remove this one
the import is in place and as you can
see
the logic still works
I still have my list and everything is
correct the difference right now is that
I've nicely split up my code where the
component is in one place so if I ever
need to come back I can just navigate to
a book.js this is all the logic for this
one and you already know that we can add
code remove code and right away all the
components are going to be affected and
the same goes with book shares in few
videos we will cover
how to set up local images in the source
folder which essentially
is a better approach because
there's some optimizations
happening under the hood so the result
is better and yes all the work we're
only going to do in books.js
so we won't have to run back to index.js
as long as the import is correct
we're good to go again these are es6
modules they're not specific to react
you can use them in vanilla.js you can
use them in node
and essentially they help us to organize
our application all right and now let's
talk about how we can set up local
images in the source folder which
essentially is a better option for
setting up the assets because like I
keep saying when the react builds our
production application effectively it
optimizes those assets
so unlike the public one where there's
no optimization we just dump the asset
and that's it in this case react is
trying to help us and essentially by
optimizing those assets
the result is that our application is
going to be faster
and in order to Showcase how that works
I decided to add one more book
to our array and essentially we're just
going to utilize the es6 modules we
covered already in the previous video
so first I want you to go back
to Amazon so find that link or get your
own images it doesn't really matter
and just get for the book one and two
so
my guys have these two
so I'm going to go and save images I
think I'm going to place it on desktop
and I'm just going to go with book one
then let me find the second one
I'll do the same thing
and now I just need to come up with the
third one
this is probably going to be
challenge but I'm gonna go with this one
bad jokes why not
so let's go here and I'm gonna go with
book
three and before we navigate to a
desktop let me also get the data for
this book
so let me open this one up
and basically this is going to be the
title and this is going to be an author
so let's navigate to the box and like I
said we want to add the third one
so let me copy and paste and let's just
change the values around so these ones
I'm going to get from the Amazon
for now I just want to change the idea
which is going to be three
then we wanna
get the
title and I think I'm just going to go
with the short one here
title
and let's get
the author
UPS keeps running away from me
let me set it up over here
and now let's deal with those images
so I have these three images on my
desktop
the folder structure is definitely up to
you for the bigger project you'll mostly
have like assets and then images folder
the CSS folder and hopefully you see
where I'm going with this for now I'll
just create a images and place it in the
source but it's a must it has to be in
the source so even if the structure is
more nested make sure that the parent
the main directory is still within the
source please don't place it in the
public it's not going to work
so let's grab
the folder and then we just want to move
all of these images over here once
they're there let's move them to the
source like I just said
and here's the deal we simply want to
import those images one by one and yes
this is a downside if you have 100
images you'll have to do
this one by one
for example if you have
images in the public then of course you
can just reference it as dot forward
slash and then whatever is the path
so keep in mind yes
it is a little bit more annoying
technically because we need to do this
one by one but the results are going to
be better and essentially we want to
import we want to come up with some kind
of name and we need to look for images
and then the file name and notice again
full path basically extension included
and then notice over here instead of the
local one or the external one for the
image what do we do we simply pass in
that variable so one two and three in my
case so let me save this I'm going to go
to books again like I said we're not
working anymore in index.js we only need
to focus on box.js and one by one let's
grab them let's go here and say import
and IMG one from and now we're looking
in the images and then book I believe it
was a one and this was the extension so
now we want to copy and paste and then I
want to set up multiple cursors and
let's just change these values so this
is going to be book two and book three
and like I said one by one
or just change it we'll say IMG one
img2 and img3
img2
and last one is going to be img3
once we save we should have a list
of
three books
and as you can see
images work as expected again the main
benefit of such approach not just for
images again we're covering images keep
in mind it goes for all the assets is
that they get optimized when react or
more specifically create react app they
told that we're using build out our
production ready application and as a
result our applications are faster okay
and before we set up a production or the
application and deploy it online so
everyone can see our awesome project
let's work on two
challenges and the first one is
following I want to set up
numbers just like they have in Amazon
now please don't worry about the CSS
the main goal is to figure out how we
can get
the correct number
for the book
so if I have a list
each value represents whether it's the
first one second one and hopefully you
see where I'm going with this and I just
want to display those numbers again I'll
show you the CSS it's actually very
simple and all that but for now just
worry about getting that number
somewhere here in a component
and also we'll set up the title that's
going to be our Second Challenge and for
both of them pretty much
if you want to work on that
independently once I'm done explaining
the challenge just stop the video try to
accomplish it yourself and once you're
ready to compare the results just resume
the video now you don't have to you can
simply just watch and code along with me
and basically like I said I want to set
up those numbers so I can see
which
item this is in the list whether it's
the first one second one
or third one don't worry about the CSS
and I'll give you a tiny tiny hint I'm
going to use index
for this again I'm not using index for
the key I'm using it to get the value
so I can clearly display whether it's
the first book second or third again if
you want to work on this independently
please stop the video right now and
resume once you're ready to compare the
results
I'm going to go to index.js and then the
second parameter in map method is the
index so
we can reference it here I'm going to go
with index and I'm going to come up with
a different prop name
of course I can go with index index but
I'm just going to go with number and
then index all right good then let's go
to a book JS so now we Navigate to a
book component and we want to grab that
number correct we're going to go here
and remember
arrays in JavaScript are zero indexed
paste what does that mean that means
that if I'm gonna go here with log and
number
I'll nicely see
zero one and two which is awesome but it
doesn't really match exactly correct so
it should be one two three what's the
solution well we can just add plus one
and in my case I'm going to place that
in a span so right after the author I'm
going to go with span allari class just
because I'll add the styles
in a second and then we can go here like
this number
plus one which effectively will get us
the right number and the reason why you
see everything displayed because of
course I already added the CSS and my
apologies let me just remove this one
for now I was already working on that
we'll set that one up in a second if you
have the same setup you should see
number all the way after the author
and also I want to showcase that once we
go back to a JavaScript land of course
we can use the template literals as well
so let's say in my case I want to add
that hashtag in front of it
so in order to do that I'm gonna go here
with the template literals and then
remember in a template literal in order
to access
the variable we need to go with dollar
sign and then the curlies keep in mind
that is a JavaScript syntax
we are back here in JavaScript plan
so we just need to follow the same rules
I'll start here with the hashtag
and then I'll go to dollar sign and then
the curlies so again I'm accessing the
same number I'm still adding plus one
the difference is that I just nicely
added this hashtag that's it and then as
far as the CSS we want to go to index
CSS I want to make book relative because
of the span
with the value of number
is going to be absolute
so in order to control the absolute we
need to set up the parent as relative
then let's keep moving and we're going
to go with number like I said position
absolute then I want to go with top
zero left
is also going to be zero
and we have font size padding and I'm
just going to add those border radiuses
since I'm using the poor radius for
entire card I just decided that
it's a good idea to do the same thing
for the sponge so padding is going to be
zero point
75 Rems than font size one
after that we have Porter and I don't
want to go with border radius because
essentially this is going to apply all
around and it's hard to see because we
don't have any background so let's say
here red of course I mean it doesn't
look as good as
when we go with border top and we're
gonna go with left radius so only the
left side and I also decided to do the
right side now you don't have to so
let's copy and paste this is going to be
bottom
and then right
let's save that okay awesome and now
let's just add some background colors
and this one I actually got from the
Amazon so
it's not really a secret you can just go
there pick the color
and it's going to spit back this one
most likely
um let's just go with color
and set it equal to a white
and with that we're done with this
challenge hopefully you enjoyed it and
in next video work on the title
challenge all right and up next let's
work on the title challenge just like
the previous challenge CSS is optional
don't worry about the CSS the main goal
is to set up an element with some kind
of title and that element needs to sit
on top of our books same deal if you
want to work on it independently please
stop the video and resume once you're
ready to compare the results and
essentially I'm gonna go back to
index.js and here I guess the biggest
gotcha is that we cannot return two
adjacent elements correct so if I'm
gonna do something like this it's not
going to work what's the solution well
we need to come up with a parent
one option for parent is what it is
react dot fragment or we can have here
shortcut like a show so let me move this
sucker down
and then let's come up with that value
so I'm going to call this um Zone
and best
Sellers and like I said CSS is optional
but
I'm still at it somewhere there doesn't
really matter where normally I
place it
as I'm adding the item but in this case
I'll somewhere in the bottom I'm just
gonna go with heading one
and text align
text line Center
then margin top
I'm gonna go to four Rems and then
lastly let's go with capitalize so text
transform and let's set it equal to a
capitalized and then also
I want you to change the title
in the public one
remember
there is this index HTML where we can
change the title
come up with the value and just change
it in my case I have react tutorial at
the end I want best sellers or something
along those lines let me open this one
up public
access HTML remember
this is where our entire application
lives then we want to find the title
instead of react tutorial we'll go with
best
Sellers and with this in place we are
done
with the challenge hopefully everyone
enjoyed it and in the following videos
we'll build a production ready
application and deploy it on netlify
okay and up next let's work on the
production application you see this is
our development environment
which works really awesome we can right
away see the results in the browser and
all that
but when we want to deploy the
application
the setup
needs to be different
essentially we're not going to have the
source and then public and all that
and in order to set up that production
application so we can deploy it on any
provider we need to stop the server
and also we just need to take a peek in
the package.json remember
initially I showed you the script
so these are our commands so start
here's the development server a build
one
is the one that builds that production
ready application and in order to run it
I'm going to clear the terminal and the
command is clear we go with npm and then
we add this run
and build
npm run build and what you'll notice
once we run the command
create react app
is going to be busy building our
application and once everything is done
there's going to be an extra folder a
build folder this is where our
production ready application is going to
live now I don't know how long it's
going to take most likely oh no as I was
saying it actually finished it so notice
this build folder right now
and check it out this is our production
ready application
and if you'll take a look at it you'll
notice that it has a bunch of static
assets so a bunch of HTML CSS JavaScript
and all that so again we don't have any
more of The Source One
this is only while we're developing once
we run npm run build this is the
production ready application and
effectively we can use this build folder
with pretty much any provider that you
pick in our case we're going to go with
metal fiber you don't have to again if
you use some other provider it's going
to work the same way just like you
normally would with the HTML project or
vanilla.js project and hopefully you see
where I'm going with this once we run
npm build
we can get this build folder that we can
use with any of the hosting providers as
far as the hosting like I said already
50 000 times in the previous video you
can use your provider but since I use
nettlefive
during the course we'll use this one
now let me be very clear they're not
sponsoring this video they're not
sponsoring the course I'm not paid to
say this I just enjoy the service they
do offer generous free tier so
essentially the only thing you need to
do is sign up that's it you'll have to
provide your email and you're good to go
and once you sign up for account
just log in and this is going to be your
dashboard then you want to go for a new
site and of course
if you just opened up you're not going
to see the sites but since I'm using
this already for quite a while I have a
bunch of sites in here
you want to look for add new site and
we'll start with deploy manually yes
with a later project we will take a look
at the
GitHub option but for now let's just go
deploy manually
and essentially we just want to look for
that build one so let's go to tutorial
and let's grab this build folder
yep we want to upload
the
process
it's going to be pretty fast and once
netlify is done processing the files we
will have our site live and if you click
on this link
you'll see our awesome project one last
thing that I want to mention in this
video if you want to change the site
name
you just need to navigate here to a site
settings let's say you're not happy with
this generic name go to change site name
and you need to provide whatever value
you want now keep in mind unless you add
the custom domain it's always going to
have this notify that app which in my
opinion is not a big deal but just in
case you don't want to so yes you'll
effectively need to use the search
engine to figure out how you can set up
a custom domain which by the way is not
hard but we're not going to cover in
this course because this is a react
course and if the name is already taken
let's say if I'm going to go with react
of course I'm going to have this error
so just keep that in mind okay so I'm
going to go with the react
horse and fundamentals hopefully that is
not taken but you never know yep
everything works like I said this is the
link now that we can share
and anyone who visits this link is going
to see our awesome application so this
is it for react fundamentals hopefully
everyone enjoy this section and I'll see
you in the next one alright we're pretty
much done with react fundamentals and
before we start discussing Advanced
react topics let's quickly cover all the
files in the source folder
that create react app provides by
default
and I'll also show you which files
I typically remove when I start a new
react project with create react app
technically this video is optional so if
you don't feel like
following along feel free to move on to
the next video
if you however do want to follow along I
suggest installing new create react app
instance and remember the command was
following first
we want to navigate to
where we will set up the project so in
my case that is going to be desktop and
then we want to type npx create react
app at latest and then the app name so
type this command and resume the video
once all the dependencies have been
installed
and once the install is complete
just open up the project in your text
error
and you don't have to bother with npm
start
since essentially we'll spend most of
this video in the source folder so just
open up the project and text error and
then crack open the search folder if we
navigate to index.js you'll see that the
setup is almost almost the same so we
have
Imports for react and react Dom we also
have here import for index CSS now of
course if we navigate there we can see
that the code is a little bit different
and again the general idea is that
essentially this is where you set up
your Global Styles or maybe all the
styles again it really depends on your
application
then we have app component which I'm
going to talk about in a second we also
have this one
so the report web vitals and essentially
if you're interested learning more they
provide detailed info in the comments
now in our case we're not going to
implement that so here's what we can do
we can simplify we can remove this code
and we can also remove this import
so that's done then what's happening
here with app.js well you see unlike the
react fundamentals where if I remember
correctly
we ended up with a book list component
which was in the index.js
a common convention is to
set up that root component as a app
and set it up in a separate file
basically we have app.js so this is our
root component this is where all our
components are going to meet
um it's sitting in a separate file and
Convention is to call this app and most
likely I don't have to say that you can
call this orange and everything is still
going to work as long as the Imports are
correct
so again it's just a convention and
basically if we navigate here in the
app.js you'll see that the import logo
so this is where we can see over here on
the screen
and since we're already familiar how the
es6 modules work of course we're
familiar with this code and then rest of
the return now we'll start from the very
scratch so
I'll remove the logo actually I'll
delete the file in a second as well
and as far as the return well let's just
go here with simple heading one
and let's say Backroads app back roads
and app let's save it because I still
want to talk about the app CSS but while
we're still in the index.js one last
thing that I want to mention notice here
how in the render
not only we have the app so that's the
root component again
the exact same setup how we had in react
fundamentals the difference of course is
the component instead of book list now
we have app
but it's also wrapped here in this
strict mode
and essentially Street mode is a tool
for highlighting potential problems in
application
it activates additional checks and
warnings
for its descendants Now it only runs in
development so it's not going to impact
your production build
and one gotcha
is that in development it renders twice
and I'll showcase that in a second don't
worry now if you want you can remove
please keep that in mind it is an option
if for some reason you don't like the
warnings you don't like the fact that it
renders twice you can always remove this
component and just to Showcase that if I
go back to app.js somewhere here
if I go with console.log and if I'll say
hello you'll notice that the moment we
save
basically it runs twice that's something
that we need to keep in mind so again
once we refresh notice essentially we
have two hellos in the console and again
it's because we have strict mode
wrapping our app component our root
component however it is not going to
affect the production
so once we ship this to production the
strict mode is not going to affect our
application
now notice here how we have import for
app CSS so essentially we have two files
we have index CSS and we have app CSS
and you can already see that
essentially we can split up our CSS code
so instead of jamming
our entire CSS logic in one file we can
split it up
for example you create a component and
you right away set up a
CSS file with the corresponding logic
now one gotcha we need to be aware of
all of this is still
going in the same pile now what do I
mean by that
so let's say if in the index CSS I have
a code for heading 1. and I'm not going
to be particularly original I'm just
going to say here color red
if we navigate back of course everything
works now
if we go to app CSS
the thing is
it's not going to be isolated by default
basically it's not going to be scoped
to just this app Js
essentially whatever logic we're gonna
add here in the app CSS it's gonna get
added to whatever logic we have in the
index file or any other CSS file and
again just showcase that
effectively we'll remove this component
altogether in a second but for now let
me just go here with heading 1 and again
we need to go with color
I'm gonna go with blue and once we go
there actually this overrides wherever I
have in the the index CSS so yes you can
definitely
set up the files and split up the logic
however keep in mind one thing
you'll still need to be careful as
you're setting up the CSS now of course
there are solutions for that something
that we're going to cover in this course
for example I am a huge fan of CSS and
JS more specifically styled components
and that's why I will cover in this
course that solved this problem but
right out of the box yes
you can nicely split up your CSS code
but please keep in mind that you'll have
to be careful
because all that CSS code ends up in one
place
so hopefully that is clear it's not
scoped by default to a certain component
all right I think we covered everything
so now let me just remove this log
let me also remove the import we won't
need that essentially we'll just delete
bunch of files we won't need them so
let's start here with app CSS we'll also
remove test so this is if you want to
set up tests which we're now going to do
then we also want to select the logo we
don't need the logo this one as well as
setup best so you should only see
once you're done with delete app.js
index CSS and index
.js
so let me remove
and yep now I have again index.js
this is where we inject
our JavaScript logic into
index.html in the public one and the
app.js is our root component okay and up
next let's switch to beat basically
instead of create react app we're going
to use different tool to scaffold and
develop our react project now I really
don't want to spend too much time on
discussing benefits of beat if you're
interested in learning more there are
plenty of YouTube videos and blog posts
that cover that
and as a side note they also cover that
in a docs just click on why veed tab in
short at this point vid is much faster
than create react app and right out of
the box it provides tons of great
features
and as a result we get way better than
experience
now if you're wondering why we covered
create react app in the first place
effectively why we did not start with
Veet right away well there are two
reasons first
there's still plenty of
code examples that use create react app
so in my opinion it's useful to know the
general layout and commands second more
importantly I really want you to get
comfortable writing react code in any
environment you see
once you start working for a company or
switch to one of the react Frameworks
for example nexjs the dev environment
will be different yes you'll still write
the same react code but folders and
commands they will be different in each
environment and therefore it's important
for us to get comfortable working
in different setups with that said once
we cover beat setup you'll see that the
general idea is pretty much the same
it's just here and there the
implementation is tiny bit different
okay and in order to get started with
beat project we first want to navigate
to the Dachshund the URL is
dot Dev again URL is
dot dev then we want to go with get
started
continue scrolling and we're gonna go
with template now I'm assuming you're
using the latest node version so if you
don't if your npm version is less than
seven then of course
use this command
but since I'm assuming that most people
who are watching have the npm greater
than seven that's why I'm gonna go with
this command
so we're looking for npm create Veet at
latest then we need to provide the name
and then we have two sets of dashes
template and as you can see they provide
bunch of templates we have for
vanilla.js for view spelled and all that
now we're looking for the react one so
essentially we just need to
structure this command so let me
navigate back
I'm going to massively zoom in again in
my case I'm going to create that project
in the desktop
of course it's really up to you where
you want to do that and now let me
carefully
grab this command so I'll take
everything up to a template first I'm
going to change the name it's not going
to be my view app
it's actually going to be a react app
and then as far as the template we want
to go with space and then type react or
copy and paste react that's really up to
you as you can see
you'll right away get the project so
that's the cool thing again I did not
stop the video or anything like that you
right away get the project and now we
just want to spin it up so first let's
just open up the text editor then I'm
going to drag and drop
and you'll see that the setup is very
very similar to the create react app and
first let's just navigate to the package
Json and you'll notice that the command
we're looking for is npm run Dev so this
is going to spin up the dev server and
before we can do that we want to install
the dependencies so we go here with npm
install so
this might take a little bit but trust
me it's definitely going to be much
faster than create react app and then we
want to go with npm run Dev again
instead of npm start we go with npm run
Dev
and also the localhost is going to be
different so yes we'll still have the
react application and we'll take a look
at the code in a second and all that
but the Local Host is going to be 5173
so up until now we have been using
localhost 3000 but now it's going to be
5173 and before we take a look at the
application I just want to quickly
mention
if you're interested
in basically the info that I'm providing
if you want to keep that as a note it's
actually located in the fundamentals all
the way at the end of the readme
so after
all the fundamental stuff
over here you'll find info on create
react app as well as beat
so I guess our project is up and running
at localhost 5173 so why don't we
navigate over there just to see what we
have
and yes probably during this video it's
going to be annoying to some people that
I'll just keep repeating that as you can
see the setup is extremely similar
because that's the main point that I'm
trying to get across
even though we're switching to a
different tool the setup is going to be
extremely extremely similar so we
installed dependencies
if we want to run the project we go with
npm around Dev as you can see here at
the top we have node modules what do we
have over there those are dependencies
as far as the differences we must must
name our files
jsx so in create react app we can name
the file
JS or jsx
in wheat the rule is
jsx so if you'll name your file JS and
then start setting up the component yes
wheat will complain
so that's the first difference we must
use jsx extension in the read now second
you'll notice that
even though the public folder is there
and the idea is exactly the same
whatever we place over here is publicly
available
there is no index HTML
so
in here the index.html is sitting in a
road again the idea is exactly the same
notice we still have the div with an
idea root so this is where our
application effectively is going to live
we can still change the title over here
so for example I can say react project
and now of course once I save
this is what I'll have here in a tab so
that part doesn't change only the
location
and once we're done with index.html now
let's discuss main jsx so unlike create
react app where we used index.js
in beat project we need to use Main jsx
and yes
as you can see the code is extremely
similar to
the index.js in create react app
so the idea is exactly the same we just
need to use Main jsx and as you can see
we're importing the app so this is still
going to be our root component now the
only thing that we haven't seen
is the use State something that we're
going to cover in a few videos but if
for example
I go here and change the jsx you'll see
that I'll have the same result in the
browser so let me go here I'll remove
everything I'm gonna go with heading 1
and I'll say
our first
beat project
and check it out once we save course
this is what we'll have on the screen so
again the idea doesn't change
we still import
the logo the same way because notice now
the assets is sitting in the source so
this is the public one this is where we
have all the assets that are publicly
available however
within the project when we're going to
be importing those assets they are
nicely tucked away in this assets folder
in the source and this should look
already familiar since we did Cover the
es6 modules and all that
and the rest of it is pretty much the
same again don't focus on this one we'll
cover this hook in pretty much few
videos so don't worry about that we also
have app CSS where basically we have all
the Styles and also the index CSS and we
did Cover differences when we discussed
the folder structure in create react app
so I'm not going to repeat that and
lastly I just want to mention that
if we want to build the application we
go with
and PM run build which again is going to
create that production or the
application and let's try it out and PM
run and build and in this case is going
to be sitting here in the dist folder so
unlike create react app which creates
build folder we have this folder
same deal we can take this folder drag
and drop and notify and we're good to go
and yes
if you use continuous deployment
the idea is going to be exactly the same
and as a signal notify right away picks
it up so
if you go with Veet right away it will
say hey do you want to use the this
folder and do you want to use this
command so again
the general idea is exactly the same
whether it's the Imports whether it's
the root component the index.html and
all that so that is not going to change
only difference is that this tool is
much better so our Dev experience is
just going to be awesome compared to
create react app awesome and once we're
comfortable with react fundamentals as
well as Veet setup but finally discuss
Advanced react topics
so in the following videos we're going
to cover things like react hooks
conditional rendering fetching data
forms context API and bunch of other
cool things
I also prepared quite a few challenges
just so we can apply our knowledge right
away and hopefully that way by the time
you're done with the section
you'll be able to apply the concepts
while you work on your own applications
so if possible
try not to rush through the content
since such approach very rarely leads to
long-term results in order to follow
along you mean some assets and they're
located in the same GitHub repo so my
profile and then you're looking for
react course version 3. and even if you
already downloaded the repo
I suggest repeating that step since that
way you'll get the very latest version
you see as I'm recording I tend to
update some stuff for example read me
so once I'm here I'm gonna go for
download zip option
then I'm gonna navigate back
look for downloads crack it open
up the directory and then we want to
grab the advanced react folder
so it's up to you you can work in the
main folder but I always prefer to work
in a separate folder then I want to open
up the text editor
and right away I'll set it side by side
with the browser again this is going to
be the case where
I'm gonna choose this option
so let me set them side by side
and basically you'll notice that it's a
pretty typical beat project we just have
here some assets and of course I'll
discuss them
in more detail
in a second for now I simply want you to
navigate to the readme and in here
effectively you're looking for these
commands now if you can run them in your
operating system in such manner awesome
if not then just run them separately so
I want to open up the integrated
terminal I'll make this one bigger and
then we're gonna go with npm install
and you know what I'll just run them
separately
just so you can see that everything
works so
we have npm installed so we installed
dependencies and then we want to go with
npm run and Dev
and essentially this again is going to
open up the project on localhost 5173
and yep we should see a heading 2 with
Advanced react and rest of the info
essentially is going to be located in
tutorial marking on file so this is just
a general readme how we can spin up the
project and all that in tutorial you'll
find effectively all of the info we're
going to cover in the following videos
and as far as our workflow like I
mentioned before this is a traditional
Veet application I just removed some
boilerplate then provided some assets
like CSS and data and all that just so
we can work on more meaningful examples
and for that I do need some assets I
also removed the strict mode just so we
don't have a bunch of logs so remember
strict mode was adding that extra login
well working and essentially exploring
stuff I don't want to have too many
locks so if you'll take a look at the
main jsx you'll see that essentially
everything is the same
there's just no strict mode in the index
CSS you'll find all of the CSS we're
going to use data this is going to be
some data that we're going to use in
examples app jsx so this is going to be
our root component
then we also have some assets here
again something that we're going to use
during the examples and there's also
public which by the way we're not going
to use and of course there's no modules
which are our dependencies now if we
again navigate back to tutorial you'll
see that basically we have this tutorial
directory
and in here we have a bunch of folders
so it starts with your state all the way
to userducer and
I'm actually working on more topics
right now so probably by the time you
install this you'll see more folders and
essentially the idea is following each
folder is going to have final and a star
so we will do a work in a star folder so
there you'll find some files and it
really depends sometimes there's going
to be just a structure for component and
sometimes I'll provide already some
stuff so yes
sometimes we'll code pretty much
everything from scratch but if we
already have covered that topic and if I
just want to provide some extra info on
that then yes you'll find already some
code in the star and of course
if this doesn't make any sense right now
you'll see as we start working on the
examples and then in the final
you can find the complete source code so
this one you can use for two examples
let's say if you want to compare your
code to mine
or you simply want to see how the
feature looks like
once it's done since again I will be
setting up some challenges so if you
want to take a peek
out effectively runs in the browser then
just set up the file and the way we set
up the file is following
so in the app.js essentially we'll just
import that file
and then we'll render it over here again
you're gonna render both you can render
star and the final this is really up to
you but you'll definitely need to get
that starter so pretty much every
lecture is going to have its own star so
you'll have to import that and set it up
over here in the app jsx and then if you
want to see the final folder again it
could be any file just navigate to
tutorial in this case you're looking for
the final one and then whatever file you
want
and the reason why you have here this
container is simply for some basic
styling so notice how it's nicely
sitting in the center it has some
padding and all that technically if you
don't want to you can just remove it and
everything's still going to work and
just to Showcase let me just navigate
to let's say app jsx
let me move up now the component name is
really up to you I'm just gonna go with
star and final because it just makes a
little bit more sense so I'm gonna go
here with import starter so that's going
to be my component name and then from
and then for now let me just navigate to
tutorial then
just as a example I'm gonna go to let's
say use ref so that's going to be seven
and then starter like I said and in
there we only have one file so we grab
this one and for now let me just remove
that heading too
then let's go with starter
and then let me close the component so
once I save notice I'll have some code
already so essentially the idea is that
we're gonna go to that file so that is
zero seven user blah blah blah blah blah
your starter essentially this is where
we'll start setting up the logic and the
same is going to work for all of the
files and like I said if you want to see
let's say how the complete code looks
like you can simply take and you know
what let me close the sidebar I'll copy
and paste over here
and once I'm done with that I'm just
going to rename since we cannot use the
same name correct so I'm going to go
here with final and let's also look in
the final folder
so let's change things around and let's
look in a different folder just so you
don't think that I'm messing with you
I'm just gonna go to I don't know maybe
use effect or you know what let me go to
your state I'll show you a nice list so
let me go to use State again we're
looking for final
we're looking for use array so that's my
final and then as an example
I'll save it here and the notice will
have a list and we can remove some items
we can clear them and all that kind of
stuff so hopefully this is clear
effectively before each video I'm going
to show you which file we want to import
so let's say the first one is tutorial
use State star and then error example so
we want to import that in the app
jsx we want to render it and then we
want to navigate to that file and start
setting up the code together and again
if you want to look at any of the final
ones
just import the file and render it
somewhere here in the app jsxn
effectively my workflow is going to be
following
I'll simply
keep changing the file name so let's say
if I have this tutorial right now I just
go with forward slash your state and
again I know that all my examples are
going to start with starter and then I'm
just going to be changing files so
pretty much you can leave the setup here
as it is you're just changing the path
that's it that's all you have to do
unless you want to take a look at the
final one then of course I already
showed you what to do so let me go to
the arrow example that's the one where
we'll start and notice in this one we
just have a heading two so in here we
basically will code everything from
scratch now a few more things I want to
mention
there will be some challenges like I
said just so we can right away apply our
knowledge so if you keep scrolling
obviously over here you'll have the
first setup challenge so
in the beginning of each video where we
have the challenge effectively I'll just
read it to you
I'll try to explain as best as I can I
might show you
the final one just so you can see how it
looks like again I'm not going to show
you the code but I'm going to show you
how effectively the feature is supposed
to act and if you want you can work on a
challenge now some of them are purposely
essentially made to fail so you'll work
on a challenge and I'll right away tell
you hey you most likely hit this bug
because I want you to have a
Real World Experience what triggers the
bug and that way it's going to be easier
to remember
the possible solutions as well and one
last thing that I want to mention yes in
the beginning our examples are going to
be with numbers and buttons
just because we need to start with
something yes of course
as we progress with the topics
I purposely chose already more complex
examples just so it's not all the time
numbers and buttons but the first few
videos yes we'll have to utilize numbers
and buttons just so we can see the
workings of react hopefully everything
is clear if not utilize the course q a
and in the next video we're going to
start working on our first example the
error example
okay and let's start by taking a look
why we need a use State hook in the
first place which by the way we're going
to
cover in the next lecture
and essentially we'll run away start
with the challenge so I want you to
navigate to the file basically a
component and create a count variable
display the value in jsx add a button
and try to increase the value
now I can tell you right away that it's
not going to work basically you won't
see the latest changes in the browser so
I don't suggest
trying like 10 different options just
basically try the most obvious one and
then resume the video and yes
I'm not going to be extremely annoying
and I'm just gonna say this once if you
want to work on those challenges just
pause the video try to set it up and
then resume once you're ready to compare
the results
so let me just go to app jsx
let me check that I'm getting the right
component again we're looking in the
tutorial we'll start with zero on your
state star and then the arrow example so
let me navigate over here close and
somewhere here I'm gonna create my
account variable so I'm going to go let
count is equal to zero beautiful
then I want to display that value
somewhere and since at the moment I have
heading 2 and we know that we cannot
return adjacent elements I'm gonna turn
this into a div
then we're going to set up a heading 2
with the actual value so here I want to
display the count let me save and I see
the zero so that concludes this is
already a good start then we want to set
up the button
right away type is equal to a button
then we'll set up the unclick if you
want the arrow function you can
definitely do so in my case I'll set up
the reference and I'll just increase or
increment whatever
your heart desires and now let's set up
that function let's go over here let's
say const handle click
basically in here you want to go with
count count is equal
to count plus one correct and let me
right away even console log and you'll
see that technically everything works
but we won't say anything e in the
browser sorry for the spoiler so let's
go here let's save we have the button by
the way if you want to add
a little bit of styles you can go here
with class name
and you can go with button again this is
coming from Global stuff
and check it out everything is awesome
but as I'm clicking the button nothing
is happening
and actually if I take a look at the
console I can see that my logic works
so this is technically correct I am
updating this value
but nothing is happening why is that
well
because we're not triggering the
re-render
something we're going to do with use
statehook
so even though
this logic is awesome in vanilla
jazzland it's not going to work in react
if we want to see the latest changes
displayed in the browser in react we
need to set up a state value
and we need to trigger a re-render and
in the next video we're going to cover
how we can do that using use State hook
all right so how we can achieve our
previous functionality in react well we
need to use a hook basically a function
that react provides and the name is huge
State as a quick sign out during this
video will heavily rely on
the structuring array principle and if
you need to jog your memory or if you're
not familiar at all with this concept I
cover this in great detail in this
JavaScript nugget video and essentially
I just want to double check that I'm
importing correct components so notice
now I switch to use State Basics so
that's the second file and if we
navigate here this is what we will see
and effectively we want to import from
react the use statehawk now we have
multiple flavors we can do it this way
so notice this is going to be a named
import so unlike let's say react this is
written like this now we're actually
looking for the curlies and we go here
with euge State and this is coming from
react now I believe
vs code is going to try to help us so if
you type here you state notice you'll
right away get the import now
alternatively whatever logic we're going
to set up in a component you can also
type it this way you can just import
react and then go with react Dot and
then use State just as I say no this is
also going to work
so once we have the use State hook like
I said it's a function we want to invoke
that function and we want to pass in the
default value and let's start from the
very scratch let's just invoke it in a
log just so you can see that whatever
I'm telling
actually is true so let me save it let
me invoke it and you know what I'll
clean the console and I'll just refresh
and notice over here
like I said we have function we invoke
it
we'll need to pass here the default
value
and we get back two things we get an
array with undefined and we also have
the function so this is going to be our
state value which we're going to change
with the second argument with the
function and this also is going to be
preserved between the renders and don't
worry if the render re-render and all
that sounds kind of fuzzy actually we'll
spend the next video discussing them in
Greater detail so we have used statehook
this is where we need to pass in that
default value that's why we have right
now undefined so if I'm going to type
here Bob Yep this is going to be my
value if I'm going to type here one then
of course you can already guess that
I'll have the value over here one so
this is going to be my default value and
of course you can pass here array the
object and all that kind of stuff so
hopefully that's clear now let's discuss
how we can access these values now the
fastest way is to use array the
structuring but just to
kind of proved the point that I'm not
making this up I'll access them one by
one so let me comment this one out let
me just copy and paste and let me assign
to some kind of value so in here I'm
going to say that this is equal to hello
again we can change these values as we
want there's really no difference and
you know what
I'll actually remove this log I don't
need it anymore I'll log the value so
let me go here with const and this is
equal to a value and then since we're
getting back the array we can do it this
way where I'm accessing the first item
hopefully that is clear so if I go here
with value
you'll see over here that it's actually
hello so whatever default value that I'm
passing and if I'll copy and paste in
here and if I'll say func which actually
stands for function at me copying paste
here as well
and let's just log the function so two
things
the default value and the function that
controls that value
now y array the structuring is
technically better well because we can
use a one-liner so let me
common this one out
and let's keep on moving and notice over
here I can simply go with const then I'm
destructuring right away out items so in
my case I'm going to go with count and
set count
now as far as naming it is a convention
to go with set count basically whatever
is the variable name so if you have name
here then convention is to go set name
but you don't have to and I'll talk
about some other conventions as well for
example for booleans and all that then
we want to go with use State and we want
to pass in that value like I said we can
pass in the string we can pass in Array
we can pass in number whatever you want
to pass in this is going to be the
default value and this is going to be
the function that controls it again the
reason why we went the long route is
because
maybe some people are not familiar with
the syntax which is totally okay
the first time I saw this so I was also
like hey uh what's happening over here
so basically we're just destructuring
these values if you don't like the
syntax you can always use this one
but my guess is you'll stick with this
one and then in here let's pass in that
initial value in our case what is that
well we want to go with zero correct
so this is where we're going to start
then let's quickly again set up that
button I know that this is a little bit
of repetition but since we just started
working in jsx I think it's going to be
a good practice so let's go here with
heading four then we're gonna go with
you clicked and then let's grab the
actual count so notice not accessing
some random variable I'm actually
looking for the count one
so the one that I'm setting up with you
state and I'll just say times here then
we want to set up our button
so the same deal type is equal to button
then class name just so we have a little
bit of
CSS and now let's also again set up that
on click and we want to set up the
function
so in here we want to go with const and
let's call this handle click
and inside of that function what do we
want to do well we wanna
invoke the set count right so we're
gonna go here with set count and before
we pass the value I just want to mention
something very important
when we invoke set count technically we
can pass here anything
so if I'll pass here string of Bob yes
instead of number this will turn into a
string above just something to be aware
of now of course in our case we will
increase the count
but
this is a very important gotcha and I
see this a lot in the course q a so I'll
reference the handle click over here and
then as far as the count what do we want
to do well we want to go with count and
then plus one that kind of makes sense
right so let's save it
and by the way I didn't add anything in
a button let's say click me and now of
course
we'll see that in the browser and also
if you log you'll see that count is
nicely increasing so again let me remove
everything here and check it out
it's really cool
that now we're triggering that re-render
so every time we'll update this value
using the function the Handler function
we will also trigger a re-render
so unlike the previous example where we
were just updating the value we didn't
see anything now you can clearly see
that everything works and
also what's really awesome you state
preserves this value between the renders
now I'm not going to do this right now
since we have tons of examples coming
out but let's say if you were to set up
another button
and set up another
callback function that increases that
value
you'll see that this one will stay the
same between the render so it's not
going to go back to zero and again let
me just emphasize one more time that we
can pass here anything so we need to be
very careful I could go here with let's
say set count and I'll pass in the pants
because why not
so let me set up my pants here and check
it out I start nicely here with zero
everything is beautiful and then I have
you clicked pants times
which is great but probably not
something you were expecting so those
are the basics of you state again it's a
function that we get back from react
it returns an array with two elements
the current state value and a function
that we can use to update the state
value and in the function we want to
pass in the default value basically
whatever
we will set up in the state whether that
is string number array and blah blah
blah blah blah and then every time we'll
update that we will trigger the
re-render
and the cool thing is we'll see the
latest changes in the browser and also
that value will be preserved between
those re-render so if you have six use
State values and if you update one of
them rest of them will stay as they are
so they're not going to go back to zero
so those are the basics of use State and
up next
let's talk about renders re-renders and
all that cool stuff all right and before
we continue let's discuss two important
buzzwords render and re-render
so essentially when it comes to initial
render
it happens the first time that the
component tree is rendered to the Dom
basically it happens when the
application loads so of this
now there's another
use case when we toggle the component
but we haven't covered conditional
rendering yet
so for now don't worry about it we'll
come back to it once we actually cover
conditional rendering for now just
remember that
essentially when our application loads
that's when the initial render of the
component takes place and this is also
called mounting so we Mount the
component initial render happens and yes
later we'll also learn how we can
unmount the component
now when it comes to re-renders
they happen when the components state or
props change
so remember our previous example what we
were doing we were changing the state
value correct and as a result we were
re-rendering our component and
essentially we can
re-render component also when the parent
element re-renders again
something that will run into
quite a few times during tutorials so
once that happens I'll just say hey
remember we talked about it for now
just remember if you'll change the state
or perhaps or the parent re-renders
that's when essentially re-render takes
place hopefully this is clear and before
we discuss the general rules of hooks I
just wanna
change it back to correct one so it's
not going to be pants and I want to
stress one more time that let's say if
I'm gonna come up with another state
value
I'm going to say set name if you don't
want to import your state and if you
already have react keep in mind you have
to import react here then you can go
this way now this used to be more
popular when we have to import react for
every component we don't have to do that
anymore so notice both of them
effectively do the same thing as just
previously we needed to import react
and that's why it was somewhat
convenient just to avoid importing your
state but
since we don't have to import react I
mean I don't see the difference right
now you can either use use state or you
can import react just keep in mind that
both of them pretty much do the same
thing and with this in place now let's
talk about the general rules of hooks
awesome and now let's quickly discuss
the general rules of hooks
so all the hooks
the ones we get from react as well as
our custom one yes later we'll build our
own custom hooks they need to start with
use
so every time you see use and then some
kind of name
just remember it's a hook
so effectively all the hooks rules apply
now in order to work with a hook
component must be uppercase and this is
something we already discussed at the
very very very very beginning when we
talked about react fundamentals now also
we need to invoke
the hook inside of the component body
so if I'll try to do this over here
use State and then I don't know provide
something again it doesn't really matter
what
I'm just going to say here hello blah
blah blah invalid hook call so hooks can
be only called inside blah blah blah
blah something that I just mentioned so
that's something important to keep in
mind also don't call hooks conditionally
and again this is the topic that I'll
showcase once we are familiar with
conditional rendering because at the
moment I fully understand if you're
looking at it you're like what do you
mean by that and essentially long story
short you don't want to place for
example a hook inside of the
if commission so don't do it like this
don't say if and again the same deal set
up the EU state for example this is not
going to work regardless whether this
condition is true or not
this is not allowed so hooks all the
time need to be called in the same order
and lastly
set functions don't update the state
immediately and again this is something
we'll discuss later essentially don't
expect
V synchronous Behavior so for example if
I go here and log the count you'll see
that actually I'm going to be accessing
the old value notice even though this is
one the value in the console is zero
again something we're going to discuss
for now
just focus on the main ones it has to
start with use component must be
uppercase and we want to invoke it
inside of the function basically
component body not bad not bad I think
we are somewhat familiar with you state
and hooks in general
so why don't we
set up
a state value with array and in the
process we'll work on the little
challenge
so you'll need to go to zero three use
data array basically import it of course
in app jsx
and then
navigate to the file in there I want you
to import data and don't worry I'll show
you where the data is located
then I want you to set up State value
and the default is going to be the data
you're importing
now it's going to be a list and I want
you to render that in the browser again
something we already covered how we can
access the value it right over and then
display the results in a browser now
don't worry about CSS again that is
totally irrelevant if you can set up the
logic it's going to be already an
awesome result
and then once you can render the list in
the browser this is an extra challenge I
want you to create
two functions one that clears the entire
list
and second one
which removes the single item from the
list and just to Showcase what we're
looking for and you know what by the way
before the data is sitting over here so
if you navigate to the route you'll see
data GIS and then here we have this
array so this is what I want you to
import in that component and then first
render it in the browser now as far as
our final result
let me just copy and paste here
I'm going to call this final
again make sure that you of course
import the correct component and in here
I just want to change this to
I know
and let's also take a look what we have
so essentially this should be your
result like I said don't worry about the
CSS effectively you just wanna
render the name the button and also a
button to clear all the items so if you
click you remove that specific
person from the list if you click on
clear items obviously we are removing
all of them
and once you're done resume with the
videos
so let me first start by doing a bit of
spring cleaning we won't need that and
then we're not
I will actually leave
so I'm not going to render that
component but I'll leave this one just
in case
next time I need to access some final
component I already have the code I just
need to change the path and then we want
to navigate to use State all right in
the star over here and essentially let's
start by getting the data let's
jog our memory how we can do that using
es6
modules so in here we want to go and
import now this is a named one so we go
with data I already know that's the name
and notice you right away have the
correct suggestion where it is located
and then second I know I'm going to be
setting up the state value and just to
hammer this home I will set up my state
value with react dot used it and then
pretty much for rest of the course I'm
pretty sure I'm just going to import
your state so first let's go here with
import and we want to look for react
okay that's awesome and then let's go
with the const and that is equal to
people so this is what I'm going to be
setting up and then set people so one is
the state's value and then the second
one is the function that controls it and
let's go over here with react Dot
so react that and then we're looking for
use state
and what is default value well passing
the data
and now we want to essentially
set up our return
so at the moment we have heading 2
instead we're gonna have a div and
we're going to iterate over so I'll say
people map
and just so you don't think
that I'm making this up I'm just going
to go with return and you know what for
now let's just go with heading four and
let's call this item what I'm interested
is the person who I well because that's
going to give me access to this object
so if I navigate to data
check it out
so I have here ID and name so this is
what I'm going to log over here
so log
and let's look for the person
let's save notice we have four items
okay that's awesome
and also I'll see you over here
the object now we do have the warning
each child
and all that stuff don't worry we'll fix
that in a second so why don't we pull
out both of those properties we'll say
over here ID
and the person and that is equal to our
person right or I'm sorry this is not
person this is his name my bad so we
pulled these ones out I don't think we
need a log anymore or let me just leave
it here for your reference and then
let's go with our div
and be right away want to set up the
wiki so let's set it up here over here
key and that is equal to my ID and then
inside of it we want to go with heading
four and let's just render the name and
if everything is correct we shouldn't
see any warnings in the browser and we
have
nicely rendered our list in the browser
so that's the first step and up next
we're gonna work on
removing the items from the list all
right so now let's complete the
functionality and as a quick signal
during this video at least
I will rely heavily on filter method and
if you want to find out more info
you can just follow this URL where I
cover everything in great detail so
let's navigate back to our example
and essentially I want to set up two
functions one is going to be
for removing all the items in the second
one is going to be for removing a single
item so let's start with that one so
remove item for now I'm not going to
pass
anything in even though eventually yes
will pass in the parameter
and I mean if you want you can set up
the log but
I think in order to speed this up I'll
just copy and paste and I'll say clear
all items so that's my second function
then we want to set up two buttons
so we wanna
set up a button right here in a div and
also if you want to set up a button that
clears all the values and that one is
going to be outside of the curlers since
I'm not going to set it in the list so
first I guess let's just start with some
HTML elements I'm going to go with
button type that is going to be equal to
a button I'm not going to add
any classes it's going to be pretty
basic
we can nicely see the buttons and now
let's also set up that clear all so
let's go here button same deal type is
equal to a button then let's add a
little bit of styles just because I want
a margin so I'm going to go with margin
top and that is equal to two Rems
on click is coming up and now let's go
with clear
items and now let's go back to our tasks
so essentially this one and as a note
I actually need to add here class name
and then that is equal to a BTN
so this one
we want to use to remove all the items
correct so what do we need to do well we
have people and set people currently
it's equal to what to our data array how
we can remove all items well we can set
people equal to an mtra by just using
set people so if I go with clear all
items and I say set people and set it
equal to an empty array I'll move
automatically all the items and since
we're updating the state value we will
trigger what will trigger re-render and
of course
as a result
we'll see the latest changes in the
browser so let's go over here let's say
on click that's the event and now we
just want to pass the reference so let's
say clear
all and items
let's save that
Let's test it out yep we remove all the
items from the list now just so we are
aware remember we can pass here the
arrow function as well
so just for your reference we can do it
this way you can go with arrow function
and then set people invoke and pass in
the value again this is very very
important concept and yes I'm getting
quite a few questions in the course q a
both of them achieve the same result so
keep in mind if you see this code
essentially it's just a shorter version
of this one and as far as the remove
item well let's think about it so we
have IDs correct so those are unique to
each item now how we can remove a
specific item from array well we can use
a filter method
where we're going to grab the ID
whatever it is one two three four and
essentially we'll just remove that one
item whose ID matches and then we'll set
the people equal to that new array so
let's try this one out
first again I just want to emphasize the
point that
each item right away have that unique
value when it invokes the remove item so
let's say here I'm going to go with ID
parameter and log an ID and if I go back
to the div that I'm returning notice
over here if I go with on click and
first of all if I want to invoke
remove item right away I do need to set
up the arrow function first and I'm not
going to go back to this topic we
literally spent like I believe three
videos on that in the fundamentals so if
you are a little bit confused please go
back and re-watch those videos so remove
item I'll pass in the Eddie and you'll
see nicely
once you click on remove that each item
basically has that unique ID so whatever
we'll pass over here
is going to be unique to that item so
like I said what can we do well we can
create new array so const new people
that is equal to what well filter
returns a new array right so we go with
State value then we go here with filter
and then we need to pass in the Callback
function
now in a callback function I'll
reference each item as a person and I'll
say if the person
ID
does not match then return basically
filter is looking for a flag
and if it matches then it's going to
return in this case if the ID doesn't
match then it's going to return
that person to a new people
if it does match
then essentially it's going to exclude
it so we go here with set people and we
set it equal to any new people
that's it that's all we have to do let's
come in this one out and notice how one
by one basically we can remove the items
from the array and
if you're wondering can we pass this
entire logic directly and set people
the answer is yes
so you can also do something like this
grab this line
don't set up the variable and right away
pass in the functionality remember this
returns a new array at the end of the
day
so yes this will also work notice I can
nicely remove John so that's how we can
set up
a state value as an array and right away
make it Dynamic by just adding a few
buttons as well as the functionality and
as you can see we are basically relying
on all the concepts we cover in
fundamentals
the difference well now we're using this
one line of code we're basically using
the use state which allows us to change
that value and every time we change the
value we trigger what we trigger
re-render and as a result we see the
latest changes in the browser all right
and before we start setting up the
object as a state value now let me
quickly answer the question which most
likely I'm going to get in the course q
a
and the question is following since now
we know you state should we go back to
let's say previous project the back
roads one and effectively add huge state
in each instance we're reiterating over
the list and honestly the answer really
depends on what you're going to be doing
with the list
so of course if you'll be manipulating
the list if you'll be removing the items
adding the atoms and all that kind of
stuff then of course you will definitely
need use state
if you know that data is not going to
change
then of course you can leave it the way
it is I mean nothing bad is going to
happen so what I'm trying to say there
is no rule that you definitely have to
use State however it is a common
practice even if let's say you're not
going to be doing anything with list
you get used State you set it up and
that way if you ever want to change
something about list well you already
have a state value so long story short I
wouldn't go back to the previous project
and change it I would leave it the way
it is but in the future when you are
iterating over the list yes setting up a
state value is a good practice okay and
up next let's work on
setting up the state value as an object
and before we do anything
let's just see why that would be useful
in the first place just like we did for
example with huge state
and also in the process
will right away utilize whatever we
learned in the previous lessons so
here's what I want you to do navigate to
starter and then you're looking for huge
State object and you know what let me
grab quickly that file here
just so you have it for your reference
in the readme
over here and you're looking for zero
four and I believe the name was use
State object over here
so you want to import that of course in
the app jsx you want to navigate to that
file and you want to set up three state
values not in my case it's going to be
name age and let's say a hobby
set up all of them with use State
basically one by one render them and
then create a button
and every time the user clicks the
button invoke a function which updates
all three state values
so as a result once you click the button
different person is going to be
displayed in the browser so let's say
these are my default values peer Pages
24 and Peter enjoys reading books now
once I click on show John I'll have John
28 and John enjoys screaming at the
computer
and once we have this one in place we'll
refactor to object just so you can see
the actual use case so let's navigate to
the object one in the star and you know
what
pretty sure I can just comment this one
out for now
and uh want to go to that file over here
and I already have the huge state so I
already imported for you and effectively
you want to set up those State values so
one by one so const
let's go in here with name
set
name and that is equal to use State and
whatever is the default and like I said
Mike is going to be Peter right away
copying paste and we want to change some
things around where this is not going to
be name it's going to be age
we'll go with set age and
this one is going to be number so let's
go with 24.
then we want to go with that Hobby
Lobby
and then set Hobby
and that one will be equal to
well I guess let's go with reading books
because that is really nice so
say read books awesome then let's render
that
and this is the case where I'm going to
use the fragment
sure so we can jog our memory how we can
do that so that's my fragment and then
heading three
let's go with name copy and paste and
effectively I want to set up rest of
them so one two and after that we'll
have the button so why don't we do this
why don't we go with heading 4 here
first one name second one page
and let's add enjoys
otherwise scream at the computer might
be a bit confusing so let's say here
Hobby
and let's right away set up that button
so let's save okay we have initial value
and basically we want to go here with
button and we want to go to class name
BTN
and we want to add on click and
let's set up a function
from here let's go with cons display
person
first let's just set up the structure
and then we'll worry about
the actual logic
so let's say here display portion and
I'm gonna write here show John since I
know that's what I'm going to be doing
so let's say okay we have the button and
then
it's pretty straightforward if I want to
change all of these three values yes
this is what I'll have to do one by one
I'll go with set and name what is the
name well that is going to be John and
you can probably or guess the other ones
so age as well as the hobby so we simply
need to change here page
and this one will be for example 28. and
then lastly we have set Hobby and this
is where I'll type scream at the
computer so scream
at the computer
okay good now we need to change this one
to a hobby of course and like I said
it's very straightforward
you have 15 values over here
if you have this type of setup where
each value has its own Handler function
essentially you'll have to call them one
by one
and therefore in the next video we'll
take a look at the object example okay
and before we refactor our example to
one state value which is going to be an
object
why don't we do a little quiz so
remember when we discussed use State I
mentioned that pretty much every time
we'll update the state value will
trigger rearrender
now in this example we have three
Handler functions
so ten thousand dollar question do you
think we're going to trigger three
re-renders
or it's going to be only one
and if you guessed only one you're
absolutely correct
you see behind the scenes
react is using technique called Auto
batching
to effectively group the update
so what that means in our example even
though we have three handle functions
it's only going to trigger one re-render
now
prior to react 18
there were actually some instances where
yes
such a code basically when we have
multiple Handler functions would trigger
three re-renders but that's not the case
anymore with reactating so in react 18
pretty much every time you have multiple
Handler functions yes
it will trigger only one re-render
beautiful so our functionality Works
technically everything is fine but we
can save some lines of code if we
refactor this to an object
and of course
it's going to make even more sense if
you have more State values what do you
think is easier to have one object that
has let's say 10 Properties or to have
10 State values again it depends on the
use case of course
if you have
a use case for 10 separate values then
of course don't just randomly group them
together but let's say alert example
what is usually in the alert well you
want to know whether it's going to be
displayed so basically there's going to
be a Boolean value true or false you
probably also want to know whether it's
going to be danger or success whether
it's going to be some red alert or it's
going to be green and you also probably
want to change the text so that's a
perfect example where actually you don't
have to set them up one by one
you can just group them together
in one object so here's what I want to
do I want to go with const
and I'm going to call this person and
set person
now this is going to be equal to my use
state
and here we'll pass in my object
and
as far as the properties well we use the
same ones
we'll say name is equal to
Peter
and let's copy and paste one two and
let's just change these values around as
well so we're going to go here with age
that will be equal to
24 yep you're exactly correct and then
lastly we have our Hobby
so we go here with Hobby
and we'll go with read books
now I can remove all
these new States we won't need them
anymore and we also don't need to call
them one by one
so now I can go with one function which
is set person and I just need to provide
the object here I'll say John first then
age
28 and then I'll say the hobby is equal
to scream
at the
computer and once I save I actually get
an error why well because remember now
our state is an object so we can either
destructure it over here one by one just
grab the properties or
we need to go with person
.name
then we're looking for person.age
and then lastly of course we have person
and hobby correct so let's do that let's
save and now everything should work so
once I click check it out now I have the
new values now be aware of the gotchas
remember
we can pass whatever value in the set
function so even though this is an
object I can pass the string and what do
you think is going to happen well our
application is going to somewhat break
because there is no more object so let's
try this one out first I'll copy and
paste or I'm sorry I'll comment this one
out my bad so go here with set person
and then let's say shake and bake and
what do you know the moment I save the
moment I click I'm nothing rendered why
well again there is no object anymore so
I simply have the enjoys these ones
they're undefined so that's the first
thing to be aware of
second
you can also overwrite by just providing
one property or two basically not all of
the properties so in this example we
provided all of the properties so it was
kind of hard to mess it up but what if I
go here and say set person and I just
say you know what I want to change the
name I don't want to change the other
ones I just want to change the name well
now I'll only have a object with a value
of Susan so let's go here let's click
and check it out again the other ones
they're not there anymore because this
is the new state value this is the
object now a way around it is
effectively to just copy the properties
from the state
so first let's just copy and paste let's
uncommon this one and
first we want to copy all the values and
then we just need to decide which ones
we want to overwrite
so I'm grabbing all of the properties
with all of the values and if I just
want to overwrite one of them I say name
is equal on whatever value so in this
case there isn't so now everything is
going to work we'll still preserve those
current values so if I click over here
notice it changes to Susan hopefully
this is clear again
it's not a solution for
every use case of course there's going
to be use cases where you will have
multiple State dollars but this is a
Nifty approach
if you can
effectively group together the state
values since it's just going to save you
time on setting up the logic again be
aware of the gotchas it's very easy to
override the value and then run around
like a headless chicken and look for the
bug
okay before we wrap up your state and
move on to the next topic let's also
cover set function gotcha which by the
way we already touched upon and let's
take a look at the fix and a good use
case for using the effects and first
let's just set up a trivial challenge
let's go to the file here's State gotcha
installer all that and set up the state
value so again practice on setting up
the use State create a button like I
said in the beginning we'll have these
buttons don't worry in next examples
we'll start making more complex setups
add functionality to increase by one and
log the state value right after the set
function
and see what is going to be the result
so again let me just double check yep
and here I'm in Houston
okay that's awesome and then in the
gotcha
first I'm gonna get the use State here
so let me try the Auto Import yep that
works as far as the initial value I'm
going to go with zero and then
value and the function well
I'm not going to be particularly
original and I'm just gonna go with set
value so that is equal to my view State
okay awesome
after that we want to right away create
that handle click since I know that it's
going to be there so handle click that's
my function and in here
I just want to set up increase by one
so it's going to be equal to set value
and let's go with Value Plus one so the
gotcha is not here
again this is going to work as expected
then let's navigate to our jsx
we want to change this around it's not
going to be hitting two it's going to be
heading 1. with our value
so that is going to be correct here and
then let's also set up that button type
is equal to a button so button here
and let's add a class name class name
will be equal to BTN and let's say
increase and let's also not forget about
the handle click so on click
is equal to handle click
so once we have this one in place like I
said the gotcha is not in this setup so
this is going to work
what I want you to keep in mind
that this is not going to happen
synchronously
so if you log here the value
this won't be already the new value
notice once I refresh once I start
clicking this is one behind
so here I have the seven
and actually in the console I have a six
and again the problem is going to be if
you have some kind of functionality that
relies on that latest value
and in the following video we'll see how
we can get that latest value which
basically is the most recent State
update all right so now that we know set
function is not going to be synchronous
now let's look at the solution you see
there's another way how we can update
the state and that is using the function
approach so
instead of passing the new state value
like we have been doing for the last
whatever videos
we can actually pass in the function and
as a first parameter by default we get
the current state now since this is a
parameter yes
Bobby Lee or Joe Coy is an awesome name
but a more common convention is to call
this current state previous state Old
State whatever I mean again you can name
this banana it's still going to work and
yes it's by default provided
by react
it effectively just provides whatever
you have currently in a state so in this
case it would provide that number right
before the update and then in here we
just need to set up the functionality
where essentially we must return
something and this is one of the gotchas
with this approach
if you don't return anything it will
right away fail why well because there
is no value anymore it's now going to be
undefined remember in JavaScript
functions return by default what they
return undefined so you must return that
value
and whatever you're going to return from
that function that is going to be the
new value so let's try this one out but
essentially
I'm going to remove this one we'll pass
in the function yes this is what we're
doing we're passing function into the
set value that's the approach and like I
said if you simply
just leave it the way it is this is
going to be undefined now I do want to
showcase that we'll access the state
value and again in my case I'm going to
call this current state so this is the
state right before the update hopefully
that is clear and yes
the reason why I'm being so annoying and
repeating that this is provided by react
because
this is also one of those things that I
see a lot in cost q a yes we're not
doing anything
right out of the gate reactus provides
that value so let's go here with current
state and I'm purposely returning
nothing just so you can see that
essentially the functionality is not
going to work notice we get back
undefined now we did get the correct
zero over here right so if we have some
kind of functionality that relies on
that latest value we need to use this
approach now since I'm recording this in
tutorial I'm going to be more explicit
keep in mind that of course you can
simply return that new value in my case
though I'm going to go with const then
I'll say new state is equal to and then
I'm just going to go with current state
and then plus one and now let's just go
with the return
and new state and I'm not gonna log the
new state hopefully it's clear that yes
it's going to be latest value so we go
here and notice everything still works
only in this case we access that very
latest value and in the following video
we'll take a look at nice example where
such approach makes a lot of sense now
before you ask
do your after setup
set functions every time with function
I mean
it's really up to you there's going to
be some instances where you definitely
need to do that
something we're going to cover in the
next video
but should you go back and now refactor
every set function instance of this one
no I mean if it works with just a
regular approach where you're passing
the new value you can definitely leave
it some people use function for
everything
that's pretty much their preference
there's nothing wrong with that but
there is no clear rule that you always
always have to use this one again
there's going to be some instances where
you must use it otherwise the
functionality is not going to work but
if you're just changing I don't know a
list to an empty list no you don't have
to pass in the function you can just
pass in the new value all right and now
let's take a look at the good use case
where we need to use
function approach and for that for now
I'm just going to remove this one and
set everything from scratch and let's
imagine that we want to invoke
the functionality in some time and for
that we are going to use the set timer
and essentially
if you just pass here the set timer
you'll see that the functionality won't
work as expected so let's try this one
out I'm going to navigate back let's say
set timeout so now effectively I want to
change that value in some time let's say
three seconds
as we know we need to pass here the
Callback function first and then the
second in how long like I said in my
example it's going to be three seconds
and then let's simply go with set value
and then let's type Value Plus One now
what is our expectation first of all
well our expectation is that every time
we will click the button let's say five
times this is going to be invoked so set
timeout is going to be invoked and then
after three seconds we're going to get
that
latest Value Plus one so if I click five
times my expectation is
that I'm gonna see over here
value five correct are we on the same
page hopefully we are so let's refresh
and one two three four five
and the value did change in three
seconds but
it's definitely not five and I can click
all day long and the same thing is going
to happen
and if you don't believe me we can set
up a log over here
otherwise you might be thinking okay
he's just not clicking the button so
clicked the button let's try one more
time I apologize if you find this
annoying one two three four five
and
should see over here five yep so this is
correct I did click it five times
but again the value does not change now
why is that happening oh you see in our
callback function when we invoke set
value
we're not grabbing the latest value
we are grabbing the value that is within
these three seconds so essentially what
I'm saying
let's imagine that I'm gonna click the
button 100 times in those three seconds
all of them will reference this value of
zero and only once we switch then the
value is going to become 2. so again
regardless of how many times I click I'm
not updating that value right away or
here I'm just saying yep please update
that value
but I'm all the time using that old
value hopefully that is clear again you
can click five more times or six or
whatever again if that happened within
those three seconds it's all that I'm
gonna be using the value right before we
invoke the Callback function first time
hopefully that is clear now what is the
solution now we know how we can use the
function approach right
so we can pass in the function again we
have access right now to the latest the
current state value which by the way
will increase as we're clicking on a
button and then we just return the new
state value so in this case I'm going to
say current
and State
and we want to go with return
and let's go with current state plus one
and now you'll see that
or functionality works where essentially
again if I refresh and if I click
whatever times
in those three seconds I'll nicely
increase the state value
by the amount of times I clicked on a
button hopefully it's clear
we're pretty much done with use state
and we are ready to move on to our next
topic and up next let's talk about
another important hook called use effect
and we're gonna start just like the
other examples basically in the app GSX
we want to navigate this time to zero to
use effect we're looking for the starter
and we're gonna go with code example and
just like with use state
the first thing we're going to do is to
understand why do we need a use effect
in the first place and in order to do
that basically we'll take a look how the
code inside of the component runs
so let's navigate to that file you
should see on a screen something like
this value equals to zero and a button
so let me navigate over here and this
shouldn't look too foreign so we have
over here huge State we import that we
set up the value set value use State and
then of course I have jsx and what do
you know I'm updating the value and
again the gotcha is not over here
now let's talk about how the code runs
inside of the component
so let's say if I set up a function and
I'm going to call this say hello so
const say
and hello so that is equal to my
function
and inside of the function what do you
know I just simply want to set up some
console log
I want to go with log and hello there a
million dollar question again we're
doing the quiz yes you got that right so
previous time we went for ten thousand
dollar question why don't we go for a
million this time
so million dollar question
if I have a function over here
and if I invoke it and as I say not yes
the function declaration can be
somewhere else for example it can be in
different file or it can be above the
component my question is
if I invoke this function inside of the
component
how often do you think it's going to run
and possible choices
we have initial render basically when
the component mounts like so so once I
refresh
only then the function is going to
execute then I have after every render
and as I know you can already kind of
see that it's definitely happening when
the component mounts then we have after
every render
and then we have I don't know randomly
after every third render and if you
guessed that it's actually happening
after every render you are absolutely
correct basically the initial render
which again happens when the component
mounts in this case when we load the
application let's say when we refresh
the browser and all that and also every
time we re-render
because what are we doing over here
remember we use state every time we'll
change the value we will re-render
correct
so let's try this one out
notice I start clicking and what do you
know in the console I have bunch of
hello there's
now it's not a good thing or a bad thing
it's just a fact that's how it works if
you have some kind of function here that
is being invoked
and for example this declaration yes
it's going to be set up pretty much from
scratch every time so every time we'll
re-render
react is going to create this function
and also if you invoke the function it
will run the code
now when do we need to be careful
well when we update the state why
because we can trigger infinite Loop so
let me showcase that I'm going to add
comment here so be careful
you will have infinite Loop
now how can we have infinite Loop if we
update the state value inside of this
function so let's go over here with set
value and then I'm going to go to Value
Plus One and before we run it let's
discuss why we're gonna have the
infinite Loop well let's think about it
so we have initial render this is where
we set up the state value and also we
set up the function and we invoke it
now inside of the function what do we do
we trigger re-render correct we go with
Value Plus One
so when we re-render again we do the
same thing we create a state value and
we set up the function inside of the
function we do what we update the state
value and hopefully you see where I'm
going with this
so hopefully this is clear and now let
me just save the file and you'll right
away see a bunch of errors in console so
again just be careful yes there are
going to be times when you will set up a
function here actually by the end of the
section I'll share a resource where
you'll see that
react is somewhat pushing for it
instead of using a bunch of use effects
to use functions like this but again
there are nuances we need to be mindful
when we set up such functions there's
nothing wrong with setting them up the
gotcha is you don't want to update the
state in such a fashion because yes you
will have an infinite Loop and that's
why in the next video we'll cover use
effect and how use effect helps us to
run code
conditionally in our application
basically we'll be able to choose when
do we want to run certain code inside of
our component all right so now let's get
familiar with use effect hook so in the
app.js I'm importing or I guess app.jsx
I'm importing the second one use effect
Basics and you'll notice that pretty
much it's the same starting point so if
I go here yes I have the same function I
have the log now in this case I'm not
updating the state value and I also have
my state value on a button and
essentially when it comes to use effect
hook in react it allows us to perform
side effect in the function component
now there's no need for Urban Dictionary
basically any work outside of the
component and if at the moment it
doesn't make any sense
trust me it's going to be more useful if
we cover some examples essentially it's
things like subscriptions fetching data
fetching data is by the way very popular
or let's say if we want to directly
update the Dom remember in vanilla.js we
can select the Dom nodes with things
like query selector and all that
this is where you would do that we also
can set up some event listeners and
timers and all that kind of stuff we'll
pretty much cover all of these examples
so
please just be patient and essentially
when it comes to use effect hook
we import use effect it's looking for
two arguments the second one is optional
and the first one is the Callback
function
and effectively whatever you have inside
of that Cobalt version is going to run
now by default by default it runs after
every render
which means pretty much initial render
and re-renders but there's a caveat
where we can provide the dependency
array and somewhat important we cannot
return a promise from the Callback
function so let's tackle all of those
things first we want to import use
effect from react whatever we do we
simply go with use and then the name is
use effect like I said hook starts with
use so all the hooks our hooks react
hooks they will start with use okay that
is clear
then let's go I guess pass say hello and
let's just go with huge effect like I
said it's looking for two arguments the
first one is going to be the Callback
function which is going to be invoked
well that depends what we have
independency array by default it's going
to be invoked after every render so
let's try this one out let's go here
with the function again you can pass the
reference you can pass here the arrow
function that is really up to you and
let's go here with log and I'm going to
say hello from and use effect
and what you'll notice that
we have few loaders so let me refresh
basically I want to start from scratch
and
you'll also see hello from use effect
and basically every time I'll click
we'll have both of those logs and as
you're looking at you're like well wait
a minute pal
we were supposed to fix this issue while
you're showing us the use effect well
remember
this is the default Behavior so by
default it runs on each render however
there's a second argument that we can
pass which technically isn't optional
but I mean quite often you'll pass that
argument and that is the dependency
array and if we set up the dependency
area empty
then it's only going to run on the
initial render so let's try this one out
like I said second argument so we go
here with comma and then we pass in the
dependency array so now once I save
check it out
you'll see that yes we have the initial
render and all that everything is
beautiful
but once we click the button actually
you won't see the second log in the
console so notice over here I only have
the hello there however the login
use effect only runs
in the initial render that's it so
that's the biggest difference if we have
just a plane function or we invoke the
function inside of the
component yes it's going to run
on initial render and on every re-render
our with use effect we can start
controlling when this functionality
around
now lastly I just want to mention that
from this function we don't want to
return a promise so
later on we'll be setting up
functionality to fetch data and a pretty
common approach is to go with a sync
right so we set up our function to be a
sync and then we can wait for something
fetch axios whatever
now we cannot do that with use effect
because there's a special thing that we
are returning from this use effect
something we're going to cover a cleanup
function and remember a sync functions
what do they return do I need to do
another quiz or no I think no so I'm
just gonna tell it to you async
functions return promise
so if we set up this function as a sync
it will return a promise and use effect
is not okay with that now keep in mind
within the Callback function I can still
set up a synchronous function and invoke
it so if I go here with some funk I set
it up as a sync and basically have the
await
keyword inside of it and again just for
sake of it I'm gonna go with Fetch and
I'm not going to provide anything and if
I invoke something this is okay you just
don't want to set up the first argument
the Callback function that we're
providing as a sync and don't worry once
we start fetching data most likely I'll
come back and discuss this particular
thing one more time so now let me just
remove that let's save and hopefully
it's clear that we have use effect talk
we import that from react we invoke it
and we provide few things
we provide a callback function which is
going to be invoked
pretty much after every render unless we
provide here a dependency array in that
case if we have dependency array and if
it's empty
the functionality inside of the use
effect is only going to run once
only when the component mounts on the
initial render unlike the regular
function which is going to be
declared and invoked
on initial render and also on every
re-render okay and up next let's talk
about dependency array and how we can
have multiple user effects in our
application
so in the app.js we want to navigate to
zero three and multiple effects and once
we navigate to this file you'll see use
State you'll see user effect and
essentially two State values
this is the case where I didn't see the
point of creating all of this from
scratch there's always so many times
when creating a button and a state value
is useful and notice over here we have
two heading ones in the jsx with two
buttons and guess what pretty much every
time we'll click we'll update that state
value and let's start with the simple
fact that yes you can have as many use
effects in your component as you want so
pretty much you can set up a use effect
for every smallest feature now just
because you can doesn't mean you should
and again I'm going to return to the
point that at the very end of this
section I'll show you a very useful
resource which is going to cover all of
these cases in more detail so please be
patient for now just remember just
because you can have like 10 use effects
in your component doesn't mean that you
should do that and essentially if I go
here with the first use effect if I
uncomment we'll see that basically once
I refresh
there is initial load right so this is
where we'll have that console log and
all that and then pretty much every time
we'll update the state values I mean
we'll see nothing in the console and the
same deal we can set up another use
effect that also is going to run only
when the application loads and again I
can keep clicking all day long and I'll
only see those two logs in the console
so that covers multiple use effects yes
you can have them in the component
doesn't mean that you can only have one
use effect
now also let's talk about this
dependency array notice how when it's
empty it only runs when the component
mounts correct but we can provide values
over here so if I'm going to go here
with value which essentially is my first
one you'll notice that not only this
user Factor runs
when the component mounts and again for
that I'll have to refresh but also
when we update this value
so this is already very powerful where
not only this functionality is invoked
on the mount but also when we're
clicking on the first button however
it's not going to happen if we click on
the second one it's only going to happen
if I add the second value over here
yes at that point
we'll have a log when we click on the
first one as well as the second one and
as you can see this is very powerful
stuff since I can have one use effect
for one value and then the second one is
going to be for the second one and you
can probably already guess that the
first one is only going to show up if we
click over here and then the second one
is going to be when we click on the
second button and of course you're not
limited to the amount of values you can
pass over here you can start with empty
dependency array and then you can have
three five or whatever so that again
really depends on situation just keep in
mind few things first you can have
multiple use effects again I'm not
saying you should but you can and then
the second one is the dependency array
where we can pass
multiple values and every time that
value is going to change we will invoke
the functionality inside of the Callback
function one more time and once we're
familiar with the user effect basics
why don't we work on a little challenge
we're essentially I want you to
fetch some GitHub users from the URL and
render them on the screen
now before we continue let me just
mention that during this video I will
use fetch API and yes I'm fully aware
that there's Library called axios and in
fact we will
use it later on in the course we'll have
tutorial and then for more complex
projects we'll definitely use axios and
if you're not a fan of fetch you can
definitely install axios and use it but
in my opinion for simple examples fetch
is good enough now if you're not
familiar with fetch at all then I
suggest utilizing this link effectively
this is the Jazz nuggets video where I
cover fetch API from scratch and as far
as the challenge we want to go to app
jsx we want to get the star from zero
four fetch data
and essentially in there we want to set
up the state and set up the use effect
and as far as the users the default
value is going to be empty all right
then set up a user effect but make sure
that it only runs on initial render keep
in mind that the URL I provided it has
some rate limits so if you'll just be
randomly testing out stuff by omitting
the dependency array well you'll exceed
that limit then you'll basically have to
wait to work on the challenge
then in the Callback function in the
user effect create a function which
performs fetch functionality
and use the URL I provided in Star file
now you can go with that then or async
that's really up to you so either you
can set up the async function or since
fetch returns a promise you can go with
that 10. and for now I suggest just
logging
so if you're somewhat confused just try
to set up fetch functionality and log
them
nothing more
just log the users if you can log the
users you already in good shape
now if you want to challenge yourself
more then set up users equal to a result
just remember that fetch returns a
promise we need to go with that then and
then we need to return that Json in
order to get the data and I want to set
that result from that Json equal to my
users
the state value and then I want to
iterate over the list and basically
display them
now I don't suggest worrying about CSS
it doesn't really matter
you can show them in any way you want
effectively I just want to show the
profile the link to the profile as well
as their image that's it and a tiny hint
if you don't want to deal with big
images and if you don't want to set them
up in CSS just add inline style for that
image and set up the width for I don't
know 50 pixels or something along those
lines again go to the file try to set up
the logic if you can log that's already
a awesome start and once you're ready to
compare the results continue with the
videos beautiful so now let's start
working on a challenge I'll comment out
the final one in the app jsx just so
it's not in the way
then we want to navigate to fetch data
and you can either use Auto Import or
you can go
basically with import and then those two
values I'll try to use the Auto Import
I'm going to go to use State yep that's
what we're getting from react and like I
said I'll set it equal to a users and
the default value here is going to be an
empty array so I'm going to go users and
then set users now that is equal to my
use State and as far as my default value
I'm going to provide empty array after
that let's set up that user effect so
let's go here and say use effect
notice we have nice Auto Import and I
pretty much always start just by logging
stuff because I don't want to set up the
functionality and then it turns out that
I don't know I'm invoking it the wrong
way or something along those lines
so I'm gonna go ahead with log and I'm
going to say hello let's save it and let
me check
yep I am nice hello in the console and
again please please please please please
please add over here the empty
dependency array otherwise you'll pretty
much have to wait to work on the
challenge you'll right away exceed the
rate limit and you'll have to wait I
believe like 15 minutes or something
along those lines so once we have the
use effect whatever we want to do well
we want to fetch data from this URL
correct and like I said we don't want to
set up this function as async because
for example in my case I'm going to use
a single weight
so I want to set up the fetching
function as a sync
but we cannot do that with the Callback
function that's not allowed what we can
do though is to set up a sync function
inside so I'm going to remove the hello
and I'm going to come up with a function
I'll call this fetch data
this is going to be my async function
and I'm not going to provide the URL
here I'm just going to say empty
parameters and all that
and I'm going to start by just waiting
for fetch so response that is equal to a
weight and then Fetch and let's provide
the URL like I said effectively this is
going to return a promise and I want to
turn this into a Json
so I'm going to go here with const users
and that is equal to a weight and then
we want to go with response and then Dot
and then Json like so we want to save
that and like I said
we just want to start by logging stuff
so in here I'm going to say users and if
in the console
I'll nicely see the users that are
coming from this URL we're good to go
now what's the problem well I'm not
invoking it correct so I'm going to go
here with Fetch and then data and check
it out once I refresh notice now I have
all my users
now when it comes to sync functionality
it's a good practice to set this up in
try catch just in case you have any
errors now I can tell you right away
that when it comes to fetch it doesn't
treat 404 as an error so unlike the
axios which essentially is going to run
the code inside of the catch if you have
404 that's not the case with the fetch
one that's kind of a gotcha so first let
me just cut this one out over here I'll
place this one inside of the try and I'm
just going to lock the error but again
if you'll go here and change the url for
example to users you'll see that
basically the error is not going to run
so go here with error and then again let
me go here with users and then notice
yes we do have an error but it's
actually called in line 13.
so we're not invoking the catch one over
here just again something to keep in
mind because for example axials if you
have 404 yes then the functionality is
going to be invoked in the catch that's
just a tiny side note so once I have the
users what I can do well we can set our
users equal to whatever users we're
getting back correct so why don't we do
this I'm going to go with set users
equals to the users and of course now I
do need to fix the URL
let's save it over here
and if you want you can actually go to a
big browser and let's test out the state
value so let me navigate to the big
browser I'm gonna go with the new tab
and all that
and I want to paste that 5173a
and if we inspect again we can take a
look at the console if we're logging or
we can simply go with components then we
have the fetch data and notice I have
the user effect so I have my function
and I also have my state value so if
we're successful this is what we're
gonna see we'll have this array of users
in the state and like I said that's why
the react Dev tools are so powerful
because you can right away pretty much
get the info okay that's good now let me
remove all these errors and all that I
don't think they're useful and now let's
just worry how we'll render them so
let's navigate to the jsx
and we'll start by setting up the
section so I guess I'm just going to
remove this one there's no need here so
section then inside of this section I'm
going to go with heading three and let's
just come up with some kind of value so
GitHub and users let's save that and
then we want to go with an ordered list
and actually already set up this CSS in
the CSS file so if you'll navigate to
index CSS and if you look for users
you'll see that basically there is
already some CSS attached to it
and essentially this is what you can use
if you want again the CSS part is really
irrelevant
the main point of this challenge was to
set up the logic so let's go here with
another list let's right away add a
class of users and then instead of that
on our list I want to iterate over so
I'm going to go here with users then I'm
going to go with map so we're mapping
over and I'll reference each and every
item as a user now for now let's just
return
the list item with some kind of value
and why I'm doing that because I want to
log and show you what is inside of the
user so let's go here with return list
item and I'm just going to say item
again there's going to be a warning
don't worry about it and yes I already
have a little bit of CSS over there but
if we log we should see what properties
we have inside of that user
so let me scroll up I mean all of them
are going to be the same but I'm going
to start with the first one and check it
out so we have the Avatar URL
effectively this is where we can get the
picture
we also have the login that is going to
be the user account and we have HTML URL
which leads back to the profile and also
we have a ID why do we need ID well
because we have the key correct so what
we can do
we can pull out those properties so I
can say here const and then ID then
login then Avatar and underscore URL
HTML underscore URL and all of that is
equal to my user and then as far as the
return well now let's provide the key
that's the first thing so here we'll go
with ID and then as far as the item I
want to place the image and I want to
set up the div again if you don't want
to use my CSS I just suggest adding the
inline for the image
otherwise they're going to be pretty big
as far as I remember so image now for
the source we want to go here with
Avatar URL alternative I'm just going to
provide the login
it's kind of a shortcut in here
and then right after that we want to go
with div
and then inside of the div we're gonna
go with heading five and we'll display
the name so let's go here with login and
then lastly let's set up that link that
navigates back and if you're interested
in the CSS again please just reference
the index CSS C essentially the styles
that I added they're not that many so
let's go here and let's go for HTML URL
and then instead of the link I just say
profile let's save that and this is what
we should see on the screen essentially
a list of GitHub users hopefully
everyone enjoyed the challenge and I'll
see you in the next video all right as
you can see in the readme technically
our next topic should be use effect
cleanup function however we'll actually
skip this and the following user effect
topic and come back to them once we're
done with conditional rendering
if you're wondering why are we hopping
like that
simply because use of a cleanup function
is somewhat tricky topic
so in this course iteration I decided to
use different example in the hopes that
it will help students to understand the
main Concepts better
and since in the example we're going to
toggle component
we first need to cover conditional
rendering yes I also prefer to cover
everything step by step
essentially in order but in this case
I did not see any other option
so again let me repeat we will skip use
effect cleanup function for now and come
back to it once we're done with our next
main topic
conditional rendering and next let's
talk about conditional rendering in
react
and in short in the following videos
we'll learn how to control what is
displayed in the browser based on some
commission and let's just start with
multiple returns
so as far as the setup
in the app jsx you should import starter
from zero three yep we're switching the
folders and then starter and then zero
one multiple returns
and effectively once you navigate to the
file you should see just the heading to
with two Imports for use effect and your
state and as far as the topic it's
actually not controversial or anything
new
let's think about it in vanilla.js
we can set up multiple returns in a
function so if I have a function say
hello that is looking for the name
parameter if name exists I can go to
early return I can say you know what the
function is going to return hello and
then whatever is the name now if
the name is not provided then of course
you will bypass the safe condition and
then we'll return whatever
we type here in the bottom now just keep
in mind that by default
JavaScript functions return undefined so
if you're not going to return anything
then basically it's just going to return
undefined so if let's say we invoke the
say hello with the parameter if we
provide the argument then it's going to
be hello and then whatever the argument
if not then it's going to be hello there
now
since our components are functions can
we do the same in react and you can
probably already guess that the answer
is yes
and effectively in this file
here is the setup we have used effect in
your state so why don't we set up a
State value and I'm going to call my
state value is loading so that's a tiny
side note where a convention is to call
Boolean values is and then whatever is
that Boolean
value so if it's loading then is loading
and then the function is set is loading
again
it's a convention
so taco and burrito is also a good
approach but
most likely a lot of times you'll see
this type of approach so I'm going to go
with is loading and then we're gonna go
with set is loading so that's the
function that controls it and we'll set
it equal to use State and the default
value is going to be true over here
and essentially it's a Boolean so we can
flip it like a switch
from True to false and false to true and
then let's keep on moving why don't we
set up a condition so I do have my
return
which essentially just says heading 2
with multiple returns Basics however I
can go here with if and I can say if is
loading basically my state value if this
is true then I want to return something
else so I'm going to go here with
heading 2 and we're going to go with
loading and then dot dot now before you
ask yes
essentially if you want you can return
entire application over here
I'm just showing heading 2 but you can
place here 10 000 divs and whatever
functionality you want and check it out
now since this is true we actually
return this heading too so we don't even
get to this return and that's how early
returns work in JavaScript functions if
this condition is true then we return
whatever we have inside of the cartilage
and now the next question is can we make
this dynamic because at this point it's
like okay I can go here and I type false
and of course everything is going to
work but
I mean in the real application you kind
of want to change this programmatically
correct and the answer again is yes now
in our case we'll just Tinker with set
timeout but in the following examples
I'll show you how we can actually do
that if let's say we fetch data for now
we'll just basically pretend that we are
fetching data so I'm going to go here
with use effect I'll provide here my
callback function and I'll say that I
only want to run it once and the
component mode and then let's set up set
timeout and inside of the set timeout we
again need to provide a function that's
going to be invoked and then in how long
and here I'm gonna go with three
thousand basically three seconds so
those are milliseconds and I'm just
gonna add comment here done fetching
there again this is going to be pretty
common example
for using multiple returns that's why I
keep referencing fetching the data
so let's go here with set is loading and
let's set it equal to false and what
you'll notice once you save basically
the way it's going to work while we're
loading while we're getting some kind of
data
will display something to the user so
user knows hey things are happening
users not looking at just blank screen
and then once we're good to go then
we'll display basically the jsx we want
to show to the user
um once we're familiar with the basics
why don't we work on another challenge
and effectively we want to implement
multiple returns when we fetch data
which again
is most common use case for using the
use effect and that's why of course
we're implementing multiple returns with
the fetching data example so back in the
app jsx you should import starter
from the zero to multiple returns fetch
data and then if you navigate to the
file this is what you'll see use effect
in your state imported and then the URL
that I want you to use
and then as far as the challenge first
practice on setting up these State
values so for now practice on a user my
default value is going to be null for
the user and then fetch data from the
URL again
you should do that of course and use
effect and all that and I'm not going to
provide any more details that's the
challenge and again for now just log the
result if you want of course you can set
up the state value and render something
on a screen
but if you see the user object in the
console
and you're already in good shape
so let me navigate back to the component
and effectively like I said the first
thing that I want to do is set up that
state value I'm going to go with const
and then user and then set user that's
my function that is going to be equal to
use State and like I said by default I
want to provide value no so nothing is
going to be there and now let's set up
that user effect so use effect in here
let's provide a callback function
and let's just make sure that we invoke
this again only
when the component loads so we don't
wanna
basically run this use effect after
every re-render and up next I want to
set up that function so I'm going to go
with fetch user is equal to a sync
that's the function and then we're gonna
set up the functionality where oh right
away Place everything in the try and
catch and as far as the
catch I'm just gonna go with error in
here and then when it comes to try now
let's again get the response back first
and that is equal to a weight so we're
waiting then fetch will provide the URL
and let's right away turn this basically
into a Json so const and then user is
equal to a weight again then response
and Json let's invoke this like I said
if you want you can set user equal to
user for now I just want to log this I
want to see whether everything
is working as I expected
so notice over here at the moment I
don't see anything
um and of course the reason why nothing
is happening because I keep forgetting
to invoke the functionalities with me go
with fetch user and now check it out in
the console
I should see the info about the user and
as you can see this is just more info
compared to when we fetched data and in
the following videos set up multiple
returns and also we'll set up a proper
jsx now before we continue you know what
let me just go over here and then
comment this one out so essentially
we can set this one up together
okay and now let's put two and two
together
effectively we know how we can work with
multiple returns and the reason why we
want to use them with fetch data because
essentially you'll have three states
you have the loading one
when we are waiting for data arrive
because keep in mind when it comes to
fetching data it's a synchronous so it
doesn't happen instantly then second
there might be an error so I don't know
maybe the values were not correctly
provided maybe the network doesn't work
I mean whatever there could be all kinds
of errors and then the last one is the
success
and essentially we go through those
States those are our options
and therefore in a state we actually
want to set up two more booleans for
loading and for error and then depending
on the values we want to display
or jsx so let's start working on that
where first I want to navigate back to
the component and let's set up those
State values again the convention is to
go with is and then the name
technically you don't have to so if I'm
gonna go here with is loading and then
set is loading and you know what by
default I'm going to set it equal to
true and then I'll do the same thing
with error now this one by default will
be false
so let's set it back to false
and then as far as these values let's go
error and we want to also change it over
here
let's save it and then let's keep on
moving before we set the user
why don't we set up two conditions so
one is going to be for loading and one
if we have an error now please
placement here is important
so if you place the loading after
the actual jsx you want to return
then it's not going to make sense
because
loading is going to be first and
JavaScript effectively reads everything
top to bottom
so if you have returned before the
loading commission then essentially you
all the time display the jsx and that's
not what we want so make sure that you
set the loading first
so the whole point
of this rant is that the placement is
extremely important and then let's go
here with the return
and we want to provide whatever value
so in my case it's going to be again the
heading 2 with loading and dot dot and
now let's do the same thing with an
error now keep in mind since this is
true we'll right away hit this condition
so this is what will return and error
basically
is going to be displayed only when we
set this one to false so we bypass that
condition and this one to True again
something very important to keep in mind
then I keep getting these questions all
the time and of course q9 that's why
spending more time on that so let's go
over here with loading instead of that
we'll just go with there was an error
let's save this and for now we'll right
away have the loading why well because
this is equal to true then let's
navigate back to our fetch user and
let's go through the logic
so we start over here fetching we
display loading okay everything is
awesome now what do we want to do when
we get back to user well we want to set
our state value right that kind of makes
sense so let's go over here let's go
with set user and now this one is equal
to a user okay beautiful
and then right after these conditions
the try and catch we wanna
essentially
set loading to false because we're done
loading so at that point we have only
two options
either there was an error we didn't get
the data or if everything was successful
then of course we want to display the
user again
it starts with loading
loading is true and then once
we're done with loading then we only
have two options and that's why right
after the catch I want to go with set is
loading and we'll set it equal to false
now let's move up here and let's take a
look at the error so if something goes
wrong
basically this should get triggered
right but again the gotcha with fetch
that it's not going to do it if let's
say the
resource doesn't exist let's say 404 and
this is something that we'll cover in
following videos so I'm not going to
spend too much time on that I'm just
going to say that yes we'll sit here set
is error and we'll set it equal to true
but you'll see that it doesn't work
with all the errors again with axios yes
this is going to be the case
this will be always in the catch but not
with the fetch something important to
keep in mind so now notice first we're
loading and then we have fetch beta now
the loading one is going to be very
quick by the way because again we're
working locally on all that so of course
it's going to happen instantly once we
set up the return yes I'll navigate to a
bigger browser and I'll slow down the
network just so you can see that it's
definitely there so once I have the user
in my state what we can do well we can
navigate down here and essentially
return something display the user we
were actually fetching and here I'm
gonna go with div I'm gonna set up first
the image this is the case where I said
that basically I want to go with inline
styles
just because I know that it's going to
be massive and I don't want to spend my
time in the CSS so this is a good use
case in my opinion for the inline ones
that's why I will go here with width 150
pixels and I'm going to add a little bit
of Border radius here so as you can see
I actually have the error make sure that
you have proper JavaScript syntax
basically we need to come over here and
we're going to set it equal to I don't
know 25 pixels now at the moment we
don't see anything because of course we
need to provide those values and
essentially for the
image I want to go again with that
Avatar I believe yep so we go here with
user and Avatar now keep in mind the
reason why we'll have to go with
user.user DOT user dot is because now we
have an object
so this essentially is the object that's
in our state
so I have a user object and now in order
to access those properties we either can
destructure it something we'll do later
because there's one gotcha I want to
show you or we can go with the object
which in my case is user and then the
property again the Avatar should be
somewhere over here
probably first one yep notice over here
that's the Avatar then as far as the
alternative I'll provide the name here
so let's go here with user and then
Avatar
underscore URL as far as the alternative
we're gonna go with user and name and
then we just want to provide
again name in heading 2 company and a
bio so we have an image then we want to
go here with
user and the name
and then after the name
we're gonna go with heading 4 works at
and again let's grab the curlies we'll
go with user and then company
and then at the very end we have the
paragraph with basically a bio
so user and then bio let's save this and
check it out now we have nicely fetched
a GitHub user so now let me just grab
this URL and let me set it up on a
bigger browser window just so you can
see how basically everything works so
let me open this one up in new tab copy
and paste everything is awesome and
essentially let me slow down the network
and we can do that if we navigate to the
devtools we're looking for the network
one and notice over here I'm actually
using fast 3G that's why I was wondering
why it
took so long in the use effect examples
oh well so actually I was all the time
using that never mind notice basically
if we go the regular it's going to load
right away however if I'm Gonna Change
it to let's say fast 3G
you'll notice that first we'll get the
loading
that's going to be displayed on the
screen so we'll have loading dot dot dot
and then we basically get the user so
that's our setup and up next let's talk
about the fetch errors not bad not bad
we can nicely fetch data in our
application we can display multiple
returns so user is aware what's
happening in our application
however before we
move on to the next topic
I also want to discuss fetch errors
gotcha now if you're not interested if
you're like I'm always going to use
axios and all that feel free to skip
this video technically this is optional
by the way let me add that over here I
mean if you don't want to follow along
you don't have to essentially when it
comes to fetch unlike the axios
it doesn't consider for example
400 or 500 to be an error instead
essentially it treats that as a
successful request now why does that
matter let's go back to our component
and let's try to mess with the URL
so first let me just mess it up the
domain and the moment I do that notice
right away I have error displayed so
this is going to be the error response
so this is going to trigger the sketch
block with fetch however
if I'm going to change this around and
if I'll add the S over here
and basically if I refresh now I'll have
this works at
so as you can see
there is an error but it's not actually
handled in here again why is that
happening because patch doesn't consider
this 404 as an error effectively we do
have the successful response over here
it's just not the user we're looking for
and the way around that is essentially
to look for the OK property if you go
over here and if you log the I'm going
to go with response notice we have the
response and then the value is true for
okay however again if we'll have here
404 and hopefully I'm not going to run
out of the requests while I'm showing
that
check it out over here this is now false
so what we can do in the success block
we can check for that response and if it
is an error we can set again the state
value so let me first I guess just
navigate to a try block and
notice over here where we have the user
so I don't want to get the Json if we're
not successful
so right after the response we can set
up a condition and I'm going to say over
here if response is not true that's what
that exclamation point means so if the
response that we're giving back is not
okay if this Boolean effectively is
false here's what I want to do I'm going
to go with set is error I want to set it
equal to true so now we'll display which
return this one over here correct
and then
after that we do want to set again
loading is false because I want to
return from this function
what I don't want to do is keep reading
I don't want to go with response Json
so I want to return however I also want
to set loading to false so this is where
we need to do technically double the
work where I'm gonna go up I'm gonna
copy and paste and now check it out I
have true for error loading is false and
then I'm returning from this function
what it means that JavaScript is not
going to read rest of the code because
again I don't want JavaScript to go with
response Json why well because I'm not
getting back the user
what's the point of turning the error
into a Json so let me go here and remove
the log let's save that and now notice
how we nicely have is error
even though technically fetch doesn't
trigger the catch block so that's the
fetch error catcher I want you to be
aware of and up next we're going to
return to the topic why or matters when
we are setting up multiple returns
beautiful and up next why don't we come
back to something we already discussed
before that order matters
and why don't we work on a little
Challenge and if I can ask you something
please don't dismiss this topic this is
literally the most discussed question in
course q a
because we do Implement that feature
later on in the project and all that and
this seems to be tripping up a lot of
people that's why I purposely in this
course iteration recording a video in
tutorial just so we can cover this in
great detail and essentially the
challenge is following I want you to the
structure properties so instead of
user.user.user.in jsx
destructure them out of the user
and access them directly
and I'm purposely not telling you where
you should do that because you might or
might not encounter the bug
and effectively that's the whole purpose
of the video
so let's start working on that I'm going
to go back to my file
let's keep on moving and again the idea
is that I don't want to go with user
user user
I just want to grab the properties and
nicely display them in the jsx so what
we can do well we can go above the
return and then one by one pull them out
right so I can go with Avatar URL then
name
then company and I believe I also have
the bio in there and that is going to be
equal to what that is going to be equal
to my user so my state value and now of
course
instead of
user.user.user dot you can simply select
and then remove those instances
so let's go over here and it looks like
a messed it up over here a little bit
that's okay let me save and if you're
refreshing everything still works we are
in good shape
now what's the purpose of this video
well
if you're gonna go above
the loading and I'm purposely going to
place it over here just so you can
clearly see the values but again
typical question is this one if you
place before these conditions why we
have there so let me move this sucker up
all the way over here by user and then
let's save
and what you'll notice that we right
away have big fat error in the console
and JavaScript is complaining
it says I cannot the structure properly
from the user since this is no
so very very important to keep in mind
if you have those multiple returns if
you're just structuring something you
need to do that after the conditions
because keep in mind this is still null
so as JavaScript is basically reading
the code okay users now let's keep on
moving and even before we have hit the
loading or error and all that you right
away start the structuring them from the
null and that's not going to work
there's a reason why we have those
conditions so only when we bypass both
of these conditions we will have that
user
I mean if there's an error then of
course we'll return this one we're not
even going to get to that line
so essentially we'll have the early
return because if there is an error then
there is no user this is still null and
again this is not controversial in the
readme I left some code examples where
this is null and we cannot pull
properties out of null so this doesn't
change we right away basically just try
to read properties out of the no not out
of the object now after returns after
the is loading and and the error yes at
that point we set the user
so at that point we should have the user
object in the state and at that point
it's great you can definitely do so
this is going to work for sure
but before that nope and again let me
just emphasize this by showing you a few
vanilla.js examples because I was hoping
that this is going to help you so if you
have some object you have a property
there
with some kind of value
I mean you can always go object.name
okay that's awesome we can get the
string now what we can also do is simply
go some object and then let's say that
we messed up the property but it's not
there this is still going to work
JavaScript is going to be like okay that
property doesn't exist however
I cannot do this we cannot say hey this
is null and then I'm going to pull
something out of the null JavaScript
will scream
yo uncomplained we cannot do that and
also the same thing is going to work
with arrays and the reason why I'm
showing you arrays example because in
one of the projects this is what we do
we fetch a list but I only want to
display the first item
and what do I need to do well I need to
go with random list or whatever array
you have and then grab the first one
however again in the beginning this is
empty so this will return undefined How
can there be a first
item in the array if the array is empty
so again if we're gonna go here with
random list
when this is just empty and then pull
out the property let's imagine I'm
trying to access some kind of property
from the first item not cool at all
JavaScript will scream yell and complain
now if you're familiar with optional
chaining of course you can make a good
argument well we can avoid all those
things and yes you're right a bunch of
times you will actually
avoid those errors if you use such
approach
and we'll definitely cover optional
training later on in this tutorial
because it is a very important concept
however
the biggest takeaway from this video is
that order matters and that's why we
have the error because the object is
still null
so essentially
it's whatever is the default value so
now let me go back over here and then
let me move this second all the way
where I have the return and now of
course everything is going to work and
we'll have no errors all right and
before we discuss one of the rules of
hooks
let's also quickly cover the location of
the fetch function
so as you're looking at this component
probably one of the questions you have
is following can we just move this fetch
user outside of the use effect or maybe
into a different file
and as far as different file yes you can
do that for sure but just keep in mind
that we're actually invoking functions
from this component
so in that case of course you need to
pass them as
parameters correct basically set up the
parameters and pass them as arguments
but as far as moving this in to a
function body yes basically component
body it's an option so what I could do
here cut it out
and then call it into a use effect now
this copy and paste and everything is
going to work now it doesn't do that in
feed however in create react app if you
do that
essentially there's going to be a
eslinteral that's going to complain that
you need to provide the fetch user as a
dependency and I want to tell you right
away not to do that why well because
we'll have ourselves a problem
so we'll have our initial render where
we'll set up the state values and all
that and during initial render what do
we do over here we invoke fetch data now
what is fetch data doing it's updating
the state value
we already know that so we will trigger
the rerend
so when the re-render happens this gets
created from the scratch and essentially
as far as this dependency array is
concerned
its value changed so what happens here
again we fetch data and again this
problem is going to be easier if I
showcase that over here now you don't
have to do that because I believe you'll
use up all your requests notice I have
403 right now basically I used up all my
searches so yeah for sure don't do that
now I have there was an error right and
effectively the reason why we have that
is because we have this infinite Loop so
my suggestion for now if you're placing
the function outside of the user effect
for now just ignore the eslint warning
you get in the console again you're not
going to have it with Veet but if you're
using let's say a create react app
that's going to be case and later when
we discuss use callback I'll show you
two approaches how essentially we can
make eslint happy and
have the function here
and also pass it here as a dependency
okay and next let's return to one of the
rules of the hooks and as a side note if
you don't want to follow along with this
video you don't have to so in my case
yes I will import the file and all that
but basically I just want to showcase a
few things and the reason why I set up
the file just so you can have it for
your reference so long story short if
you don't feel like it you can just sit
back and relax and watch me struggle so
if I navigate to the file d03 hooks rule
you'll notice that I have a your state
and use effect I have some kind of
condition again this is just a random
value and
the Boolean value is true
so remember when we discussed hooks one
of the rules was don't call hooks
conditionally
so this is not going to work you cannot
place a hook inside of the if condition
hooks need to be called in the same
order
and just to show you another example
which sometimes gets discussed in the
course q a let me first comment this one
out and then uncomment the second one so
you'll notice over here I have the early
return
now this again is not something you want
to do you don't want to place use effect
after this condition because keep in
mind if you're returning that's it we
stop reading the code so effectively we
call the use effect conditionally and
Veet is not going to throw you a bunch
of errors but if you use for example
create react app
you'll have a bunch of warnings and
errors in the console and all that so
again just few things to keep in mind
don't place
the hook inside of the if condition and
also be careful if you have multiple
returns basically if you have jsx
returned based on some condition don't
Place use effect after them make sure
that use effect is always before those
conditions and then yes of course you
can set up tons of multiple returns so
that is still okay but you don't want to
call this one conditionally it's not
going to work okay and up next let's
quickly discuss truthy and falsy values
as well as short circuit evaluation in
JavaScript
because we'll heavily rely on these
topics in the following videos now I can
tell you right away that if you're
familiar with these topics feel free to
skip this video I'll just quickly cover
the major things we need to be aware of
again the whole purpose is
we'll use that in react and I really
want to make sure that we're all on the
same page if you're familiar with these
Concepts then feel free to skip that and
effectively in JavaScript we have falsy
and truthy values and it's going to be
easier to remember the falsy ones and
those are false zero empty string null
undefined and not a number with that
said you have to sit here and memorize
them now just don't be surprised when we
use for example empty string in our
conditions just remember that it is
falsy now why do we care about that well
because
truthy and positive values can be
evaluated in the condition
so we can set up a condition not with
just true and false the Boolean value if
let's say I have hello and as a quick
side note so these are the falsy ones
and all the other ones are truthy that's
why it's going to be easier to remember
the falsely ones so fuzzy ones will
evaluate in the condition to false and
truthy ones will evaluate to true so
again back to your example if you have
these values so X Y and Z and the first
one is a string a valid string second
one is an empty one and third one is a
zero
for the first one if you'll set it up in
the condition actually you'll see in the
console axis truthy so this evaluates
the true again instead of a Boolean this
is a string with some kind of value now
when it comes to a second and third if
you'll run this code you'll actually see
in a console that it evaluates to false
so in the console you'll see Y is fuzzy
now why do we care about that because we
also have short circuit evaluation
and essentially it just allows us to
write code in more concise way and we
can do that by using and operator
and or operator
and as far as the end operator it
Returns the first operand basically this
value over here
if it is fuzzy or the second one if the
first one is truthy so let's just back
up a little bit and let's start
everything from scratch so this one is
zero what it is it is falsy correct and
this one is what it's truthy because
it's essentially a integer that is not
zero now if we have this and operator
then basically if this one is falsy
it will be returned
so if you have two of them and the first
one is falsy then that's the one that's
going to be returned from this
expression now
if it's the other way around if you have
truthy as the first one
then it will return regardless the
second value
something to keep in mind and when it
comes to or operator
it Returns the first operand if it is
truthy
or the second operand if the first one
is fuzzy so as you can see it's the
other way around
if we have example of again zero and one
since this is falsy
the second one is going to be returned
so opposite of end operator
and if this is truthy
then the first one is going to be return
hopefully that is clear and again the
reason why we quickly covered both of
them is because we will use them in our
react setup and as far as
function example since we're working
with functions if I have function
display name and if I'm looking for the
argument of name
if it is provided
then of course I'll have the argument
because in return I have a short circuit
operator I have the or one and remember
if this one is full zip
basically if we don't provide it then
it's right away gonna return the second
value
if this one is true then it's going to
return the first value again let's
double check
if the first one is palsy second one
will be returned if it's truthy then the
first one is going to be right away
return
hopefully we're on the same page and up
next let's see
how we can set up such functionality in
our react components beautiful and once
we have jog your memory on the short
circuit evaluation as well as truthy and
falsy values in JavaScript now let's try
to set them up in react and we'll write
away start with the challenge where
basically I want you to navigate to this
file and I want you to create two State
values one is going to be truthy and one
is going to be falsy and then in the jsx
I want you to set up both conditions for
each operator so
try two of them with palsy so or and and
and the same goes for truthy and a tiny
hint
you want to do that in the curlish in
the jsx so let's start working on that
basically
in the objects I have a star and at the
moment I'm rendering this file okay
that's good
that's an awesome start now let me
navigate over there as you can see I
just have huge State import and now
let's set up those
two State values now you can go with
Boolean that's definitely an option but
I'm just going to go with empty string
and string with some kind of value so
those are going to be my ones I'm going
to go over here and say fuzzy now let's
create that value so text and set text
and that is equal to use State and like
I said we'll start with the false even
then I'm gonna copy and paste so with me
select both of these lines over here and
this is going to be true thing so truthy
over here and as far as the name I'm
gonna go with name
and set name
set name and in here as far as the
default one I'll go with Susan
okay that's awesome
so now let's navigate to jsx and let's
go over here with div and before we type
anything let's just refresh our memory
that in a jsx we cannot do something
like this I cannot set up here a if
condition if and then something this is
not going to work so we'll have some
kind of condition regardless of the
value
will get right away an error something
to keep in mind so let me set this one
up
in a separate line
and let me just add that value
just so it stays for your reference so
let's go over here and let's say it
won't work
I'll work over here and let me comment
this one up and since we cannot use if
conditions in jsx but we obviously still
want to display stuff based on some
condition that's exactly why we need to
understand how short circuit operators
work in react and now let's keep on
moving and effectively you want to set
up four heading fours and in there again
I'll have both conditions so let me
start with the first one and I'll say
fuzzy and this is going to be or example
let me set up a colon then I'm going to
go with the curlies and I'm looking for
a text so that's my falsy value and I'm
going to use my or operator
so now you have to guess which one is
going to be displayed is it going to be
the text one basically empty string or
is it going to be a hello world and once
I save I have Hello World why well
because with or operator if this is
going to be falsy then it's going to
display the second value so now let me
copy and paste then like I said I want
to set up four of them so this is going
to be and and then this will be truthy
so now let me select both of them
and I'll say truthy
and this one will be and
and here
effectively I just want to change the
operator and once I save notice now I
have empty string
so this is how it's going to work in
react again it's the same as in
JavaScript if we have falzi and we have
and then effectively we display the
first one so now let's just change this
around where it's not going to be text
essentially I want to go with name and
you'll see that we have
opposite Behavior where if this is or
then we'll display the first one however
if we have the and one
then of course we'll display the second
one so if this is truthy
then we right away display the second
value and lastly I just want to mention
that of course we're not
limited to just set up this
functionality image.jsx directly I can
also do something like this where I'm
going to go with constant and code
example and that one is equal to
whichever value I want so again I'm
going to use the same one where I'm
going to go with text and then
hello world and then we can render it
right away in the jsx just showing you
multiple
options that you have let me save that
and of course since this is falsy again
we have or operator so we display the
second value
ratcheted for General concept and up
next let's look at the most common
examples okay and once we're familiar
with the general concept now let's take
a look at some examples so in the app
jsx I want you to import zero five and
then the examples and as far as the
component notice over here
we have a few more values basically we
still have the empty string still have
some kind of text also a user and we
also have a Boolean value
and effectively when it comes to or
quite often it is used to display some
kind of default value so let's say if I
navigate here and if I set up a div and
then inside of that div
I want to go with some kind of heading
2. Imagine This
I have some kind of value
in this case I'm going to go text and if
that value doesn't exist then I want to
go with some kind of default one now if
you're wondering like why value wouldn't
exist well keep in mind that quite often
we'll be getting stuff
from the API and it's not guaranteed
that for all the items that property is
actually going to be there so this is
very useful where you can be like okay
try to set this property if not then use
the default value and of course let's go
with name here and you'll see that if
the value is there then of course it
will display the value so that is a
pretty common approach for or operator
in react now when it comes to and it's a
little bit different where instead of
text you essentially control what
elements are going to be displayed now
I'm going to show you both examples
where we use the elements as well as the
components just keep in mind that both
of them effectively work exactly the
same way so if I go here and right after
text I'm just going to go with the
curlies and I'll say if text
evaluates to true what do I want to do
well then I want to return a div with
two heading twos so let's go over here
and let's say div
close div here and then inside of the
div we want to go with those two heading
Tools in one I'm gonna display the name
so I'm going to go over here and I'll
say adding two whatever
and return
and then right after that we want to go
with heading two and I'm going to access
the name over here and notice once I
save I don't see anything why well
because this is false correct so this
one is an empty one
and as a result we don't return anything
basically we have nothing in the browser
and that's something important to keep
in mind where in this case
there's always going to be that having
two tag however if we use and operator
and basically we set up whatever we want
to return you'll actually notice that
there is no div with those heading tools
it just doesn't exist so we only have
this heading 2 with default value we
don't have that second dip now of course
if this is going to be truthy if we'll
add just let's say even one character
you'll right away notice that first of
all
since we have the or operator here it's
going to display this one and when it
comes to text well now since this
evaluates the true now we actually
render div with those two running twos
and of course we access the name here as
well so those are pretty common
approaches where again we use or inside
of the element if we want to display
some kind of default one and we use and
to control effectively what we return
now of course this is going to be
dynamic at the moment we're just hard
coding but normally this is going to be
dynamic so let me set it back here to an
empty string and again notice how we're
not returning anything and before I show
you the component example let's also
cover that we can use the not operator
so at the moment this is fuzzy right
that's why we don't display anything
however
if I stick a not operator in front of it
you'll see that actually everything is
displayed now if you're not familiar
with not operator in readme essentially
you'll find code examples for vanilla.js
again I don't want to spend too much
time on that because I want to move on
with react topics but again if you need
to jog your memory on the not operator
please utilize the readme where you'll
find the vanilla Jazz examples and of
course it's going to be easier to
understand so essentially if I just
stick here the exclamation point in
front of it I'm good to go I'm actually
displaying this why well because by
default essentially this is all Z
however with not operator I'm looking
for the opposite value so now this is
true thing
and I display it over here again
something important to keep in mind so
I'll copy and paste I'll remove this one
and I'll just comment this one out over
here just so we don't have too many and
as always you can reference do you read
me as well and now since we're familiar
how we can use the and operator to
return some elements why don't we also
take a look how we can do the same thing
with components so below my first
component I want to go with second one
I'm going to go with const and then I'll
just say sum component now I know that
I'll pass the prop so I'll write away
the structure it and essentially I'm
going to be looking for the name prop
so let's go over here
and then as far as the return we'll do
the same thing
it's just now we'll return from the
component so if I go with return Then
space and I'll cheat a little bit then
I'm just going to copy and paste so
that's going to be my component
let me scroll up over here and I guess
I'll do after not so I'll set up over
here a logic where
essentially if
the value is true then I want to return
that component and in this case I'm
going to be looking for the user just to
use a more complex example so notice
user set user use State and this is an
object and of course this will evaluate
to true so now let's scroll down and
let's say over here that if the user
exists only then I want to display the
component so say over here some
component and then I want to pass in
that name prop now what is it going to
be equal to well I'm going to go with
name equals to user.name and then I want
to close over here the component and as
you can see now in the browser we have
John because that's the value over here
again both of them do exactly the same
thing
so either you can return a bunch of
elements or you can set it up here in
the component and also please keep in
mind that like I keep saying this is
going to be dynamic so essentially
you'll try to fetch the user from the
database if the user exists then I want
to display
some kind of component with the values
that represent that user and if it
doesn't exist let's say if
the API or database returns that this is
null what do you know we're not
displaying that component altogether
hopefully that is clear and up next I
also want to show you how we can use
ternary operator in jsx okay and while
we're still on the topic of conditional
rendering examples when we also quickly
cover turning operator because this is
also something that you'll see quite
often in jsx and just jog your memory
effectively in JavaScript we have this
option to check for condition and if
it's true when we return the first
expression if not then we return the
second one and the way it's going to
work in jsx first I want to navigate
back to the same file so again we're not
changing the files in here we're working
the same one first I'll start with some
kind of divider and I'm going to go with
heading 2 and I'll just say bernary
operator
and then in here when we add a little
bit of
CSS and I'm just going to add some
margin top bottom
and left and right I'll keep it zero so
one Rems and then a zero and after that
I want to render the button so let's go
with button let's add a little bit of
styles here so I'll say here last name
and then that one is equal to
BTR and then inside of the button
I'm gonna check for is editing and if is
editing is true then as far as the
content is going to be added and if not
it's going to be add so let's go over
here and let's say is editing and then
we want to set up the question mark here
and then the first value is going to be
if it's true so if is editing is true
then we'll display edit if not then
we'll go with ADD save that and now of
course since this is false that's why we
go with ADD now if we'll change this to
True you'll see right away that text
actually is added and not to sound like
a broken record but of course normally
this is going to be dynamic so if I go
back over here to false then I'll have
ADD and I also want to showcase how we
can
use the theory operator to return
elements just like we covered with and
operator so this is one option where we
just check if the value is true and then
we return the component but we can also
use turnary operator and essentially if
it's true then we return one set of
elements or the components and if it's
false then of course we return
other set of elements and in here again
I'm going to check for user so I set up
the curlies I'll go here with my ternary
operator and let's start with a div and
again just to speed this up I'm going to
grab this value over here so let me go
here we wanna copy and paste Yep this is
what we want to do now I'm not going to
probably return two of them you know
what I'm just going to go here with
heading 4. and then inside of it I'll
say hello there and user so what am I
doing over here well since I have a user
object
if it's true if it's not null then of
course I'll display div with the
username now if it is false
then I'm gonna go with colon over here
and basically I'll just say hey
you need to log in so there is no user
so in order to do that I'm just going to
change here heading 2. I'm not going to
be looking for a user because now I know
that this is false of course and then
I'll just say please login and you'll
notice that right away we have hello
there user John
and if we change this to null again then
of course I'll have please login so let
me go back to John and we successfully
covered the most common examples I know
that last few videos were probably a
little bit tedious because we were just
flipping the values from True to false
and that's why up next I'm going to work
on two challenges where you'll be able
to utilize this knowledge all right and
first I want to work on the toggle
challenge so in the app GSX import this
file zero six toggle challenge this is
what you'll see on the screen and as far
as the challenge I want you to create a
state value and in this case I'm going
to go with Boolean please keep in mind
that of course you can set up a
different value again we're talking
about truthy and falsy just to make it
easier I'm gonna go with Boolean then in
the jsx we want to return a button and a
component or element so for sure turn a
button
and then after the button set up some
kind of element or a component that's
really up to you in my example I'm going
to use the component but of course you
can use the element as well and then
when the user clicks the button toggle
the state value this sucker over here
and then based on that value
conditionally render component element
and I want to right away tell you that
there's multiple ways how we can set
this up so again if your logic works
do whatever makes the most sense to you
now as far as my setup first of all I
want to navigate to the file so I'm
going to go to toggle challenge you want
to grab the use State again I'm going to
go with Auto Imports so I'm gonna go
with use state
let's grab that one and it's going to be
false by default now as far as the name
I'm gonna go with show alert and then
comma and then set show
alert now that is equal to of course my
value okay good let's save that and like
I said now we want to set up that button
so in here I'm going to go with div
and first is going to be my button
so begin blah blah blah blah class name
BTN and then on click for now let's not
worry about it I just want to showcase
how it's going to look like so I have my
toggle button and like I said after that
if you want to set up elements or
element you can definitely do so in my
case I'm going to set up the alert just
so I can showcase some classes that we
have in CSS so in here if I go with
alert component
and then as far as the return if I go
with let's say div
return and then div let's add class name
so we have two of them alert which
basically adds the general Styles and
then I also have alert danger which
essentially just adds some colors and
all that kind of stuff so let me close
it here and let me say hello world let
me save this and now I want to go up
where I have the toggle Challenge and I
want to just display the alert for now
this is what we're gonna see on the
screen now awesome
up next I want to actually toggle this
value so first of all let's come up with
the function and in my case that's going
to be toggle alert so I'm going to call
this toggle alert that's my function and
then before I set up the functionality I
want to actually invoke it every time I
click so remember it was on click and
then we want to go with toggle and alert
and as far as the functionality well we
want to toggle the state value right and
like I said there's multiple ways how we
can set this up at the end of the video
I'll show you a shortcut but for now we
can simply do it this way where I'm
going to check what is the value of show
alert basically if this is true then I
want to go set show alert then I'll set
it equal to false and very important we
want to go here with the return Why well
because I'm going to be setting up logic
after my condition and if I don't add
the return Then basically it's going to
hit this
functionality as well because that's how
JavaScript is reading the code so let me
go here with true and notice so if this
is true I want to set equal to false if
not then basically we'll just skip this
condition and we'll set it equal to true
so this is awesome but of course alert
is always going to be displayed we also
need to implement right now our and
operator correct so I'm going to go with
show alert if this is true and what do I
want to do well that's when I want to
display that alert so let me save it
over here and notice
once I click this is of course now true
and I display the alert once I click one
more time then of course it's false and
I don't display the alert and as far as
the shortcut let me keep scrolling and
notice over here this is not operator so
essentially we can just make it a
one-liner where instead of setting up
the entire function and all that I can
just pass here the arrow function and I
can say set show alert and then not so
the opposite value of the current value
of show alert so if it's true then set
it equal to false and if it's false then
set it equal to true hopefully that is
clear
so I'm gonna navigate back again I'm
gonna comment this one out just so it
stays for your reference and now let's
do that one liner where basically we
will go here with my arrow function and
then we'll just say set show alert and
set it to the opposite value
let's save that and then notice our
functionality still works Everything is
Awesome we still have that alert
component if this is true however now we
have less lines of code
all right and up next I want to work on
the user challenge so essentially in the
app GSX we want to import this one the
zero seven
user Challenge and as far as the
challenge we want to set up the state
value in my case I'm going to go user
and default value is going to be no then
I want you to create two functions One
login function that sets the user equal
to a object with a name property so you
simply want to set it equal to object
that name property and some kind of
value again that value is totally up to
you and then we also want to set up a
log out
button
and for that we'll need a logger
functionality
and in there I want you to set user
equal to a null
so set it back to the default value
which is null and then in the jsx use
the ternary operator to display two
different setups so if the user exists
we want to go hello there and then try
to get the username because remember
we're setting the user equal to an
object with the name property and also I
want to display the logout button
so if the user has already logged in I
don't want to display the login button
that doesn't make sense I want to
display the logout button and then if
it's false if the user is false I want
to go with heading 4 and please log in
and a login button so let's start
working on this challenge first I'm
going to go with const and like I said
in my case I'm going to go to user and
then set user that is equal to my use
and then state so that's imported and
we're going to go with no that's going
to be the default value and right out of
the gate let's set up those functions so
const login
and that one is equal to a function here
and then I want to go with set user and
I want to set it equal to an object so
name and in my case I'm going to go with
vegan
food truck because why not and then I
also want to add here a comment where
normally
connect
to DB or API so essentially you're not
going to be hardcoding this
normally you'll connect to the database
if everything is correct if it's the
right password and an email and all that
you'll get back the credentials for the
user and that's where you'll set it in a
state value now if it's not then of
course nothing's gonna happen you'll
display probably some kind of error
message
but hopefully this is clear so of course
in this example we're basically hard
coding we're saying yeah once we log in
everything is going to be fine but it's
not always the case
and of course later in the course we
will connect to a database and we'll
check what's happening and if everything
is correct that's when we set the user
but again the main idea is going to be
exactly the same you have that flag the
user basically and if it exists it's
awesome I want to display it if not then
I want to go with a logarithm hopefully
that's clear copy and paste I don't need
a comment here
I can set it up as null as well
no and
I want to call it logout here
let's save this and now let's work on
the jsx so first I want to display the
div then instead of the div I want to
set up right away js6 and I want to go
with user
so essentially I'm checking that user
value and remember I have two options if
it's true it's one thing if not then
it's something else so let's start if
it's true and again yes you can set up a
component over here so if you want to
work on the challenge more
you can set up these returns as separate
components so in here let's go with div
I'm going to set it up as heading four
remember in this case user exists so we
can simply go with hello there
and we can try to access the username
now if it's null then it's not going to
make sense correct so user.name okay
that's awesome and as far as the button
well like I keep saying we're not going
to display the login
we want to display the opposite one
which one is that well that's the logger
one so let's go with button class name
BTN okay that's beautiful on click and
now let's go with our log out button and
the same goes for the text so log out
here let's save it and we'll have an
error don't worry we'll fix that in a
second
essentially we want to grab here this
div
and we want to copy and paste
now here we're working with opposite
values correct so we're going to go here
with please log in and we're going to
change the button this is going to be a
login button
over here
as well as here let's save that and
check it out
now we have
div with these values and the moment
we'll click will actually flip it
so notice this is what we have right now
e in our browser right so these are the
elements we're returning however once we
click check it out now we're turning
different values so now we have hello
there vegan food truck so essentially
we're displaying that user has logged in
successfully and now he or she has an
option to log out and once we log out of
course we have the previous screen The
Heading 4 with please login hopefully
everyone enjoyed the challenge and I'll
see you in the next video all right and
now let's go back and discuss use effect
cleanup function and why it's useful so
yes
once we're done with conditional
rendering we'll actually go back to zero
to use effect and
take a look at the cleanup function and
you'll see in a second why and let's
start with the challenge so I want you
to create a state value and
in jsx set up a button which toggles the
state and based on that condition return
a second component now that's a totally
simple return you don't need to worry
about returning 10 000 elements
literally it can be a heading 2. now
what's important in the second component
create a use effect and run it only
on initial render and remember in order
to do that we needed to use a second
argument
in the use effect and once you have the
example in place then we'll discuss
why we have such interesting Behavior so
again we're looking for use Effect Star
and then zero five cleanup function
that's what I have in the app jsx and
then as far as the file
first let's just go with some kind of
state value so in my case I'm going to
call this toggle const and then toggle
set
toggle and that is equal to use
huge State and by default let's set it
equal to false but after that let's set
up that return
so right away go with return and I'm
going to remove the heading too and I'll
go with div instead and then in here
let's create that button then we're
going to go to class name and that BTN
we also want to right away add on click
and let's pass in the arrow function as
far as the logic will go with set toggle
and we'll use that not operator so set
it equal to the opposite value and then
in here
I want to set up some kind of text and
I'm going to go toggle component let's
save that yep I have the button
everything's awesome so now let's set up
another component and based on that
state value let's toggle it so in here
I'm going to go with const and then for
random
component
again the entire gotcha is the result
you'll see in the console so that's the
most important one first for now let's
just go in random component then
let's go with heading one man we'll say
hello there
hello there now we already know that of
course we can toggle it correct so if I
go here and if I'll say toggle and paste
on that value if it's true then I want
to return the random component if not
then nothing is going to be displayed
so we're expecting this Behavior correct
all of that is good so now we're putting
two and two together where we can use
conditional rendering we can display the
component but also keep in mind that in
any component we can set up the use
effect correct so let's try it out we're
going to go here with used effect so
we'll pass it here and then remember
like I said we have two arguments we
have the function that's first
and then we have the dependency array
now as far as the function here we're
going to go with some kind of log we'll
say hmm that's interesting and you'll
see in a second why so
um
this is interesting okay good let's save
it and now million dollar question yes
we're going back to the quiz
how often do you think this is going to
show up
so remember use effect
it has the dependency array and
technically this is empty
so two options
either it's going to show up only once
when the component renders or
there's actually a gotcha and we'll see
it more often so let's try it out I'm
gonna go over here and check it out
every time I click
I actually have this Behavior
now before we continue why is this
happening well remember long long long
long time ago we discussed
the render and re-render correct so
let's go with I don't know initial
render maybe this way I'll be able to
find it
yep over here remember
we discussed the initial render and
re-renders and I said that
for time being let's think of initial
render
where basically the application loads so
that's when we render for example this
sucker over here the cleanup function
however
when we start toggling the component
essentially we Mount and unmount the
component and during the mount we repeat
initial render
so of course the functionality inside of
the use effect will run even though the
dependency array is empty but notice now
I'm displaying the hello there that's
the initial render and yes if there's
going to be some kind of logic inside of
the random component of course it will
re-render if you'll have to use state
but my main point in this video is to
Showcase that just because we're used to
use effect just running once
when the application loads it's not
going to be the case if
you're displaying the component
conditionally because in that case that
initial render is going to happen every
time you basically Mount and unmount
Mount and unmount
and this is why
the cleanup function which we're going
to discuss in the next video is going to
be useful just don't be surprised if you
have some kind of component that is
being mounted and unmounted and even
though you do have this dependency array
as empty the functionality inside of the
use effect which in this case is just a
simple console log
keeps running every time we basically
show the component again it's not a good
or a bad thing in the following videos
we'll take a look at few examples and
when it becomes a problem just something
very important to keep in mind but yes
you have this initial render when the
application loads but for components
that are being displayed conditionally
actually it's going to happen when you
also Mount the component okay so
hopefully it is clear when we're
toggling the component when we're
mounting an unmounting component the use
effect even though it has empty
dependency array is going to run every
time we show the component basically
every time we Mount the component unlike
in this example the cleanup function
which is only going to be mounted once
now this is just a fact
when it becomes an issue well if we have
some kind of functionality that
essentially just keeps on running
now I picked two examples the set
interval and the event listeners keep in
mind that of course there are other use
cases and essentially the main point of
these videos is just to showcase
how we need to be careful when we are
toggling the component if we have some
kind of functionality that might
possibly lead to an issue that's when we
need to go back and set up the cleanup
function please keep in mind you won't
need to set up cleanup function for
every use effect but yes in some
instances it's a good practice now when
it comes to set interval basically it
comes from vanilla just just like the
event listeners and essentially we go
here with set interval we want to pass
in the function we want to invoke and
then
essentially the interval so in my case
I'm going to go with one second and I'm
not going to be too
dramatic and I'm just going to pass here
the log I'm going to say hello from
interval and what do you think right now
is going to happen
so if I toggle the component
I have
is interesting okay that's what I
expected but I also have this hello from
interval so that's the functionality
now where it becomes really interesting
is when we actually
on toggle the component notice how this
just keeps running even though the
component is not displayed and again
this can lead to some serious issues
let's imagine you're subscribing to some
kind of service
and essentially you still have this
running in a background even though the
component is not displayed anymore
what's even more interesting the more
times I'm going to click the faster it's
going to go because now I'll have more
set intervals now what is the solution
well it's a cleanup function and the
syntax is a little bit funky so just
bear with me we want to go here with
return
and we want to return a function and
then whatever is within this function is
going to be invoked and I'll showcase
when it's actually invoked and that's
the reason why we don't want to set this
one up as a sync like so because react
is expecting that if you're returning
something you're actually returning a
function now when it comes to set
interval it actually returns an ID so in
here I can go to const and then whatever
the variable and then in order to clear
this interval we want to go with special
method it's called clear interval and we
want to pass in that ID again this is
just for Interval but effectively yes
when you have a cleanup function what
you want to do is essentially just to
clean up whatever functionality you have
over here so if you're subscribing to
some kind of service you want to
unsubscribe otherwise it's going to be
running in the background and now notice
something interesting we're basically
I'll click I'll have the hello from
interval but the moment I hide that's it
the interval is not running anymore and
I can click all the time
but
you'll see that essentially it's not
going to be running if the component is
not displayed now when this one runs and
this one is a little bit tricky where
basically if I go here with log and if I
say render
and you know what let's clean out these
logs for now
let me comment them out you'll see that
of course when it runs well on a show
render right so this one we're not
toggling only when we Mount the
component basically when the application
loads that's when we essentially render
this component the cleanup function now
if we go here inside of the cleanup
function and if we type log and we'll
say
clean up
you'll see that essentially it runs
after this render
and before the use effect so that's how
we can clean up after ourselves so let's
refresh one more time initial render
then once we click what happens well we
re-render this component right
because we change the state value
and now check it out once I'll click
again I'll re-render and I'll clean it
up so notice
I have another re-render because again
we flip the value and then I have the
cleanup so essentially it runs after the
render and before the use effect so in
our case basically when the component
and mount that's when we run it
hopefully that is clear again this is a
function we want to return we want to
set up here some kind of functionality
and
we want to do that in order to clean up
whatever we have in the use effect just
so it doesn't run in the background okay
and now let's take a look at another
example and in this case we're going to
use event listeners again something that
is coming from vanilla JS and
essentially the way the event listeners
work in vanilla JavaScript we just go
with the element in this case I'm going
to go with window and then we add The
Listener and then whatever event we want
to listen for so in this case I'm
looking for the scroll one and then we
want to pass in the Callback function so
essentially this callback function is
going to be invoked every time this
event fires and in our example
we want to go over here we want to set
up the function inside of the use effect
and all that and then we want to attach
that listener on the window and then
we'll see some interesting behavior and
of course after that we will clean this
up because that's the main point of
these videos so let's start over here by
just removing everything and let's come
up with that some funk again doesn't
really matter what happens in here and
therefore I'll basically leave it blank
that's irrelevant over here so I'm just
going to say here some logic and then
now let's go with window again in react
we do have access to the window object
we go with add event listener we're
listening for scroll and basically we go
with comma and then some function so
this is going to be invoked so let's
again click and
refresh and all that let me click over
here notice we have the render okay
that's what we expect what we don't
expect probably is if we go
to a bigger browser window and if we
check the event listeners in tabs and if
we refresh basically see over here that
we have quite a few event listeners so
let's go here notice how I toggle the
component and once I refresh I have here
the scroll and now notice how many I
have over here so essentially
every time I toggle the component I'm
actually attaching that event listener
on a window and again
eventually this can lead to an issue now
some students have complained that they
don't see that and every time I go and
double check in my browser I can still
see it again you're looking for event
listeners and then you want to refresh
and you want to check out every time
you'll toggle the component essentially
the value is going to increase over here
so you'll have more event listeners now
if you don't see that again just trust
me that that's the behavior so now let
me navigate back and let's see how we
can
fix that issue and again we want to go
here with the return
a function and we want to go with window
then the method name is remove event
listener and in here we want to pass in
the scroll then comma and then we want
to pass the same function so in this
case it's going to be some function and
now you'll notice that
once I refresh
once I toggle the component and refresh
yep I have one so that's fine but then
once I hide the component and refresh
notice I don't have any more of that
scroll event and effectively that's how
we can use the cleanup function in a
Year's effect not bad not bad we're
pretty much done with use effect as well
as conditional rendering for that matter
but before I let you go let me share one
particularly useful resource which is
from react docs and it essentially
covers use effect Alternatives now
before you start yelling at the screen
yes there are still use cases for use
effect so no we did not waste our time
on learning use effect especially
if you consider how much code out there
is still using use effect
now since the article is quite extensive
I'm just going to give you a general
gist
you see when the react hooks came out I
believe it was version 16.
developers started using use effect for
pretty much everything
and as a side note yes
I was one of those developers as well so
I'm not casting any shade however
such approach basically to have use
effect on top of use effect can
potentially lead to clunky code
basically hard to read and manage as
well as some performance issues
so in this article the reactive is
simply encouraging the community to
consider alternatives before jamming yet
another
use effect in the component
and if I may make a suggestion try to
find some free time to skim through this
resource again you don't have to go line
by line take a look at the general ideas
and the next time when you want to set
up a use effect just come back to it and
see whether there is a better
alternative
quite often you'll be able to achieve
the same functionality by adding logic
straight in the jsx or by setting up an
extra function in the component
lastly one major use case for use effect
used to be data fetching something we
already covered in the previous videos
however as I'm recording this course
iteration at this point in time there
are some great libraries for example
react query which actually allows to
fetch data with just one line of code
so basically without doing too much work
we already can use less use effect
instances in our applications
as you can see in the code example we
simply install the library use a custom
hook and right away get back data error
loading and a bunch of other useful
stuff about our request what's more such
libraries also take care of things like
caching and synchronization so it's no
surprise that they are gaining
popularity with the speed of light
especially for bigger projects with
bunch of requests and yes as a side note
we will build a project later on of
course with react query now does that
mean that you have to use such library
in a small project where you have only a
few get requests
no I probably wouldn't do that just
something to think about when you start
working on your own projects simply be
mindful and consider alternatives all
right and up next let's talk about the
project structure essentially I just
want to showcase few ways how we can
structure our project because while
we're working on somewhat small project
this type of approach where you set up
the components folder or whatever you
want to name this folder and then set up
all your components there is awesome but
as your project grows and you have a
need for more files you might want to
implement different approach and
effectively we're going to work in the
zero four project structure will work in
a star one and as you can see at the
moment it's empty and also in the app.js
I'm not importing anything so jsx is
empty I just have the container
and effectively one way how we can
set up the structure for our project is
by
setting up every component as a folder
so let's imagine that we have some kind
of nav bar component and instead of just
setting it up as component I want to set
it up as a folder and in there I'll
actually have the CSS file now
the goal here is following essentially
as our project grows we might want to
keep all the files that are associated
with that component in one folder
and in turn is just easier you don't
have to run around your project and look
for CSS files the test files and all
that you know that hey this is a
component and these are all the files
that are associated with that component
so let's try this one out and in the
process we'll take a look at multiple
approaches so in here I'm going to go to
starter I'm going to go to a new folder
and let's just call this navbar and in
here we'll just set up some example
component again
it's really irrelevant what we have over
there so I'm just going to go with
navbar jsx let's create the component
I think I'm going to change it to
heading like so and then I'll create
empty CSS file again it's irrelevant
what we have over there
just want to showcase the example so
I'll go here with navbar and then CSS
and of course
if you want to test it out you can set
up the CSS over here and you can Import
in Napa I'm not going to do that then I
want to go back to app jsx and I want to
import that component again
the goal of this setup is essentially to
keep all the files that are associated
with that component in one place in this
case it's just navbar CSS but of course
there's other things that you can keep
over there and in the app jsx if we want
to grab this component we simply go with
the name of the component and we use the
Auto Import and check it out now of
course I have the nav bar displayed on
the screen and again all the files that
are associated with this particular
component are located in one place but
here's the gotcha
not as this one
we have navbar and then navbar
and this is somewhat annoying
where essentially yes I have a nice
folder but I don't want to keep using
two names here one after another which
essentially are the same and one
solution for that is to create here
index
so we're going to go over here with
index.js and basically we can set up the
logic here in the index.js so for time
being I'll just copy and paste because
we will change our logic in a second for
now I just want to showcase that if
let's say I go to index.js and then if I
go back to my app one I can omit that
nav bar now I do need to fix the
extension my apologies I keep forgetting
with Veet that we need to go with jsx so
let me save Here and Now check it out I
have the navbar so essentially we save
that one word here so instead of navbar
navbar since this is a node project it's
essentially a node thing where if you
have index in the folder that's going to
be used as an entry point so whatever
you have over here here is going to be
right away exported so in our example we
don't need to look for specific file we
can just say Okay so get me the navbar
folder aka the navbar component
now what is the issue with this setup
well if you have tons of files
effectively it just becomes bunch of
indexes so it's very hard to navigate
around your tabs so let me show you a
way how we can
have our cake and eat it too basically
we won't have to use that nav bar nav
bar and we also will have a bunch of
these indexes over here so I have the
navbar component and I have the
index.jsx what I can do in
index.jsx I can import
the nav bar and then export it as
default so it's going to look like we're
going to go over here export and then
default
and we're looking from and since it's in
the same folder we just look for the
navbar and if I navigate back to the app
jsx first of all if I want to do
something in the navbar well I'll be
using this tab right so this is my
component and I'm just using index to
export that component and here nothing
changes so if I want to grab the navbar
component then of course I'm just
looking for the folder and as you can
see everything still works so we have no
issues
so that's how we can set up essentially
a folder for every component and few
ways that we can use index.js to
simplify our workflow now let me stress
something it doesn't mean that now you
have to use this kind of setup for every
project again this only makes sense
if your project is big and you need some
kind of structure to navigate around the
project all right and up next let's take
a look at another approach where we can
set up named exports and this is
definitely something we're going to use
during the course but again I want to
stress something this only makes sense
if you have a bunch of components in the
folder and you'll see what I'm talking
about in a second and effectively we'll
definitely use this one when we're going
to work with react router because in
that case you have quite a few pages and
it just makes easier
if you set up such named exports so
first we want to navigate to the starter
and we want to create another folder and
in this case let's call this pages
now inside of the pages what we want to
do
we want to create two pages the home
page and the about page and little
spoiler alert when we're talking about
pages in react essentially we're just
talking about the components so I'm just
going to create here home jsx I just
need to remind myself all the time that
I need to go with jsx so we want to set
this one up this is going to be our home
page and then we want to do the same
thing with about so about and then js6
same there we want to create that this
is going to be our about page and if we
navigate back to app jsx
I mean everything is awesome we'll be
able to access the pages same deal we go
here and then we also want to go with
about so this doesn't change but notice
how
we're getting quite a few lines of code
over here and imagine if you have 10
pages
so essentially every time you want to
use all of them you'll have like I don't
know 20 lines of code or something like
that and there's a way how we can
simplify this
so first let me remove this number we're
not going to need that and back in our
Pages we can create another index.jsx so
remember that's going to be our
entry point over here and we can import
or the components from this directory
so essentially we can do like this I can
go with home so I'm importing home and I
also want to do the same thing for about
like so so I'm going to go with about
and then from the index I want to export
that so I'm going to go with export and
I'm going to go with home and about and
essentially if you have 20 components
this is what you'll do you'll import all
of them in the index.jsx and you'll
export and the beauty here is that if I
go back to app jsx
I don't have to provide the path for
every component I can do like this let
me remove now these ones are named
exports so the names need to match
that's something important so here I do
need to go at home and I do need to go
with about if you'll go here with
contact or whatever it's not going to
work so first let me just showcase how
this works and then
we'll take a look at the error example
as well so now let me remove home
because notice now we're looking for
that index and check it out everything
still works
so essentially if you have 20 components
you can nicely import them effectively
in one line of code no I mean the path
is a little bit longer so it's
technically two but hopefully you see
where I'm going with this so instead of
using
the import for every component we're
going to import all of them together
again we set up index jsx in that folder
that's going to be the entry point and
one by one we grab those components and
then we export them but again keep in
mind if you're gonna do here like this
if you'll say hey get me the contact
what do you think is going to happen
we'll have big fat error right so if
we'll save notice it says well there is
no named export contact that's just
something to keep in mind now you can
set up the aliases and all that I'm not
gonna go as deep
in these examples we'll just stick with
the ones that we just covered so this is
a nice way how we can group all of our
components together and Export them as
named exports okay and lastly let me
showcase how we can export group of
components so this is going to be a
little bit different and also a very
useful extension glean and maybe less
useful to some people but to me also
very useful a code spell checker so
first let's start with example directory
where
we'll take a look at how we can export
as a group
first I want to navigate to app.jsx I
want to clean this up so I'm going to
remove the existing ones then we want to
navigate back to the star we'll create
another
folder and in this case the folder name
is going to be example
example in here let's create two more
components
so I'll call this first component and
second
as always sex jsx so let's create that
component I think I'm going to go with
adding two just so we can see it better
so first component okay awesome and then
we want to do the same thing here with
the second one so second and
component
jsx okay beautiful let's create that
awesome and then let's change it to a
heading two so another way how we can
export from this example essentially I
can set up a index
and I can import all of these ones
what I have in the example in the jsx
now why that would be beneficial well
let's imagine you have some kind of
component that is using
for example five other components again
instead of those components being just
scattered around your project if you
know that you'll definitely use those
five components inside of that one
component well it kind of makes sense
you set up index.jsx you just import all
of them and you're good to go so just to
Showcase that we can go new file then
remember yes index
jsx or JS is going to be the main entry
point so at the moment we create that
file yep as far as the paths and all
that it's going to point to this example
and in here we simply want to create a
component
and let's call this I don't know example
why not so let me select
all of them and we're going to call this
example we'll also rename this and then
we want to import those two components
so we want to go here with the first
component and second component and you
know what I think it's going to make
more sense if I'll place a div over here
and then one by one I'll add both of
those components so first component
close it here and then second component
as well so Auto Import second component
awesome let's save that and it looks
like I forgot to change it over here so
we need to go with example
and now we simply want to go back to app
jsx and when we want to grab that
example folder so let's go here example
and check it out I'll have example and
first and second component again
something that has a very specific use
case you don't have to do that for every
project but here and there it's somewhat
Nifty and that's why I decided to add a
two tutorial and now let's take a look
at those two extensions like promised so
first of all this one somewhat
straightforward but extremely extremely
useful for me the code spell checker and
it's somewhat self-explanatory it just
checks for spelling errors this is very
useful especially if you're following
along
because it will right away notify you if
your name is off now it's not looking
for the error you're just going to say
Hey listen
the spelling here is incorrect and why
I'm telling you that because quite often
I see students
sharing their code and I can see that
the problem is that they used the wrong
name in the first place let's say
there's some kind of spelling error and
then later on they use the correct one
and then things don't work so I think
it's going to be easier if I showcase
that let's imagine that in here I'll
have some kind of function so I'm going
to go with const and then handle and
change
now everything is awesome but let's
imagine that as I was adding this
function instead of handle I went like
this so right away I have this blue
squiggly line which is going to tell me
Hey listen I mean technically there's
nothing wrong with your code but you
should probably check this does this
really make sense as I know this is
super useful for me because I'm the
worst speller ever and then I also want
to showcase the glean extension and
what's really cool about this extension
we can pretty much take elements we want
to set up as component and right away
create a file so let's imagine the
scenario in the app I have some kind of
element let's say div and inside of it
I'm going to have a heading three and
I'm gonna say hello world now if I want
to set up a separate component what is
normally the
path well I need to create a component
somewhere here right then I need to grab
the elements and then copy and paste and
it's much faster with gleam so
effectively I can select the elements I
want to extract I want to click on the
light bulb and check it out we have this
option extract component to file we
click we need to pick the directory my
case I'm going to go to Source keep in
mind but of course you can go tutorial
for example I'm just picking the easy
option and then we're going to go here
with test so the file name and I'm going
to go with jsx and notice how right away
not only it sets up the component not
only it Imports it but it also right
away sets up the component file as well
and what's really cool it even provides
the props which is super Nifty if for
example you're iterating over the list
and then you're passing in some props
into the elements you can essentially
right away set it up as a component and
extract it again super super useful
extension we save it over here and
notice
the result did not change however this
is much faster and effectively this
concludes the project structure
section and up next I want to talk about
how we can leverage JavaScript in react
all right and up next let's talk about
how we can leverage JavaScript basically
how we can use JavaScript to fix issues
if the data is missing and if you're a
little bit confused on this entire topic
don't worry as we're going to be working
through the examples you'll see what I'm
talking about first notice over here
that in the app I'm not importing that
and I'm doing that on a purpose because
we'll set up everything from the scratch
so let's navigate to tutorial and we'll
right away start with the challenge and
as you can see the further we get in
tutorial the more challenges we have
because now I want you to utilize
everything that we have learned so far
and in this video or
more precisely in this section so most
likely in the following video will rely
heavily on optional chaining and if
you're not familiar with this topic
please utilize this
JavaScript nuggets video now I do have
the info also in the readme so if you
don't feel like watching the video you
can just scroll down in the readme as
well so first I want you to navigate to
zero five leverage JavaScript and you're
looking for the starter
and in there we basically want to set up
the component now before we set up the
component I just want you to navigate to
data.js and take a look we have this
people array so this is what we're going
to be importing into a list one so
whenever I say people just think of this
array and as you can see in here we
basically have list of objects and each
object represents the person and the
question here is that some object
have the properties for example nickname
and the images URL and some don't and
before you wonder why is that the setup
because this is I wouldn't say quite
typical but don't be surprised if you
work with an API and that's the case
again I'm not saying that every API has
this issue where basically the data is
missing but you will run it through some
instances where essentially yes
some items have certain properties and
some don't and also it happens quite
often when you work with headless cmss
essentially a nice graphical interface
where you can add your own data and for
some weird reason let's say you forgot
to add that data that quite often
happens with an images trust me on this
one for sure and if you're wondering why
we have this weird nested structure
again when it comes to images don't be
surprised if you actually see this in
the real world it's not as
flat as you might expect so you're not
going to have a bunch of items with just
okay name nickname and image no when it
comes to real apis yes you have this
nested sometimes weird structure so the
sooner we get comfortable with that the
better it's going to be in the long run
so hopefully this is clear hopefully you
haven't turned off
since I was just ranting here about the
array and now let's navigate back so
effectively this is the challenge we
want to create a new component I'm going
to call this list call this I don't know
orange still going to work and in the
list I want to import the people all
right again from the data I just showed
you and I just want you to iterate over
and render name that's it let's just
start very simply
we'll display the name now once
everything is correct once you can see
the name in the browser
after that I want to set this one up in
a separate component basically what
we're turning and this is a good use
case to try glean extension now you
don't have to but I will I'll just
showcase how the extension works and
then in the person try to render all
three properties and I'm sorry this is a
mistake we're not going to be looking
for a sister we're going to be looking
for the image so initially when I was
building this example I used sister but
in fact we're looking for the image and
as far as your question do I effectively
need to get this URL yes you're
absolutely correct so in order to show
the image you'll have to figure out how
to access the URL which is quite nested
as you can see
and if everything is correct yes there
will be a bug effectively that's the
point of these videos to show you how we
can avoid such bugs so try to work on a
challenge and whenever you're ready to
compare the results resume with the
videos Okay so let's start cracking
first I want to navigate to the star and
I'm going to create that list so as you
can see the star is empty and I simply
want to go list j s x in here let's grab
the data
so we're looking for people array in the
data I'm pretty sure it's going to give
me an auto import so I just want to set
up the list first and then inside of it
I want to iterate over data so where I
have the div I'll simply go with an
expression and I'll try to type people
and if everything is correct I should
see them yep as you can see everything
Works nicely now I have the people okay
that's good it's going to be an array so
I do want to iterate over
so let's go here with map and I'll
reference each and every item as a
person and then as far as the return
like I said simply for now we want to go
with person.name because that's the
property that all of the items have as a
quick send out
when it comes to key you can actually
use the name in this case as well so
remember all this time I've been showing
you following approach where if you have
the div or whatever element you want to
return
um if this is where we're iterating we
want to go with key of course and then
we want to go with that unique one so up
to this point all the time we have been
using the ID keep in mind that in this
case let's imagine that we don't have
the ID over here
we're still loving the name and at least
in this case since I have four items all
of them are unique so yes
you don't always have to go with ID but
it's going to be somewhat common because
with the case of ID it's always going to
be unique so here I set up the key it's
going to be equal to person ID and then
I want to render that I want to go with
person dot name let's save it now I want
to navigate back to app jsx I think I'm
just gonna do it right after the hearing
2 because why not and in here I'm
looking for less than again I'll rely on
the Auto Import like I said if
everything is correct this is what we
should see on the screen
great start and now let's navigate back
to the list and now try to set up this
one as a separate component now if you
want you can create the file yourself
and all that or you can utilize the
extension I showcased I believe in the
previous section
basically which one was that this one
over here the project structure so I
want to hover over it I'm looking for
that light bulb and I want to go here
with extract component to the file and
in here we just need to look for the
correct path we need to make sure that
this is the one that we click okay
awesome we want to create a new file and
we want to come up with a name so in my
case I'm going to call this person and
then j s x and check it out again we
right away have the import we right away
have the component and then if you check
the person notice we right away have the
prop set up as well now as you can see
there are some issues here so basically
either all I have to pass the person
from the list or in my case since I'm
going to be spreading out I'm actually
going to remove these values over here
so it's not perfect but at least it gets
us halfway correct so let's just
navigate back and in here essentially
again I want to set up that key so I
guess this is the case where I can just
simply grab this one
over here person and like I said we can
use the name over here like so and then
after that I want to pass the entire
person
so I'm going to be spreading out all of
the properties we can most likely save I
believe and then back in the person
I'm not going to be accessing person in
such a way
I'm gonna go one by one so I'm going to
go with name then I'm also looking for
nickname that's the second property that
I want to showcase and I also want to
get that URL
now in order to access that URL what
I'll have to do well I'm gonna go with
images correct since that's the array
over here
and for now let's just leave it the way
it is and let's decide what are we gonna
be returning so in here there's going to
be a div and let's just try it out with
a name because like I said there's going
to be a bug So eventually we'll have an
error so for now let me just see whether
everything works yep so I can nicely
display the name now let's go with
nickname so right after that we want to
go with paragraph and I'm going to come
up with whatever value so nickname and
as I say note this is now what I wanted
to do
so let me just take this one out
and then I'll place it here before the
curlies and now let me access the
property
and we already have a little bit of
issue where notice only the stud muffin
is displayed since only Bob as this
particular property and again this is
something that we're gonna fix in the
following video and when we'll
definitely get a bug is when we'll try
to get the image now I'll purposely
access it above since it's just going to
save me essentially setting up the whole
thing in the jsx so if I have a bunch of
nested properties essentially that is my
preference where I do it above the jsx
keep in mind that of course you can do
it in the GSX as well as far as the
alternative I'm going to go here with
the name and I'm sorry I forgot to
actually mention a
tiny suggestion you probably want to go
with a small width my bad so let's go
here so if you have massive images just
add in-line Styles like I'm doing right
now so we're looking for 50 pixels and
now let me grab that image so let's go
over here const I'm going to call this
IMG and whatever we want to do well we
want to go with images correct that's
the area over here and
I'm looking for the first item
and there I'll have the small so that's
the object itself and then in there I
have the URL so one by one let's
navigate there again we're looking for
the first item
then I want to grab the small object in
there
I'll have the URL property and that is
going to be equal to my image and let's
try to access it over here
and like I said we'll have big fat error
so in the following videos
we'll work on these errors and we'll see
how we can leverage straight up
JavaScript
to fix it and have something displayed
on screen and before we cover the
solution let me just quickly mention
that in the readme you'll find info on
default values
and also the optional training so
both features will implement
in this video and if you want to find
out more info if you're not familiar
with them you can always utilize the
readme so back in the person
let's start with the nickname that's
going to be a little bit easier so let
me just comment out the image just so we
don't have that massive error and notice
over here we still have it because of
course I am also accessing the image
over here so I'll have to do it in two
places let's comment this one out and
for now let me just remove those
messages
and as far as the nickname what is the
issue well again
not all of them have that property
what's the solution well one of the
solutions is obviously to use the poor
Operator just like we covered in
conditional rendering correct
so I can go here and say shake and bake
and what do you know now all of them
have at least some kind of value
okay that's good but we can also utilize
the fact that when it comes to functions
in JavaScript we can provide right away
a default value
so if you're setting up a function and
you're passing in the parameter you can
also provide a default value just in
case it's not provided shown here I know
that I'm going to be looking for a
nickname however if it doesn't exist
what can we do well you can set it equal
to shake and bake
and what do you know now the result is
going to be exactly the same again this
is just straight up JavaScript something
that you can utilize as you're setting
up your react components now the second
one is
sort of the same the problem again we're
having in here if we comment out we have
that annoying
error which essentially says hey you
cannot access
the properties from nothing
why well because if we go back again
only the third item has the images
so if I'm trying to do this for Bob
Pierre and all that it's not going to
work
so what word can do well we can do it
the long way so bear with me I'll show
you basically what we were doing before
the
optional training and then I'll show you
effectively why optional chaining is so
cool
and the way it worked before
we simply needed to
repeat bunch of and operators
so in here I'm going to go with image
and I don't think I'm going to leave
this one for your reference I don't
think there's any need so first I go
with images and I'll say listen
if the images exist then look for the
first one
so essentially I'm using the N1 now if
there is a first one then I'll look for
small so essentially one by one you just
keep repeating them so what I'm saying
here is if images exist get me the first
one now if the first one exists then get
me the small property so in here I just
want to take this copy and paste and yep
I want to say hey
if it's there then grab me the small one
and you can probably already guess that
yes in order to get the URL what do we
need to do we need to copy and paste and
then we need to just chain essentially
here this URL like so so we grab it here
and notice how we nicely don't have the
error so essentially if I refresh I'll
see no errors in console and also
the one that has the image
is going to have that in the jsx as well
so once we save notice I have
person displayed now rest of them don't
have it
so that's something that we need to work
on but at least the one that has the
image well I'm nicely rendering that in
the jsx
and essentially let's first worry about
how we can shorten this code and then
we'll worry about how we can display at
least something in the browser so first
yes this is awesome
but I mean it would be nicer if we could
just get it done in less lines of code
essentially less characters and the way
we can do that is by using optional
chaining in JavaScript so here we go
with const and then again IMG and if
you're wondering this code is going to
be again located in the readme so you
can always reference it so we want to go
here with images and then we just go
with question mark
and if
the property
exists basically if it's not null then
everything is good if not then we'll
right away just get undefined this is
also awesome where we don't have that
annoying hey you cannot get properties
out of null so essentially what I'm
saying here if images exist awesome get
me the first one if that exists then get
me small if that exists then actually
get me the URL now
this is great but it doesn't solve the
issue
where at the moment notice only one of
them has the image and it's probably a
nicer setup if you have at least some
kind of default image correct and not to
do that
you actually need to look at the assets
and you'll see that I provided some SVG
and yes basically this is something that
you'll need to set up manually yourself
whether that is in the cloud Mary
whether that is locally
you'll need somewhere a default image so
in my case that's the default Avatar in
the asset so now let's navigate back to
the person and we want to import that
now please keep in mind that we're
sitting in a source so we need to import
we need to name the variable and then we
need to provide the path so in this case
I'm going to go with this one I'll call
this Avatar and then from and now let's
go one level up then two levels up three
levels up we're looking in the assets
and we want to go default and then
Avatar and then SVG
and now we can utilize the or operator
where I can say Hey listen check four
Images check for the first one check for
small and URL and if it's there awesome
return this one if not well just set it
equal to my default Avatar and what do
you know now we have a list and if the
item doesn't have the image at least we
display something now quite often as
you're looking at the optional chaining
code you'll see this approach as well
where essentially let me comment this
one out
and you'll see this one and effectively
this operator let me go back to read me
I left it here for your reference so
it's this one that's the operator you're
looking for now I'm not gonna go into
great detail what's the difference there
extremely similar uh if you're
interested then please utilize the
search engine again
instead of the or you'll see these two
question marks and that's this operator
and if you want to find out more info
just please go to your favorite search
engine and pretty much we're done with
the challenge as you can see we can
utilize straight up JavaScript
to essentially fix the potential bugs
that we might encounter once we start
working with apis and I know that some
of you think this is totally weird
example there's no way there would be
such structure and then there's no way
that properties would be missing I mean
he's totally making this up and again I
don't want to be a bearer of bad news
and I'm not saying that every API is
going to have the issues but once you
start working with external apis just be
prepared that structure
might not be what you
expect it's going to be pretty nested I
can tell you that right from the get-go
and also here and there properties are
going to be missing so if you ever seen
a console JavaScript complaining that it
cannot access certain property right
away think ding ding ding ding ding
there's a property missing so even
though I'm expecting something
back from the API and I'm trying to
render it here
well it's not coming through and as far
as suggestions my always suggestion is
to limit the amount of items you're
rendering so if I hit this bug yes one
by one effectively I comment out the
stuff and then I go back and check which
value is missing so normally I would log
the person back here in the list and
then I would go over where potentially
that property might be missing just to
Showcase that if we go here with log in
person we'll right away see that only
some of them have those values now of
course this is somewhat simple example
where I right away can see that but
normally this is the place where at
least I can start working on the problem
because this is going to give me at
least the idea of what data I'm getting
back awesome and next let's talk about
forms in react and we're going to start
working in this folder so we're going to
go to zero six forms and we'll start
with the first file however
since I want the examples to look
somewhat nice
we'll spend the first video just by
setting up the form with some
classes and labels and all that now if
you're not interested in doing that just
navigate to the readme look for
controlled inputs and basically copy and
paste this content so this component
copy and paste and set it up in the
controlled input essentially that's
going to be the first step now don't
worry we're not going to do that pretty
much for every file
I believe we have all here five of them
so essentially in the next videos we'll
just reuse this nice looking form
so first I want to navigate to app jsx
like I said we're looking for zero six
forms then starter and then controlled
inputs so that's what I have on the
screen now let's navigate over here
and effectively we just want to set up a
form and if you're wondering where the
classes are coming from that I'm about
to use well they're located over here
so if you look here in this file let's
say if we search for class of form
you'll see these Styles and then same
goes for label input and all that so if
you're interested of course
you can navigate over there and see what
styles I'm setting up
so let's go over here in the controlled
inputs we'll remove the heading 2. and
effectively we're going to return a
formal ad right away a class form as
well
inside of it let's place a hitting four
and let's say controlled input so that's
going to be our first topic after that I
want to set up a div with a classiform
row and you can think of it as a divider
so it's just going to add some nice
margin so let's go here with div let's
add a class of form
row and then inside of it first let's
set up a label again it's just a HTML
thing and notice over here it's going to
give this html4 so that's the HTML
attribute by the name of four and you
add that to the label and then once you
click on the label then it nicely sets
the input in the focus and you'll see
once we set it up how it works so in
here we want to provide the ID so
whatever ID we're about to set up on the
input so I know that my one is going to
be named so of course I'm going to set
this one up as name then we want to type
the text inside of the label and you
know what there's one thing missing and
that is the class
and for that we want to go with form and
label then we want to go with that input
and we'll start with the most basic one
the text input so let's go here let's
look for text name for now let's leave
it blank because I want to show you
what is going to be the use case so for
now let's not worry about it but yes
eventually we will use it and then here
we want to go with name so again these
two need to match and in react it's
html4 in normal HTML it's going to be
just A4 attribute and we do want to add
here a class so we'll go with class name
and that is going to be perform input
let's save it and this is what we should
see on the screen and again if these two
match then basically what happens notice
once you click on a label
it nicely sets the
Focus for the input and
since I also want to set up one for
password or email sorry password is
coming up for now let's just go with
email and we want to change those values
so everywhere where I have the name I'll
set it up as email and as far as type
yes it's also going to be an email so
let me select over here
let me go to email let's say that okay
we have the second input and lastly
let's just add that submit Button as
well so for that we want to go button
then we want to go with type and submit
and in here let's go with class name ptn
again Global button class and then we
want to go with BTN block which just
stretches
that button
to the size of the container in this
case form and as far as the text I'm
going to go with sub emit let's save
that and we're pretty much good to go so
this is going to be our setup for the
remaining videos in this section
and of course in the next video also set
up the functionality for now we just
have a good looking form okay and now
let's start working on controlled inputs
and essentially when you hear controlled
inputs just think that there's going to
be a state value now it can be one value
which represents all of the inputs
something we're going to cover a little
bit later or it can be a case where each
input is going to have
a state value that is associated with
that input and as you're changing the
value in the input
you're automatically also changing the
value in the state
and then in turn the input shows the
state value and if this is somewhat
confusing just think of it this way
basically whatever we're going to be
typing this is going to be added to the
state value and then whenever you're
ready to submit the form you can just
grab that state value and do whatever
you need to do whether that is to post
some data on a server or to set up some
kind of functionality and hopefully you
see where I'm going with this so if this
sounds a little bit confusing again just
bear with me basically like I said we
want to start by setting up State values
and in this case we'll do a state value
for each input later yes we'll combine
all of them in one so for that we just
need to go with your state and
since I have name and email it kind of
makes sense if I name my state values
the same correct so I'm going to go here
with name and then set
name and that is going to be equal to
use and state that's what we want to set
it up over here and we'll start with an
empty string because this is what we
have in the input and then we want to
change it around where this is not going
to be name
it will be email and then we're looking
for set an email
so this is our initial setup and then we
want to set up a function that is
actually going to be invoked every time
the user is going to type something in
the input and remember in the react
fundamentals we covered that the event
that we want to add to the input is on
change so as the user is going to be
typing something in the input we will
invoke the Callback function which of
course we need to set up first so let's
go here and let's say const and then
handle
and I'll change that's going to be my
function and remember that we right away
have access to the event object there
and for now let's just leave it blank
and then when it comes to input if we
want to set up controlled input on each
input we need to add two things
we need to add a value
and this needs to be basically equal
to that state value so I'm going to go
here with name and second one is that on
change and yes both of them need to be
there
otherwise it's not going to work so in
here I'm going to go on change and then
I want to pass in the Callback function
correct so I'll go with handle change
and save it now the last thing
that we want to do is to set up the
functionality and if you remember in
react fundamentals I said that we have
access to the event object and from
there we can get tons of cool things the
two most important ones I guess the ones
that we're going to use the most in the
course are
event.target.name and event.target.value
now for now we don't have the name and
I'll showcase that basically we'll get
an empty string but we'll definitely get
the value
so let's go over here
let's say log
and we want to go with event dot Target
dot name copy and paste and we also want
to set up the value and for this I'll
actually move to the bigger browser
window because I do definitely want to
showcase the state so this is going to
be the form on a bigger browser window
and if we inspect
the components right away see the
controlled inputs okay awesome notice
our two State values so they do exist
and then as I'm going to be typing I'm
going to get two things first one is
going to be empty because there is no
name set on the input our second one is
going to represent whatever the user has
typed now notice something interesting
though we're not persisting this value
input so this will always stay empty
string why well take a look
because our state value is an empty
string
so when we're setting up controlled
inputs that's why we need
all of those things we need a state
value we need both of those
attributes on the input we need the
value as well as the on change and in
the Callback function this is where
we'll update the state value
how we can do that well we can use set
name correct and again keep in mind this
is going to be empty if there is no name
attribute and later we'll set up the
name attribute and we'll use it but I
definitely want to showcase that if
there is no name attribute then I mean
it's just going to be empty so I'll
leave these ones for your reference
and here's what I want to do I'm going
to go with set name and then I want to
grab whatever I have in the value so
let's involve that and let's say event
dot Target dot value and now the
interesting thing is going to happen
so we have the state value we have the
on change and as the user is typing
we'll be setting the state value equal
to whatever is in the input and then in
turn we use that value here to display
it in the form so check it out here and
I think again I'm going to use the
bigger browser window just so you can
see that we're definitely updating that
state value now check it out essentially
whatever I have in the form gets here
has a state value and that's why
I can see that in the form as well so
hopefully this makes sense okay so that
should do it for the first controlled
input but what about the second one what
about the email
because as you can see at this point
we're just updating the name so if I'll
add this handle change to the email I
mean it's not going to work
even though I can add the email as a
value
to the input I mean in here I have set
name not set email
so what are our options well we can set
up another function so let's say we can
rename this so it's not generic I can
say handle name change and then for the
email of course I'm going to go handle
email change or we can use the error
function and effectively
this is totally up to you if you have
more logic then of course it makes sense
that you set it up here as a separate
function however if you're just passing
event.target.value then we also have
this option where instead of the handle
change which by the way you can always
find it in the readme and therefore just
so it's cleaner I'm going to remove
what we can do here is set up our Arrow
function remember we do need to grab the
event so that doesn't change and then
invoke set name directly here so I can
go here with email dot Target dot value
and you guessed it correct
for all the inputs we basically need to
repeat these two steps we need to set up
the value I mean considering that you
already have the state value
we need to set up the value and we need
to set up the on change and then in the
on change we just go with set and then
whatever is the name of the input so
let's go here
let's keep on moving this is going to be
my input I want to copy and paste again
these are different values so it's not
going to be named it's going to be email
and the function is also going to be
email let's save that and again let's
navigate to the big browser window and
if I'll type over here
let's say some kind of dummy email
doesn't look like it works here
maybe just needs a little nudge let me
try right now John
and as you can see now everything works
so now both of them are controlled
inputs and essentially our workflow is
going to be we'll set up value and on
change and then we'll set up the on
submit as well so let's navigate
where we have the state values
and let's just add a on submit on the
form
and let's
create a handle submit
so I just need to create that function
handle
submit and
hopefully you remember from the
fundamentals that again we have access
to the event object and in here the
first thing we want to do is prevent the
default Behavior so we invoke prevent
default and then we can do something
again at the moment we're not going to
do anything in this video but
technically this is where you post to
the server where you do something with
the value so say do something and
essentially we just want to access both
of the values so in my case I'm just
going to log it so I'm going to say
name
and email and once I save
notice how I can nicely type so John and
then John at gmail
and once I click on submit and check the
console notice I have both of the values
I have the John as well as the email so
essentially that's how we can set up
controlled inputs in react beautiful and
once we're familiar with controlled
inputs why don't we work on a small
challenge and first what I want you to
do if you haven't done that already go
to app jsx and look for zero two user
Challenge and this is what you should
see on a screen
basically I prepare the form now I
didn't set up any functionality again
it's just a straight up form you'll have
to do all of the work and as you can see
in this case we're just using one input
that's it that's pretty much the only
difference and as far as the challenge
well it's following so first
create a control input
and in my case I'm going to call this
name and you'll see why it actually
makes sense then set up on submit
basically for now just a placeholder
don't worry about the logic yet
if you can log
that user has submitted the form
basically if you have prevented the
default and all that you're in good
shape so first set up those two things
then I want you to import data array
from data
and just to drag our memory so we're
here so this is what we want to get
we want to get this data array and
that's why we'll go with name input
because this is the property we have in
the object and once you have
successfully imported the data set up
another state value in my case I'm going
to call this users and set the array as
a default value and I'm purposely being
somewhat vague because we have covered
all of these things already then I want
you to iterate over
the list and display right after the
form so if we navigate to the user
challenge notice this comment over here
so this is where I want you to display
the users that are in the array again
don't worry about the CSS if you can see
the name
correctly displayed in a browser you're
in good shape
and at the very end we want to set up
following functionality when the user
submits the form
add a new person to the list now
if you find this one easy you can work
on extra challenge where I want you to
add a button
to whatever we're returning basically
the item and set up the functionality to
remove the user from the list
so if you're interested work on this
Challenge and once you're ready to
compare the results resume with the
videos Okay so let's get cracking first
I'm going to navigate to the user
challenge
and I'll create those State values
basically I know that I'll have two of
them so
while I'm setting up one I might as well
set up the second one so name and then
set name that is equal to use
State let's pass in the empty Value
First copy and paste then like I said
Marcus I'm gonna go with users
set and also when I do it over here now
for now since I haven't imported
anything let me just set it up as an
empty all right let's save this and now
I want to set up that controlled input
so
I need to look for my input and then
here remember value
that is equal to the state value and
then the second one is the on change and
this is going to be equal to our Arrow
function we'll grab the event object and
we'll go to set name and we'll pass in
the event dot Target and then the value
so now we have our controlled input next
I wanna set up just the log
when we submit the form so here notice
Veet is pretty quick basically the
moment you type the value it spins back
the center don't worry you don't have it
everything is correct and like I was
saying we want to set up that handle
Summit so let's go here and I'm going to
call this handle submit
we're gonna get the object yes the event
object more precisely and here let's
start with prevent
default and I'm going to go with just
log
I'll say
form
submitted okay good and now let's
navigate to the form
and then let's set up on submit
beautiful and let's pass in the handle
submit let's save that and if everything
is correct we should see form submitted
awesome
and once we have this setup in place now
let's grab that data so let me try here
whether I can actually do it data and
nope that doesn't give me anything okay
let's grab it from the file so import
data and then from and now we need to go
quite a few levels up so one two and
then this should be coming from the data
let me just double check quickly so data
data yep that's the correct one probably
not the best naming but as I was setting
up
that's the one that I used so this is
going to be our default value for the
users and now let's navigate over here
where we render and then like I said
right after form we're gonna go users
and now let's iterate over those users
and simply return a div since we
potentially might set up a button again
that is totally up to you but in my case
I'll try to do that at least and then
users map so we're iterating over and
then this should be already very
familiar we have done that quite a few
times during the course and that's why I
keep pushing for you to set it up on
your own
because we have covered that you just
need to practice that's it there's no
real secret and as far as the return I'm
gonna go here with div
and then let's set up the key this is
where we're iterating over so I'm gonna
go to user ID because I know
that in my array in the object more
precisely and then as far as the value
well like I said let's not over
complicate things we're just going to go
to user and then name let's save and
this is what we should see on the screen
so here's our task and you know what let
me make this one as heading to so it
stands out now every time
the user submits the form
essentially we want to add a new user to
our array
so this basically is the main challenge
and effectively we can do it this way so
first I have the handle submit correct
now I need to grab the value of the name
but here's the thing user might try to
submit the form basically without
entering anything
and this is normally where we would
display the alert or some kind of toast
or whatever that all the values need to
be submitted but in this case we'll
simply return from this function
so the most basic check is following I
can say if
and if there is no name if you want of
course you can log stuff that's totally
up to you but in my case I'm just going
to go with the return and you'll notice
that if the user tries to submit the
form with empty values I'll have nothing
in a console so again this stresses the
point that we're not going to get to
this line JavaScript is going to keep on
reading and this is the earlier turn
jumpsuit is going to be okay
this actually matches there's no value
in here so I'm just going to return from
this function that's the most basic
check again for the empty value and yes
before you ask if you have multiple
values let's say name email password and
all that then basically you go with or
and then again you check so we go this
not operator and we say
if it meets the condition then we're not
essentially doing anything we're just
returning from the function so that's
the first step now the second one if
there's actually some value so let's say
if the user types something and I click
notice form submitted now I want to
construct that user
and this is the case where yes basically
I'll have to create a new object on the
Fly and I'll have to add it to my
existing array
so let's start over here let's say that
there is some kind of value
first thing we need to do is set up that
ID now of course you can hard code
somehow but one neat trick while you're
basically working on some simple
application like this one you can just
use some helpers and in this case I'm
going to use date dot now again this is
not for serious projects in that case of
course it's going to be more complex but
also keep in mind one thing that
normally you're communicating with
database anyway and database is
responsible for setting up those IDs so
this is just for practice where since I
know that
my user has both ID and name I just
manually need to create that ID
because name of course is going to be
provided by this input hopefully that
makes sense so let's go here with cons
and then fake ID and like I said I'm
just going to use date dot now but
please don't use that in any serious
project and if you want you can log
essentially those are going to be
milliseconds
from I believe 1970 or something along
those lines so if we go over here
and if we type check it out notice this
is going to be my value again
just something Nifty that we can use
while we're working on this project so
let me just comment this one out for
your reference if you want and then now
let's construct that user so we're going
to go here with const new user and that
is equal to an object so I have two
properties first one is going to be at e
which is going to be equal to fake ID
and then the second one is the name Now
where's the name coming from well it's
coming from the state correct over here
and we only get to this functionality if
there's some value in the input if not
then we won't even get to it and now
let's construct that new array the one
that we will set up using set users so
in here let's go with cons and then I'll
call this updated users and then that
one is equal to first I want to spread
out all of these values because I'll be
adding to this array again I don't want
to override that keep in mind we can
pass here whatever we want so if you'll
just simply Place new user in the set
users you'll set your array now equal to
an object that's not what we want to do
we want to spread out so we want to copy
all of the current values from the users
and then we want to add the new one so
say here new user and we'll use this
updated users and set it as our new
value so go to set users and we'll pass
in an updated users and lastly
it kind of makes sense if we clean out
the input right
otherwise it's just going to stay there
and the way we do that is simply by
typing set name again same function
whatever we have over there and we just
provide the empty value now I don't
think we need any more of this one we
can remove and now check it out
essentially
as I'm going to be submitting something
this is going to be my new user and then
if user tries to submit with empty
values nothing happens however if we do
provide the value and if I say Bob
then check it out if I take a look at my
browser I have Bob over here and input
is also nicely set to an empty string
and Just for kicks as far as the extra
challenge now let's also set up those
buttons and let's remove the user if the
button is clicked so first we want to
navigate where we have the return that's
why I set up the div and we're going to
go with button and I'll just type remove
in here we're gonna go with on click and
eventually we'll set up some Logic for
now simply go and empty Arrow function
just so we don't have the error and I'm
also going to add the class name and I'm
going to say BTN so that's going to be
my generic button class
and now let's move up and set up that
functionality where essentially I'm
going to call this remove user it's
going to be looking for one thing and
one thing only it's going to be looking
for the Eddie and as far as the logic I
want to use filter again
and essentially return only the items
whose ID does not match whatever I'm
passing in so again I'm going to call
this updated users in this case I'm
going to speed this up a little bit by
just copying pasting so this is going to
be the same however I'm not gonna spread
out values this way I know that filter
returns a new one so I can simply say
users
and then filter
and as far as the Callback function I'll
call this person and I'll say if the
person ID
doesn't match then return
if it doesn't match the ID that we're
passing in however if the ID matches
then that person is not going to be
returned and of course again we set
users equal to this new value and now we
just navigate down here where we have
the arrow function and essentially we
want to go with the remove user and
we'll grab the user ID so user dot ID
let's save this and now one by one I can
remove them that concludes the entire
challenge hopefully everyone enjoyed it
and I'll see you in the next video okay
and up next let's talk about how we can
set up one state value for multiple
inputs and before we begin let me just
stress something it's not something that
you have to do if you have multiple
inputs so it's not a requirement however
you'll see this quite often and
therefore I think it's important that
you know how to set it up and basically
the logic behind it also
during this video will heavily rely on
Dynamic object keys and if you need to
jog your memory on that please utilize
this JS nuggets video so first we want
to navigate to app jsx you want to make
sure that we're sitting in the zero
three multiple inputs and then let's
navigate to the file
so in here
we want to set up one state value
which is going to represent all of the
inputs so at the moment notice instead
of just name and email I also have the
password so instead of setting up three
state values I'll set up one how we can
do that well we can create that State
value as an object correct so let's go
to use
State this is going to be my object and
I just need to come up with the
properties now before we do that why
don't we also
come up with a name so in my case that
is going to be user and set user so that
is going to be my set function
so as you can see nothing changes
that part still stays the same
difference right now is that we'll have
an object and basically each input
we can set it up as a property in here
so we'll have name I'll also have the
email
and also have the password and as far as
my default values they will be empty
string if you want to go with some
different
value of course that is totally up to
you so now I have the user and now let's
think about it
in order to set up the input
we will have to have a function correct
so why don't we create that and the
beauty here is that we can use only one
function since we have only one
State value as an object we can also set
up only one function so I can say handle
change and hopefully you see that it
kind of saves us a little bit of time if
we have multiple inputs so again we only
have one state value and we'll only have
one function so that's basically the
benefit of such approach and now once I
have the function
let's not worry about any logic in here
I will navigate to all of the inputs and
here's what we want to do
we want to set up the value however in
this case
it's not equal to the state value it is
equal to a state value which is a user
and then that and then the property and
in this case of course it is name and as
far as the function well we go here with
on change and we set it equal to our
handle change
and effectively we want to repeat that
for all of the inputs again we have name
email as well as the password so let's
change it here to email
and
let me grab this one more time
and copy and paste
so of course now the state value is
going to be a password all right awesome
now let's decide how we can access the
actual value
because if I'm going to go over here
if I'm going to say e and
first let's just log e dot Target and
value you'll see that everything is
correct but we don't know which
input we're referencing here as far as
the target again let me remove this one
and then notice yeah everything is
awesome
I mean I can see whatever letters I'm
typing and of course the reason why we
don't see anything in the form is
because we're not updating anything so
the state values stay empty however
the big problem here is that I don't
know which input am I typing here
so yeah I have S but what is it name
email password and therefore we need to
use the name attribute remember the very
very
beginning of this section I covered it
we can also access the event Dot
target.9 and of course
that needs to be here in the input as
well and therefore I'm going to go here
with name and I'll set it equal to name
why I work because that's my state value
basically so this is always the funny
one when you show in the example because
it's like name equals to name yeah
that's effectively my property now it's
probably going to make more sense here
with an email because now name will be
equal to email and you guessed it
correctly we need to do the same thing
for the password so this is a must if
you have such setup where you have one
state value and it's an object yes you
will need to use this type of approach
you'll definitely need the name as you
saw before when we had two inputs and we
used Straight Up functions these State
functions you don't have to do that
I mean you can always add the name but
it's not a requirement in this case
since we have one function yeah this is
what we need to do so let's go here with
log and let's say event.target
and yes this will reference
basically whatever
input the user is typing in so this is
name and then this is the value the same
is going to be for email and you guessed
it for the password again we see nothing
yet in a browser because we're not
updating
but this is already an awesome start
so we have the name and we have the
value so here's what we want to do
we want to take this name and we're
going to update that specific property
here
in the object with what with this value
how we can do that well
this is the interesting part we need to
use the following logic first of all we
go with set user so that's our set
function then remember we have multiple
values so I cannot simply go with name
and then whatever
this is going to effectively remove
these two
if I use such approach so that's not
going to work what we can do
solution is dot dot and then user so
essentially I want to spread out again
all of the existing values first
because I'll be overriding
only one at a time right I'll be typing
in one input at a time and after that we
want to dynamically update the proper in
the state and set it equal to Value so
first let me set up the code and then
I'll try to
explain as best as I can because again
this is something that pops up quite
often in the course q a where I'm gonna
go with these square brackets I'll pass
in
event.target.name and please keep in
mind that this value
will be either name email or password in
this case
so of course if you have 15 of them
then it's going to be one of those 15.
so this will reference whatever we have
here in the name and what happens it
will access dynamically this property in
the object that's why it's so important
that they are the same
that essentially you have the properties
in the object and they match exactly
what you have over here because
otherwise if this value for example is
names
and you'll try to set it in the object
it's not going to work so make sure that
they match exactly whatever you have in
the object so we are accessing
dynamically this property and we'll set
it equal to what we have here the value
right so we'll go with
event.target and then dot value let me
save and like I promised I will come
back to this one don't worry and now
let's go over here and notice we nicely
type and I still have those logs I don't
think I need them let me navigate to the
big browser
and let's see we should see the state
value as well
looks like I need to refresh here as far
as Veet let me try multiple inputs
notice so now my state is an object and
as I'm typing I'm actually providing
values over here
for the name for the email hand password
and like I said yeah this triggers a
bunch of questions in course q a
so as far as my explanation well let's
think about it if I'm gonna go over here
and if I'm gonna just hard code one of
the properties if I'll say
name like so in any input I'm going to
type
I'll be just updating the name so let's
try this one out notice
I can save all here and basically notice
how it essentially just typing a value
over here even though we're typing in
this input and the reason why we see
nothing in these ones well because these
ones are still empty correct so even
though I'm typing in the correct input
as far as the value it's showing up here
in the name because I'm hard coding here
and the same is going to work for
password the email and all that that's
why we need to set this one dynamic
so this will be dynamic depending on
what depending what we have here
so if it's time then this will
dynamically access the property in the
object that is name
if it's email then it's email hopefully
you see where I'm going with this and
that's why we go here with event Target
and name of course if you have already
some experience with Dynamic object Keys
then this should look very familiar
again the reason for that is because we
have multiple properties we have
multiple inputs but we have one function
and therefore every time the user types
something in one of the inputs I want to
check two things not only I want to get
the value but I also want to get the
property and I want to access that
property and I'm going to set it equal
to whatever value I have in the input
and as far as the handle submit let's
set it up here let's say on submit in
this case
let's come up with the function name and
I'll submit and you know what I think
I'm just going to copy and paste I think
it's going to be faster so handle not
change we're looking for submit we do
want to get the object we do want to
prevent the default
and instead of setting the user I simply
want to log it
and again the only gotcha right now is
that it's a state value so once I type
here and of course since this is an
email
field we will have to add the add one
and let's go with mail.com
and check it out the moment I press
submit
now I have the object in the console so
essentially rest of the logic is the
same whatever you want to do after that
so yes of course you'll check for empty
values then you'll set up some kind of
functionality and a common approach is
then to clear the values so this doesn't
change the only difference that right
now we have an object and while we're
still in a row let's also cover
a few other input options more
specifically I'll show you the gotcha
when it comes to check boxes and we'll
also take a look how we can display the
select input basically when we have a
list of options so in the app jsx grab
the starter from zero for other inputs
and this is what you should see on the
screen essentially a forum with few
labels and a submit button
so first let's go to the file we're
looking for other inputs in Star and
this is going to be our entry point
um let's start by setting up two State
values and let's start with shipping
which essentially is going to be our
Boolean value so here let's go with
const and then shipping and set
shipping
and we'll set it equal to use State and
by default it's going to be false and
then we want to navigate to our form and
we're looking
for this one the first form row where we
have the free shipping in the label and
in here let's set up the input first
it's not going to be equal to type text
we actually want to go with checkbox
and since Emmett right away spits out
this name one we might as well provide
that so we're not going to use it
in this example but normally if you
would you type whatever is the state
value over here and then when it comes
to Eddie same deal we're going to go
with shipping let me save and now notice
where I have our own little checkbox
over here after that let's set up the on
change and also let's create the
function now unlike the input the
typical text or email or password we
actually want to go with checked and we
want to set it equal to that state value
so unlike the value equals to the state
value now we go checked
so let's go here first checked and that
is equal to my state value which again
is a Boolean and then when it comes to
function first we need to create one so
let me go over here and in my case I'm
going to call this handle
shipping
so that's my function I'll be looking
for the event
object and as far as the logic
first let's just log
event.target.checked so that's the one
that we're going to use not event.target
that value
because notice we don't have the value
in here we have the checked so let's go
here let's say event dot Target and
checked and I'll right away use the
value that's coming back and I'll set it
equal to my shipping in the state so in
here I'll say set shipping and set it
equal to that value
and essentially it's going to be either
true or false depending whether you have
clicked on it or not
and the very last thing we want to do
over here is to set up on change and set
it equal
to the handle shipping let's save this
again we'll have this warning in the
console but basically you'll notice that
every time we click on the checkbox
we'll get back the value and we're
setting that in a state
and I guess the major gotcha about the
checkbox is that we want to use the
checked instead of the value and when it
comes to select input essentially it's a
list of options so normally you'll have
some kind of list again typically it's
going to be dynamic so it's going to be
coming from the API and you want to
render them inside of the select input
and you'll set them up as option element
and then you're going to State there's
going to be that one value that
represents whatever the user has
selected
so first we need to create a state value
and here just be careful because I named
the state value framework
and the latest Frameworks
and
you don't want to mix them basically
when we want to display the options we
want to iterate over Frameworks but when
we want to provide the value we want to
look for framework
and
I'll remind you that once we get there
so frame work and that is going to be
equal to set framework
so let me copy and paste and I just want
to change it to a uppercase and as far
as the default value this is totally up
to you I'm gonna go with react since
that's the first item here in this list
but of course you can set any of these
values
let's also create the function because
we'll need that
so for now
copy and paste so it needs to be the sub
we won't
actually use the checked one so of
course I can remove we won't set up the
logic for now we'll simply go with
handle and then let's call this frame
work let's save that and after that we
want to set up the select input where we
have the label for the framework so
let's go here with select again Emmett
is going to spit right away name and ID
so we might as well provide those values
so in here let's just write framework
so again this is very important we are
now referencing the state value not the
list
we'll work with the list in a second so
set it equal to framework
and as far as the options this is where
we want to iterate over the list so
first let's display them and then we'll
add the value as well as the on change
so let's start over here we effectively
want to iterate over the Frameworks so
we set up here the curlies we go with
Frameworks then dot map so we're mapping
over and then as far as the value
I'm going to reference this as a
framework
framework and as far as the return we
want to go with keyword and then we're
looking for the option
then since we have a list yes we still
need to provide a key
and in this case we don't have the Eddie
however those names are unique so I'm
going to go with framework so
essentially I'm referencing the
parameter and then inside the option
This is Where I Wanna showcase
one of those options let me save and
notice that everything is correct
however nothing is going to happen
so essentially yes we're changing this
but if we navigate to the big screen
you'll see that I'm not changing that
state value
because we haven't set up the logic yet
so technically this is view but of
course in the state I still have the
react and it's very similar to typical
input
so we don't need to go here we checked
that was only for the checkbox again we
go with value we go with frame work
very very important not Frameworks but
framework
and as far as the on change well we want
to provide
our handle framework correct let's
provide this function
and as far as the functionality we
simply want to go with set framework and
it's going to be located again in event
dot Target value so if you're wondering
can we pass directly the arrow function
like we have been doing yes absolutely I
just thought since we have handle
shipping here we might as well set up
another one so we go with framework and
then we'll look for event.target and
then the value let's save that and now
if I navigate to the big screen we
should see that we're also successfully
changing the state value so that's how
we can work with check boxes as well as
select inputs in react okay and as a
very last thing in this section I want
to show you a very Nifty alternative to
controlled inputs you see we can also
submit the form with uncontrolled inputs
basically without referencing the state
value now in the following section I'll
show you an example
of how we can do that using use ref hook
but in this video I'll show you how we
can accomplish the same task with form
data API which in my opinion is a better
approach if you have more than one input
as far as form data API it's coming from
vanilla.js and effectively
it's a interface that allows us to
construct
a set of key value pairs representing
the form fields and their values and if
this sounds somewhat funky don't worry
as we're going to be working through the
example you'll see what I mean now if
you're not familiar with form data API
or
you just want to get more info on it
please reference this JS nuggets video
where I cover warm data API in Greater
detail effectively form data API has
quite a few methods on it
and since I don't want this video to be
half an hour long I'll just show you the
most common ones so first let's just go
to app GSX notice over here I have the
starter
I'm looking for zero five form data and
once you navigate you'll see that we
have a state value so essentially it
doesn't do anything I'm just going to
use it to Showcase something we also
have right away handle submit on the
form and we prevent a default hopefully
we are clear why we need that and then
we have three inputs so we have the name
one the email as well as the password
and as you can see I messed up over here
that should be a password I already
provided the ID and I also provided the
names this is very important when you
work with form data it's a must to have
a name that
effectively represents that input so if
you do decide to work with form data
just don't forget about the name it's
very easy to do that and then your
functionality is not going to work
and as far as the setup let's start with
this
let's get on the same page that if I go
to handle submit and if I log not
event.target but if I log event dot
current Target
this will point to what
this will actually point to a form so if
I go to console and if I submit notice
this returns a form element
and as far as the difference so the
event.target
refers to the Dom element that triggers
an event however the current Target
refers to the Dom element that event
listener is listening on so in simple
English in our case
since the event
our on submit is set on a form
sure enough
event dot current Target returns are
form element now why is that useful
because in vanilla Jazz there's form
data API which is just a cool setup how
we can directly access the inputs we
have
as well as the values so in this case
I can go with const and I'll call this
form data and I'll set it equal to new
form data and one gotcha don't call the
component form data essentially you'll
have an error that's why I named this
uncontrolled inputs not form data
because essentially
react is going to think that you're
referencing the component and once we
have the new form data it's looking for
that form that's why we're going to go
with event dot current Target so we go
here with event and current Target and
let's just see what we get back so let
me move this sucker down
and I'm going to go with form data now
don't be surprised if you see Elvis in
the console so don't freak out
essentially everything is correct it
just works a little bit differently so
the first time I started working with
form data I was like well wait a minute
did I pass the correct
Target because I don't see anything
don't worry
in order to access the values
we have few approaches we can use the
get method on this form data so for
example
if I want to get the name
I'm going to go here with name I'm going
to set up some kind of variable we go
with form data and we go with get and
then whatever is the name so again
that's why it's important whatever is
this value over here so if I'm going to
go with name you can probably already
guess what we're going to be getting
back correct so let's try something else
why don't we try
let's say email I'm gonna go here email
and yes of course that input needs to be
there and if I log this
I'll actually see the value once we
submit the form so if I'll type here
John and Gmail once I submit check it
out I'll have this value over here so we
have a few options like I said I'm not
going to cover each and every method if
you want to find out more about form
data please reference that video but in
this instance what we can do one by one
we can grab the email password and name
yes that's definitely
one option however there's a little bit
better option where we can transform
this into an object directly and the way
we do that we use object Dot from
entries which again is
essentially a method that we get from
vanilla.js because what we need to keep
in mind that this form data actually is
an array of arrays and just so you don't
think that I'm making this up let me go
here where I have the log let me go with
spread operator I'm going to go dot dot
and then we're looking for form data Dot
and I'm going to go with entries just so
you can see both of them then let me
save with me refresh and I'll have to
provide the values again so in this case
I'm going to go John
John over here as well
and then lastly we want to go here with
some kind of password and once we click
like I said what we're getting back from
form data entries and as I said you can
find all these methods over here notice
it has quite a few of them that's why I
said that we're not going to cover all
of them I can spread out the entries and
I'll have this array of arrays so this
is going to be the name of the input and
then this is going to be the value
and even though this is nice
most likely you'll want the object for
example if you want to submit this data
to a server how we can do that well
first of all let me comment these ones
out as always
all this functionality is available
already in the readme and let me go here
with const and I'll call this new user
and I'll set it equal to object dot
again this is coming from vanilla.js
basically it's not provided by react
it's just JavaScript and effectively
object Dot from entries
turns an array of arranged data
structure
into a object with key value pairs
and you can find a vanilla.js code
example in readme and then here we pass
in the form data and what you'll see are
as a result we have this new user now so
once I click check it out now I have an
object with all of these values
and the kicker here is that I can send
it to a server I can do some kind of
functionality and all that cool stuff
again the main point of this video is
that we don't always have to set up
those controlled inputs if we don't want
to
for example we can use form data pass in
the form as long as we have the names
and all that we're good to go we can set
up the functionality here in the handle
submit
so please don't think that you always
always have to set up controlled inputs
it really depends on your preference and
pretty much the application you have in
some instances you'll do that in some
you'll be like nope I actually want to
go with phone data and lastly let's look
at one major gotcha so we did something
with this user data we're good to go now
we want to clear out the values
you see
if we just re-render those values that
are going to stay over here and that's
why we have over here the state value
the set value so just to Showcase that
I'm going to go to set value and I'm
going to go with Value Plus One
and essentially what you'll notice that
even though we re-render correctly
because remember we're updating the
state value
these are going to stay and as far as
the values just so we can save a little
bit of time I'm just going to type some
G brush ones
I don't think makes any sense to type
anything meaningful let's click and
notice we did update the state value
it's actually happening everything is
correct however
these ones stay in input and if you want
to clear the values you want to go with
event dot current Target and then the
method name is reset so we save this one
and now notice pretty much the moment I
will submit
basically I'll do something with the
data and as a quick sign out of course
you would check for empty values so in
that case either you would get them one
by one or in the vanilla.js video I
actually show you how to do that by
iterating over array which is just less
lines of code and then once we click on
submit notice how we nicely clear the
values and again
don't think that they always stay empty
again if we provide over here something
in the inputs notice again we'll have
the new values here as far as the new
user and we also nicely clear out the
inputs awesome and up next let's cover
use ref hook
it's a lot like use state
so it preserves the value between the
renders but the difference is that
updating userf does not trigger
re-render so remember when we work with
use state every time we
update the value
we trigger re-render
now it's not the case with user ref very
often use ref is used to access
downloads but there are some other Nifty
use cases as well of course it really
depends on the projects you're going to
be working on but at least in my
experience
since I don't use use ref to access form
inputs
use ref is not something I use in every
project but once in a while there's a
very specific use case where user f is
the right tool for the job we're going
to start just like with the other
examples where essentially we want to
look for zero seven user F star and then
zero one use ref Basics and
of course I want to import that in the
app jsx and I want to navigate to that
file and notice over here I already have
the state value I have handle submit
that just prevents the default and I
have the form
as well as the heading one
with the button and as I'm clicking I'm
increasing the value here and you'll see
why we have this kind of setup in a
second so essentially if we want to
start working with us ref just like the
other hooks we want to import that from
react and we want to come up with the
name so in this case we're not looking
for an array of values we're just
looking for one value so I'm going to go
here const and then we just come up with
a name so in my case I'm going to call
this container as a quick sound I
actually like to think of use ref value
as a container
then that's just my mental model and we
want to go here with use ref
so that's the hook and then we want to
pass in that default value
so in my case I'm going to start with
null but keep in mind you can pass here
whatever you want and then if we log
you'll notice something interesting
if I log the container
and if I take a look at the devtools
you'll see that it is an object and it
has the current property and the current
property is equal to that null so
current property is always going to be
equal to
whatever you sit here as a default value
and yes react behind the scenes is going
to set this one up as an object so
notice we did not do anything basically
we just set up the user ref and this is
what the react return now once we have
this one in place essentially
we have two ways how we can set this
value because of course you don't want
to always keep it as no
one way we can set it ourselves
basically using some kind of
functionality which is going to be
actually our second example or you can
use this container and set it equal to
any of the Dom nodes now in our example
yes we will use the input because it's
somewhat common but keep in mind you
don't have to
I mean you can set it equal to any Dom
nodes and if I remember correctly in the
project we're actually going to use the
navbar just so we have multiple examples
but yes this is pretty typical to set it
equal to an input if you remember when
we talked about controlled inputs and
form data API in the previous section I
mentioned that there's another way how
we can use uncontrolled inputs and
essentially that is using use ref hook
so once I'm done with my long speech and
all that here's what we want to do
we want to find the element again in my
case that is going to be the input and
we're going to go with the ref so that's
the attribute we want to use and we want
to set it equal to what well we want to
set it equal to ref container so
whatever you created with the user of
now we don't see anything because of
course this is essentially the initial
render correct so in order to see our
actual value we need to set up the user
effect
so in here I'm going to go with user
effect and then we'll pass in the
function now I don't care about the
dependency array I just want to showcase
that essentially once our initial render
takes place
we run this user fact and in there we'll
see a different picture so here we're
going to see error of container that
actually has this input again something
important to keep in mind that yes we
have two ways that we can set up the
user of
we can either set it equal to any of the
Dom nodes and the reason why we see that
right now because this runs after
initial render correct this one is
happening during the initial render
that's the difference and we can also
for example set it
ourself again that is going to be our
second example and once current is equal
to our Dom node
what can we do well pretty much anything
once we get the Dom node I mean sky is
the limit
for example
I can grab the value and this one of
course I'll do it in handle submit so
again this was just the Showcase that
after the initial render
now in the rough container we'll have
access to that input but we'll actually
use it over here in the handle submit so
in here effectively we want to grab the
value by using value property again this
is just coming from vanilla.js so if I'm
going to go here in the handle submit
and if I'm going to take a look at the
value it will actually give me whatever
is typed in the input so if I'm going to
go here with cons name and ref container
then current again I'm accessing the
property and since the property is the
input
basically I can run with value again
this is coming from an ljs you access
the Dom node and if it's an input you
can actually run dot value and
effectively this is just going to get us
whatever the user has typed in and then
again we can do something about it now
that's something in our case it's simply
going to be logging the name so notice
this essentially is no let me comment
out we have quite a few logs here but
then if I type something and if I press
submit check it out now I'm getting this
value so this is how we can set up again
uncontrolled inputs using use graph so
that's the first example we're going to
look at and in the following video we'll
take a look how we can use use ref
to avoid running some functionality on
the initial render and you'll see what
I'm talking about in a second okay and
now let's take a look at our second
example where we will change the value
of use ref and we're going to start just
like the first one where essentially I
want to create a value with user and in
this case I'm going to call is mounted
and I'll set it equal to use ref and
just like before
I want to provide some kind of default
value and in my case I'm going to go
with false again I probably don't need
to say that now is mounted essentially
is an object in there there's a current
property and that one is equal to a
false now I also probably don't need to
remind you that if I have here a huge
effect and if I add here
dependency array and if I provide here a
value basically
the state value over here every time
I'll click on a button guess what
essentially the functionality inside of
this use effect is going to run correct
so let's kill two birds at the same time
I'm gonna go with is mounted and let's
save and notice pretty much every time
I'll click I have this current is equal
to false and once we have established
this why don't we talk about a very
specific use case
what if I don't want to run certain
functionality after initial render so I
do want to run it
after that every time the value changes
but not on the initial render again this
is not probably something that you're
going to use in every project but here
and there this is
a Nifty solution where essentially you
can just avoid running some
functionality after that initial render
and the way we do that we essentially
check this value
and if this one is false
we set it equal to true
and then after that every time this
value changes this is equal already true
and then the functionality is going to
run now one gotcha though don't check is
mounted because this will always be an
object
so this will be true we need to check
for the current property and if you're
someone iffy on that let me showcase
what I'm talking about
so inside of the use effect first of all
I think I'm going to remove this one I
can set up the if condition and I can
say if is mounted current
is false then don't run basically return
from the use effect so in here I can say
is mounted and current again don't check
for is mounted because it is an object
so essentially
it's going to be true
I'm checking for the current property
which in the beginning is false and if
that's the case then I want to go with
is mounted so notice now I'm actually
changing that value myself
I'll set it equal to true and then I'm
going to return so true and then I
return and after that if condition I
actually want to set up that
functionality now again in my case that
functionality is simply going to be
log and then re-render like so but let's
take a look what is the result so notice
I refresh and there's nothing in the
console and I'll only see something in
the console once actually
I'm changing this value
so essentially what we're doing we're
avoiding to run whatever functionality
after initial render again not something
that you'll do in every project but once
in a while you might hit this use case
and lastly I just want to showcase how
we can set up nice Focus around our
input and since we're not triggering
re-render we won't have this infinite
Loop so I have rest container which
essentially is pointing to my input
correct so I can set up a use effect
instead of the use effect
I'm going to pass in the function and
then since I know that I'm accessing
container then current so that's my
input in vanilla.js we also have this
Focus we just invoke it again this is
not reacting this is vanilla.js and
check it out basically the moment I'll
refresh I'll have this Focus around the
input and what's really cool that since
use ref
does not trigger re-render essentially
you won't have this infinite Loop like
you would if for example you would be
using use effect without the dependence
array and then updating the state value
hopefully that is clear and we can move
on to the next topic okay and up next
let's see how we can create our own
custom Hooks and custom hooks are great
for
abstracting some functionality basically
to have less lines of code in the
component and as a result it's going to
be easier to manage our component and
also once we have custom hook
we can bring it from Project to project
which of course speeds up our workflow
our rule of thumb quite often use effect
logic is a great option for custom hook
and lastly
all the hooks rules apply to our custom
hooks for example they do need to start
with use for the setup in the app GSX
look for zero eight custom hooks star
and then zero one toggle so we'll start
with somewhat basic example and then
we'll work on the fetch one and once you
navigate here
in the component you can see that I'm
using your state I have show set show
default value is false and then every
time I click on a button what do you
know I'm toggling the component
and essentially
if I have for example three four five or
whatever components that have this kind
of functionality the toggle
functionality
I can set up a pretty simple custom hook
where first we're going to navigate to
the starter and go with new file and
let's go with use again this will have
to start with you so might as well right
away set it up and I'm gonna go with
toggle and in this case we can go with
JS now if you want of course you can set
up jsx but in my case I'm going to go
with Js and essentially the way it's
going to work
we'll just take this functionality and
return from that customer so first let
me grab this just so it's faster then
let's come up with the function again we
need to go to use and in this case I'm
going to go toggle here when I know that
I'm going to be looking for some kind of
default value that's why I'll use this
as a parameter I'll say default and then
value and of course I'll pass that value
when I invoke the custom hook
and in here as far as the logic it's
pretty much the same I want to have show
and set show and I want to pass this
default value so let's go back over here
and we'll cut it out
copy and paste and instead of false I'll
actually go default and then value now I
also want to set up the toggle function
the one that I'm invoking here and I'm
going to go with const toggle let me
close the sidebar
as far as the functionality same deal
basically I want to go with Seth show
and then the opposite value whatever it
is and then from this huge toggle we
have multiple options
if you want you can return an array so
you can go here and say return
and then the first value
can be show and then the second one is
toggle so notice basically we're making
a huge state
just a little bit more complex
so in here I also have the toggle
function so hopefully it's clear so we
have the state value but I'm just adding
this extra function
so now I'm returning this and then
backing the toggle
I can access it the same way I can go
use toggle and then the first value and
the second value now I actually prefer
turning this as an object
It just fits better my mental model
where I know that there's going to be
some properties there and I just want to
access them now
this is totally up to you
if you want you can set it up as an
array and then of course we want to
export that so I'm going to go here with
export default
and then we're looking for use and then
toggle that's what we're exporting
and now back in the toggle one instead
of State we don't need the State anymore
we want to import the use and then
toggle and I'll rely on my Auto Imports
remember we do need to provide the
default value
either that's true or false and just so
you can see that it works I'll actually
go through and then remember we are
returning the object correct and as far
as the properties what do we have over
there well we have show and we have the
toggle so now this stays the same this
doesn't change but here where I have the
on click
basically I have the toggle
notice the moment I save right away see
the component why well because the
default value is true and then the
functionality still works I purposely
picked a very basic example
of course
as you're looking at it you're like well
I mean are we really saving time again
it really depends if you have 10
components that use the same toggle
functionality yeah this is very Nifty
and in the following example you'll
truly see the power of the custom hooks
again this is just to showcase the main
setup yes we can use here use State yes
we can use use effect whatever hook you
want make sure that you start with use
and then when you actually invoke the
hook if you have some default value you
need to pass it in so for example if I
flip it to false notice now I don't see
the component on the initial render but
if I go back to true this is still going
to work so again I refresh and I'm good
to go so that's the basic setup and in
the following video we'll try to do the
same thing with our fetch functionality
okay and once we're familiar with the
fundamentals of custom Oops why don't we
cover more complex example and here's
the challenge
in the app jsx import 0 to fetch data so
it's in the same folder just a more
complex example and once you navigate
there remember this is essentially
a component that is fetching a GitHub
user
and now let's try to set up a custom
hook
so effectively we want to move away
pretty much most of the logic so try to
come up with that custom hook
and a hint
hooks should return is loading his error
and user and it should take URL as a
parameter so again if you're interested
try to set it up and once you're ready
to compare the results resume with the
video
effectively like I mentioned use effect
quite often is a good use case for the
custom hook notice all these lines of
code it would be nice if we could just
move it to a separate file and
effectively we'll have less lines of
code and it's going to be easier to
grasp the functionality once you come
back I don't know in two days three days
or I don't know a half a year
and the way we can do that we can set up
the custom hooks so let's navigate back
to the starter I'm going to go with use
and I'll set up two examples first one
is going to be use fetch person
this is going to be kind of a specific
case and then I'll show you how we can
make this more generic basically how we
can have a custom hook for any data so
let's start over here I'll say fetch
person.js and then let's create that
function first
so let's go here with const use fetch
and then user
or person sorry
I mean it can also be a user of course
correct then we want to set up the
function body and first let's just take
a look at our component
so I have is loading is error and user
all of these three state values can we
move them to a custom hook yes of course
because essentially What's Happening
Here
we just set up a use effect and
eventually we get back the user or of
course if there is an error
so let's try that first I guess let's
grab these Imports and I'll right away
basically cut them out we won't use them
in this file
set it over here
then we pretty much want to take the
whole thing yep it's that drastic so I
want to First Take These State values
set it up over here inside of the
function
and then we want to grab the use effect
so whole thing over here let's cut it
out as well
and copy and paste because this Hook is
going to be looking for that URL now of
course if you know that you're going to
be using the same URL you can hard code
in the use fetch person but if you want
to make it more Dynamic set up the
parameter so here I'll say whenever I
invoke use fetch person I'm going to be
looking for that URL and of course in
this case it's this getup one and then
we're pretty much done we just want to
return all of these three values yes
effectively it's that simple remember
the use toggle
in the component what did we do well we
invoked it correct so initially is
loading is going to be true
then we're going to invoke the use
effect only
after the initial render and here we
have all this logic where we'll grab the
URL which matches the parameter of
fetched the data if there's an error
will return now if not then we'll return
a user
so essentially yes it's that simple and
here let's just go with return
and we want to go with is loading again
if you want you can return an array but
especially if I have like three values
that's definitely a good use case for a
object in my opinion let's go here and
then we also want to return a user and
then we want to navigate back to fetch
data
and essentially in here we just want to
go to use fetch for some reason it's not
importing that's fine let's just pass in
the URL and remember this one is
returning three things it's loading his
error and if there is a user correct so
we go here we set it equal to and then
we just check for is loading
same goes for is error and then we have
the user and now million dollar question
which one is easier to read
if you have eu's fetch person or
all these lines of code and as I said
the reason why nothing worked actually I
didn't export that my bad so I'm going
to go here with export default
and then use fetch Versa let's do this
and then back in the fetch data of
course we want to import that
so I'm gonna go here with use Fetch and
I'll cheat a little bit where I'll grab
the import but I'll remove this line of
code because otherwise I'm going to get
the narrow so now everything should work
again notice we have nice loading one
if there's an error we'll get an r and
eventually we get the user so that's how
we can set up a custom hook with more
complex example and as a side note
whenever you start working with react
query or other fetching libraries the
setup is going to be extremely similar
that's why I thought that it's very
important for us to understand how
fetching works with use effect of course
those libraries do way more than just
this
they do caching and all kinds of cool
things but the idea is going to be the
same you're going to get some kind of
custom Hook from the library that hook
is going to be looking for some
parameters and of course it depends on
the library what parameters the hook is
looking for
and essentially you'll get back a bunch
of useful info about the request and you
can use that info to set up
conditions to access the data and all of
that cool stuff and lastly as far as the
custom hooks let me show you how we can
make our function more generic basically
our use fetch person because I mean
chances are we'll probably want to fetch
more than just the user for example we
want to fetch an array or something
along those lines so again the
functionality pretty much is going to
stay the same I'll just change some
names and what we're returning from the
function and as a result we'll be able
to use the custom fetch hook with pretty
much any data not just with a user
object so let's try this one out where
first I want to navigate to the star
I'll create a new file and I'll call
this use fetch pretty generic correct
then pretty much I want to take the
whole thing
one by one we'll just change some values
so copy and paste over here and instead
of user why don't we call this data I
think that's pretty generic correct so
data set data and as far as default
value I'll still keep it as a and L then
we want to change around the name it's
not going to be fetch user I'll actually
call this fetch data and I just need to
remind myself that pretty much
everywhere where I have fetch user I
want to also
rename it to a fetch data so page data
here and then we also invoke it now I
don't have user anymore I have the data
so instead of user from this hook I'm
returning a data and then lastly notice
over here
as far as the response I'm calling this
a user well
we can come up with response so that's
going to be pretty generic where I'm
going to go with set data and I'll set
it equal to respond now let's save it we
want to navigate to batch data and let
me double check yep
of course I have a mess up here it's not
fetch person
I'm gonna go with use and then fetch and
same over here now technically this
should work because the export is
default but
I'm gonna rename that and then back in
the fetch data instead of use person or
move this
and we want to set it from the scratch
where I'm gonna go with use and then
Fetch and we still want to pass in the
URL now you're probably wondering okay
what about the user since that's what
we're using in this component well we're
not getting back any more user this is
actually data so we have two options you
can remove the user and go with data but
then just keep in mind that everywhere
where you have reference to a user you
also need to use data or you can simply
add an alias again a JavaScript thing
where I'm saying yeah I want to grab the
data out of the use fetch however in
this component I'm going to call this a
user that's it notice everything still
works in this case we have the generic
one which effectively we can take from
Project to project and then every time
we want to get some data we just invoke
the use fetch pass in the URL and if
everything is corrected we have no
errors
once we're done loading we'll get back
the data and up next let's discuss
context API and we're going to start
actually with the challenge where I want
you to see the pain of prop Drilling and
the challenge is following
first you want to navigate to the star
in zero nine context API and create
three components create nav bar jsx
then nav links which you want to Nest
inside of the number and then user
container
which you want to Nest inside of the nav
links one so yes I don't want you to
Nest use your container and nav links
inside of the navbar no our use case is
going to be the navbar component which
basically is our parent then the child
is nav links and then the user container
is nested inside of the navic so
essentially we have this
three level structure now after that
once you have the basic setup in place I
want you to import navbar.jsx in the app
jsx
now as far as my solution I'm going to
remove the container just so it looks
like a nav bar because I have all that
padding in the container and all that
and it doesn't look very good if I place
that nav bar but you don't have to do
that and also don't worry about the CSS
the main goal of this challenge is to
work on a logic if your example doesn't
look exactly like mine don't worry about
it again we're just focusing on the
functionality so once you have that
nested structure
then in the nav bar I want you to set up
a user State value the default is going
to be an object with some kind of name
property
again whatever you want to place over
here as well as the logout function
that sets the user back to no
no
I want to pass both of them down to a
user container and just to give you a
hint yes you will have to pass those
values through the nav links now in the
user container I want you to display
user as well as the button and then once
the user clicks the button I want to set
it equal to null now there's an extra
challenge
you can also use conditional rendering
and basically if the user is null then
you can display please login notice over
here that's the final example but again
this is an extra challenge our main
focus is to get both of these values
down from the nav bar to a user
component and once you're ready to
compare the results
resume with the videos Okay so let's
start working on the challenge
first I want to navigate to that folder
so again we're looking for context we're
not looking for the final one
we'll start working the star and we want
to set up those components let's start
with the main one so nav bar jsx let's
set up the component okay awesome and
then we want to do the same thing for
the nav links as well as the
what was the name
I believe they named it user container
yep that's the one so let's continue I'm
going to go with nav
links jsx again create the component
okay awesome and then lastly we want to
create that user container user
container jsx again
set up the component let's save now
remember we have nested structure so
I want to go to navbar and First grab
the nav links so in the nav bar I will
add a class here
of navbar just for style so I'll say
here nav
let's add the CSS and the class is
navbar and then in here inside of the
nav bar I'll have the heading 5 with
some kind of logo
so in this case I'll go with context API
and then I also want to grab those
navlicks so let's set up that component
and we want to import them like so let's
save now I don't see anything because of
course in here I'm importing the
complete one so now I right away want to
go I guess
two hey app jsx and when I grab the nav
bar from the star
so again
we'll have two of them and like I said
I'm not placing anything inside of the
container and since I still want to
showcase the final one I think I'm gonna
go with the react fragment
so I'm gonna go here with star
then it's not coming from the final it's
actually coming from the Star and then
let me set up that fragment first
and then inside of the fragment we'll
place a final so that's going to be on
the top and then we'll have the star
let's save it and I actually get the
narrow because
in the final one I'm looking for context
and of course the moment there is no
context now if you're wondering about
the folder structure notice the final
one there's going to be two examples
there's going to be a prop drilling
which is the one that we're going to be
working on right now so if you ever want
to compare the results look for prop
Drilling and then there's going to be
the context one so that's going to be
our complete example with context API so
in here I need to change the path where
it's not going to be context it's
actually going to be a starter and then
nav bar let me save it this should do it
and now notice
so I have context API that's my logo and
I have the nav links so up next I want
to go to a now links and I want to set
up the logic as well and in here it's
going to be a div with nav container and
then inside of it we'll have an old list
with nav links and then the user
container so I guess let's start by
setting up that div we do want to add a
class of nav container
and then let's go with that on our list
so this is where we'll display those
links so an ordered list and let's call
this nav links and in here list item and
I'm just going to go with an href and
for time being I'm just going to pass in
the hashtag so we're not going to go
anywhere and then let's copy and paste
and this one is going to be about
now after the unordered list I'm gonna
display that user container so again
let's use the Auto Imports let's grab
the user container and now notice
I have the links and I also have the
user container and before we set up any
kind of logic
in the user container I want to set up
those values in the navbar and
effectively I want to set up the state
value the user and I also want to get
the logout one so let's go over here
let me close the sidebar I'm going to go
with use
State like I said the default value is
going to be that object in my case the
name will be Bob so name is equal to a
bob now what are we getting back well
we want to get back the array
the user and set user now we also want
to set up right away what the logger one
so const logout and as far as the
function in here we want to go with set
user and set it back to no
and like I said the main
challenge here is to get both user a log
out down to a user container
so not just the nav links but the user
container how we can do that well since
we can only pass props down
we go to in nav links and we come up
with a prop so I'm going to go with user
is equal to user and then log out is
equal to a logout
let's save that now we want to go to a
nav links and essentially yes even
though we're not using any of these
props in the nav links component we'll
have to grab them and we'll have to pass
them down to a user container so it's
not an official name but effectively
it's called prop drilling where you're
passing
through the components that are actually
not using those props because again we
can only pass props down and as you can
see in this case we only have what three
levels basically we have parent child
and let's call it grandchild but it's
pretty normal in the application to have
five six or whatever levels so probably
your next question is are we gonna have
to do that well yeah if we're not using
the state libraries or the context API
which we're going to cover in the
following videos essentially that's the
setup there's no way around it so let's
go back over here let's say that I'm
going to be looking for a user and a log
out and yep the same deal I want to go
with user is equal to a user and I
probably don't have to say that of
course you can name this prop
differently but I just find it
convenient if we go with the same name
so I'm gonna go logout is equal to a log
out and then in the user container this
is finally where we're going to use them
so again same deal we go with user and
we want to set up the logo and now let's
work on pretty straightforward jsx where
I'm going to set up a div I'm going to
add a class name of user container and
then inside of it for now I'm not gonna
render anything conditionally I'll just
say hey grab me the user and also set up
a logout button so I'm going to have a
paragraph with hello
their comma then let's grab the user and
remember the property his name and then
right after the paragraph We will set up
a button
so button
class name
is going to be a button and then on
click
it's going to be equal to our logar one
so log out here and as far as the text
let's just go with logout let's save and
notice I have Bob and once I click I
actually set this equal to null now
we're going to have an error here
because once the user
essentially is null then of course we
cannot access the name property and in
order to avoid this error remember we
have the optional chaining where I can
say Hey listen if the user exists then
grab the name if not then just return
undefined so no others
once I click hello there and basically I
have nothing there because the value is
undefined and I also want to add to
uppercase just to Showcase that we can
use multiple
optional training operators and I'm
gonna go with two
upper
and case here let's save it so I'm
saying if there's a user grab the name
if there's a name then set it to an
uppercase so now once I refresh notice I
have Bob and then again once I click I
have nothing and then lastly let's set
up that conditional rendering where
if the user exists then of course I want
to provide the paragraph and the button
however if there's no user I simply want
to go with please login and for that
I'll first set up a paragraph I'll say
please log in and then above both of
them for now I'm gonna go user and
remember we go with question mark and
then we have two options
so first if it's true we return
something and then if it's false so
let's start here by cutting this out but
there's another gotcha if you copy and
paste there's actually going to be an
error because notice we have effectively
two adjacent elements and we can only
return one
now the way around that is again either
to set up a div or we can go with a
fragment copy and paste and now
everything works and then in here since
I'm returning only one cut it out and I
can set it up so now notice since the
user is no I have login
however once I have the user I have
there hello there Bob and once I click
now essentially I log out the user now
pretty much most of the functionality we
already covered
at some point during the fundamentals
and tutorial like I mentioned already
previously the main reason for this
challenge was to give you a first-hand
experience
of such nested structure so if you do
have
a component a parent
and you have the nested structure where
you have some kind of child and that
child has child on its own and you want
to pass something down from the parent
to let's say
grandparent let's call it that then you
will have to pass the props
through all of the components even
though technically this component is not
using any of these two props all right
and now let's take a look how we can use
context API which is provided by react
to essentially solve our issue like I
mentioned already in the previous video
if you want to see the exact example we
just completed look for prop drilling so
in the context one
you'll actually see
the setup which we're going to work on
right now now the reason why I'm telling
you that because I'll remove essentially
the user and logout from the nav links
as well as the nav bar and user
container so we'll start from the
scratch keep in mind that if you ever
need a reference it's right over here in
the final so one by one let's remove
them because that's not how we're going
to pass them down so let's remove over
here
let's save
then we want to do the same thing in the
now links
effectively we're looking for a way to
bypass
this one or multiple components that we
have sitting in between the main one the
parent and then whichever component
wants to use those values so let's
remove this and we'll probably have a
narrow right now so you know what
let me just
return something else for now again
we'll remove this I just don't want
react to start looking for the user
value and all that let's just go with
the return and we'll go with hello world
let's save it we should be good to go
now how we can pass those values
down without doing the prop drilling
well like I said we need to use context
API now there's multiple ways how again
we can invoke this if you have react
imported you can go and react and then
create context but again you'll have to
import react of course notice once I
save I'll have big fat error because
react is not defined just like with huge
state or we can right away import that
correct so since we already have used
State we can go to create context
and essentially in the parent we want to
invoke that create context and this is
going to return two things it's going to
return a provider component and a
consumer component however
since there is a huge context hook
I mean there's really no need
for the consumer however we will use the
provider so first I want to go above the
nav bar and I'll right away export since
eventually we will import the context
I'm about to create in the user
container that's why I right away go
export and then const and come up with a
name and since we're working in the nav
bar I mean kind of makes sense
if I named the snap bar context that one
is going to be equal to create context
we can pass in the default value but
we're not going to do that and
essentially once we invoke this
we get back bunch of useful stuff and we
can log that one here
so if we go here with context we should
see a bunch of cool things in a console
let me just
clean it out notice
essentially this is what we're getting
back but
our main interest is in this provider
that's what we definitely want to get
again
we used to use consumer but now use
context hook which we're about to cover
actually replaced it so there's no need
for it anymore and basically if we go
here with DOT notice
I have these options and the provider is
what we're looking for
so we want to grab that provider and go
to a main parent basically the component
which is going to provide those values
and we want to wrap the return
in that provider so we go to our nav bar
and let's say not I think I can just
move this and then we want to wrap our
nav in the navbar context that's the
name Dot and then the provider now
what's really cool that provider has a
value prop
and essentially whatever you'll pass
over here you'll have access anywhere in
that tree again we have three components
but please keep in mind you can have a
setup with 15 components so anywhere in
that component tree you'll have access
to this value now
you can simply go here with hello and
you'll be able to pass it
however as you're looking at it you're
probably thinking what's the use case of
hello I mean it's nice that I can access
it in the user container but that's not
what I'm looking for and you're
absolutely correct
so here's what we can do we can turn
this value into an object so please keep
in mind this is not a special syntax
again I'm just simply going back to a
JavaScript land and I'll set it up as an
object
that's it this is not a special Syntax
for double curlies I keep getting these
questions in the course q a
so I really want to stress that I simply
want to set up an object and if you
want to make it more readable
you can set it up over here you can
create an object and then pass it
directly here in a value if that's
easier for you to read
I'm not gonna do that but
just an option so I have an object and
now notice effectively I can pass both
of them down here in the subject as
properties I can say user is equal to
user and logout is equal to a log out
let's save that and now we need to go to
a user container and notice how we're
nicely bypassing the nav links and we
want to grab those values and for that
we'll need two things we'll need a
navbar context that's why we're
exporting and also
we'll need a huge context Hook from
the react so let's navigate to a user
container
and in here let's import both of those
things the use contacts as well as nav
bar context
so I'm gonna go for now above the return
again I don't want to get the error and
essentially we want to go with use
context talk which is a special hook
which is looking for that context again
this is coming from react
just like you state use effect and all
that
and we want to pass in that nav bar
context or whatever context you have
so the one that's in the parent whatever
you create over here you export and then
the use context is going to be looking
for that so here I can go with navbar
and context and since my Auto Imports
are working we're good to go now what is
this returning well
let's go back to your navbar what are we
setting up over here an object correct
so let's try this one out I'm gonna come
up with a variable and I'll set it equal
to a value and you'll notice nicely in
the console that we have access to that
object so every user with the name
property as well as the logo
so in my jsx I can either go with Dot
and then grab the logout or user or we
can do the structuring right so instead
of grabbing the value I'll say yep I
know for sure that I'm getting back the
object so let's go here with user and
then the logout and of course I simply
want to return hello world and
everything is going to work like peaches
and again the main goal here is to
bypass the navx notice
networks is not getting any props it's
not passing any props
I'm getting everything directly here in
the user container and my functionality
still works and since we just covered
custom hooks why don't we put our
knowledge to a good use
so notice in the user container
we are getting used context and we're
getting that nav bar context and
essentially in any component all
throughout your application I mean in
this case of course it needs to be
nested inside of the nav bar but in the
following videos I'll show you
how we can set up a global context
hopefully that is clear pretty much
anywhere where I want to use that yes
I'll have to grab these two things I'll
have to grab the use context as well as
the navbar context
now this is a good use case for a custom
hook
so instead of these two Imports I can
set up one custom hook and then just
import that
so back in the nav bar
I first want to come up with the name in
my case I'm going to call this use app
context but sky is the limit so let me
add here custom hook and then
effectively we want to export it because
same deal we will use it so const and
then call it use
so notice we still using the used so
that doesn't change
otherwise the stuff is not going to work
use app context that's my function and
what do I want to do from this function
I simply want to return use context
which I'm importing over here
and the nav bar context
so effectively this line over here so
first let me navigate back I'll remove
both of them from this user container
just so you can see that I'm not messing
with you let me go to a nav bar
copy and paste we don't of course need a
nav bar context but we will need this
use context in the enable one and as far
as the logic we just want to invoke this
used context once and we want to provide
the nav bar context so I'm going to go
with use context and then I'll provide
nav bar context so now I want to save
and again keep in mind we're exporting
this so now in the user container I can
replace this used context with use and
then app context now please keep in mind
that there's also one in the final
so don't grab that one just set up this
one over here let's save it and then
notice how
our functionality still works and if
you're looking at it and you're like
well this just saved us one line of code
keep in mind when you use context
globally against something that we're
going to cover in the next video
you'll be accessing
that context quite a few times and then
it's much easier to just use one hook
instead of importing the use context as
well as that particular context each and
every time you want to access it in the
component okay now let's see how we can
set up a global context basically how we
can provide some data to all components
in our application now for this one I
will create a new application just
because I want to set up everything from
scratch and if you want to access my
final application basically the
application I'm about to create
I will add it to the main repo
in the Z assets folder so as I'm
recording this video of course that
folder does not exist but by the time
you're watching the video just go to the
main repo effective way where you got
the advanced react and then the last
folder should be there and the name is
going to be Z assets and in there you'll
find this application now if you're
interested you can also try to set it up
yourself the global context and here are
the steps I'm going to create a new
application with feet and we're going to
go with npm create and blah blah blah
blah blah then we'll install
dependencies and run npm run Dev
to spin up the dev server in the source
create a context jsx file and set up two
things a global context with create
context
and a component which I'm going to name
app context with one state value now
from the app context return a
globalcontext DOT provider the component
and then wrap the entire application
which we're gonna do in the main jsx and
there's going to be a gotcha effectively
we'll have to jog our memory on the
children prop so if you're struggling to
set this up this is totally fine now
once we have wrapped our entire
application
then we want to set up a custom hook so
we don't have to import two of those
things
when we want to access the context and
then just try it in app GSX there's
going to be app.jsx and in there just
try to lock whatever you have in the
value prop in the global context
provider and if you can see some value
that means that it's going to work
everywhere in our application
so let's get cracking and
I think I'm just going to copy and paste
there's no need for you to watch me how
I tap this so I'm just going to go with
City
bus stop
and let me
massively zoom in copy and paste again
npm create beat latest and Global
context that's the name of the
application
Dash Dash or hyphen hyphen space dash
dash template and then we want to go
with react one so once that is done I'm
going to open up a new window
because I might want to showcase
something and read me
and this is again totally optional but
I'll send them side by side
so there's my browser
that's my text error let me open up the
integrated terminal we want to go with
npm install and we also want to go with
npm
start or I'm sorry it's not create react
app we're going to go with npm run Dev
and I know I already have set this quite
a few times but if both of those
commands don't work one after another
just run them separately result is going
to be exactly the same and once I open
up 5173
this is what we should see on the screen
and since we're now familiar with the
use state
this shouldn't look very foreign we have
count set count your state and what do
you know every time I click on a button
I'm increasing the account
so now let's set up that Global context
please do that in the source so don't do
it in a public or the node modules let's
create a new file here and I'm going to
call this context
a new file
let's go with context and jsx
and first I guess let's set up that
Global one
so first let's go with const I'm not
going to export that because there's
going to be a global hook basically a
custom hook that's gonna set up
everything
so I'm gonna go with global context and
that is equal to create context and we
just want to invoke that that's the
first step after that we want to set up
the component which we're going to
return from this file and I'm going to
call this app context that's going to be
my function here
as far as what we're returning well
we're going to return a global context
dot provider correct so let's go with
return keyword
and then let's set up that Global
context dot provider
and for now we don't have anything in
there so we're not going to set the
value and as far as
what are we gonna set up in between the
component tags well that's the gotcha
that we're going to discuss in a second
so for now don't return anything and of
course we do want to export that so
export default
and we're looking for app app context
okay good
before we set up the value why don't we
also
create the actual State value in my case
simply going to be name
and set name and as far as default value
I'm going to go with Peter okay good and
then remember
there is a special prop on this provider
and the name was value I do want to pass
in the object in here and inside of the
object there's going to be a name
property and also a set name property
save that now both of them are
effectively passed down but of course we
haven't wrapped our entire application
correct and as I said I don't know
whether I covered this before but
in es6 essentially we can do the
shortcut so if you're looking at your
like I don't understand how are we
passing here name equals the name
well if we have this kind of setup
where the property name is basically
equal to a variable and the same over
here so set name is equal to set name we
can shorten this up again if you have
this kind of setup
then essentially you can shorten this up
and just type one
in this case name and set name okay good
we have covered that so now let's
navigate to the main GSX because we want
to wrap our entire application
effectively our app component
and it's located over here so unlike the
nav bar
where effectively we imported a nav
links and then the user container inside
of the knowledge now we want to wrap our
entire application
so we're not going to import for example
app over here no we want to go to
main.jsx we want to import our app
context
so the import is in place and now this
is really up to you if you don't want
the strict mode if you don't want those
extra logs and all that you can simply
remove it or just place the app context
within the strict mode just please don't
wrap the
react trig mode in the app context
that's not going to make sense so we
want to go here we want to set up a App
context and yes I'm basically creating a
new component and I'll just remove this
one over here so now we're good to go
but there's one gotcha the moment we
save we're going to see nothing on the
screen
uh if you're wondering why is that
happening well remember long long long
long long long long time ago we talked
about the children prop I believe it was
all the way back in the fundamentals
and at the moment if we take a look at
the context notice we have nothing in
here so of course I can type here
context and everything is going to be
fine it's going to be displayed on the
screen but essentially that's not the
goal so I want to grab that app
component and then since all my
components are going to meet over here
in the app
I wanna wrap it in the provider and as a
result all my components
are gonna have access to in this case
name and set name
how we can do that well I kind of
already gave you a hint
since app right now is within the
component tags
now we want to go back to context and
essentially we want to access the
children we have few ways we can go here
with props
and then instead of the silly context
I can set up correlate and we can go
with props Dot children or
of course we can just shorten this up
and set up the structuring and as you
can see the moment I save everything is
correct so now everything is going to
work
again this is totally up to you if you
want to go with props
in my case I'm going to go children here
and then I can remove the props as well
before we go to app.jsx Let's also set
up that custom hook
in this case I'm going to export it
right away and I'll call it use global
context that's my custom hook as far as
the functionality
I want to invoke use context so please
be careful most likely vs code will try
to invoke the same one the use Global
context we don't want to do that
essentially we want to go with use
context which is coming
from react again this is a special hook
that is looking for one thing and one
thing only it's looking for the context
you want access to in this case it's
going to be a global context since we're
exporting this I can nicely hop over to
app jsx I know that I'm getting back the
object correct so I'm just going to go
here const and the structure it right
away I'm not going to look for set name
hopefully it's clear that I'll have
access to both of them and that is going
to be equal to my use Global context and
I just invoke it and just to Showcase
that everything works
I'm going to log name so if I go right
now
to my devtools I'll see Peter which
means that any component that is going
to be in the app where basically all our
components meet
it will have access and not only those
components but if I have any components
inside of those components
so hopefully that is clear this is how
we can set up a global context using
context API and also hopefully you see
how useful is our custom hook where now
we don't need to do those two Imports in
every file essentially we just grab the
use Global context and we're good to go
okay and next let's cover use reducer
hook and essentially you could think of
user doucher as a light version of Redux
one of the most famous State Management
libraries out there so here's the deal
as your application grows in size it's
going to be very hard to manage
everything with just use State
especially if you have multiple
developers working on the project
that's where State Management libraries
like Redux come into play since they
provide much needed structure and set of
rules which in a perfect world leads to
less bugs and easier code management
the problem with such libraries is that
they require quite a bit of boilerplate
code
and some time to get used to the
terminology so react released use
reducer hook and I like to think of use
reducer as a middle ground
between using full-blown State Library
and just using huge state
now a few more things before we begin
exploring user reducer first
don't get frustrated if some of this
stuff looks foreign and weird
It's Perfectly Normal
it simply takes time and few projects to
get used to use reducer or any State
Management library for that matter
second because I have to introduce quite
a few new weird sounding terms like
dispatch and reducer and the action I
purposely picked the example we already
worked on
and we'll just refactor it to use
reducer
hopefully that way it's going to be
easier to grasp all of the funky use
reducer terminology and lastly please
don't think that from now on you only
have to use use reducer or even more
drastic refactor all your existing apps
to use reducer it's a tool that has a
very specific purpose and as you work on
the bigger project you'll definitely
notice when there's need for it
basically when it's a good time to
implement use reducer or completely
switch your app to State Management
Library like Redux toolkit okay and as
far as the setup we're looking for
folder 10 use reducer we want to grab
the star and we're looking for use
reducer and essentially if you take a
look at the file and folder structure
you'll see that we have only one file so
I want you to grab that starter in the
app GSX for now I have
commented it out because I want to
showcase something so essentially grab
the starter and if you navigate to the
file you'll
notice that it's one of the projects we
worked on before
and effectively we cover that in New
State when we talked about the arrays so
this is the same exact example where
we're importing the datum
we set this using use state so that's
our default one and then we display all
the people and then we have an option to
remove specific person or clear playlist
like I said I purposely picked this
example because I think it's going to be
easier to grasp all of the use reducer
Concepts since you don't need to worry
about this functionality we already
covered it before and let's start with a
tiny challenge
I want you to add to this one a reset
functionality now don't worry we're not
going to do that right away with
userducer we'll simply do it by just
adding a function
and in that function essentially I want
to set back the state to an array and
once you have the function I want you to
set up a button
and once the user clicks the button then
we set basically the empty array to all
of the items and I want you to render
that button conditionally a hint you'll
most likely use the ternary operator so
notice two options either I remove them
one by one
and once I have the clear list I have
now reset button which essentially sets
it back to all of the items or
we can simply clear it and same deal the
moment I have empty list I want to have
a reset button which essentially sets it
back to our default people all right so
first let's work on that and then we'll
Implement user reducer essentially I
just want to add a little bit more
functionality
just so
it's more interesting when we cover use
reducer okay I'm done with my big speech
let me navigate here use reducer
hopefully I'm in the correct one yep
it's in the star and essentially let me
just set up the function I think it's
going to be faster if I just copy and
paste I'm looking for the function name
which usually is the most
hardest thing in programming
so let's go here with a reset list and
instead of empty array what do I need to
do well
I already have the data correct so I
just pass here this is an empty one this
just resets to
our original array and then we want to
keep on moving Keep On Moving I have
this button now I need to set up a
functionality where once the list is
empty
I'll display one button and if I have
some values then I'll have the clear one
how do we do that well we go here with
the curlies and what is going to be our
condition people and length correct let
me double check it that's my state value
so don't set this as data that's a
little bit different that's our original
array and here we're looking for people
and I'll say if it's less than one I
have two options what is my first one
well that's a reset one correct because
this is the one that
is displayed if it's less than one then
I want to reset and I'll work on that
one in a second and now let me check if
this is false basically if I have some
items I want to display this button so
let me cut this one out okay good that's
my first one and basically I'll use the
same structure so just copy and paste
over here I just need to change some
values around where the text inside of
the button is not going to be clear it's
going to be reset and instead of
clearing the list what do we need to do
yep correct we need to go with reset so
now check it out again two options I
think I'll pick this one just because
it's faster and notice now I can reset
now of course I'm showing this because I
already have the complete application in
my app.js
my apologies notice here I have the star
I will I guess remove the final there's
no need hopefully I didn't make some
egregious errors
you save notice that the result is
exactly the same so that's already a
good start
I can remove yep I can reset and I can
also clear so that was the first
Challenge and up next we'll get to know
use reducer all right so now let's
refactor our application to use reducer
since there are going to be multiple
steps of course we're not going to do
that in one video
but let's just do a basic setup and
arrive out of the get-go I can say that
most likely this video is going to be
the most difficult one
because unfortunately I'll have to throw
multiple terms at you right out of the
gate unfortunately there's no other way
in order just to create that setup
I need to provide you values and yes
they have funky names so my apologies if
something sounds weird my best
suggestion is just to re-watch the video
a few times and hopefully by doing so
you'll understand the stuff better now
eventually we'll remove this one but
since I don't want to have some massive
errors on the screen since I think it
might get distracting for now I'll just
leave this one over here again
eventually this is going to be gone what
I do want to do for now is just comment
out this functionality because we'll
move this one to a reducer a function
we're about to create so it's not going
to be sitting here anyway and I don't
want that functionality to run so let's
just comment this one out so as the user
clicks any of the buttons nothing should
happen that's exactly what I want so in
order to get started with use reducer
first we need to grab be hook correct so
we go over here now of course we can do
the Auto Import and all that but why
don't we change this around and just say
use reducer again all of this is coming
from react now
when it comes to you state what do we
pass in
we pass in the default State correct now
with use reducer
it's a little bit more complex we need
to pass in two things we need to pass in
a default State and we need to provide a
reducer
effectively a function
that is going to manipulate the state
like I said
right away many funky terms now keep in
mind that it's just a convention to call
this reducer you can call this banana
pudding it's totally fine but yes most
likely you'll always see the reducer so
let's start working on that I'm going to
go to use reducer I invoke the hook and
yes eventually we'll set up the values
that we're getting back for now let's
just worry what we need to pass in like
I said two things a reducer function and
a default state
so first let's come up with that
function
I'm going to go to constant you simply
want to create a empty Arrow function
that's all you need to do the hardest
part probably is going to be coming up
with the name that's why I'll stick with
convention and I'll just say producer
not a vegan food truck so reducer here
and for now let's just try it with empty
one I'm not sure maybe we'll right away
have to pass in the state but let me
just try with an empty one so this is an
empty function that's our reducer this
is where we'll control essentially our
entire state so we need to pass this one
first so then
we need to pass in the default State Now
default State can be anything however in
my case it's just going to be an object
with a people property which is going to
be equal to the data so pretty much
whatever we have over here
but yes normally you have multiple
things in there you can have is the
modal open have you fetched the data is
it loading and all that kind of stuff
um
while we were working on a project
you'll definitely see that for now let's
just start very simply and create that
default state so I'm going to go here
with const and you know what I think I'm
just going to move this one up because
pretty much once we set up that default
state
there's not going to be much work in
there but reducer yes we'll do quite a
few things in there so let me just move
this one up default state so that's the
second thing you'll always always need
to provide
and of course keep in mind one thing
just because initially you add people
doesn't mean that
you cannot add later for example is
loading so as your application grows
essentially you just keep adding these
items in a default state
that's how it works so don't worry that
pretty much prior to setting up your
whole application you need to right away
come up with the state no keep in mind
you can keep adding things that's
perfectly fine and all of them
eventually
will be over here as our default state
so let's pass it
I'm gonna go with default State and
we're pretty much done with this part
so now let's move on the other side of
the equation over here
remember would you state what did we get
back eight people and set people right
so a state value and a function it's
very similar
with use reducer however
we're getting back a state and we're
getting back a dispatch so the main idea
is the same but the implementation is a
little bit different so let's try this
one out I'm gonna go with const yes it's
still an array but this time it's not
just
one state value this is our entire state
so if I'll have 50 values in here yep
it's going to be represented here in the
state now again in my case I only have
people
but I want to stress one more time
you can have a bunch of values and all
of them will be represented here with
the state
now since this is an object how we can
access things in our application well
state DOT State DOT state DOT hopefully
that's clear now the second thing is the
dispatch so we're going to go here with
dispatch again this is a naming
convention
a bobo is also a nice alternative
and yes this function is updating the
state but here's the biggest gotcha
there's the biggest difference between
you state and the use reducer when we
talk about dispatch we'll have to do
this
somewhat funny uh syntax where let me
keep moving and show you that so when it
comes to dispatch we need to do this
we'll basically go dispatch will invoke
it like so and then we'll pass the
typing now all of that is coming up I'm
just showing you that essentially the
area is the same yes we are updating the
state however this is not happening
directly
so remember with set people or any of
the set functions in each state
we just invoke them and this immediately
changed the value of people that's not
how it works with user reducer so that's
where that structure comes into play you
cannot just willy-nilly come in here and
start updating the state no what you'll
do you'll dispatch you'll pass in the
action basically what you want to do and
then it's gonna go through the reducer
and then whatever we get back here from
the reducer it's going to be our new
state so yes multiple
steps and multiple new terms like I said
this is probably going to be the hardest
video because I just have to cover these
things unfortunately there's no way I
can show you a use reducer setup without
talking about them that's not going to
make sense so let me try this I might
need to pass in state I kind of want to
leave it for later videos but if I'll
get some bugs of course we'll have to at
least talk about it a little bit so this
is going to be our initial setup now we
can bravely
take this one out so we won't need it
anymore that's it we can remove it and
then remember
we have people now do we have a state
value now well
not really right so what do we have we
have state and in there I have the
people so let's keep on moving and you
know what I'll just log so you can see
the state
but since again I don't want to have
some unnecessary errors I can tell you
right away that in a state we have the
people and now instead of accessing the
people directly we're grabbing the state
so here's the deal
as far as access yes we still do the
Good Old State value and then since this
is an object we're grabbing some
particular property but the update is
not going to be like this you're not
going to go hey
um let's update the people already in
the state let's create new people and
set state DOT people equal to that no
that's not how it's going to work we'll
have to use the dispatch it's going to
go through the reducer and all that
shebang so let's keep on moving at him
here I also have people and I just want
to add State again let me see whether
we're getting back the error if we don't
return the state we might so let me save
and if everything is correct then I will
talk about these suckers in next video
the state and action that we need to
pass in and up everything
seems to be working and check it out
so this is my state object
and this is my array correct State
object I have people and now everywhere
in my application I basically grab these
values whatever they are again in our
case it's just a people but there can be
more things in there so that's the
general setup for use reducer and in the
following videos of course we'll start
talking about how we can update this
state because it's nice to have a
default state but obviously we want to
implement some functionality okay we
have the initial setup in place up next
let's talk about how we can Implement
some functionality and like I already
probably mentioned 10 000 times in a
previous video essentially when it comes
to use reducer or again since it's a
Redux light effectively the same
functionality Works in Redux you want to
dispatch something called action and
that action is going to be handled here
in the reducer and then whatever gets
returned from
the reducer is going to be the new state
so here's the deal by default this
function whatever we said over here
whether that is a vegan food truck or
banana pudding or Bobo whatever it gets
two things it gets state so that is the
state right before the update and the
action basically what are we trying to
do and since those are parameters we
simply go State again just a convention
and an action
okay hopefully we're clear on that and
now let's see how we can change
something in that state basically how we
can Implement some functionality
because what we need to understand it
was the same deal over here when we for
example remove the item we just change
the state value and essentially we want
to do it over here as well we just don't
want to do it directly you want to do it
through the reducer and you can pick any
of the functions I think I'll start with
clear list because in my opinion it's
going to be the easiest one to grasp and
essentially if we want to update
something if we want to change that
state value we go here with dispatch
and like I said we have this somewhat
funky syntax where we invoked this patch
but dispatch is looking for an object
and we must must must must must must
must must must must must provide type
over here type property yes you just
have to do that I didn't make that one
up
and as far as the type it's equal to a
string so I can say here do something
or I can type whatever string value I
want and I'll handle that in the reducer
now a convention
is to use
all uppercase and actually assign a
variable to this one I'll show you in a
separate video why we want to assign a
variable for now let's just stick with
convention and what are we doing over
here
we are clearing the list right so yes
essentially I would go with clear
and then list
this is just a convention you can write
it in camel case you can write it all in
lower case that's totally up to you just
remember that you'll have to handle that
here in the reducer so whichever option
you pick just stick with it otherwise
it's going to be very confusing and
don't be surprised if you are working on
a bigger project with other developers
and you'll see this syntax yes this is
pretty common so essentially what I'm
saying I want to clear a list so now
dispatch is like okay reducer now you
handle that I did my work
I dispatched an action so back in the
reducer
like I said we have two things
we have the state and we have the action
so state is going to be the state before
the update so once we're done with this
function there's going to be a new state
value please keep that in mind and the
way we handle that let's just First Lock
two things state or you know what let's
start with an action just to Showcase
what we have so notice here right so I
have my array now once I click there's a
big fat error and we'll talk about it
why we have nothing on the screen but
for now let's just focus on this one so
notice here I have the clear list in
line 9. so this is what I'm getting
that's my action now why we have this
whole thing not just type well because
we can provide more data in here and
you'll see that in a second once
essentially we need to remove a person
so we'll add more things over here but
if we just log this action this is going
to be the object that we're passing in
now what are we interested in well we
want to get the type correct because
we'll do something with that type that's
the one that screams hey I want to do
something
now
why do we have this massive error well
whatever we're going to return from the
reducer
is going to be that new state value so
notice this line 27 here
our state why is it undefined
well because reducer is basically a
function by default returns undefined so
this underscores the point whatever
you'll return here from this reducer
will be that state value so check it out
I can go here with return
and I can say shake
and bake
now I'll still most likely have the
error once I click the clear again once
I save technically everything is fine
but check it out I'll have the same
error and again we can scroll down and
we can see that nothing works why
because again line 28
shake and bake
is my people property somewhere in the
and of course the answer is no so
here's what we want to do first of all
we'll talk about the default returns in
a second that for now let me just get
rid of it and I'll also remove the
console log here in the reducer
essentially one by one will check for
these actions yes
if you're wondering do we have to do
this manually that's correct that's the
setup we go here with if now quite often
you'll see this switch operator used I
actually don't like that approach again
switch is an alternative to a bunch of
if statements I actually find if
statements more readable so we go here
with if and then I want to check for
action and remember the type is the
property correct so we go with type and
I want to check whether it is equal to
now what am I passing here clear list so
what do I need to set here same deal yep
that's correct so we'll take it here
copy and paste and that's why I'm saying
you can come up with whatever string
value you want over here just make sure
that you use the same one in the reducer
otherwise it's not going to work and
then we need to set up the functionality
so whatever we'll return from this is
gonna be my new state value
so how our functionality is going to
look like well we'll go with the return
because we want to return something and
essentially I want to spread out the
current state values why well because
even though I'm clearing the list keep
in mind that if I have is loading over
here and let's set it equal to false
what do you think is going to happen if
I'll just return empty array yes as far
as the people array my functionality is
going to work but keep in mind
if I'm not going to include this is
loading then essentially your reducer is
going to return a new state and that is
loading is going to be gone
so just like previously
effectively we want to spread out or
copy
the current state values so this is the
current state before this update and we
want to spread them out we want to copy
them
so now we're also passing this is
loading otherwise it's going to be gone
and then we want to overwrite then I
want to go with okay what is going to be
the new value of the people well we
wanna set it equal to an empty array
correct so we go here with people
and check it out it's not different
to what we have already in a clear list
we're just doing that in reducer and I
really want to stress that point that's
why I picked this particular example so
now let me save it let me clear out the
console app a bunch of errors in there
and now everything should work where
again
in clear list we dispatch a specific
action called clear list and then in the
reducer
we handle that I check for Action type
I grab the current state whatever it is
of course now we have the default one
but keep in mind that as we add more
functionality of course it's going to
update itself
so the state
is going to be the current state before
that particular action and then we
return a new value
this is our new state this is what we'll
see so now let me clear and check it out
notice everything works here
so there was no error and notice this is
my new state now
so initially I had four items and now I
have zero however notice how nicely we
still keep the is loading so we did not
lose this one over here so essentially
that's the general setup when we want to
update something in the state with
dispatch
we need to provide a type which is going
to be our action we need to tell what
we're going to do
and then in the reducer we handle that
type and whatever we return from the
reducer is going to be our new state
value okay and before we set up rest of
the functionality let's just talk about
the conventions and first let's start
with actions like I already previously
mentioned it can be any string you want
but in order to avoid some weird typos a
convention is to set this one up as a
variable
and then you're just avoiding some silly
bugs just to Showcase that if we go back
to our application notice in here we
have clear list but what if in the
reducer I mistyped and I said clear list
now do these ones match
and
the answer of course is no so now what
happens when I clear the list well I'll
have big fat error because
we are right now returning undefined
that's the default one since
we're not hitting this condition correct
and a way around that is effectively to
set up variables
that have the same name so if you have
clear list yes the variable name is also
going to be clear list so
why don't we right away set up those
variables we have only three pieces of
functionality so it's going to be pretty
quick I'm gonna go with clear list and
the other one is equal to my clear and
underscore list then I want to do the
same for reset something we're going to
work on in the next video so reset list
now that one is equal to reset and
underscore list and then lastly I have
remove item so again const and remove
item and at the very end of this section
will actually set it up in a separate
file and we'll import it because that is
a pretty typical setup since you're not
going to handle everything in just one
file so remove underscore and then item
and now where I'm checking in the
reducer as well as in the clear list
where I'm dispatching instead of passing
this string directly I go with clear
list that's my variable which holds the
string so this just
omits some weird bugs let's save this
let's first double check
we don't want any bugs here yep we can
nicely do so and now let's talk about
the state that we're returning from
reducer
you say what if I go to a reset list
something we're going to work on in a
second
and just pass some random stuff now this
could be because I just haven't created
yet the functionality in the reducer to
handle that dispatch or I just for some
weird reason access to your wrong
variable what if I do something along
the lines of type and then something
again we'll have big fat error correct
because we're not handling it here and
essentially we have two approaches just
to Showcase bam this is what we'll get
we only have clear list over here and
you can always return each state like so
so I have bunch of conditions I'll check
for reset list I'll check for remove
item and all that now if
the action type does not match any of my
conditions I'll simply return H state
so notice a clear that should definitely
work and once I reset technically
nothing happens I'm just returning a
state
which was right before the update and
since we did not perform any update I
just returned State and call it a day
now this is a valid approach however
how are we going to know if we have a
bug
so alternatively you can actually throw
error and this is very useful because it
right away tells you like something's
wrong with your application you need to
check it and the way we do that and
I think I'm just going to leave this one
for your reference just in case so
return State and the way we throw the
error we go through new error again this
is a JavaScript thing we're not making
this up just because we are in react
then I'll set up a template string and
you'll see in a second why so I'll say
no matching and essentially I'll look
for the action type action and then type
so access it and I'll just add here a
text action and type let's save this and
like I already said probably
twenty thousand times effectively this
just helps me if I see this I know that
listen somewhere I'm dispatching an
action that I'm not handling it that's
very useful notice reset bam and at
least I can go to console and I can be
like no matching something action type
so let me double check
the action that I'm dispatching so
essentially those are the conventions
when it comes to actions as well as how
we handle an action that we're not
catching in the reducer all right and
once we're familiar with the
fundamentals now let's work on a small
challenge where
you can try to reset the list yourself
so set up a dispatch and handle the
action in the reducer and once you're
ready to compare the results resume with
the video so
I'm going to navigate to use reducer
basically I'm looking for reset the list
instead of something
I'll use my variable and what is that
well that is reset list awesome
I'm pretty sure I can remove this one as
well as the previous one here
and then let's just scroll up and inside
of the reducer right after my clear list
I'll set up the reset one now please
keep in mind in this case order does not
matter if I place it before or after
clear list I simply want to check again
for Action I think in order to speed
this up I'll just copy and paste we're
not checking for Clear list we want to
go with reset so now notice how nice it
is that we have that variable which
right away grabs me in that string
and instead of
returning empty I'll just set it equal
to data that's all we have to do again
let's refresh so we don't have
the errors in the console and let's just
try it out
yep
it's empty and once we click on reset we
set it back to data array okay and we
also want to do that with a remove
person our last piece of functionality
and again if you want to set it up
yourself
set up a dispatch and then handle that
action in the reducer a tiny hint as far
as ID
you want to pass it as an extra property
in the object the one that you're
passing into a dispatch so let's get
cracking I'm going to navigate to use
reducer I'm looking for a remove item
and here we want to go with this patch
we want to invoke it we want to pass in
the type and in this case I'm looking
for remove item comma and you can
definitely pass here the ID like so you
can go with ID equals to any because
keep in mind that if you don't pass the
ID how are you gonna know which item you
want to remove I mean remove item okay
but which one
so you can set up the condition you can
even return a state but it's not going
to make sense if you don't have access
to that specific ID
and you can pass it like so ID equals to
NAD however the convention is to call
this property a payload
set it equal to an object even though
you're passing in one property yep set
it up as an object and then pass the ID
the name whatever so let me just
showcase the
could mention we go with payload that's
our second property it is an object yep
and then in here we go with ID and then
equals to an ID
so now let's navigate up
and in the reducer right after reset
list
I want to come up with another condition
I'll say if action type and in this case
I'm looking for remove item if that is
the case what do I want to do well first
let's just start by returning a state
and I want to showcase where we have
that ID right now so I'm going to go log
and then I'm just going to look for
Action let me save and then you can
click on any of them and check it out
you'll see here remove item and then
you'll see the payload so in order to
grab that ID what do we need to do well
first of all my spelling and notice this
is even with the extension so just
imagine how well air quotes I'm doing
without it so this is a payload my bad
and let me save it again basically we
want to go with payload and then Dot
and then the ID that's what we have to
do so type is remove item and then they
payload over here
so now let's navigate to that condition
and the setup is going to be pretty much
the same I'm gonna go with people filter
right so of course I'll have to access
it using state I'm going to get back to
new people and in here instead of ID
I'll say action payload and ID and of
course I can destructure it so let me
take this one up there's no need to set
it from the scratch again the difference
right now is that
people is in a state
so we go here with state DOT people and
the second thing this ID is located in
the action dot payload Dot and then the
Eddy and like I just said before of
course you can destructure it above you
can look for ID which is located in the
action payload and as far as what we're
returning well instead of State we're
going to go with dot dot state so we
return all of the properties and then
let's set people
equal to our new array which is going to
be new people
and that's it that's all we have to do
now again let's be clear we have a bunch
of things in here
doesn't look like I have any more logs
pretty sure I can remove this one and
our functionality should work check it
out I have the list I can clear it I can
reset and I can move them one by one we
get to an empty array and we set it back
to I believe four items okay and lastly
in the use reducer section I want to
show you
the approach we use as our application
grows basically
as we're getting more and more actions
and we handle them in the reducer
it's not going to be
easy to keep it in one file as you can
see it's getting hard to read and
therefore we just essentially split it
up of course in our case we have only
three actions
so this is only going to make sense if
you're getting more actions but still
the structure is going to be exactly the
same and if you want you can work on it
yourself essentially create a new file
I'm going to call this actions JS and in
this case since we're not going to be
creating a component we can get away
with just JS I think this is too much
and then you want to set up all the
actions from the use reducer in there
and you want to export them
and of course you want to import them in
the user Edition since you'll still need
to use them you just want to keep them
in a separate place and as soon as this
is not reducer this is actions like so
then you also want to do the same thing
with the reducer
copy and paste the logic in that file
and then keep in mind that you'll still
need an actions
so yes you'll have import for actions in
two places in use reducer as well as the
reducer JS and then lastly from the
reducer JS export reducer and then
import it in the use reducer
so let's get cracking I'm gonna go with
new file I'll call this actions Js
beautiful
and then the second one is going to be
reducer JS as far as the actions I think
it's going to be more straightforward
where in the reducer I just want to grab
them here
copy and paste and we simply want to add
those exports
since we'll use them in the use reducer
as well as the reducer so now if we go
back
to a use reducer
we want to go above the default state
remember we have a bunch of things right
now coming from the file and one by one
we can just access them so clear list
first one then reset
list and then lastly we have remove item
so all of them are coming from the
actions and if everything is correct
then the functionality is still going to
work so that's the first step we
separate the actions now let's do the
same thing with reducer and just so we
can speed this up I can tell you right
away that we'll need those actions in
the reducer so copy and paste yep that's
going to be the setup pretty much for
every action that you have you'll need
to import it most likely in two places
where you dispatch it and also in the
reducer that's quite typical setup
so let's go with our reducer right now
take this one out
copy and paste and then we want to
export so export default
and then reducer beautiful let's save
that and then back in the user educer we
also want to import the reducer and I'm
gonna try to do the Auto Import let's
see whether that works yep so I can
nicely grab my reducer and like I just
said if everything still works
which by the way it doesn't data is not
defined ah you see something really
interesting that I forgot to mention of
course we also want to grab the data in
the reducer right now since we're using
it over here so let me add that one to a
readme
where I have the reducer import actions
import data
so let's go back to I guess user user
first let's copy this one since it's in
the same folder we don't need to change
the path
simply you want to copy and paste and
now everything should work so let's try
this one out
I can clear I can reset and I can remove
them one by one
so those are the fundamentals of user
reducer and now you're ready to move on
to the next topic okay and up next let's
see how we can test and improve the
performance of our react applications
now before we begin few disclaimers
react as fast by default so all the
techniques we're going to discuss in the
following videos
make way more sense when you are working
on a bigger application not a small
to-do list type of application
also please keep in mind that I
purposely picked simple
and straightforward examples just so we
can spend all of our time and energy on
the performance topics okay and at the
very beginning of our react performance
Journey let's see what exact issue we're
trying to solve so first in the app jsx
navigate to this folder so tutorial 11
performance starter 0 1 and Lower State
and once you get there you'll see that
it's pretty typical application I have
here index GSX this is where
my components meet in this case it's
just a list and also there's a person
component now in the
index.jsx I have two State values one is
people
which is using data which is coming from
our data file as the default one
and I also have the count
and the initial value is zero so at top
I have the button and below it I have a
list component where I'm passing the
people prop
you can probably already guess that in a
list I'm just going to iterate over it
and return a person component and in a
person component I simply render a name
and in here I have a console log that's
it I mean it's not a magical application
so here's what I want to show you though
what's really interesting that every
time I will click on a button and I'll
increase the count
my person component will re-render so at
the moment you're looking at the console
you can see okay I have four renders
well that makes sense I have four people
in the array I can clearly see that on
the screen
however what we probably don't expect is
this notice every time I click
I'm getting more renders now is it the
end of the world in this application
absolutely not again these are just
example applications where we're trying
to take a look at the issue and what
Solutions we have however
in a bigger application if you have a
component tree of
whatever 60 components yeah that is an
issue if you're basically re-rendering
for nothing you're just changing one
value here in the Lower State component
and then
your entire tree
constantly just re-renders now before we
take a look at the tools and solutions
and all that let's discuss why is that
happening so if we navigate back to a
readme file you'll see that
when we covered re-renders I mentioned
this
component re-renders when the state
or props change correct
but if you take a look at the setup
right now you
are probably wondering okay but nothing
changes over here so the people stay the
same as well as the person stays the
same right whatever I'm passing in the
list
it's not changing it's pretty much the
same thing I'm just passing in that
person object
so there's another reason why components
re-render and that is when the parent
element re-renders so what's happening
here in the index.jsx every time
we update the count what do we do we
trigger re-render correct we cover that
when we talked about use State the set
function
and what happens
the list which is a child also
re-renders
once the list re-renders what's
happening with person component it also
re-renders
and before we
take a look at the tools
let me also quickly cover something that
has been popping up
in a course q a and essential is this
setting up a use effect is not going to
solve our issue so let me navigate here
notice this use effect
let me
save and refresh yep I have now two
console logs four for render and four
for this log inside of the user effect
and technically as I'm clicking I only
see the render however
this doesn't stop the component from
re-rendering essentially the only thing
we're doing we're invoking whatever
functionality we have here in the user
effect when the initial render takes
place
but
the component itself still keeps
re-rendering
so yes it's a solution if you have some
kind of function that you don't wanna
trigger each and every time the
component re-renders however it's not
going to solve the issue of person
component re-rendering just because the
parent component re-rendered and if you
still don't believe me in the next video
we'll cover tools and then you'll
definitely see what I'm talking about
and before we take a look at our first
solution let's see how we can utilize
react Dev tools to measure the
performance of our application needless
to say that my assumption is that you
already have installed the react Dev
tools so if you haven't yet please
reference the react fundamentals part
where I covered the install
step by step and once we install the
tools we'll get these nice tabs
in the devtools the components and the
profiler and throughout the course we
have been looking at the components
however in this section we'll spend a
lot of time in the profile and before we
navigate to the profiler let's also
discuss something very important if I
navigate through my extensions
while I'm developing I can see that the
react developer tools have that red icon
and once I click on it notice it right
away tells me that the page is using
development build of react and something
important to keep in mind
by default while we're developing our
application is going to be slower
because react is doing
extra checks so don't be surprised if
your development application is slower
again that is happening for a reason and
that is happening by default so for
example if I navigate to one of the
projects we worked on during the course
and notice this is a hosted URL and if
I'll check I'll see that this one is
actually blue and this is also something
very important to keep in mind you don't
want to ship your development
application to production
so you don't want to host your
development application
well I will because it's not meant for
production
so whenever you want to push this up to
production make sure that is actual
production ready application hopefully I
make myself clear and once we navigate
back
now let's go to a profiler and before we
even look at anything let me just show
you my setup so we're all on the same
page so once I click over here notice as
far as the general
I'm using the Dark theme but of course
you can switch to light or Auto or
whatever
then as far as density I went with
comfortable I just like that they're
spanning all across and this one is very
Nifty this checkbox and you'll see in a
second why basically every time I'll do
something it's just gonna highlight the
components that are re-rendering then we
have debugging in here I have first two
check boxes and then when it comes to
components I'm just expanding the tree
by default and I don't think I changed
anything in here I have this setup and
then for the profiler I just have record
y each component rendered while
profiling and essentially if we want to
take a look what's happening in our
application we just go to this button
notice the start profiling it's going to
turn red and then start doing something
in the application and like I mentioned
before
I like that option where it highlights
pretty much
all the components that are re-rendering
and
I'm going to use this ranked I just
prefer this setup better but of course
you can also use this one
and effectively you can see that okay my
application loads right I expect all of
them to render then on every button
click notice all of my components
re-rendered and it even nicely tells me
why the parent component rendered
so what happens
all the items in my list are
re-rendering pretty much I clicked 13
times and same scenario now of course
the times are going to be different and
all that but that's not the main point
the main point is
that all my components are re-rendering
just because I'm changing one value in
the state and in the upcoming videos
we'll cover possible solutions to such
problem okay and what's our first
possible solution well we can lower the
state
in other words
I could just move the state variable as
well as the button to a separate
component let's think about it do we
really need this count over here in the
Lower State I mean I'm just showing it
in a button
so simply I could create a different
component let's call it counter move all
of the logic over there
and then
just import that in the Lower State and
as a result yes we will be updating that
state value but that is not going to
trigger re-renders in the Lower State so
let's try this one out when navigate to
the star we want to create a new file
and we'll call this counter jsx and once
I'm here I'm just going to create that
new component and then basically we want
to jump back to index.jsx and grab the
values I guess let's start with our
return and in this case I can just cut
everything out but that is not going to
be the case with the import so make sure
that you leave that use stately imported
because in the index we're still using
it correct so this one just copy
let me set it up above the counter
let's go over here copy and paste and
then in here I just want to grab this
count one
so this one again we're cutting it out
set it up over here in the counter and
then lastly we wanna
go back to the index and we want to set
up that counter component so counter
component let's save that and now let's
use the dev tools that we covered in the
previous video so now let me navigate
back Let me refresh
that's always a good starting point and
then let me again record notice I'm
starting profiling and I can right away
see that only my box
is being highlighted which essentially
is a good thing that means that only
this counter component is re-rendering
our not the rest of the list so now let
me stop over here and notice all this
time only the counter is rendering right
so that's my initial render and then all
of these times I'm clicking on a button
only the counter is basically
re-rendering why well because State
change notice
why this rendered well hook one changed
which effectively is our name now
million dollar question are you going to
be able to do that in all the instances
of course not
but this is definitely something I want
you to consider before you grab the
memos and use callbacks and all that
they're going to be instances where you
can simply just split up the logic
so instead of jamming everything in one
component and then having those
unnecessary re-renders essentially the
moment you move
the logic to a separate component that's
not going to be the case anymore so
notice now I only have 400 and I still
have of course the use effect code so
that's the first solution to our issue
we can simply lower the state right so
we can just set up separate component
and add all of the logic in there so
that way we're not going to be
triggering these unnecessary re-renders
okay and once we're familiar with the
concept now let's work on a small
challenge so first in the app jsx change
the folder so now you wanna get the
starter from the second one and once you
navigate there you'll see that there is
index.jsx there's also a list so the
same deal and the person
now the logic works just fine if I go
here and say Bob it's going to be nicely
added to the list or notice as I'm
typing stuff in the input all of my
components again are having that
flashing border around them why well
because we are re-rendering those
components so I want you to fix that
just like we covered in the previous
video so navigate to
index.jsx and the side
what do you need to move to a separate
component to avoid this issue and I can
give you a tiny hint once you set up the
entire functionality you'll also need to
fix the ad person so that's the only
place where you'll actually have to
change your functionality a little bit
so try working on that and then once
you're ready to compare the results
resume with the video
so first let me just navigate over there
that's my index let me just double check
that's the correct index one
and once we're here let's just establish
why is this happening well I have the
Forum correct I have the value and on
change and in there
I have a name State value
so every time I'm going to be updating
that state value
I will trigger what a re-render
so what happens with a list and a person
they also get re-rendered so first we
always need to look what is causing the
issue in this case it is the name one
now million dollar question can remove
name into a separate component basically
can I set up a form in a separate
component and of course the answer is
yes
I'll just have to move some
functionality as well
and lastly I will have to pass in the
add person down to a form so this one
we still want to keep it here because
we're working with the list
however we'll have to provide a
parameter because add person won't have
access to the name State value and
you'll see in a second what I mean so
first we find what is causing the issue
it's this name State value and now we
just want to set it up in a separate
component
so let's navigate here I'm going to go
with new file we want to go with form
jsx
then here let's create that component
that's my Forum I'm exporting all that
is awesome and then one by one let's
grab everything that we need so I'll
start here with my return so we won't
need it over here cut it out
copy and paste in the form okay awesome
then as far as the logic
like I just said add person will stay
here
I mean I'm working with the list makes
sense for this function to be in the
Lower State component however I do want
to grab this one and I'll submit
and I also want to set up that state
value correct so let's cut this one out
and we will also need that use state so
back
in my index I just want to copy this one
so I will navigate here copy and paste
and now everything is nice now the only
thing that's missing is that add person
however like I already
said I believe two times now add person
does not have access to this name
anymore so what do we do well we just
pass it as a parameter we just say name
here that's it and you nicely saw how it
was crossed out essentially add person
doesn't have access to the name unless
we provide that as a parameter so in
here we want to go first with the form
so form component
like so we grab the form and we want to
add that person correct so add person is
equal to add person we pass the prop we
can save it here now it's going to
complain and all that don't worry about
it
back in the form
you want to grab add person and now
everything is fine we just need to pass
in the name so we go here with the name
that's it that's all we have to do and
essentially
I want to clean out my console now
notice how nicely as I'm typing only my
form lights up why well because we're
not triggering those re-renders anymore
that's it we're only working with the
form and of course once we submit yeah
of course we're updating the entire list
so there's going to be a re-render
that's exactly what we want so once we
create that new list I do want to
re-render the list as well as the person
but I don't want to do that while I'm
typing stuff in the input okay so we
know how we can push the state down
awesome
but it's not going to be possible in
every instance so there's going to be
times when yes you basically need to
have that state value
but you still wanna
avoid those re-renders
and in order to do that we can use a
react memo function now please don't
confuse it with use memo which we're
going to cover in few videos
essentially this is a memo function that
is coming from react I want you to start
by navigating to this folder so zero
three hooks in the app
jsx and essentially once you navigate
here you'll see that we have our first
example where as I'm clicking on a
button I'm increasing the count which in
turn
re-renders the component which in turn
re-renders the list as well as the
person component and if I need to have
this state value here there's nothing I
can do I cannot just move it to a
separate component we can
pass the component the list component in
this case through the memo one basically
we go and look at the tree of our
components and essentially you decide
that hey if I stop this list from
re-rendering
what's going to happen well the person
also won't re-render
and the way we do that we simply
navigate to a specific component in this
case again it's a list so you would look
at the component tree and then we want
to get that memo function from react
as with the rest of the functions we
have few flavors we can go the react dot
memo and then pass the component let me
add here component
so component here or I can just grab the
memo function and effectively
it returns a memoized component in
simple English it just means that now
the component will check whether the
props have changed and if they haven't
which again is happening right now with
our people the people prop is not
changing we're just re-rendering the
Lower State component and if that's the
case if the props haven't changed well
then the component won't re-render let
me go to a list
so now let me go above my list and I'm
going to go with memo and that is coming
from the react and effectively where we
have the export we simply want to wrap
the list
in the memo so essentially we invoke the
memo and we pass down the list
and as a result notice once I refresh
only the component the parent component
lights up because that's where we're
setting up those State values and if you
don't believe me let me navigate to the
bigger browser window I will refresh and
all that let's start from the scratch
and check it out notice over here I'm
increasing the count all of that is good
once I stop notice only the Lower State
we rendered so rest of them the list and
each person component they didn't
re-render because props did not change
so essentially lists stayed the same and
as a result we did not trigger those
unnecessary re-renders
okay and once we have established that
memo function is awesome
now let me throw you a mind grenade what
if we have a remove person function
and keep in mind
it totally makes sense
to set this function in this component
why well because the list is here
so let's set up this function remove
person
pretty much the logic is going to be
following we'll grab the ID and we'll
only
return items whose ID does not match and
then we'll set
the array the people are equal to that
new value and then we want to pass it
down because of course I want to invoke
it in the person component now in my
case I will copy and paste
since we have done that quite a few
times during the course I really don't
see the point of setting this up from
the scratch so let me go back to the
next copy and paste and then we want to
pass it down to a person like I said so
we're gonna go the remote person is
equal to remove person okay beautiful
then I'll copy and paste right away
because we want to do the same thing in
the list we just need to remember that
we need to structure it here as well of
course so remove person and then let me
save the index
and then back in the person I want to
actually grab two things
I want to grab the remove person
and I also want to grab the ID and then
right after the heading four I'm gonna
go with button I'm not gonna set up any
classes you can definitely do so if you
want I'm just gonna go with on click and
this is going to be equal to my arrow
function and here let's go with remove
person and let's pass in the ID
now everything is awesome and by the way
everything is not awesome because I did
forget to add some kind of value here
and I'll just say your room move so now
everything is awesome however we'll
probably notice something interesting
every time I'll click on remove
I'll be re-rendering so this is
something we expect okay we're changing
the list so of course it's going to
re-render okay but what about this
what about count
we have a memo right
so this shouldn't be happening
I mean we established in the previous
video
that memo is checking for those props
and if they haven't changed
well then the component doesn't
re-render
and we saw that in a previous video that
was the case however we add this
function and now even without going to
the performance tab I can clearly see
that these ones are also re-rendering
so why is that happening
you see memo is doing its job
everything is fine with the memo we
don't need to pass some kind of extra
argument or anything like that
the problem is this function
if you remember all the way back when we
covered them let me find this
use effect the first one code example
what did I say
I said that
this function
is going to be created from the scratch
correct and it's also going to be
invoked if you're invoking it here so
every time the component is going to
re-render two things are happening this
function gets created from the scratch
so in our case let's remove person and
in here we also invoked it now we're not
doing that in the
component here but we are creating this
function from scratch every time
the state gets updated
and here's the thing
as far as JavaScript is concerned
this prop has changed so every time we
click on Account button we re-render the
component correct
and every time we render
we create that function from the scratch
be a remove person
so now in the list component yes this
value is not changing this one pretty
much stays the same
so memo fix that however
when it comes to remove person
since it gets created from the scratch
each and every time
JavaScript things that yeah the prop
changed and we can actually go to a
devtools and we can see that so let me
first go to a profiler record and now
check it out I'll click I can clearly
see that they are rendering and we'll
nicely see that the reason for that is
because props changed
so notice it even says the remove person
changed that's why the list is
re-rendering even though it's the same
function
and therefore in the next video we'll
cover a huge callback hook which
actually helps us to solve this issue
okay so how we can fix this mind grenade
issue well we can use use callback hook
which in react allows us to memorize a
function or basically remember the
function it takes two arguments the
first one is the function you want to
memorize so of course in our case that
is going to be remove person and the
second one is the array of dependencies
and we're already familiar with array of
dependencies because we have worked with
it when we used use effect hook correct
so
it only creates that function if the
value in dependency array changes
so for example if it's empty if it's
nothing there then of course it's only
going to create that function the first
time the component
renders basically when the initial Mount
takes place so let's try this one out
we're going to navigate to
index.js and as I know I suggest pausing
the video and try to set it up yourself
in the readme you can find the
syntax that you need to use just try to
implement this in our component and
effectively we want to grab the hook
it's called euge callback and then where
we have the function
now I want to pass this function into a
used callback so that's going to be my
first argument and the second one is
going to be that dependency array so
first let me navigate here let me push
this one down and also use callback and
first I'll just pass empty dependency
array just so you can see one major
gotcha
so now this is empty now this is
happening only
when the component mounts let me cut
this one out and we pass this one in so
it still removes the person all of that
is good
is just now we're creating it
only once only the first time when the
component renders so now check it out
once I click count I don't have those
unnecessary re-randers and we can
actually double check that if we again
navigate to the profiler
record
over here looks like I need to refresh
yep I start recording and notice
only the component re-renders not the
person one so let me stop it over here
and check it out everything is awesome
however
I said that there's a gotcha so
everything is beautiful use callback
creates this function only once but
you'll notice that our functionality
doesn't quite work
notice I basically removed one person
after that I get stuck and just keep
flipping these values and the reason for
that is following you see when we create
this function
basically
this is the list that we're working with
so once we remove that first person we
actually change that value correct
initial Aid was 4 and now it's three
but we still keep using that old value
and I think it's going to be
very useful if we log it so let me go
with console.log and let me set up
people and you'll see what I'm talking
about so let me refresh over here
function gets created okay I don't see
anything because I'm not invoking it but
check it out once I click I have four
items over here right but then the next
time I still have the four items and
that's where the issue is functionality
is not going to work because pretty much
all the time just working with the
initial array but since we're moving
items of course
our array is changing the people State
value so long story short this is why we
want to pass the people as dependency so
pretty much every time
will change the people array we also
want to generate this function from the
scratch so there's going to be instances
where you just create this once
basically you'll have empty dependence
here and yes there's going to be
instances where you do need to provide
some various independency array
otherwise as you can see our
functionality went bananas so now let me
save and let's test it out notice our
functionality works and yes we do
re-render the
person that's totally expected because
we're actually updating the people State
value however
the person is not going to be
re-rendering
if we're clicking on account so now
notice as I'm clicking on account
everything stays the same and if you
still don't believe me
we can go back to our favorite profiler
record
and check it out I only have that main
component over here I won't have the
person re-rendering just because I'm
updating the account value again we did
that with use callback hook which takes
two arguments first we want to pass in
the function we want to memorize or
essentially remember and then the second
one is the dependency all right okay and
once we're familiar with use callback
hook
now let's see a pretty typical use case
for it and for that we're actually going
to navigate away
from the performance one
and we're looking for the final one in
the use effect technically this video is
optional if you're not interested you
can just watch and don't switch the
directories so essentially remember when
we fetch the users in the user fact zero
four fetch data I did mention that
essentially we don't want to set the
fetch data outside of the use effect
and then pass it in dependency array
which Veet doesn't complain about but if
you're working with create react app
you'll see this es lint warning now I'm
not going to place it in dependency
array because I don't wanna
basically run out of my requests however
I will cut this one out from the use
effect let me copy and paste so that's
my fetch data
notice once I run everything is still
awesome everything still works but like
I just said normally with create react
app you'll get that warning in the
console now that is not an error but it
is a warning
the reason why we don't want to pass
fetch data directly in the user effect
same deal because this one gets created
from the scratch so essentially you'll
have that influent Loop however since
now we know how to work with use
callback here's what we can do
I can go here with comma use callback
and essentially just set up this
functionality over here
so let's try this one out I'm going to
go to use callback in this case it's an
empty dependency array so I don't want
to pass anything in here cut this one
copy and paste and we're good to go let
me save it notice the functionality
still works
and in this case I can nicely add fetch
data to dependency array because now
this fetch data will only be generated
once
when the component mounts during the
initial render and while we're on a
topic of news callback why don't we also
cover use memo which is very similar the
difference is that use memo memorizes
the value that we're getting back from
the function so essentially again it
remembers that value now in this example
I'll just show you with slow function
but later on of course we'll use it to
debounce some functionality so in one of
the complex projects essentially there's
going to be a input and we'll use use
memo to the bounce some functionality
basically to run some functionality
later now why am I telling you that just
so you don't think that we can only use
for the example I'm about to show you so
use memoize is actually very cool you
can do a bunch of interesting stuff
again in our case we'll just take a look
look at the slow function example so
the way use memo works is very similar
to use callback we get use memo and then
again notice
it's looking for two arguments first one
is going to be the function however in
this case we're returning something from
the function
and then the second one is going to be
the dependency array now in our case in
our example we won't have any values in
dependency array it's only going to run
once now as far as our example
let's imagine that in our project
we have some kind of slow function
that's doing some kind of calculation
now I will simulate that by setting up a
very ugly for Loop so please don't judge
me on this one so essentially let's
create a function I'll call this slow
function.js in there set up this
function again simply there's a value
that I'm setting up a for Loop which I
haven't done probably in four years or
so and then once I'm done with this long
for loop I just return a value
effectively it's just going to take
quite some time to generate that value
so this function returns a value and in
the index I want to import the slow
function I want to invoke it and I want
to set it equal to value and you'll see
the result so let's navigate to the
hooks like I said in my case I'll call
this slow function and as I said if you
don't want to work on this example you
don't have to you can just see the
result and I'm pretty sure you'll get
the main gist of use memo so let's go to
tutorial let me grab this I don't think
there's a need to create it from the
scratch
now I want to make sure that I'm going
to start
yep that's my function then we want to
navigate back to index we want to import
that function and I'm going to rely on
Auto Import and I'll right away set it
equal to a value so say value is equal
to and then slow function yep we invoke
it we don't need to pass anything and I
simply want to log the value
so let me go with console log
and we're looking for the value let me
save and again same deal
pretty much every time I'll click on
account
it's gonna take
time for my component to render you'll
see that it's definitely slower
if you would have for example some kind
of input and if you're typing it's going
to be with delay
so let me just showcase that I'm going
to go to button and I'll click like six
seven times
and you'll notice that the value is not
updating right away why well because
again we're changing the state value we
are re-rendering and what do we do in
each render we run this slow function
and since our slow function is really
slow well that's why it takes ages for
me to see that count of nine and this is
where the use memo hook can definitely
help us again the syntax is extremely
similar to use callback we can go with
use memo we import the hook and now I
wanna
set up this slow function in the used
memo and as a result you'll see that the
slow function is only going to run once
when our initial render takes place so
let's go to user memo again two
arguments in this case I'll pass in
empty dependency array then
I wanna grab my slow function but again
this needs to return a value so let me
cut this one out I'll pass here the
arrow function like so and then we'll
invoke slow function and now you'll
notice that once we refresh yep the
initial render takes a little bit of
time but after that everything's cool
so unless I provide some kind of value
in this dependency array
this initial value the one that takes
really long time
for the slow function to calculate
it's only going to run once
I'm only going to get that value on
initial render and that's it since the
value is not changing essentially I'm
not slowing down my component every time
a state update takes place with react 18
we also got use transition hook
which we can use to treat some
functionality as less urgent so imagine
this scenario in your app
there is some kind of user interaction
which triggers some heavy computation
for example user types something in the
input and based on the input value you
filter I don't know 20 000 items
here's the thing while the computation
is taking place it will actually block
the UI
basically our app will be less
responsive and as you can imagine that's
not a good thing ask yourself
as a user what's more annoying waiting
for some data to arrive or tirelessly
clicking on the button
so use transition just allows us to Mark
certain functionality as less urgent
which in turn prevents the whole UI
blocking thing
with that said like I already mentioned
before react is Fast by default
so even though this is a very cool
addition to the library it has very
specific use cases and most likely it's
not something you'll use immediately in
all your applications and once we're
familiar with the general concept now
let's take it out for a test drive
in this video we will heavily rely on
array Dot from method so if you're not
familiar with it or you need to jog your
memory please utilize this JavaScript
nuggets video where I cover everything
in great detail
as far as the location in the app.jsx we
want to grab the starter
from zero four react 18. again zero for
react 18. this is what we should see on
the screen basically there's going to be
an input and we'll have some items below
and if we navigate to the file
you'll see that I have two State values
I have one for text so that's for the
input and I also have one for items
which initially is just empty array so
in here I have the form everything is
awesome I have the handle change I also
have heading 4 right below the form so
this is where we are displaying the
items at the moment they're empty
there's nothing there and as far as
handle change well I have set text I'm
just grabbing the value all of this is
awesome
however let's imagine that
I attempt to do something very
interesting
first I'll create new items
using array.com and I want to construct
a very big array therefore I provide
here an object with a length property of
000 and then the second one is the
Callback function which gets invoked for
every item now I don't care about the
actual item I do care about the index
and yes this is the case where I'll
cheat a little bit and I'll set up the
key as the index
now inside of it I also want to return
an image
which essentially is that nice and cute
wheat SVG
so remember the public folder I talked
about at the very very beginning in
react fundamentals since it's in the
public I can just go forward slash and
beat SVG then once I create that array
the 5000 items basically just a bunch of
wheat SVG images I want to set it equal
to my new items and if everything is
still fast we can also slow down the CPU
because it's one thing to work in
development with a fast computer but
it's totally different if you're
somewhere out there with Spotty Wi-Fi
struggling with I don't know iPhone 3 or
whatever so the way we can slow down the
CPU so again we're not talking about the
network we can also do it with a network
in this case I want to slow down the CPU
we go with performant insights let me
make this sucker bigger
and then notice here it says no
throttling I can actually go with CPU
and I can make it I don't know four
times slower something along those lines
now let me make this one again smaller
and you'll notice something interesting
since I'm running this pretty much on
every keystroke
you'll actually notice that my input is
going to be somewhat slow so I haven't
saved the file yet so notice I can
nicely type and everything is awesome
however the moment I save the file and
the moment I create those 5 000 items
every time user
presses something in the input you'll
right away notice that it's very slow so
I typed few characters and notice how
long it took for them to show on screen
and it's going to be a little bit faster
once we already have all the items and
all that since of course we're not
changing the path but hopefully you can
see the issue
so we need to somehow fix this where I
still want a fast response here in the
input
and then this one the new items well
that can happen in the background so
let's try this one out where I want to
go to import and I want to grab use and
then transition so that's the hook I'm
looking for then I want to go right
after the items and I want to invoke it
and it's getting back to you things
it's getting back is bending and the
start transition
so the slow function this one over here
or functionality
maybe be more precise we want to place
that in the start transition and then is
pending we'll use
effectively to Showcase that something
has happened so we're gonna go here with
const and then is and pending
and then comma and we'll say start
transition now like I said that is equal
to my use transition and I think
I'll make this one smaller it's somewhat
annoying here so yep we invoke them then
let's go to a handle change
and let's set up that start transition
and now let's pass both of these things
inside of it now we do need to set up
the function here first
so let's do that let's grab these two
suckers so the
array with 5000 items and the set new
items good and now let's scroll down a
little bit and where we have the items I
actually want to look for the is pending
the value of spending and then if we're
loading basically if it's true then
we'll display loading dot dot and once
we're good to go then we'll display the
items so right before D heading four
let's open up the curlies I'll go with
is pending and I'm gonna go with the new
operator so if it's true what do I want
to showcase let me go here with heading
four and then loading dot okay awesome
and then if it's false basically once
we're done then we want to display those
items so let me cut this one out copy
and paste and once I save you'll notice
something interesting that now the
response in the input is going to be
much faster and notice we have this
loading so essentially something we want
to keep fast which is the response to
our user
is still going to happen fast however
the slow functionality
is going to happen in the background
okay and now let's see how we can do
code splitting in react
which in turn will allow us to
progressively load or lazy load our
application
before we take a look at the code let's
discuss the main benefits of such
approach first
improve performance by splitting up a
code into smaller more manageable chunks
we can reduce the size of the initial
JavaScript payload that needs to be
loaded this results in Faster load times
and improved performance especially on
slow networks or low end devices
second better user experience
with code splitting only the essential
code needed for the initial render of
your application is loaded the remaining
code is loaded as the user interacts
with your application
leading to a smoother less blocking user
experience
you see especially when it comes to
bigger projects not all the pages and
components are equal
meaning there are certain resources that
are used More Often by the users for
example typically
which page do you think gets more
traffic
the homepage or the contact page
so million dollar question
if some resources are used less often
than the other ones does it make sense
to jam all of that code when we
initially ship our application to the
browser because keep in mind the more
code we send
the more time it will take for the
browser to compile it which in turn will
affect how fast the user can interact
with our application
so wouldn't it be nice if we could
prioritize the important resources over
the less important ones
in order to Lazy load our components or
progressively load our application we'll
use a tool called suspense now suspense
is a series of apis and it actually has
been around for quite some time but at
this point in time only the code
splitting feature which we're about to
cover is fully supported other ones are
still experimental including data
fetching and therefore we won't discuss
them at this time lastly in our example
we'll progressively load a big component
when the user clicks the button
however a more realistic scenario is to
Lazy load our component when we have
multiple Pages which is something we'll
cover when we discuss routing in react
so this is just general info and we will
revisit this topic later on in the
course okay and now let's see suspense
in action
for that we want to navigate back to the
same folder
the zero four react 18. and notice over
there I created a slow component and
essentially the idea is going to be
exactly the same as in the previous
setup where I want to create 5000 items
remember those are images and then
in the component I'll use use State I'll
set this one up as default value and
essentially I just want to render them
on a screen so now I want to go back to
index.jsx
and effectively I'm not going to touch
any of this logic I just want to
showcase something
so I'm going to go below this is pending
and I'll just showcase the slow
component and as I said you know I'll
just refresh just so we don't have two
of them on the screen so still within a
section I want to go with slow component
let's save that we should eventually see
the component on the screen so let me
refresh notice it took a little bit of
time but eventually we see those 5000
items again the idea is exactly the same
this time we're not
getting them from the input
we are importing the component and of
course the reason why everything is
happening so slow is because I'm still
throttling the CPU now
what's also interesting
if I navigate to the bigger screen
you'll notice in the network tab
more specifically if we look for Js
since we are right away
displaying the slow component we are
also importing the JavaScript code
correct but what if we have a different
setup what if I create a state value
I'm going to call this show
and
set show and I'll set it equal to let's
say the default one will be false so
that's my Boolean value
then I'll set up a button that toggles
it so right above the component
I'm going to go with my button
I'll set up on click
let's invoke here
the set show so set show and we'll set
it equal to the opposite value whatever
it is in a state and let's just call
this toggle now in this case I do want
to add a class so class name is equal to
BTN
and then when it comes to slow component
I want to go to show
and only if the value is true I want to
display it
so let's go here
let's save again let me navigate to the
big screen
and notice
even though I'm displaying this
component only
when the value is true
I'm still importing
right out of the gate right so I'm still
grabbing that JavaScript logic even
though there's no guarantee that the
user will click the button
and essentially it would be better if we
only import this logic when we actually
need to display that component correct
so instead of importing everything on
our initial render which of course is
going to add the loading time we only
want to import that slow component when
the user actually wants to work with it
in this case clicks the toggle button so
how we can do that well we need to First
navigate up and we'll need to grab two
things we'll need to grab suspense
components so this is a component that
react provides and we also need to go
with lazy then we have this somewhat
interesting setup where we want to go
with const we need to come up with an
iron in my case it's still going to be
slow component and that is equal to lazy
so invoke this then we provide a
function and then we go with import so
as you can see now we're importing this
dynamically
so we go with forward slash and of
course the path is still the same so now
I want to remove this one the straight
up import and then let's keep on moving
and now we want to wrap
our component
in the suspense
and we also want to provide some kind of
fallback so I'm gonna go
and I'll wrap the slow component in the
suspense
component then pullback prop basically
what do we want to display when we're
loading and I'll just cheat I'll grab
this value over here
and after that we want to place the
slow component inside of the suspense
and now notice something interesting
when I navigate to the big screen and
refresh you won't see anywhere the
import for the slow component JavaScript
code
only once I click here notice then I'm
importing which again is really really
awesome because it allows us to decrease
our initial load time
since we're not grabbing all of the
JavaScript code and only if the user
decides to interact with the component
only then we import so essentially this
is how we can lazy load our components
or in other words we only import the
functionality when there is a need for
it One Last Thing Before I Let You Go
typically we will wrap our entire return
in suspense
since that way we can lazy load multiple
components
now the syntax and the result is the
same
we will still provide fallback prop and
for all of the components we import
progressively the fallback value in this
case the loading text will be displayed
the reason why I wrapped only the slow
component in the previous example was
just to underscore which component we'll
get that fallback value all right up
next let's cover what is Redux toolkit
and why it's so useful
you see when it comes to bigger
applications
especially
if they're built by a team of Developers
one of the biggest challenges is State
Management yes context API is very
useful tool but it clearly has its
limits especially when we talk about big
applications with tons of features
and in order to solve the issue over the
time various State Management libraries
have been introduced by the community
and without a doubt for very very very
long time one of the most popular state
libraries has been Redux now before we
continue let me stress something Redux
is not part of official react again
Redux is not part of official react even
though they are used together very often
now
even though Redux solves a lot of
problems it also introduces some new
headaches in short it requires bunch of
annoying boilerplate and manual setup
especially when it comes to Advanced
features since you'll need to install
more libraries and add some more config
setup which over time especially if you
have to do it for every project just
becomes annoying and this is where Redux
toolkit comes into play so creators of
Redux notice the general need for
opinionated approach while setting up
Redux applications and as a result they
came up with Redux toolkit which
effectively is Redux with batteries
basically it means that all the popular
extra libraries and setups are built in
and do not require extra setup
as a result there is no time consuming
setup
and over time it speeds up our workflow
tremendously
so with Redux toolkit we can have our
cake and eat it too meaning we get all
of the benefits of Redux without any of
the manual labor and as always we'll
start with extensive tutorial where
we'll cover all of the major building
blocks of Redux toolkit during tutorial
we'll build this card application and in
the process we'll see all of the cool
Redux toolkit features in action so
things like store slice reducers action
creators and of course create async
thunk which handles a synchronous
functionality in order to follow you
will need a star and you can find it in
this GitHub repo so look for my profile
Jones milgar and the actual repo name is
Redux toolkit tutorial then the name of
the repo that you're looking for is
Redux toolkit tutorial and once you get
here just pick the option that makes the
most sense to you
I think in my case I'm gonna go for
download zip option then
I want to crack it open
and in the folder you'll find two more
folders
the final as well as the starter and
needless to say that in the final one
you'll find the complete source code and
then in a star is where we'll do all of
our work so let me take this sucker out
let me open up
the text editor Visual Studio code
oh right away set it side by side now
this is a standard react application I
used create react app the only
difference is that I removed some
boilerplate code and I also add some
resources so in here what we want to do
is run npm install and also npm start so
npm install
and PM start and there is an app so at
the moment notice there's only having
two we have some car items which we'll
use in the beginning as our data and
also a few icons
I'll discuss them a little bit later
index CSS all our CSS and also of course
index.js so once you get the repo once
you get the star install all the
dependencies Run npm start you should
see in the browser they hear into with I
believe it was Redux toolkit and if you
do we're in good shape and we can
proceed to The Next Step a quick update
I upgraded this project to react 18.
which also means that in the index.js
you'll find create root method instead
of react Dom render
which was used when I recorded this
project
now let me be very clear
all of the upcoming content is still
valid and up to date
only few lines of code in the index.js
are different
since the latest react version uses
create root method instead of react Dom
render and yes in a few videos when we
set up Redux store
we still want to wrap the app component
in the provider just like I showcase
during the videos so again let me repeat
all of the upcoming content is still
valid and up to date the only difference
is the react version now this app uses
react 18. in the star you'll also find a
readme file where I laid out all the
steps we're going to take as well as
some useful links and first if you want
to find more info about Redux token you
can always utilize this link so this one
goes directly to their docs and we have
few ways that we can add Redux toolkit
to our project first we can go with
straight up template
so in that case instead of going npx
create react app and then the app name
we also add this hyphen hyphen and then
template and Redux now from my
experience they add way too much
boilerplate so essentially I always
avoid that and in general I just go with
the Redux toolkit so I set up the
application let's say with create react
app and then install the toolkit
separately and we do that with npm
install and then add Redux JS and then
forward slash toolkit and also We'll add
react Redux
and I'll talk about it in a second now
let me just quickly mention that if for
some reason
you get some issues when you just run
MPX create react app and again it's not
specific to this template one if
something goes bananas with npx you can
always try to go with create react app
and then the latest one so this is just
a side note now back to the toolkit so
when we install
reduxjs toolkit we actually install fuel
libraries so we install the Redux which
is going to be our core Library we also
install Emer which is going to allow us
to mutate the state we install Redux
thunk which will handle the async
actions and also we install reselect
which will simplify the reducer setup so
these things of course will only make
sense if you already have worked with
the Redux so this is already provided
for us and of course we'll see all of
those things in action and if you didn't
work with the Redux before don't worry
of course I will explain all of them and
also as an extra we get right away Redux
devtools and also combined reducers
right from the get-go again if you
haven't worked with Redux I totally
understand if none of those things make
sense but don't worry we'll talk about
them later now why we also install this
package the react Redux well you see
Redux can be used with any front-end
framework it's not specific to react in
order to connect our application to the
Redux this is where we'll use the
package by the name of react Redux now
needless to say that of course if you'll
take a look at the packages on
you will see the both packages you'll
see the toolkit as well as the react
Redux but just so you don't think that
there is some funny business going on
let me copy this line of code let me
install both packages and once the
install is complete we can start setting
up our Redux store so the install is
done we go with npm start and if we take
a look at the package Json you will find
the toolkit as well as react reduct and
with this in place now we can start
setting up our application with Redux
toolkit okay and once we have installed
all dependencies up next I want to set
up the store and you can think of store
as the entire state for your application
so remember previously we used context
API now in this case we'll use toolkit
and we'll set up the store and the
syntax is following where first we want
to create store.js somewhere in the
source we want to import configure store
function from the toolkit and yes in
order to speed this up I'll just
reference it as toolkit please keep in
mind that of course I'm talking about
the Redux token and then in this
function
we want to pass in the object and in the
object there is going to be a reducer
property which is going to be object
itself and then in here we'll set up our
features and I fully understand that I
mean this can look somewhat fuzzy don't
worry as we start setting up the
features you'll see everything in action
so for the time being just bear with me
and then once we have the store we want
to export that and this is the case
where you can export this as default
so the difference of course is just
export default and then the store or you
can go with name export and then we want
to go back to
index.js we want to import store from
the store file as well as the provider
from react Redux like I said this is the
library that connects Redux store or
Redux to our application and similarly
to context API
we want to wrap our entire application
so we're going to grab this provider
there's a store prop and we just want to
pass in the store coming from the store
file so let's get cracking first
I'm gonna go with store Js
in here let's import configure store so
import we're looking for configure store
notice right away I have suggestion for
that and then let's set up that store
like I said at the moment it might look
somewhat funky the moment we'll set up
some features it will make sense so
let's go here with const and of course
I'm adding export as well I'm going to
store that is equal to configure store
let's pass in the object let's set up
the reducer is an object itself and for
time being it's going to be empty and
most likely we'll get the warning in a
console don't worry about it again
all of this functionality is coming up
and then let's navigate to index.js
Let's import both of the things let's go
with import then store
um this is coming from the store file of
course and also we want to get that
provider so import and then we're
looking for provider now that is coming
from react Redux and now let's wrap our
entire application so let's say provider
here let's close it out let's wrap our
app and then we want to set up a store
prop and we want to set it equal to our
store
and if nothing breaks we are heading in
the right direction so then we can set
up the slice again like I said
if you see this warning don't worry
we'll fix it in a second beautiful and
once we have the store in place now
let's set up the slice and I fully
understand that this name is totally
funky you're like what slice are you
talking about and I want you to think of
slice as the feature of your application
so if we take a look at the complete
project you'll notice that yes we have
the card functionality
but we also have the model
and you can think of it as two features
our application so we have one feature
for the model and the second one is
going to be for our card and of course
the bigger our application
the more features we're going to have
and in the Redux toolkit land it is
called slice now in order to set up
slice a common convention is to set up
features folder but of course naming is
always up to you but then whatever is
going to be the name of the feature so
in my case it's going to be card that's
why I'll set up a card folder and then
we want to set up a file again like I
keep mentioning the naming is up to you
but again typically you'll go with
whatever feature and then slice JS now
in there
you'll want to get create slash and
don't worry about this one that create
async thunk let's say not I'll remove it
worry about that later and then we want
to invoke that function create slash we
want to give it a name again it's
totally up to you but in my case I'm
going to go with card and then we have
initial State Property
where we just set up whatever state we
want in my case I'll set it up as a
separate object and in here I'm going to
go with cart items with an amount so how
many items I have in a cart what is the
card total both of them zero and then is
loading true because eventually we will
load this from the API then I'll log the
sucker
the card slice and in there we'll have
the reducer and of course I'll talk
about this one a little bit later once
we get there and eventually what we want
to do is in the store we want to import
cart reducer so that's going to be the
function that controls this state in our
slides so think of our application we'll
just split up the functionality where
this slice is just responsible for the
cart and this reducer specifically is
going to modify it whatever
functionality we set up and then in that
reducer that we set up in the last video
notice there's a complaint that there's
no valve reducer now we want to set up a
key now key name is really up to you
just like everything else and I know
that you're probably sick of hearing
this but I just want to make this clear
where this is totally up to you you can
call this banana pudding if you want
just remember that later once we start
setting up our functionality yes of
course we'll have to access this name so
therefore I'm going to go with cart and
I want to set it equal to reducer so the
function that we'll have access to
and a function that will allow us to
control this
piece of State for this specific
functionality hopefully this is clear so
now let's go to Source we want to create
new folder like I said common convention
we'll call this features so features our
application in our case cart and model
then let's create another folder and
we're gonna go here with cart then
inside of the cart let's go with new
file and we're gonna go with cart slice
Js so once we're here we want to import
we want to import and we'll say create
and slice now for some reason it does
not oh yep it does so I have the
suggestion and let's right away invoke
it I'm going to call this const card
and slice and that is equal to create
slice
it's a function we pass in the object
and here we can set up a bunch of
properties
so first we want to set up the name
so I'm gonna go here with card then we
want to go with that initial State this
is the case since I have more properties
might as well set it up as a separate
object so let's set up here initial
state
and then we'll add card items which
initially is going to be empty array but
then we'll take a look at multiple
approaches to local data and then the
data coming from the API I also want to
go with amount so how many items I have
in the cart and Please be aware that I'm
not just talking about the products I
have in my card I'm actually
looking for the item count
so how many items of that specific
product I have and this is going to be
that amount hopefully that is clear then
we want to go with total so Total Money
both of them zero initially and that is
loading because eventually we'll pull
this from the API so that's going to be
our initial State once we save notice
right away
initial studio in here references the
initial property then we want to log
this sucker and we want to quickly
import install.js now in a second we'll
do more proper setup I just want to
showcase what we have in the card slice
so let me save it then I'll navigate
back to the store and for time being
let's just import the entire file like I
said more proper setup is coming let's
just go here with the features
red card and then card slice and once we
import of course we right away invoke
the file and here we'll see that console
log so we'll have some actions here
something that we'll discuss a little
bit later once we set up some reducers
we have case reducers again something we
don't need to worry about right now get
initial State again a function that gets
the state name and then notice all the
way in the bottom we have that reducer
so this reducer
is the one that is going to control that
state in this slice that's why we want
to export that we want to export this
and in the store we want to come up with
a key and set it equal to that reducer
so let's try this out I'm going to go
with cart then instead of just getting
the file I'll actually look for that
reducer but I'll set it up as a default
one so for time being I'll comment this
one out we'll come back to this one
because again we'll talk about these
actions eventually and now I just want
to export that reducer now there's
Million Ways How we can export Us in
this case I'm going to go export default
and then cart slice dot reducer again
this is an object and this is a property
so let's export this event in the store
we wanna import so I'm gonna go with
cart not slice but reducer again if you
want to name this differently of course
you can and then we're going with from
and now go with cart equals to card
reducer and we shouldn't see any error
messages anymore because now we have the
proper set up so now we can take a look
how we can access the data first from
that initial State and then of course
eventually also take a look at how we
can set up functionality to control this
but our first step is going to be
accessing this data okay and before we
go any further let's also quickly
install Redux devtools and the good news
is that as far as the code we don't need
to add any configuration basically the
moment we install Redux toolkit we're
good to go however when it comes to
browser we do need to install extra
extension and the extension you're
looking for is this one Redux Dev tools
and in the Chrome if you want to install
extension just go to your extensions
and then more specifically look for open
Chrome web store and then in here look
for the Redux one not the Red X 4K
apologies Redux so this is the extension
you're looking for and once you do that
let me open this up in the big browser
so that's my localhost 3000
you'll notice a tab it Redux Tab and
here we'll be able to find bunch of
useful info now at the moment
I mean we have a clean application we
only have the state but yes eventually
once we set up the reducers the actions
and all that yes this is going to be a
very useful tool now at the moment the
only thing that I want to showcase that
this is our state notice that's my card
card items amount total and is loading
and yes of course
in our store
once we add more reducers
all of them will meet over here and
that's why this tool is very useful
because as will dispatch our actions
we'll clearly see how our state changes
beautiful and once we have set up
the Redux details up next let's see how
we can access that initial state in any
of the components
so we have the initial state in the
slice
and let's say that I want to set up a
navbar component where I want to access
the amount
and the setup is following where we do
want to create the components folder
then navbar.js and in there we'll import
cart icon so that's the component that's
coming from the icons folder and I'll
discuss how we can set up the component
e in the following video because at the
moment I do want to focus on the state
value access and then we want to import
use selector so that's a hook coming
from react reduction
and then in the navbar component before
the return we want to invoke use
selector and the selector is looking for
one thing it's looking for the function
and as a parameter we get access to the
entire state so we're talking about the
entire store
again in our case we just have the card
but eventually we'll add more reducers
over here so since this is a parameter
of course we can call it whatever we
want so you'll see probably state but
actually my preference is to call this a
store because that signals to me that
that is entire store so the entire state
of my application and then more
specifically I'm looking for DOT card
wire
because that's the name of the property
over here and then initial state if you
remember we do have the amount property
and of course there's Million Ways How
we can set this up for example we can
just return from this function this
amount or since in this case we're
returning the entire object we can to
structure it so let's try to set this up
where in the source I want to create a
new folder and I'm going to call this
components over here then let's set up
that nav bar
nav bar JS in here
like I said first let's import card icon
something I'm going to discuss in the
following video then we also want to get
that U selector
so let's say use
selector hook that is coming from react
Redux and now let's set up that navbar
component so I'm going to use my
extension I'll set up the number and
first let's set up the return and then
we'll worry about the actual state so
let's say here nav I do want to add here
a div so inside of the div let's go or
I'm sorry inside of the nav let's go
with there let's add a class name of nav
Center and here we want to go with
heading 3 Redux toolkit
and after that let's save it and we
don't see anything so let me refresh
don't see anything in the browser and of
course the reason for that is because I
didn't import in the object so let me go
back
and in the app.js let's import the nav
bar
and then let's set it up over here
so what I want to do as far as the
return in app.js
I just want to go with Main and then the
number so instead of the heading to
index toolkit we'll go with main tags
and then first we'll set up the nav bar
and then we'll set up rest of the card
items as well so that should be our
number okay that's awesome
and as far as the other stuff
I think I'm gonna go here
with a card icon but that is going to be
placed in the nav container so right
after this heading three I'm gonna go
with div the class of nav container and
here let's set up that cart icon yep
that is how it's going to look like and
then let's go with div the class of
amount
container and then paragraph with a
class of total total hyphen
and amount and at the moment let's just
place a zero here let's save this and
now let's see how we can access the
entire state of our application so first
let's just log the sucker let's say use
selector
so that's the hook and like I said it's
looking for one parameter which is going
to be our function and then inside of
this function as a parameter we get that
entire store so for time being I'm gonna
call this store and I'll log it I'll say
but the only thing that I want to do in
this function is log the store and what
you'll notice in the console
is our entire state which is just
awesome if you ask me so take a look
over here we have card items we have a
mount and we have the total so again I
know I'm repeating myself
but essentially the idea is that
using this use selector notice how we
don't need to pass anything coming from
the specific slice or nothing like that
we can right away in this function axis
our entire store
and essentially what we want to do we
want to return something
whether that is specific
property for example amount or of course
you can return the entire card and then
you can the structure so first let's
just set it up where
we return the amount so notice over here
we have undefined in line five because
we're not returning anything from this
function yet
and let's set up over here in the
paragraph and then we'll take a look at
the the structuring option as well I
don't think I'm going to leave this for
your reference because again
we'll set up multiple ways anyway so
first let's go with a mount and that one
is equal to Let's again invoke use
selector let's pass in the function and
I'm going to be setting up the arrow
function and I'll go right away with
implicit return so again in here we are
accessing the entire state of our
application and we go with store cart
because that's the property value
and yes once we add more reducers
in our store then of course we'll be
able to access it so I'm gonna go here
let's say with modal and I'm not going
to pass anything in because I do need to
set up the reducer then of course we'll
be able to access with
store dot model hopefully that is clear
and this is very very useful because
again we don't need to import anything
specific from that slice we have access
to entire store and then let's go with
the mount so this is what I'm returning
from the function
and probably it's not going to be
surprising if I pass here the value
still going to be zero now let's test
this out though let's go to our features
slice and let's change this around let's
say there's going to be five items
number one I save notice now of course I
have this value of five so we know that
our functionality works and like I said
there's million different ways how we
can set this up and one of them is
actually the structuring so I know that
I can return store Dot card which is
essentially a object correct and then
inside of it I have the amount property
so this is also valid honest value did
not change and we didn't get any bugs so
that's how we can access data from our
slice we need to pick the component we
need to use a use selector and here we
pass in the function
and as a parameter of this function gets
the entire store and then we just need
to pick what we want to return in my
case I want to return cart from this
function it is an object and it
represents this initial state
and more specifically I'm looking for
the amount that's why I destructured it
and then I display it here in the return
as far as the icons in this project I
decided to go different route where I
use the hero icons site so once you
navigate there you'll notice a bunch of
nice icons and essentially I just set
them up as components so let me show you
with one and then you understand the
general concept just pick the icon you
want in this case I think I'm gonna go
with this bad one and as far as I
noticed there's really no difference
whether you go with jsx or SVG
so let me just copy this one let's
navigate back and then in the icons
you'll notice full-blown components that
I will right away export so let me keep
scrolling and I'm going to call this
testing so I'm going to say export const
that's going to be my testing component
and in here you just want to set up the
value you want to return
so this essentially will be the icon now
I am styling it though in CSS and in a
second you'll see what I mean so I have
this testing icon right now so that's
the return that I just copied so now
let's navigate to the navbar since I
already have the import for the card
icon
and let's set up over here the testing
one as well
and we can place it anywhere we want so
let me put it side by side and you'll
notice that this is a giant ore I'm
sorry well I already applied The Styling
so maybe this is not gonna work over
here maybe let me set up here the
fragment and then you'll see what I mean
so let me move the sucker down again
this is just temporary you don't have to
follow along
but you'll notice that if we don't apply
a styling we'll get this massive icon
basically that's the default that they
provide
so in the Styles in the index CSS
I added some styling for specific icons
so now I'm talking about the cart icon
and also same applies for these ones
over here as well so not only you'll
need to get the icon but notice over
here I applied some width as well as the
color and of course you can add more
Styles so essentially that's how I set
up
my icons where I created icons Js
and in here you'll find three icons so
one for the cart and then the other ones
for the actual card items and I imported
the icon from the hero icon so I set it
up as a component I export and then I
import in any of the components that I
want and then I just need to apply a
little bit of styling and you want to
Target the SVG so now let me remove the
testing one
and also let me remove it from the icons
since we won't use it and now let's
proceed to The Next Step all right and
up next let's work on our car items so
at the moment it is empty array or I did
prepare
an array of products just so we can set
up the initial functionality yes
eventually we'll fetch this data from my
API and in the process we'll practice of
how we can set up asynchronous
operations in Redux toolkit but for time
being this will be hard-coded data and
it is located in the car atoms and as
you can see it is an array where each
item is an object with some properties
so what we're going to do we're going to
set up the initial State equal to that
array so of course we just need to
import and then we'll repeat the same
steps like we did with an amount in
number however since we have unraveled
after iterate over and all of that cool
stuff so first what I want to do is go
to the card slice and we want to import
we want to import those card items so
let's go here with car items it is a
default export so it doesn't really
matter how we call it here
and then we need to go two levels up
we're looking for the card items and in
here
what do we have the initial State let's
set up current items equal to current
items now if we want to see that we can
either go to the nav bar since in there
we have the use selector and we can of
course log it or
we can take an advantage of the Redux
devtool so let's navigate here
let's refresh just so we're on safe side
if we navigate to the Redux depth tools
now what you'll notice that card items
in the card
is an action array like I said each
object represents that item with a bunch
of useful properties so our next step is
going to be setting this up in the
app.js where we'll grab them we'll
iterate over and then for each item
we'll return a component with the image
the title and rest of the stuff not bad
not bad so we set up the card items
equal to an actual array instead of
empty one now let's set up two more
components the cart container just and
cart item.js
and just the Showcase so this is going
to be the container where we'll have all
of the items as well as the total
and the clear card functionality now
eventually we'll add the model but the
idea won't change if we click on clear
card then of course we'll have empty
card and then we also want to set up
that cart item where again we'll display
all of this info and yes we'll practice
on use selector again where in the card
container we not only want to get the
car items we also want to get the total
as well as the amount because we'll use
that amount
to display some things conditionally in
this case if the amount is less than one
then I'll display this and then if there
are some items in a card then of course
there's going to be a different logic
and in the card item we'll just pass in
the ready as a key as well as the
properties of the atom and then we'll
destructure it now when it comes to card
item for the most part we'll get there
our action creators which of course will
set up a little bit later so for now we
just want to worry about rendering the
cart items on the screen
so let's get cracking where I want to go
two components and let's go here with
cart
container.js
and I also want to set up that card
item.js now when it comes to car animal
work on that one in next video
for a moment and as you know it should
be card items should be call Item one
and now let me fix this one as well
where I'm gonna go with cart item now we
want to import that in the cart
container so let's set up this component
as well
so r a f c e and that's right away
import that card item so let's go here
with cart item then we want to navigate
to the app.js and we also want to get
that card container so let's get that
one and I'll place it right after the
container meaning the number sorry and
we should see on the screen card
container awesome
now what's next well let's take a look
at the readme where we do have the car
item we also want to get the use
selector and now from my application
State I want to get the entire card and
I'll adjust the structure columns total
as well as the amount like I said the
amount we'll use to display
conditionally empty card
um again I already showcased that but
let me show you one more time this is
what we want to set up if the card is
empty and we'll control that with the
mod now if there are some values in the
card then this is what we want to return
we want to go with Section header
iterate over card items
and then also in the footer we want to
display the total with the clear card
button so let's set this one up where
I'm gonna go with import then use
selector from yeah Redux let's right
away access all of the items so let's
say here const
I'm looking for cart
and items
total also we want to get the amount and
all of that is equal to use
selector let's pass in the function and
what we want to return we want to go
here with store or state however you
want to call it
store and then cart so we get all those
values right away let's set up that
condition where I'll say amount is less
than one if that is the case what we
want to return well we want to go here
with section
then let's add a class name of card
and let's set up some logic over here
let's say here header
and side of the header we'll have a
heading to your
bag and then right after that let's go
with heading four and we'll say empty
card now we do need to add here empty
cart class
and let's add a text your card is
currently empty or your bag
it's empty let's save it now since the
amount is zero this is exactly what we
display so in order to see the atoms of
course we'll have to navigate back to
the card slice and again for time being
we'll just hard code this don't worry
eventually we'll set up some action
creators
that control this logic essentially will
set up some reducers and by default
Redux toolkit is going to give us those
action creators so let's go back to the
cart container
and right after this one you want to set
up another return so as you saw this one
was if we have less than one and now
since we hard-coded we have four
so in here we want to go with another
turn
another section
and we do one on a class so class will
be
equal to cart
and then the same deal we want to set up
that header
so header over here
and inside of it we're just gonna go
with heading to your bag
your bag let's save that one and yeah as
I know this is wrong so it should be
class name
then we want to iterate over the card
items so for time being we just want to
set up a div then we want to grab those
card items we want to run the map and
this is the actual array correct and
then for every item we want to return
that card item that we just set up
and we want to pass in the data now on
the screen we'll just see that text
whatever we have over there so here we
have the Karam but eventually yes we'll
access it and we'll correctly display it
so we're mapping over I'll call this
item so now I'm talking about each and
every object over there let's go with a
return then let's set up a cart item we
do need to pass in the key since this is
react and I already know that there's a
an ID property now if you don't believe
me
you can navigate over here and you'll
clearly see that so each and every item
has that ID property so let's say here
dot ID and then I want to use the spread
operator Dot and then pass in rest of
the properties let's save it so since we
have four items we have four card items
on the screen and then right after this
one right after this div let's set up a
footer this is where we'll display the
card total as well as the clear button
cut which eventually will revoke the
model and clear the card so I'm gonna go
with a horizontal line here then let's
add heading 2. with some data so total
span and set of this one I want to set
up a dollar sign I'll say total yes the
moment it is going to be zero
don't worry about it and as I not
actually messed it up over here it
should be there with a class of card
total my apologies that's why the CSS is
not correct
and after that we want to go with that
clear card button so still within the
footer
we want to go with a button let's add a
class right away it should be the end
clear begin
and let's say clear card
let's save this let's refresh so we
don't have any errors and this is what
we should see
on the screen where again we used use
selector
to access our entire store more
specifically we looked for cart which
represents that initial state in the
initial State we have all these values
so we're able to structure and then we
check for the amount
if it's less than one we display the
message if we have some items in there
then we just iterate over them and for
every item we return that card item and
then below that we have total which at
the moment is zero eventually this will
be dynamic as well as the clear card
button which eventually will remove all
the items from the cart awesome and up
next I want to set up the card item
where we're passing in all of the data
from the cart items so we go here with
dot dot an item basically we spread out
all the properties so we can access them
of course here when we destructure the
props and then we just want to set up
some return with the image title and
rest of the stuff yes of course none of
the buttons at the moment will work but
at least we'll have a better looking
card item and also we want to get two
icons from the icons we want to get rest
of them the Chevron down and Chevron up
so I'm gonna navigate to the card item
first let me grab both of them let me
get the import then we're looking for
Chevron down and Chevron
Chevron up
after that we want to go in the
structure all of the props so we're
looking for ID
image title price as well as the amount
and as far as the return let's start
over here with simple article
so we want to go here with article and
let's add a class of cart
item then we want to go with image and
Source will be the image
so let me say here dynamically image and
as far as the alternative well we have
the title for that so let's save it and
we should see the images and if we do
and of course we can proceed to the next
step
after that we want to set up a div
ing four is where we'll display the
title so let's save that then we also
want to set up the price so let's say
here heading 4 with the class of item
price which comes with a little bit of
styling and then I'll add the dollar
sign and I'll say a price let's save
that then we want to set up the button
so right below we'll go with button then
class and remove
iPhone B10 and we'll say remove would
save that and then we just want to set
up those buttons to increase or decrease
the amount so we want to do that right
after this div
so this is where we set up the heading
force and the button but after that we
want to go with another div there's
going to be no class
well we want to set up a button let's
call this amount
hyphen BTN and then let's add that icon
over here so in this case I want to go
with Chevron up let's close it okay good
then we want to copy and paste and set
up the rundown
so the class is going to be the same
mount button and here we just want to
say Chevron down and in between them
this is where we'll place the amount so
let's say here paragraph class name
amount and we want to render the amount
so say amount over here let's save it
and for all of them we have one
of course in the following videos we'll
set up the functionality that allows us
to change that and with this in place
now we can start slowly
adding our first reducers okay so how we
can set up the functionality with Redux
toolkit so if you remember previously we
needed to set up the action we needed
dispatch and then we always always need
it to return a new state and then just
of course copy the values and all that
now this is not the case with Redux
token in fact it's much much much easier
and the way we can do that we simply go
with a reducer's property in the slice
and again key value pair
so in my case I'm going to call this
clear card that's going to be the name
of my reducer over here now as a
parameter this function gets a state and
notice how we don't have to return
anything I don't have to return the new
state and always avoid the mutation
basically remember with user reducer we
always always needed to return a new
state we don't have to do that right now
why because when we installed Redux
token we also installed email Library
which behind the scenes does all the
heavy lifting so in our case we can
modify the state or mutate the state
directly and yes you're not
hallucinating this is clearly the code
that mutates the state
the reason we can write such code is
because Redux toolkit comes with Emer
library now it's also really cool that
if we take a look at card slice
Something That We're logging right now
in the card slash.js we have actions and
the moment we create that reducer
will be able to see the action created
by the name of yes exactly the same
Clear card
and what that means is that we don't
need this code again remember with use
reducer we set up the action we set it
equal to string and we didn't set up the
action Creator per se when we used user
reducer
but the idea would be that we actually
set up a function that returns that type
so we don't need to run around with this
variable basically have right away
function and
optionally we can also pass in the
payload now why am I saying this because
now we can directly use this clear card
we don't need to set up the variable we
don't need to create the function
essentially it's already provided for us
and then in order to invoke it
we need to get another Hook from the
react Redux and this is use dispatch
so remember
with userducer we use dispatch in this
case we right away get it if we invoke
use dispatch and then we invoke this
patch so whatever we're getting back
from here and we just pass in action
Creator so yes we do need to import
clear card that's why we're exporting
over here on this export console and
then name import or I'm sorry name
export
and then we just need to use it and
don't worry if some of this seems
confusing at this point
it will make total sense once we
complete the entire setup so first I
want to navigate to cart slice like I
said we want to start over here by
setting up that reducer the one that is
going to clear the cut so let's go here
with a reducers
and it's going to be an object inside of
it we just need to come up with name for
our reducer okay so it's going to be
clear card it's going to be a function
that gets the access to the state now
also we'll have access to the payload
basically
let's say we want to pass in the ID
something we'll do a little bit later
which is going to be a second parameter
for now we don't need to worry about it
I'll set it up as a arrow function and
like I said
I know I keep repeating this but we can
mutate the state directly because behind
the scenes immer takes care of that so
we can go here with State then what is
the value here it is card items whatever
I want to do I want to set it equal to
an empty array that's it that's all I
want to do and now let's go to the cart
slice let's uncomment the log
and we'll see in the console that yes we
have name and all that but now in the
actions we have a function we have
action Creator by the name of clearcard
and again the beauty indices
the fact that we don't need to set up
anything manually as far as the action
as far as the action Creator we right
away get in by default
and the only thing we want to do is pass
in
the clear card function
into whatever we're getting back from
this bachelor use dispatch and then pass
it in so let's go back to the slice and
instead of logging which as I said I'll
comment this out we want to go with
export const so all of these will be
named and yes we'll add more functions
of course over here
and let's go with clear card and now
where are we looking we're looking in
the cart slice dot actions so let's set
it equal to cart slash Dot and actions
so from that object we export this and
now we just need to decide well in which
component we're going to use it of
course in our case that will be cart
container yes eventually we'll set up
the model
so we will move that functionality from
the card container to the model but for
now
let's just see how we can invoke it in
here so let's say use
this patch that's the first one then
comma and Below or above it doesn't
really matter we want to go with that
huge dispatch
so const is going to be equal to this
patch whatever we get back use dispatch
invoke we don't need to pass anything in
then let's keep on scrolling keep on
scrolling this is where we have our
button and now we do want to pass in the
arrow function because of course I don't
want to invoke this immediately I only
want to invoke it when we click on a
button so let's say here on click
then let's pass in the arrow function
and we'll say that every time we'll
click on a button will dispatch
an action and in here let's pass in that
clear card again
the beauty here is that we don't need to
do all of that manual labor we just pass
in the function that the side note I
didn't import so let me go back we want
to go with clear card which is coming
from the card slice now let me save it
and in here it says unknown event
handler because I probably did some oh
yeah this is not right and once we click
this is what we'll see now we're not
displaying this one the condition simply
because we're not controlling the amount
yet don't worry all of that is coming up
for time being we are just displaying
The Heading 2 with your back here and
the total basically since we removed all
of the items since it's set equal to an
empty array we just have the your back
and the total and with this in place now
we can set up rest of the reducers and
while we're still on the topic of State
Management in the Redux toolkit reducers
let's also cover
an alternative option
and that is simply the fact that we can
return a new state from the reducer so
let me comment this one out let me type
here return but we need to be aware of
the major gacha and that is following
whatever we will return
from reducer as our new state will
become the new state so let's say if I'm
going to return an empty object yes our
state will immediately turn into an
empty object without any of these
properties same works if I'm gonna
return here empty array so let's say if
I return an object and if I just say
card items equals to an empty array yes
I will update this property
but automatically I'll remove these ones
just to Showcase that let me save it let
me click on clear cut and you'll notice
that now I'm nothing here as far as the
amount as well as the total and I can
clearly see that if I navigate two
adapto's so let me open up the Redux
death tools on a small browser window
and then when it comes to our state
notice all of the properties are missing
now only the card items is there
so let me comment this one out and let's
take a look at the use case where
this is going to come in handy so in one
of our upcoming projects we'll have some
pages and in there we'll have a bunch of
inputs that are going to be our state
values
and essentially there's also going to be
a clear button
and the idea is like this once the user
starts typing something let's say
changes some values around here
at some point maybe he or she wants to
clear out all the input values so in
that case we're gonna take that initial
state
and we'll just return that from our
reducer so let's say you set up your
state with whatever default values
and then
when you have the reducer that just sets
it back to default you just pass that
initial State as a return in your
Edition so that's one of the use cases
where this comes in handy but we do need
to be careful again whatever we're going
to return from the reducer will become
that new state value so if we omit some
of the properties yes they will be
excluded okay and once we can clear the
cart
it's a smooth sailing from here
we just want to set up those functions
we want to add the functionality and yes
we will take a look at the action how it
looks like and why we're looking for the
payload and I know I said this already a
million different times but
since right now we can modify the state
directly
there's tons of ways how you can set
this up now I purposely kind of tried to
showcase the mutation approach where yes
of course
in these examples for increase and
decrease we can return a new array
but I purposely just found the exact
item and then updated the amount plus or
minus and also of course you can combine
increase and decrease into one function
let's say you can call this toggle and
of course you'll just have to provide
here more values whether you're
increasing the equation that could be
your challenge for now we just want to
focus on remove
item and the first thing that I want to
showcase is the fact that we can access
the payload so whatever we pass in
because in order
to get the specific item in order to
remove it I do need to get the Eddie
correct if you're paying attention in
the card item we did this structure
already however
we haven't used it here so this is
something that we will pass into the
function
and essentially as far as the remove
item I'll get it from action.payload
because that is a structure I'll name
this item ID
and then I just want to set equal State
card items to the new array now I wasn't
doing this purposely again there's tons
of ways how you can set it up but in
like I said just thought that filter is
the fastest one so let me go to state
DOT card items we filter it we look for
specific item
that does not match the Eddie and we
return that into this car items so if
the ID matches
so whatever we pass in Manchester to the
80 then that item won't get returned and
in the process we'll move it from this
array so let's try this one out where in
the cart slash
let's set up that remove item so I'm
gonna go here with a move item and first
I just want to showcase
how we can access the payload so first
one is the state so we access the state
here then I'm gonna go with action and
later I'll showcase how we can structure
that and for time being let's just look
for the action and now let's think about
it where do we want to access all these
functions they remove items increase
decrease and not calculate totals so
only these three well we want to get
that in the car item so first in the
card slice we want to export that again
what's really cool is the fact that the
name is exactly the same we don't really
need to think about it and as I said it
shouldn't be remove items it should be a
remove item I apologize for some reason
I just keep adding those s's there then
let's navigate to the card item first we
want to import the remove item so we're
looking for a remove item
and notice how right away we get that
named import and also we want to get
that dispatch so let's just set it up
over here where we'll say import then
use dispatch that is coming from react
Redux then
the very top we're gonna go here with
const dispatch
and that will be equal to use dispatch
let's invoke it and then let's look for
that remove button
so now basically every time you click on
a button
we will remove that specific item so
let's say here on click
again we do want to pass in the arrow
function first and then let's say
dispatch and we'll go with a remove item
and now let's pass in the ID
so first thing what you'll see once you
click is the log in the console so let's
click and check it out
in here we see two things
first we see type
so notice how that is right away already
set up for us like I said we don't need
to do anything right away it has cart
and then remove item so this is the
action that we're dispatching and we
also get the payload now can you pass in
the payload as an object absolutely but
if we pass in as a simple property
then we have payload is equal to
whatever
so knowing this we can set up rest of
the functionality where in the card
slice
I'll assign action.payload equal to an
ID const and I think I'm gonna call this
product ID or sorry now I'll call this
item ID so const
Item ID is equal to action payload
and then
let's set up the new value for the state
card items State again yes we're
modifying this we're going to go with
cart items is equal to and now let's
access the old value basically before
the update and we can do that with State
card items then let's run filter and
like I said if the ID matches the item
won't be returned so essentially we'll
remove it from our cart items array
we're going to call this items and I'm
gonna go with implicit return where I'm
going to say if item id does not match
the item id only then return it from the
array
and as a result check it out and click
and we just keep removing the items from
our bag again yes we're not affecting
the amount as well as the total all of
that is coming up but we should be able
to remove all of the items from our cart
be it with clear card or individually by
clicking on the remove button all right
and now once we're familiar now we can
remove item let's also do the same thing
with increase and decrease now in order
to make things interesting I already
destructured the payload so remember
we're getting the action object and
we're looking for the payload so in this
case I just destructured that in the
case of increase I'm going to State card
items find so we get that specific item
in this case where the ID matches unlike
the filter approach and then I just want
to update the amount so every time I'll
click on the increase button will
increase the amount of specific items we
have in the cart for this phone or that
phone
and hopefully you see where I'm going
with this and eventually of course this
will also affect the amount as well as
the total and yes I'll set them up
pretty much right away since the
functionality is exactly the same apart
from the fact that in this case we
increase and in this case we decreasing
like I said if you want to challenge
yourself set up a toggle functionality
where you look for one more value
increase or decrease which of course is
going to be in the payload and then
depending on that set up the
functionality but for now let's just
worry about these two so we're gonna
navigate to cart slash and then right
after move item let's say here increase
let's set up our function
let's say State like I said we'll right
away look for the payload
I'll set it equal to
and when it comes to functionality we
want to go with const first we want to
get that card item each specific one
where the ID matches and we can do that
with state
card items dot find then let's pass in
the Callback function let's say item and
then Item ID is equal to payload and
we'll pass this in as an object so it's
going to be payload
dot ID
and then
let's increase that amount so now I'm
accessing that one specific card item I
have the amount property and please
don't confuse this with the total amount
so that's the total with all of the
items that we have in a cart
when we're talking about this cart item
on property we're talking about this one
over here for that specific card item
and we'll just say card item
mount
so whatever it is right now plus or yeah
in this case plus one and then
in order to set up decrease you want to
copy and paste you want to go with
decrease still going to be a payload
okay all of that is awesome we'll still
look for the card item the difference
here is minus one and then we will add
them of course to our exports so let's
say increase
decrease and we want to navigate to the
card item
we want to import the other two as well
so we're going to go here with increase
then decrease
both of them and first let's set up the
increase because for a decrease we'll
have to add a little bit more
functionality
so let's go with mount button let's say
on click we already have dispatch so we
don't need to worry about that one and
we just want to pass in the increase
so we're gonna go here with this patch
and then inside of this patch let's pass
in the increase and like I said in order
to make this interesting I'm gonna go
with an ID now normally if you're
setting this up as an object of course
you'll pass in more properties
but in this case I won't do that and for
some reason oh yeah my bad so I set up
the import in the wrong place
me out of comma here
and hopefully everything is going to
work Yep looks about right and if we try
this out notice how again we're changing
this value over here for each item and
again the functionality here is
following where we look for the payload
which in this case is an object that's
why we go here with payload dot ID just
to Showcase that we can pass in more
data and then we just increase the
amount and the same thing we can do with
decrease so let's go back to the card
item
I'll take this entire thing 40 on click
or copy and paste and now let's go with
decrease instead so say decrease again
pass in the area that doesn't change
it's refreshed so we start from scratch
and now notice how we can decrease the
amount now the problem is that we're
going negative
so I think it's going to make a bit more
sense if we'll check for the amount and
again we're talking about the amount of
specific item not overall amount and if
it is equal to one
we want to remove it since that way
we'll have zero items in the cart
and if it's bigger than one then of
course we just want to run the decrease
so I'm going to go back to this on click
and we'll set up if amount is equal to
one that means that we're pressing the
button amount is already equal to one
and if that is the case well we might as
well remove the item from the card
correct we'll say remove item and we'll
just pass in the edit now we do want to
pass the return right after because you
don't want to continue reading the code
and if the amount is bigger than one
then of course we just decrease the
amount so let me go here let me refresh
and notice I can increase I can actually
decrease so all of that is working but
the moment I get
the amount of one if I will click the
decrease I'll automatically remove the
item from the cart all right and up next
let's take a look at how we can
calculate the totals because at the
moment yes
we can nicely control our cart but that
is not affecting the amount then we have
all the way at the top and also it's not
affecting the total and in order to fix
that we'll come up with new reducer
we'll call this calculate totals and I
went with this functionality so I
created new variables amount and total
then I iterate over the current cart
items and each of them has the amount of
property
so I just add to the overall amount one
so the one that represents the entire
card and the same goes for a total only
in this case I multiply
the amount of items I have with the
price and that is equal to the total one
so I set up the loop I add
both of these values and at the very end
and just go with State amount is equal
to amount so whatever we created over
here the same goes for total now where
do we want to invoke that one that's a
good question let's keep on scrolling in
the readme and I actually set this one
up in the app
so in the app
I will set up a use effect
on that user effect will depend on the
car items so use use selector grab the
card items from the cart and then every
time there's going to be some change in
the car atoms will dispatch the
calculate totals and as a result
both of those values will change in here
as well as in the total so let's try to
set this one up and let's start by
creating the function
calculate and then totals
again it's going to be our function
we'll access the state as far as the
logic let's go with let amount is equal
to zero and let's say not I have a tiny
bug over here then I want to copy and
paste and let's just say total so by
default it's always going to be zero and
zero
then we want to go with State then cart
items let's iterate over so call this
for each and then we'll access each and
every item and each and every item has
the amount and Total Property and we
just want to add this to the total
amount therefore we'll go with plus
equals and then item amount now when it
comes to the amount of money we want to
multiply the price that each item has
with the amount of items we have in a
cart so total is equal to and now in
this case we'll go with plus equals item
amount multiplied by item dot price and
once we have this one in place
up next we want to set State amount
equals to amount that we just set up and
the same goes with total so let's go
here let's say total is equal to total
and after that we want to export that so
let's say calculate totals and we just
need to set it up in the app.js so let's
navigate to app.js
and in here let's grab first the U
selector and use dispatch we'll need
both of them
so let's say import use dispatch use
selector and we'll set it equal to from
react reduct and also I want to get that
calculate totals so let's say calculate
totals that is coming from the features
okay beautiful and as far as the logic
well first let's grab the card items and
we'll use you selector for that so cart
items now that is equal to use selector
let's pass in the function and let's say
here store is equal to store cart and
I'm not going to repeat myself how we
can access that and also we want to set
up that dispatch so const dispatch
not is equal to use dispatch let's
involve that
and let's finally set up that use effect
so let's say here use effect
and then as far as the Callback function
we will invoke this every time there's a
change to the cart items so every time
we'll update something
related to the card items we will invoke
this use effect specifically we want to
go with dispatch and we want to pass in
calculate totals so check it out
now we still have four here but I can
clearly see my total
and what's going to happen every time
we'll click on any of the buttons and
all that nicely display whatever items
we have in the card now there's tiny bug
over here
basically we need to set this one to
fixed essentially how many uh numbers
after that and don't worry we'll do that
in a second but the goal here
is that now every time we remove item
from the card or we clear the card
altogether
it will affect the amount of items we
have which we display over here and also
the total now in order to fix the bug
there with too many numbers we just need
to go to card container
and where we have the total let's go
with two fixed so that's again the
JavaScript method that we have access to
and we'll say that we only want two
numbers after the dot so now everything
is going to work
and just like that we have calculate
totals in place and every time we'll
make some changes to our cart
they will affect our initial state in
the card slice all right and up next I
want to set up a modal and in the
process we'll create another slice and
we'll see how we can access data when we
have multiple reducers in our store and
the first step is going to be creating a
model JS with following code and then we
want to import that in the app.js and
place it above the number so we'll start
working on that where first I'm going to
create model Js
I'm going to set up any kind of imports
in this case
we haven't set up the slice yet so let's
just create that component
and as far as the return we want to go
here with a side
and we want to add a class name of modal
container and as I said if you're
interested in the CSS just please look
for those classes in the index CSS then
we want to create a div of the class of
model inside of it let's say heading 4
with the text of remove all items from
your shopping cart and after that we
want to go with button container where
basically we'll place two buttons just
to Showcase how it's going to look like
let me go to complete one
and again we'll display that once we try
to clear the cloud so this is going to
be the result so right off 30 heading
we're gonna go with div with a class of
BTN
container inside of it let's place two
buttons first one will be confirm one
and the second one will be the clear one
type for both of them will be button
then class name BTN and I'll call this
confirm vtn and as far as the text I'm
gonna go with confirm as well and the
same deal with the clear one we just
want to change some values around where
it's not going to be
confirm it's going to be cancel instead
and instead of confirm hyphen vtn we're
going to go with clear BTN now we want
to go to app.js
we want to get this particular component
so
I mean let me try here with the Auto
Import Let's see we have model yep
that worked and once we save check it
out this is going to be our model so we
have the component now we just need to
set up the logic all right up next let's
set up the slice for the model
so remember we have features folder
for time being we only have one feature
we have the car
but now I want to add the Moto feature
which is going to be located in the
model slice and then we want to set up
the functionality where again we're
going to go with create slice
we want to set up some initial state in
this case it's going to be is open
and I'll set it equal to false then we
want to go with model slice come up with
name initial State and right away let's
set up those two reducers we're gonna go
with open model and close model we want
to export that and we also want to
export model slash reducer and in the
store we want to set up another key only
in this case it's going to be equal to
this model slice reducer and
as a result we'll be able to access the
state as well as the reducers all over
our application and the first thing that
we'll do
is in the app.js we'll grab is open
and we'll display this one conditionally
so I'm gonna go to the features we want
to create a new folder let's call this
modal then we want to go to new file and
we'll call this model
slice JS and then inside of it we first
want to grab the create slice so let's
go here with create and let's see
whether yep gives me the import then we
wanna
set up the initial state in my case just
going to be one property again this is
just a practice
working with more realistic application
where of course there's going to be more
features so we're going to go here is
open and by default let's set it equal
to false
false and then let's set up that slice
so const modal slice is equal to create
slice let's pass in the object name
model
then initial state is equal to initial
State let's right away set up those
reducers now what reducers we're gonna
have we're gonna have open motor reducer
which is going to be equal to state
and action again we're just practicing
as far as the action we're not going to
use it and in here let's just say state
is open so if I want to open a model
what is going to be value well you might
as well set it equal to True kind of
makes sense don't you think then let's
copy in page then now we want to close
the model now what is going to be the
value for is open well let's set it back
to false then we want to export three
things the main reducer and I'm not
going to log it we already have done
that so export default now of course we
have different object but the property
we want to export meaning the
method is still the same we want to
export the reducer that's number one and
then remember those action creators so
we're gonna go here with export const
and now we're looking for open model
close model and both of them are coming
from modal slice and the actions now
in order for everything to work we
definitely definitely definitely need to
go to store
so let's find where is that sucker over
here and then in the store now I want to
get the modal slice
so I have to change some things around
this is going to be coming from the
model
name will also be modal this is going to
be a modal reducer and yes of course the
property I'm going to go with model as
well so model will be equal to modal
reducer
so that's good now let's try it out in
our application on a big screen
and
at the moment we're calculating the
totals notice we have our E2 actions not
only the init and we also run calculate
totals what I want to showcase though is
that
set up just cart now we also have the
model
and now let's utilize that we're in the
app Js
not only I want to get the model I also
want to access what I want to access is
open
and I want to set this one up
conditionally since in a second we'll
add all the functionality so in here
remember we were accessing the cart
so the only difference is that now I
want to access the modal and I'll say is
open
is
open and that will be equal not to the
store cart
I'll say store model
and where I have the model
will have the conditional rendering
where I'll say is open if it's true only
then display the model so let's move it
in and since the value is false we don't
display the model now if I'll manually
go back to model slice and I'll say that
the value is true
I mean
you're not going to be surprised
probably by the fact that we display the
model okay awesome
so now let's add that functionality
where instead of just clearing the cart
why don't we open up the model when we
click on this button and then once we
get to the modal container then we'll
decide do we really want to remove all
the contents and then close the model or
we simply want to close the model so
first let's start in the card container
and I'll send out yes you'll find all of
the logic here in the readmewhere first
in the car container we want to get the
open model from the model slice and
instead of clearing the card directly
we'll go dispatch and open model and
from there we'll finish everything in
the model just so let's start in the
cart container
so we have all of these Imports okay
that's awesome
but we want to copy and paste and we
want to get open modal from the modal
slice open model and instead of card
slash we're gonna go here with model and
then modal slice then let's keep on
moving I don't think we actually need
this import anymore
so we can remove it and then where we
have the clear card
now let's pass in the open modal
same deal we invoke it so that doesn't
change now the difference of course is
going to be that now once we click on
clearing cart we display the model so
now let's navigate there and let's
handle that
so what first do we need over there well
we'll need quite a few things first we
want to get the closed model because
regardless on which button we click I
want to clear it I want to get the use
dispatch I'll need it since I wanna
invoke some reducers and I also want to
get the clear card so notice how again
we're getting this data from multiple
slices model slice and card slice and
then of course we'll just set up the
functionality so
let's go back over here let's set up all
those three Imports we're gonna get the
closed model
closed model and I also want to get the
clear card for your cart and also we
want to get the use dispatch so let's
see where that is going to work so use
this patch yep I have all of them so now
I can remove these suckers then we want
to quickly
set up the dispatch where effectively we
just go with use dispatch and we invoke
it and now it's set up the functionality
where if we click on confirm I want to
do two things
not only I want to clear the card but I
also want to close the model now if we
go to cancel then we'll just close the
model so let's go here with button we're
gonna go with on
click and then in here let's pass in the
function
and then
We're not gonna pass in any kind of
argument we'll just go with dispatch
then clear
card
that's the first thing we want to invoke
and then the second one it looks like I
have some weird bug oh yeah oh here and
the second thing is the close model
so let's pass this one in and I know I
keep repeating this but I really like
the fact that we don't need to do any of
that manual labor where we need to set
up the actions and all that in this case
we simply right away get those functions
and we pass in dispatch which obviously
is way less time consuming and also less
chance for errors so let's do the same
thing with this button and the only
thing we want to change here is clear
card where we basically want to remove
it so if we confirm then our card is
empty if our we just click on cancel we
close out the model so that's how we can
add another feature to our application
all right and now let's see how we can
set up a synchronous functionality with
a Redux toolkit so here's the plan so I
have quarters API
basically an API that serves some Json
data just so we can practice on fetching
data and in the use reducer project we
already work with this URL so it's
course API and then react use reducer
card project which essentially Returns
the same data that we currently have in
the card items so use this URL to fetch
data when initially our application
loads
and here's the thing we cannot just
simply set this up in our current
reducers it's not going to work that's
why with redex toolkit we install
another Library the thunk one and from
the Redux tokit we get this create hsync
funk
and we right away wanna invoke it and
the result we want to export
so this is something that will require
directly in our components so it's a
very similar to how we exported the
action creators from the reducers
however in this case we export this
directly in my case I'm going to call
this get cart items so we invoke create
async Funk and it's looking for two
things for the action type so
essentially in here we just come up with
a name
of our action and second is going to be
that callback function
now in the following video I'll show you
more options but at the very least we
pass here this function and this
function needs to return a promise
um I'm just using fetch to fetch data
and remember
when we go with fetch dot then we return
basically a success response and with
catch of course it's going to be the
error but regardless from this function
we are automatically returning the
promise this is what the Callback
function is looking for it's looking for
that promise and of course you're not
limited to the just fetch you can set up
all kinds of things in here but just
remember that this function needs to
return a promise so of course if you
just stick async in front of it
then by default it's going to return
promise which is something that we'll
take a look at in the next video and
then in the fetch I want to pass in the
URL
so the one that gets me the product and
when it comes to this callback function
it returns a life cycle actions so if
you remember when we work with promises
we add few options
promise could be pending it can be
fulfilled and rejected
so where we have the create slice what
we want to do is set up extra reducers
property it's going to be an object and
then in order to access those life cycle
actions the syntax is like this where we
go with name what we're getting back and
then that pending fulfilled and rejected
and yes
these need to match to the T
because
they're provided by the Redux token and
then we wanna and close this with the
square brackets
and then we'll set this equal to a
function so what do we want to do when
we're pending basically when we're
loading that's why we have the state
value is loading and we'll set it equal
to true then what do we want to do if
we're successful and this is the case
where the data that we're returning in
the case of success in our case response
that Json is going to be located in the
action payload and of course the lug it
just so you can see so once we have
successfully data we want to set is
loading to false and card items to the
actual payload and if there's some kind
of error we have rejected option and in
that case for this application we just
want to set is loading to false
and also keep in mind that when it comes
to fetch 404 is not an R so we'll only
have this one if there's some kind of
network error and at the very last we
want to grab get card items in the app
app component and then when our
application loads we want to do two
things we want dispatch get card items
so the asynchronous function
and then we also want to grab is loading
from the state and while we're loading
we'll display this
and once we're successful we'll set the
state card items equal to the data that
we're getting back
so let's try this one out where I'm
going to go to card slice
and first I want to grab that create a
sink thunk so that one is coming from
Redux toolkit then I want to set up the
URL so right after the import let's go
here with const URL and you have two
options you can either get it from
readme or you can just navigate here in
the browser so since I already have it
open in the browser
I'll use this approach so again this is
the URL where we can fetch those
products just like we have in the card
items and then let's keep on scrolling
and we'll go with
create a sync thunk and we'll set it
equal to our function but we want to
right away export it so let's say const
get cart
items and that is equal to creative sync
Duncan like I said it's looking for two
things
the type so in here we just need to come
up with a name in my case I'm going to
go with cart forward slash get
card and I'm so that's going to be my
action and second will be that callback
function
and here let's right away go with return
fetch let's pass in the URL then that
then so if you're successful I want to
turn this into a Json so say response
response Json let's invoke that and then
let's also go with catch and don't worry
next video to take a look at more
reasonable approach how to handle this
but for time being I just want to get
that data from the URL so let's go here
with error and then log that sucker
and once we are done
we want to keep on scrolling and in the
create slides right after reducers the
property name is extra reducers notice
we right away get that suggestion and
like I said then we get those life cycle
actions
so for every function that we will
create
in this case it is get card items we'll
get those three life cycle actions
pending fulfilled and rejected and the
way we can access that we go with the
same name so get card items in this case
and then notice we right away have those
options fulfilled pending and rejected
so in my case I'm going to start with
pending that is why we're still loading
and in this function same way we can
access the state and also we can get the
action so action is going to be useful
once we get the data for now while we're
pending we just want to grab the state
and I want to set the state is loading
value equal to what equal to True
correct so while we're loading is
loading will be equal to
true then we want to copy and paste like
so we just want to add the commas so
there's no bugs in here and we want to
change these ones around where instead
of bending now I'm looking for fulfilled
and in this case I do want to add
another parameter which is going to be
action and again this action will
contain the result
if we're successful so in this case if
we're successful we return the Json
response and what I'm going to do is set
my card item so state
and then cart items equal to what action
and payload and yes let's also log it
just so you can see where it's coming
from but I can tell right away that
there's a payload property and that's
the one that holds those card items so
let's log the action and lastly
we also have rejected
and like I said since we're using fetch
it's only for network errors and for
time being also the sequel to false and
also
there's a tiny issue here once we have
the data of course the loading will be
false
so we don't need to export this we're
actually in good shape we already export
that function
here with export now we just want to go
to app.js we want to grab the function
get cart items we want to invoke it
once our application loads and we also
want to check for is loading so let's
navigate to app.js
and since we already import
the calculator from the card slice
simply want to add a comma and we'll go
with get card items and then let's keep
on moving not only I want to get the
card items I also want to check for is
loading sorry for loading then we'll
display different return and then let's
set up a different use effect
where I'm going to go with use effect
and I'll invoke it
only when my application loads so once
my application loads what do I want to
do I want to dispatch and we'll go with
get card items and we'll invoke it it's
also set up that return
where basically if we're loading this is
what we want to return we want to go
with Dave with glass of loading and then
heading one loading so let's set it up
here if is loading it's true then we
want to go with return
then let's set up the div here let's add
a class of loading and on the side of it
we're gonna go with heading one and
loading dot dot and once we save for
second we'll notice that loading and
then we get the product and if you don't
believe me
let's navigate to the big screen over
here let's refresh and then let's check
it out in here we have the pending which
is going to be for that loading one and
we can clearly see our state
so notice how awesome it is in the feed
explos where you can clearly see your
actions so what actions were dispatching
and what is the state at that time and
we can even see the difference so
basically if I'm gonna go here with
fulfilled notice this is going to be the
difference so in the cart
we basically get this is loading and we
set it equal to false and also in the
console you can see what we're getting
back remember I said that once we log
over here in the card slice
we are logging the action so what is in
this action it is a payload and that's
the data that we're getting back so we
have this array of four items we set
here State card items equal to the
payload so again something we can
definitely double check over here so if
I go here with State notice with
fulfilled for example this is going to
get me those car items those four card
items and one more thing that we can
actually do is go back to the cart slice
and set this equal to an empty array so
the car items and that way you'll
clearly see how we can change this once
the Theta gets here asynchronously so
let's navigate back again let's refresh
just so we are on the safe side and if
we go right now with action fulfill them
if we take a look at the difference now
I'll notice two things first of all is
loading changed from True to false and
also notice how we switch the card items
so initially it was empty array and now
essentially we get those four items and
again all of our functionality still
works we can clearly see that in our
actions over here
but now we're getting this data
asynchronously once our application
loads all right and lastly I just want
to showcase what options we have with
the Callback function because in our
previous example we just looked at the
most basic setup
so now let's go over the more complex
one and don't worry in this video you
don't have to type along and in fact we
won't use any of this extra data in our
current application the goal is to
Simply get the gears in your head
turning and showcase large amount of
options we have and first what I want to
do is install another Library the HTTP
Library by the name of axios because I
do want to showcase
how essentially we can return a value
for the error and since fetch is not
responding to 404 basically for fetch
the 404 errors are not errors I actually
want to use the axios instead again if
you don't want to do that you can just
sit back and relax where I'm going to go
with npm install axios first then we
definitely want to spin up the dev
server of course so npm start let me
close this one then we want to navigate
to cart slice I think I can remove the
items we won't need it anymore so axios
from axios let's keep on moving and
before we do anything
like I said we can create this function
right away as a sync which essentially
just means that we'll right away return
the promise correct so go here with a
sync and that also means that we can
await so we can set up more logic so let
me remove all of this code here and
let's just go with try and catch right
away since we can also do that and then
let's wait for that response so I'm
going to say here const and then
response is equal to oh wait now I'm
going to go with axios and then I'll
pass in the URL and if we're successful
what do we want to do we want to return
that response again keep in mind we are
returning a promise and yes we're
handling that in the X reducers so none
of this functionality changes right now
we're just switching right now our
create a sync done callback function to
a sync where we're using axios now once
we save we will get some errors in the
console don't worry about it the reason
for that is because when it comes to
axios the data is located in the data
property and just to Showcase that let
me go here with log and then response
and you'll see in a console
if you scroll up you'll notice over here
this is what we're getting back and
essentially what we want to do we want
to pass in this data property
down to these lifecycle actions so we're
talking about this one over here so
let's scroll up and we'll go here with
return and let's go with response and
then there again
this is just because that's how the
response is structured so once we save
notice how everything worked correctly
where again we're getting those items
and if we take a look at the action it's
still the same thing we're getting this
payload and the payload is that array
so that's the first thing that I want to
mention also well we can pass here the
arguments now what does that mean well
in our case we're not going to use that
but we need to imagine that let's say
we're going to be setting up some kind
of functionality and we do want to pass
here the value let's say whether that is
a user or some kind of parameter or
something so in this case I'm just going
to say random
and if we want to access that again in
our case it's not going to change
anything but if we want to access that
this is going to be the first parameter
so in my case I'm going to go with name
and let's simply log that and we'll
clearly see
that we can access that value again not
something we'll use in our application
but it's very very important because
there's going to be applications where
of course this is going to be important
the fact that we can pass something here
from our component and we can access it
in our create async thumb that's the
first thing that I want to mention now
second we also have access to thunk API
again you can name it differently but I
mean common convention is calling this
Bank API which gives us even more
options now what am I talking about well
first of all let's log something let's
go with log then let's access bank API
and you know what let's just log the
entire thing
so you know what there's quite a few
things here in the console so let me
remove this action basically I'll
comment this one out for your reference
and also hopefully it's clear how we can
pass the parameters from the components
so that's clear
but then check it out we have this
somewhat giant object with bunch of
useful things
so here's the thing we could get the
state now what's interesting we're
getting the state of the entire
application
and this should get the wheels turning
in your head because that means that we
can get any values from the rest of the
features so let me quick quickly
showcase that so I'm gonna go with log
and then thunk API and then let's go
with get State and let's invoke it and
in the console I have both I have the
values for the card as well as the model
so imagine if you have for example a
user feature where you're setting up the
user yes when you're setting up your
async action
you can actually access it so I can set
up the user in a different feature
and I can still access it with the help
of this tank API which is very very very
powerful and also what's interesting
well we can dispatch
if we take a look at the object over
here notice we have this dispatch option
so what we can dispatch well for example
let's open up the model while we're
fetching so let's try this one out we're
right after the get State and all that
we go here and we're gonna go with funk
API
we're gonna go with this patch and now
we want to pass in open and modal again
something that is not even in our slice
and check it out and as I said I forgot
to add here
the parentheses notice even though this
reducer is not even in this feature we
can still access it with tank API and I
know you're sick of hearing this but
this is extremely powerful because we
can do all kinds of functionality in the
create async thumb and lastly what I
want to showcase is how we can return a
specific response because at the moment
yes we have catch and we are basically
getting the error but normally from the
API
you'll get some kind of specific message
so first of all how we can pass this
through again we're gonna look for thunk
API and we want to go here with the
return first of all and then the
property or the method you're looking
for so let's go here with thunk API is
reject with value so in this case I will
hard code this but keep in mind that
normally with axios it's going to be
located in error dot response so in here
let's say something
went
wrong like so and then let's keep on
moving let's keep on moving and where we
have the rejected now we can look for
that action in our case again we don't
have any error values in the state or
nothing like that but let's just log
whether we can see that action whether
we can see that everything works and
since we are using axial so now I can
mess up the URL and for axios it will be
an error what that means well we will
trigger this and we'll basically pass
this value
down to our rejected so let's save it
and then notice in the console we right
away see this log and we have this
payload where we have something went
wrong so for example if we're getting
some kind of error from the API it's
going to be located and error response
and we can actually pass this down using
thunk API and then reject with the value
so that's how we can set up asynchronous
functions with Redux toolkit and this
concludes our tutorial hopefully
everyone enjoyed it and I'll see you
next videos if you have been following
along with the videos and if your app
uses latest Redux toolkit version most
likely
you see the following warning message in
the browser the object notation for
create slice extra reducers is
deprecated and will be removed in rtk so
Redux took it
2.0 please use the Builder callback
notation instead
and before we navigate to the docs
effectively
it means that we need to refactor our
extra reducer setup in the card slice
now the good news is that we won't have
to change our logic too much only the
way we pass our callback function and
life cycle actions
so let me click on this link we'll
navigate to the docs create slice yada
yada and we're looking for that I mean I
keep forgetting his name the Builder
callback notation that's the one that we
want to use effectively like I said we
won't have to change too much
so we'll go with X reducers and I will
have a function so pass in the function
and the first parameter they call
Builder so we will also call it Builder
and then we go with Builder the dot add
cache
and then lifecycle actions stay the same
so we're still looking for pending
fulfilled as well as rejected and the
same is with the Callback function it's
still going to have the same parameters
we'll just pass it here as a argument
so life cycle actions stay the same as
well as the Callback function the only
difference is that now we need to pass
them as arguments in this ad cache and
yes for every life cycle action
just like we did with object notation
we'll just add this case
and I think
it's going to make more sense if we just
start working on that so let me navigate
back again I'm located in the cart slash
I have my extra reducers as you can see
we have these lifecycle actions for get
card items and now we just want to
refactor this to Builder I mean again
let me double check
for some reason I just can't remember
the name Builder callback notation
that's the one that we want to use
um in order to
make it easier I'm just going to type
here extra reducers on top and I'll
reuse the code
so that way you can clearly see that the
setup is pretty much the same so here we
want to passively function like so
that's the first step then we want to
set up the parameter
and we'll call this Builder and then we
go with Builder and then add cache so
this is a method so we need to pass in
some arguments the first one is going to
be that a life cycle action what do we
have over here we have get card item
spending so that's the one that we want
to use so let's cut this one out pass it
in as you can see syntax stays exactly
the same the only difference is that now
we don't pass this into the square
brackets that's it that's the first
parameter second one
or argument more correctly the second
thing that we want to pass is that
callback function and notice how the
syntax pretty much stays exactly the
same and yes
the same parameters State and action and
yes we still update the state within the
function body again I know I'm being
annoying right now but I just want to
make it extremely clear
that all the functionality we have
learned so far stays the same the only
difference is how we invoke it here
that's it that's the only difference so
let's cut this one out again the
function make sure that you don't have
any syntax bugs and we're done that's
our first case for depending one and of
course what do we need to do we need to
set up the same ones for fulfilled
rejected then we can remove the sucker
altogether and we're going to be good to
go we'll have no warning messages in the
console and as you saw in the message
where if you're using the
Redux toolkit 2.0 or creator of course
then
essentially it's not going to be
supported so let's just go with that
case yes effectively we just want to
change here add one and then I'll add
one more case right away like so and now
let's set it up
this one is going to be straightforward
we just want to copy and paste
there's not much logic in here so let's
cut it out let's pass in the comma the
only thing you need to look out for is
some uh sewer syntax bug
so let me take it here which by the way
I'm an expert on so I'll take my sweet
time while I'm setting this one up comma
here copy and paste yep everything is
good to go we just remove the extra
reducers we save once I navigate to the
browser as you can see I have no error
so now our extra reducers is using the
Builder callback notation all right that
concludes the video thank you for
watching I hope you enjoyed this video
and learn something new
if you want to continue learning react
and take your skills to the next level
be sure to check out my reactors in
there you'll find bunch of additional
in-depth tutorials challenges and
projects designed to help you master
this powerful library to get started
just head over to johnsmilk.com thanks
again for watching and I'll see you in
the next one